Lee Howe is a core maintainer of felt so
he is a great person to teach this
massive svelte course for beginners
spell is a front-end JavaScript
framework for making interactive web
pages leave starts at the absolute
beginning with creating your first svelt
component and continues on to teach
every component you need to know to
develop applications using svelte hello
hello I'm Lee how
so today we are going to write our first
Spell components
so
usually when I write a spell component I
will head over to the svelt rapple it's
it's like a playground where you can
write your components without having to
worry about all the setup it's just
right and then you take a look at the
results and if you're happy with it you
can even download the codes and run it
in your environment so let's see so
let's head over to the repo which is
felt.dev Rebel or if you are in the
svelt.dev website you can come over here
to the top right corner and click on the
rebel button and so here is this
playground that I mentioned you can play
around with it I'm something and see the
results immediately on the right
and you can download as I said which you
can run your code so we'll take a look
at that later on but first let's open uh
Zoom this up and let's start with our
first component so I'm going to name
this first component about components
so first thing first as well component
is if it's written in one file and the
file extension is have to be end with
dots s v a l t e dot svelte so a spell
component is a file that ends with a
dots felt extension
and the syntax of what you're going to
write in here is going to be similar as
HTML
so uh as felt syntax is actually a
superset of the HTML syntax so if you're
familiar with writing HTML you can just
write it over here for example I'm going
to write H1 hell
my first cell component
whoops
and I'm gonna have a few paragraphs
uh let's see paragraphs
hello world
and I can have style text like how you
would in your HTML uh file where you can
have style tag and install your elements
that you like so I'm gonna make my H1
the color
Rebecca purple
this is the purple color that Rebecca
loves the most and
a Rebecca's favorite color and you can
change P tag to maybe a different font
size font size
44 pixels right so you can add Styles
you can have HTML just like you would in
HTML right so you can add some
um attributes so I'm going to come over
here and say at the anchor attack so
link
to my YouTube and then can add okay
attributes just like how you would in
HTML so I'm come over here and say okay
this is my YouTube channel uh hopefully
you come
okay this is my link to my YouTube
channel so you can click over here
so you can have a hashref
um attributes and you can have children
like you would in HTML so
um let's see let's come over here gonna
have a I'm gonna wrap all this within a
div
right so you can have children you can
have attributes just like you would in
HTML
and lastly could the Logics for your
components will be in a script tag
right so we will explore how you will
write your logic for your components but
just for you know anything within script
text will be like JavaScript so you can
have something like let's uh name equals
Lee how right this is Javascript you can
write any JavaScript you like over here
so one thing you need to take note is
that unlike HTML you can have multiple
Styles uh tag but in a Cell component
you can only have one styled egg right
only one and that one is important right
same goes with script hack you can only
have one script tag or else you get a
warning an error a build error right so
that it is that is it sorry that is it
lastly
um when I show you this I'm going to
download this I'm going to open it up
I'm gonna open it up
and let's let me allow me to open up my
code editor
so I'm using a vs code over here
um
where I have so this app.spel is what
we've written over just now
and to use this components in in a setup
that you would right this is a quick
preview of how you would do is you will
come over here in the mean JS file and
you will import your swell components
and it will be a class it will be a
default export and you can use it where
you choose where to Mount Your
components I will talk about this in
more detail later on and even how to set
up your environments how to set up build
settings right but this is just to let
you know that your components will be in
a DOT spell file and you can import from
anywhere and use it like a component
like a class
let's talk a bit more in detail about
styling in Spell components
so over here on my screen we seen what
we have left over from the last video
where we created a H1 a paragraph a div
and a link right and we started using
CSS
uh it within a style tag
and now I have another component called
components Dot svelt and I'm going to
import this component into my
app.spel right so bear with me if you
are not familiar with this because we're
gonna talk a bit about them more in
detail later but as you can see how
important is I'm going to import
components from the file and then when I
can drop my component over here right
like this so
my first component hello world and link
to my YouTube is from amplus felt and
component another components by wall and
link to my Twitter is within another
component
so what I'm going to share today is a
few things first
the style that you write within a
component is going to be scoped meaning
all the styles that you write only apply
to all the elements within this
component
see take a look at this I have the same
heading 1 paragraph and div and anchor
tag in another component
and but if I write the Styles over here
it's only going to apply to the H1 in my
component only the this only the my
first component is being colored in
purple
and only the paragraph within this
component is going to be font size 44
pixels see the other com paragraph in
another component is much much smaller
so first thing the style is being scoped
within your component meaning any
elements it only apply to all the
elements within this file this file that
you look at right now
so uh it it means actually spelled
will read through all the selectors and
figure out what element that it will
apply to and then does some svelte
Magics over there
so this gives us a few Advantage first
is that of course you are more confident
with the styles that you're writing
right now because uh it will you will
make sure that it will only apply to the
components over here to the elements
over here of course not just limits to
attack uh if you can have a class like
this class
I'm gonna say uh links and I can style
it over here as well so links will have
a
let's see uh text align right so your
right line and even if you have another
class over here
it will not write a line right so it's
not just elements you can have class
selectors the same it will only applies
to all the elements that's written
within this file component so you are
confident enough that if you change
something will only apply to all the
elements within a component so you don't
have to worry about messing up other
components
two
because svelt knows what elements it
will apply to and this also means that
if you write something like uh for
example if I already remove this I don't
have any elements that has a class links
actually this felt will know that you
have a selector that is not applied to
any elements within this file
so
um there is a warning and also you you
and so that you know that you have to
remove them because it's not applied to
any elements anymore
and what's good about it is also that
during compilations fellow actually
removes it so if you go to look at the
CSS output uh text align right is no
longer here
so while we are looking at this CSS
output I do have to point out that right
now if you look at
um I want to point out actually how this
works so svelt will actually find out
all the elements that
will be targeted and then add a special
class to the elements that will be uh
that that will be targeted by all your
class and then so and then it will use
that class to increase the specificity
of your selector of course your selector
will be more specific right now but it
will make sure that they will increase
the specificity the same way for all the
selectors so that
um if you have selectors over here make
sure that the specificity the relative
specific specificity among the selectors
is still the same
right so so that it does not just add
like a class over here and then bricks
uh make this slightly higher specificity
than the links you will not do that like
it will make sure that relative
specificity is still maintained
so if I come over here and inspect the
elements you will see that because I'm
targeting H1 and P over here
uh if you take a look only H1 and P will
have that special class applied let me
Zoom
hopefully it's not too small
all right so let's let me zoom and let's
scroll so only the H1 and the P tag will
get that uh special cost supplied but
the div and anchor attack because you
are not you don't have any selectors
that applying to this element so that uh
so the special class will not be added
to your to these two elements right so
spelled nose felt will do what is the
most optimized thing it will not just
apply blindly to all the elements
so look again at the CSS output you have
H1 and p uh being increased with this
class special class right so so just let
me demonstrate the case where I'm saying
that if I have class over here say links
um you'll make sure that if you come
over here link starts felt and P dots
felt so relative specificity is still
the same uh is still one up in the class
specificity
uh yup so
so this is scope styling and this is not
just applied to selectors it's also
applies to
um keyframes animation frames so if I
come over here I see keyframes
I'm going to write a zoom animation so
like bear with me
let me type that out transform
scale
three
and maybe 50 time I'm gonna transform uh
scale 0.5 okay I'm gonna apply this uh
Zoom animation for
my header come over here animation and
then I would say Zoom uh five seconds
and finite
so you see that I'm applying an
animation to this H1 for five seconds
with this Zoom
and my point is this Zoom is being
scoped to this component only
uh meaning if I come over here I'm going
to copy this and I want to apply it to
my H1 as well
sorry I should write Style
H1
animation
Style
you'll see that
Zoom is not applied to these elements
right or rather you apply the zoom
animation to these elements but Zoom is
not defined because these keyframes that
you write is only limited available to
your elements over here it will not
pollute any other Zoom animations out
there
so look again at the CSS output you will
see that
animation uh uh although it's minified
but you can still weekly figure out that
this keyframe name has been changed it
will add svelt Dash Zoom special just
it's a hopefully it will be unique
animation name and then you also apply
that to your animation so this animation
that you write over here is scoped
within your component
so you may ask me like yeah that's great
but what if I want my Styles I want my
selectors to be not just apply to the
components over here I want you to apply
to all the Hedge ones out there as well
yes so if you want to do this and you
are very sure that you are going to do
this we have a backdoor hash uh catch
hatch that you can work around right you
can this is like an escape door to use
if you want your if you are sure enough
that you want these selectors to be
available globally and how you would do
it is you will apply your ads a pseudo
selector called global
and wrap it with your H1
so immediately if you take a look at
let's come over here and inspect first
immediately you can see that your
sorry let me expand your H1 immediately
you can see a H1 no longer has that
special class because it's not going to
Target this H1 only right so it does not
need to have that special class anymore
and if you come over to look at the CSS
output H1 is
no longer having that special class so
this H1 will apply will have effect to
all the H1s out there right so if you
look at here you can see immediately
this uh component is also a purple color
as well
right so if I come over here for P tag
global
you see that Bible or like
yeah buy wall will be
um
44 pixels as well so this selector will
become a global selector as well
and lastly you will ask me how about my
animation frames I want to have a zoom
over here
um how what how
um if I want to use zoom out elsewhere
say I want to come over here and say H1
and P to apply the zoom animation
how do I make this animation keyframe to
be globally available well you would
have to prefix it with a global
Dash Global Dash so you have to prefix
your animation name with this prefix and
there you go it will be available
globally right so if you take a look at
the CSS output again your Zoom will be
your keyframes will be named zoom and it
will go everywhere
so there you have it you can CSL Styles
in svelt is scope to your components to
all the elements within your components
only and if you want to escape from this
there's an escape door for you which is
to use a global pseudo selector uh sorry
yeah pseudo selector or you can
uh use a dash Global dash for your
keyframe to make it globally available
let's take a look at how we can add data
to your Spell components
over here I have written as well
component which has a h heading which
says hello world and image tag that has
a logo for the spell logo
what if I want the the contents of the
header to be dynamic I wanted to come
from somewhere that can Define from my
code import from somewhere
and how about I want a dynamic
image URL for my image tag right so that
is when you need to write a script tag
over here
script tags in as well components allows
you to add Logics to your components and
add Logics and data in your component
so I can come over here and Define
content say hello okay let me just copy
instead of typing it out hello world
and I can also have an image URL
um which is this one let me copy it
whoops
and if I so that I can have Dynamic
contents over here Dynamic data and I
want to apply it to the
um to my elements over it below so how
do I do that
well in this result if you want to use a
JavaScript expressions in your HTML you
would use Clear brackets curly brackets
so instead of writing hello world I can
have my curly brackets
and I within a clear brackets I can
write any JavaScript I want so over here
I can write content so any variables
that you define within a script tag as
long as it's at the top level then it
will be available for your script tag
what I meant by top level is that if I
come over here if I Define a function so
I call it function full and I Define
contents over here hello I buy world
then this variables that you define is
actually scoped within a function it's
not at the top level so if I comment
this out then you will say content is
not defined
fair enough so I have to Define it at
the top level
same thing goes for um
your attributes I can come over here
remove this and have a curly bracket so
anything within curly brackets will be
able for me to write JavaScript so I'll
come over here I say image URL paste it
in boom I have a dynamic attribute in
um in in my HTML elements
so a few things about this uh you can
omit if if this is uh this is just a
value for the entire variable will be
able for your attributes you can
actually omit the code sign well it's so
it is useful for some people where maybe
they are writing HTML uh they are used
to writing HTML then you can keep that
code sign and it's also useful for
editors that does not support svelt
um you have that code sign on it makes
the and you can start you can select
your language as HTML and then it will
syntax highlight the syntax highlighting
will still works fine
so that's one thing and secondly if I
instead of defining image here I'm going
to define a source over here you see I'm
typing Source it goes to Source
um this may be a bit more keystrokes
than you type so we create a shorthand
for this if you have case like this you
can actually write this in States so
this curly brackets wrapped with the
source is exactly the same as writing
Source equals source so if you have a
variable that the name of the variable
is exactly the same as your attribute
name then you can have this shorthand
instead
so in summary you can write a curly
brackets and you can have any JavaScript
in there B it's the content or an
attribute and lastly we've seen how you
can write a shorthand for attribute if
your variable name is the same as the
attribute name
we are going to talk about reactivity in
sweld
well reactivity is a previous fancy word
that means that if you update a variable
it should reflects on to the Dom or your
screen
in the previous video we've seen how we
can add Dynamic data Define your data in
the script tag and then you can use them
in your HTML templates and today we're
going to look at how we can update those
data and then get it reflected onto the
screen
so over here I have a count it says I
Define a count variable as 0 and I use I
show it on the screen using the color
brackets count over here
and that's it and I have a buttons and
these buttons what I want to do with
this button is I want when I click on
this button it will increment uh the
count variable so we haven't learned
about events handlers yet but let me
just type it in and show you that how
it's done
we'll talk about them in more details in
the next in the next videos so in this
video just assume that this will add on
click so they increments the count so
how do I increment the variable counts I
can do it like how I would do it in
JavaScript I'll just come over here
account and then I say plus plus this
will increment the count
will it work yes of course it will just
work like this so you come here you
increment count and then it just works
like magic uh do you don't have to do
anything else so what happens over here
what I just felt will analyze the code
redraw the code and it will has some
sort it has a sense of what are the
variables being used in the template and
these variables is called a state a
stitch within your components so this
stage is only for your components so the
state we have over here is called count
and whenever we're trying to update the
state
spelled will knows as well so whenever
you update the state spell will update
the components uh updates elements and
then reflect over here you're using
console right it will reflect it will it
will update this element and so that it
will reflect the latest value of the
count
so now this begs the question how does
swell knows that I'm updating the state
well it tries to analyze the code that
you write but of course it has its
limitation so there's a few things that
svelt looks at and sveld knows that it's
updating the states so here is
here let me list them what they are
right first is assignments so if you try
to sign counts to another variables so
let me remove this for now counts equals
to 10 this is assignments you're
assigning 10 to count as well knows that
this is updating the variable count
right the states count so click C 10
appears on the screen
secondly let me go ahead let me comment
this
secondly you can have update statements
update statements so what are update
statements update statements are like
this this is like updating this is a
unary operator that updates a variable
so this works
uh you can have update assignments so
counts plus equals to two let me comment
this when you click your plus equals to
two so uh so plus plus minus minus plus
equals times equals divides equals uh
times equals all these are update
statements so else knows that you are
updating this variable count
and if count is a state variable then it
knows that it needs to update the
component
so let me comment this and let's take a
look at the third one and it's the last
one updating
or assigning
a property
so say for example instead of having
count I have an object object equals and
then I'm gonna this object has a
property called count so that I don't
have to change too much of my code so
over here in the clear brackets any
JavaScript you can write so I can write
object.con still works
so here if I try to update this property
say I try to update it by say object
count plus plus
then this will still works so how how
spell looks at this statement is that I
see you're updating a property of an
object this object this variable called
object and if this variable is a state
variable right again if this variable is
a state variable in this case it is then
it knows that this is uh when when you
do this you need to update the component
at the components you have to trigger
component updates
same thing goes with object dot counts
equals to 10 let me comment this out
uh if you click it will update as well
so uh updates or assignments on property
will Kickstart that
so anything that falls outside of this
three category will not Kickstart uh the
spell will not know that you're actually
updating
the variable and thus it does not runs
an update cycle
which means that you're still able to
change the variable but then it's just
not reflected on the screen
so let me get you a few examples
so uh
not
an update to svelts
so first is
um again we have an object right so
let's let's take this example if I now
object uh if I assign this object to say
data
and I come over here data.account plus
plus
you you would expect that the object
counts has incremented right you would
expect that
um if I click this you should see but no
it does not why so swell looks at this
yes it's an update statement but this
data is not the states this variable
data over here is just a variable within
this function so it has no idea no idea
that um
this data over here as a state so that's
why it does not
updates the component so you may ask me
like well this is obvious right data is
equal to object yeah this is obvious in
this case but what if you have another
case where data comes from
a parameter or something else right this
is object you pass by reference you
Updates this data you should expect to
see it reflected but how does shroud
knows you you have to trace a lot of
things so swell does not know at all it
is too difficult to know so that's why
if you are updating a variable and this
variable uh is not a state object it
will just look at this statement and if
this statement the object is not a state
this is not a state then it will not
Kickstart an update cycle
just so you know that we have already
updated this data but it's just not
showing on the screen I'm going to come
over here
uh uh have another function called uh do
something else
and I'm going to this time around I'm
going to say object dot uh full equals
to 1.
so calling this function will will tell
us as well that object has updated and
you need to go through and update this
the component so if I have a button over
here
says do something else
something else
right so my the point I want to show you
is this if I click increments a few
times
the data the object the data is pointing
the same object as the object it's the
same reference so uh you you should have
already updated the count the value has
changed balance well does not know that
it needs to update the components so
that's why you don't see this being
reflected over here
but right now if I come over here I have
a do something else and this do
something else uh
assign one to the object right so it
looks over here object.full object
is a state so I'm gonna update my
component so if I click this right now
you see that it reflects immediately
right it tells that object has updated
so it it knows that you need to update
all the elements that relies on the
object it comes over here it looks at
object account huh what's the value
right now it is 11 so I need to update
so you see 11 reflected on the screen
but if you click again this nothing
happens because well just look at this
statement it says data data is a state
no okay I I can't do anything about it
right so this is something you need to
know you you need to know this is the
limitation of the svelt's reactivity
over here
let's take a look at another example
this time round we are going to look at
um methods for example array methods so
calling a method
so if I have
um object as an array instead
okay
and I am going to call up
object dot push okay so here I am going
to say object.lank right so every time
when I call I'm going to push one item
again
and over here I should show the object
length I want to see the length of the
object but if I click click click click
click click nothing happens
I think better you should just
json.string G5 so they can
have a better look at all the items
right so I click click click click click
nothing happens again object the push
it's felt has no idea you're calling a
method whether this method will affect
this object itself no idea at all it
could be just calling a function method
and it does something else like console
long or do something else right it has
no idea that this will affect object
so that's why it does not updates to
everything so you've come again if I
come again to click at this something
else this will do an assignment and a
signing object tells that object has
changed and then hopefully it's felt
will
Updates this right so if I click here
see it's updated because well knows that
okay you are
updating objects so I come over here
object has changed uh Json 25 of object
has changed I reflects it on the screen
so now svelt knows right so
um calling a method or update or you're
assigning a a reference to another
variable and update that variable
has no idea that you are changing the
states so these are the few caveats of
limitation of the svelt's reactivity
lastly let me share you with a tip this
tip hopefully will help you to
understand this whole reactivity better
so over here
um
zwelts will compile all this code into
JavaScript so let's take a look at the
JavaScript outputs come over here we
scroll down you will probably see
um this increment function
right so everything that we've written
is copied over here
right it's nothing special
well nothing special is a problem if you
don't see anything different then which
means that any when you try to change
the variables over here it has no it
does not trigger an update cycle
if we scroll down to look at the do
something else you see that something is
different you you see this dollar dollar
in validate function this function tells
svelts that hey
update this uh uh assign this update
this object and then also click start a
new update cycle so if I uncomment this
you see that in each statements that I
said wool Kickstart an update cycle you
see that they all comes together with a
dollar dollar invalidate a well counts
does not okay that's because we count is
no longer as dates right so if I Define
counts over here
uh you probably will see that and to use
it to show this conversion
you'll see that all of them will have
the dollar dollar in validate
um
function being called alongside with
them because it knows that uh you are
updating the states and this state is
being used in your template so go
updates right so all this has invalided
by the case that I say the caveat the
limitation does not have
so this hopefully this little tips will
help you to better understanding house
wealth reactivity works so try to write
something on the left and take a look at
the right and see where the swell picks
it up at this dollar invalidate function
and you know that whether this will
Kickstart an update cycle
let's talk about event listeners on
svelt
so you probably have seen me done it
before how I add a click event listeners
to increment the buttons but in this
video we are going to dive deeper and
explain all the things you need to know
about adding event listeners
on your elements in your spells
components
so let's take a look at the rebel over
here
I have a H1 and if I want to add event
listeners this is how I would have done
it if I write vanilla JavaScript I would
have a reference to the elements like
the H wand and then I will say add event
listener and then I'll pass in the
events name in this case if I want to
add click I will say click and then I
will pass in the event handler so I will
write event I will have a function
and then I will do something on the
events right I can have a I can Define
this function ahead of time
say on click
so there's two ways I can uh create the
function inline or I can create a
function ahead of time and pass the
reference to the function in this add
event listener method
so the same thing goes in the elements
in your svelte component I will start
with the on directive so on o n and then
a colon defines that I will start to
Define an event listeners so ons and
then I'll pass in the
name of the event so over here I say
click right so I'm going to copy it and
paste it over here so on click
and then I just like how you would pass
values to a attribute you you do a equal
sign and then curly brackets because I
want to pass in a function so curly
brackets and then I'll pass in the
function reference to the function over
here and there you have it so if in
these events I would I do a console log
click
you will see that when I click on the
hitch one there's console out the click
message
so that's
that's how easy it is to add events
listener to elements in your cell
components but one thing we didn't cover
is that if you have to if you do it this
way in your vanilla JavaScript you have
to remember to remove the event listener
when you no longer need this H1 heading
1. but in svelt if you do on click over
here the event listener will be
automatically clean up by its weld
component if this H1 is no longer in the
Dom so one thing it's automatically
clean up so you don't have to worry
about it at all
so uh and then as I mentioned earlier on
we can either pass in a function or a
inline we can inline a function over
here so same thing we can do that in
zvelts as well you can come over here
and create an inline function so
anything within the curly bracket is uh
we can write JavaScript in there so
click again
so I can write an inline function over
here
and you would expect it to work as well
you may be worried about inline
functions if you're using other
Frameworks because you might be
wondering uh would this be creating this
function over and over again uh there's
no such thing as well about having to
running something over again right this
function is not if you are not going to
change this function this function is
not going to be changed then this
function will be just defined once and
attached to this H1 once and that's it
so if you don't believe me come over to
the GS output you can take a look over
here this function click again is
defined over here once and then this is
being passed into somehow pass it into
this uh
uh my uh function right so this function
is being declared defined once you you
don't Define you if you try to search
around there's no law no one is defining
this function over and over again I can
guarantee that to you so no worries
about uh no any performance penalties
whether you're using a function or
inline functions
okay with that settled one thing I want
to cover before we end this video is
about event modifiers so let me come
back with this on click because it's
easier for me to do it over here so a
lot of times we love to do things like
say uh events that prevent defaults
right for example if you have a form and
then you add on-summit event and you
want to prevent default prevent the
default behavior of that Summit so that
you can make some validation and then
cancel the requests things like that you
you often come in case where you have to
write events of preventive for if you
have some events like drag and drop you
always needs to do like prevent defaults
then one great tip for you you don't
have to do it you don't have to like
come over here and then for each of the
click you have to write it here you can
come over here and add event modifiers
basically you do this
uh pipe and then you pass in a modifier
so a prevent default modifier will
automatically add the event prevent
default for your uh event handler
so uh so you can have event prevent
default so what else besides that you
can have stop propagation so that is
application that is also another
modifier that does the events.stop
propagation for you by default
so for example if you have a nested
element so for example here I have a
parent and then I have a child I can
come over here on click and stop
propagation
and come over here on click on parent
you would assume that uh
oops
so you assume that this will not
propagate the events up to the parents
to that will not propagate and Bubble Up
the events to the parents right so this
is uh you write stop propagation is the
same thing as coming over here and have
events and write event.stop propagation
it's the same thing so you can use even
modifiers or you write it your own it's
up to you
so for people who are familiar with ad
event listeners you know that the third
parameter over here is that you can add
some options to the events listener
right let me pull up the
mdn documentation when you say add event
listeners when you scroll down there's
options and options you can pass things
like uh capture once passive so how do
you pass these things to your event
listeners because you can't really
control it over here right you you have
no way to to get involved with the
advantages so you use event modifiers as
well so for example if you want to have
a capture event you want to register
event at the capture phase you can write
on clicks pipe capture
now if you click on uh when you click on
a child you see that the parent is on a
capture face so parent will be called
first before child
and once about once you can do that as
well you can have a pipe and then once
so now the parent will only
register once so it was you it will be
using these options once uh as as
defined over here in the add event
listeners same thing with passive so
passive is a you have to pass in a
Boolean so true or false has different
meaning in it right so if you want true
you will pass it as passive and you want
false you will pass in as non-passive so
it really depends on which one do you
want
okay and then uh
so you can see over here I
um I can pipe as many
[Music]
um
many event modifiers as I want and the
order does not matter I can type in
all the event modifiers as I want right
so the order does not matter and one
last event modifier I want to share with
you is self
so um if I come over here and say self
so this is not in the event listeners
over here
but what self does is hopefully it's
self-explanatory self means that if your
event listeners uh if the events or
Target is self only it will trigger
right so meaning in your event handler
you're checking event.target
equals to the current element and if if
it's true then you will do something
right if it's true then you do something
so if I do self then if I come over here
and click apparent you'll see that log
out parents but if I click on the child
then yeah the current the target is the
child and it propagates to the parent so
it's the target is not the parent so you
don't see console log parents when you
click on the child
so prevent default stop propagation and
then we have capture then you have
passive and non-passive you have once
and then you have self seven modifiers
that you can use if you can't remember
all this don't worry you can always find
them in the spell.dev docs they will
they are all listed over there
events modifiers
yeah all of them all seven of them are
listed over here you can take a read
we are going to talk about one big
important features in svelt and it's one
of those powerful thing that sets vaults
apart with everyone else
which is the reactive declarations or
statements well so what is reactive
declarations and statements
we shall see
but let's start with this example first
so over here
I've created a component that has
accounts variable initialized with one
and I have two buttons which has
decrements and increments so whenever I
click I will increment all decrements
the value of counts and at the same time
I have these Expressions called counts
times two
this this uh anything within a curling
brackets can be a JavaScript expression
so over here I'm going to say counts
times two over here so I can see this is
always two times of the count
so this is okay right uh nothing's wrong
with this but what if I have another
button over here
and
uh but I'm gonna call it do something
because I'm not sure what I'm gonna do
yet because they click me
okay and in this function I'm gonna
Define this
uh okay now I know what I'm gonna do I
want to console out
the value two times of counts
so I probably have to come over here and
say counts times two again and so that
every time when I click I see the value
two times of account is printed in the
console
so nothing's wrong with this
because this example is simple but what
if you have a more complicated example
where you have a super complex formula
over here and you and you want to assess
this variable
adopt at a lot of places well at that
point of time you probably would realize
that you can't calculate this on the fly
anymore and you want to come here and
Define this variable called double
so initialize with counts times two
so I'm going to show double over here
but and then I can use this as well
but as soon as you do this you realize
that
um so at first it's 2 is correct but if
you increment it's still two because you
got to update this variable double so
you come over here and look at all the
places that you does you do counts plus
plus that you all count minus minus
anywhere that you make changes to counts
you have to say updates the value of
double as well and this does not scale
uh it works but this does not scale
because what if you have another button
uh
I'm gonna call uh
e scale because it's just not scale all
right
okay I'm gonna say multi multiply
all right so I come over here as a
function called multiply
and what I have what it does is that it
counts equals counts times count
always multiply by yourself
um so now again
uh I need this is our single again
because I need to come over here and do
double equals counts times two I need to
remember to do that every time I change
I add a way to updates
um
count
so this is error prone every time your
updates counts you need to remember to
update double and this is this does not
scale so what should we do well this is
where reactive declarations
comes in
so uh this
statements itself
so a declaration is a type of statement
and this statement itself is a
declaration statement
because over here we actually declare
this variable double
so reactive declaration is a
it's a declaration statement that
instead of use called let's double equal
something it starts with a label dollar
so this dollar label over here
um if you if you have so you use a
dollar label over here and you write
double equals counts times two right so
you replace the
good old declaration and you with this
reactive declaration
so what is this dollar label thing well
this is actually a label statement
um used usually with loops uh for Loops
while Loops where you can label a loop
and then you can break it right if you
have a multiple nested loops and you
want to break
the loop at the second level right you
normally break can only break the
nearest level but you want to break like
some first level second level or the
level of Loops then you have to label
them and then you break with the label
so this is actually a label and if you
know if you know that this is a label
which means that actually I need to
Define this variable double
right uh but then you don't have to you
don't have to come over here and let's
double right in normal JavaScript you
you would have to do this but in results
what we do is that we call this reactive
declarations and we will inject the lens
double for you so you don't have to
declare it or you don't have to define
it
so you write this and then there's this
magic of reactive declaration what this
does is that it will always execute
every time when you call when you change
count so which means I can save my time
not to do this uh my code is cleaner as
well I don't have to come over here and
manage the double whenever I change
count and you can see this double value
changes
instantly when I change counts so this
this is reactive declaration
so let's talk a bit more on this
reactive declaration so you've seen like
why we need this because every time when
you change a variable you have to
manually pin stickingly updates a new
value that derives from this right
so you see the why but let's talk about
like how it works in more detail so uh
over here the title I say reactive
declarations and statements so this does
this is not just declarations this can
be any statements so any statements that
start with a dollar colon will be a
reactive statement so I can come over
here and say console log count this is
again a reactive statement so reactive
statement reactive calculations the only
difference is that
the creation is to declare something and
if you declare something means that you
don't have to Define let's double
yourself right it's being declared
together with these statements
um and sometimes of course you you uh if
you write this it does not uh it is
still okay right you can still Define it
but the point is you can you can omit it
if you want to
so
um so these two okay
reactive declarations and reactive
statements and how does that work how do
they work how that works is that
actually they will actually look at what
I call a dependency after statements so
what dependency means is that if
something so these statements this
reactive decorations or statements
depends on something and what is that
something that something is variables
States variables that is
um that is being used within this
statement itself okay so what are they
so for declarations it will always be
the all the variables on the right of
the equal sign
right it depends on these variables to
to to update the value of double right
so anytime when you see an assignments
in a reactive statements on equations
the one on the right are the
dependencies so this double depends on
count right two is not available so for
statements you don't have assignments
then all any variables that you can see
here are the dependencies right so if I
say count uh so over here this example
will have two the console it depends on
console and depends on count
over here it depends on count
so I prepared some more examples over
here
let's let's see them
so full name
first name last name so this is a
decoration so all assignments so
whatever on the right which is the first
name
on the last name is the dependent so
anytime first name or last name change
this whole thing will be evaluated
but here for us this case will be a b
and c any time A or B or C changes this
whole statement will be evaluated
but here is num1 num2 and calculate
uh because it's still the assignment and
over here this is statement so whatever
is account if this is the same example
so I'm gonna remove this
right copy this down over here
right over here
um do something
A and B so anytime any of these changes
um you will have to re-evaluate these
statements right so when we reevaluate
say in our previous example we
re-evaluate meaning we'll re uh re
re-evalid this which means that we're
gonna reassign the new value to the
double the variable double
so why this is important well this is
important because if say for example if
you have do something
do something
A and B
but you do something with say console
log a b and c
you do something at A and B and C
um
then you have to know that anytime C
changes it will not really you will not
call this function at all because it
only depends on here right so if you
define this only do something A and B A
or B or do something changes we'll call
this function again but anything that is
being used over here C is from outside
like if you have counts out from here or
you
come up with a new variable D over here
whenever they okay this can't change
right but any variables that you refer
from this function outside of this
function changes uh this will not call
meaning it will not call this function
right so that is one thing that you need
to take note of
so second thing that you need to take
are notes off is that
um when this is being evaluated right
one this is being called is important
because when this is being inverted
depends well decides when this the value
of the double being updated so if you
come over here and I say console log
double
uh I'm just gonna add this so that you
know that it's double
I come over here and you run this and I
click increments
you'll see that this value always lags
behind of what what it shows in fact
this is actually the previous value that
you see right if I click scale you see
that this uh wait now it's 18 when I
click it shows 18. this is the previous
value you have an update double right
you tell me that whenever you change you
will you will update this value of
double yes but not immediately it's not
immediately it's asynchronous it's
asynchronous it's it does not happens
immediately but it happens right right
before svelt update the Dom right before
right so uh right before it Updates this
double over here the the it evaluates
this okay it gets a new value of double
now it's 20 and then it shows on the
screen
but over here
it's not yet not there yet so when you
come over here you change counts see
that the double uh the value of double
is still the old value
so this is important because uh spell
can't go all everywhere else whenever
you change counter and then increment a
double immediately uh there's a lot of
work so it only happens right right
before
this is felt updates are done so this
note number two that you need to take
note of
then uh the third thing that I want to
talk about is the order of
um
the reactive statements right so I can
come over here
um I can come over here and then do
something like uh console log double
so let's let's practice what this
statement depends on depends on Console
depends on double right so anytime
console a double changes uh this
statement will be re-evaluated
so uh you expect that double
uh so so over here every time doubles
changes your this all right so you
expect this will shows the latest value
of double well in fact it does right so
now it's four you re-evaluate this right
before it updates the Dom okay uh double
is now four and then you console log
four
but what happens if you write this right
before the when you evaluate double
or if you write it right before
uh civil actually will reorders it for
you
so what it means is that spell actually
will look through all the reactive
statements and reorder them reorder them
based on the dependency order
so uh in this case double depends on
counts right this statement says double
depends on count
this statement says it depends on double
right nothing not it does not create
anything but it depends on double and if
I come over here and have another
variable say quadruple
uh equals to double times two so this
quadruple depends on double
so you would expect that a okay you
can't see quadruple okay let me let me
show it here quadruple
right so
um
whoops
yes quadruple is written before the
double equals to count times 2 but
the dependency has order itself so you
have to reorder as well not you have to
but as well will reorder this for you
we'll say Okay doubles depends on count
so this but then quadruple depends on
double so this has to come after
all right and then this console depends
on double so this has to come after so
if you have cases like this you have
cases where
two things that depends on double then
the initial ordering does matter right
the order does matter is just that if
there but then if there's dependency
other than that counts in priority
higher priority than your initial
ordering so for example if I come over
here console log uh
double two equals to double
right these two statements both this
step both the both of these two
statements depends on double
but the initial order does matter so if
you write double two first then C double
two and double but if you come if you
reorder this reshuffle come over here
you'll see double first before double
two right the order does matter but if
the dependency but the dependency order
comes first
so that is notes number three the
dependency uh the order of reactivity
reactor the order of your reactive
statement
will be reordered based on the
dependency order
um so hopefully this uh these three
notes the dependency order
and then the what is the dependency and
the
sorry let me let me and then they will
be evaluated since asynchronously these
three things if you remember it
carefully
you will you can avoid a lot of a lot of
pitfalls involved with reactive
statements or declarations
uh lastly a few other things that
probably you also need to take note of
is that reactive decorations or
statements only happens at the top level
so only here if you come over here and
they find something like this uh double
equals counts plus two
or something it has no effect outside of
the top level it already shows you this
warning right so
yeah that is something else a small
thing that you need to take note of
to talk about reactivity as well as we
talk about reactive declarations and
statements and I think it's time for us
to talk about the tick function so what
is Tick well tick is a built-in function
from zwelt that returns a promise and
This Promise will be resolved when the
update is finished right right after as
soon as any updates any pending updates
that is already applied to the Dom then
the tick the promise returns from a tick
function will be resolved
um enough with this definition let's
take a look exactly what it is so over
here I've prepared an example over here
you can see that this is what we left
off from the reactive declarations uh
video If you haven't watched that links
in the description
so over here we talk about uh if you
remember I talk about reactive
declarations are evaluated
asynchronously they are evaluated right
before as well applied the changes to
the Dom right right before so over here
if you have an increment uh so it right
over here you have a double reactive
double that is always two types of
counts but in this function increments
when you increments count double is not
this statement is not evaluated
immediately right so over here if you
console out double you will still get
the old value
so if I click over here you can still
see that it's it's showing four but it's
already updated to 6.
so
how do we make sure if we really want to
get the uh the value of double uh to be
the latest value what should we do over
here
well we talk about tick function right
so obviously we're going to use the tick
so you're going to import tick from
sveld
and tick is a function that returns a
promise
so you can use dot then when the promise
resolved
and when it resolves which means that
all the changes that's going to be made
uh will has already been applied to the
Dom meaning Dom changes has been applied
meaning this double has been already
updated to the latest value right this
this statement will be evaluated right
before you apply a changer so when
changes has already applied definitely
double is already two times of the
latest variable account so come over
here and I move this double in
all right so this I'm gonna say after a
tick
and just for comparison I will come over
here and say before tick
so let me click on the button you can
see that before tickle gets to
because uh this is a
synchronously and then at and then when
swell decides to update because there's
a changes value decides to updates the
Dom and you evaluate this double and
then you apply all the changes you see
two times two equals to four on the
screen and then this promise returns
from tick will be resolved which you can
then console this value out so this
although it look it seems that it's
coming right after another but it's
actually a run a little bit longer than
that right so if I come over here if I
say uh if you're familiar with
asynchronous and synchronous you should
know that this happens
asynchronously so it's way after even if
I have put before here you should see
that before comes uh comes way earlier
before the aftertick
so
um this so tick function it's it returns
a promise and a lot sometimes I I I
don't really like to use the then this
is just my personal preference sometimes
I like to change the function to be a
asynchronous function so that I can
await the tick
so I come over here and with the tick
and then console
console this out over here so this this
is a Sim this is the same behavior as
what we've seen before instead of um
it's just that I can use async awaits so
that
um it's less nested I would say like I
because I don't have to do the Callback
function in the dot dance it feels like
it's nested in I since it's one straight
line I can I can wait for this promise
to resolve and then do my thing over
here so it's the same thing it's just my
personal preference of writing it
so what are the use cases of this tick
function
well I prepared another example that
um you can use this tick function as
well so I'm going to import this
component called input dot spelled
so let me come comment out everything
and just show the inputs
so this input I uh we've learned how you
can add event business right so I add an
input event listeners so every time when
something has changed I will update the
value to be whatever the value of the
input to uppercase so right now I have
my so just to show that show the effect
I comment all the two uppercase when I
type anything
the value will this the value because
we're passing in the value in so the
value will be whatever I'm typing in
right so I don't have my caps lock on uh
but I when I type something you see that
it will automatically converts to
uppercase because
the two uppercase will convert the value
and then you get the uppercase value of
the value and you pass it in and then
you update the input
however this way of updating the value
of the input because the input the value
of the input originally is lowercase and
then you you change you assign it to a
value and then you've you have to use
this variable value to assign the input
value right you're calling
uh internally it's calling input of
value to this new value that we
evaluated and this value is not the same
as whatever it's internally in the input
so what happens is that it will clear
whatever state you have within the input
uh it's a bit
I'm not sure I will describe it well
enough but what what it means is that if
I come over here I type something and I
try to highlight something
and when I try to highlight something
there's an internal state of this input
so if at this point of time I try to
change the input value programmatically
right if I do don't do anything and I
change the value programmatically
um we'll lose the state you will create
all the text and then replace with the
new text and what happens is that right
now if I manually type some uh let's
let's come over here I have a button
right just to demonstrate this
on click
if I come over here and say
value equals to XXX
all right so I type something I
highlight something and as soon as I
click
oh okay I think we need to set some time
out over here then
I want to make sure that we are still in
focus of the input so when I click I
have uh
five sec
three seconds
before it's being triggered
all right so I try to type something
highlight something okay I can highlight
something and as you see when the value
updated the cursor will shift all the
way to the right right because you
change every you change the text right
there's no way to restore the cursor
position it so even if you come over
here
and you do something like
uh value equals to Value 2 uppercase
because just now we change it to xXx
right definitely there's no way to
restore the cursor but if you come over
here type something all lower caps and
highlight something
and then I change everything to
uppercase you see that my cursor jumps
all the way to the back so that that's
annoying actually if you if you don't if
you haven't realized it yet that this is
actually very annoying especially when
you implement this updating the value
within a input Handler
meaning if you come over here
you try and type something
and I highlight something and I suppose
to press on Q right now
uh it jumps all the way to the back and
I type Q again you'll see that it it
it's typing at the end of it instead of
like it where my cursor was supposed to
be
so how should I solve this well I can
save the selection start and end of
where the I can get the selection start
and end from the input so I can come
over here and say let's selection start
go to this
input.selection start
and get the end of as well
and one once I change this value I want
to restore the selection right input a
selection starts equals to selection
start
so once I update I want to restore it
so let's try and see
so if I type okay right now I'm going to
type Q I'm going to press q q
but it still jumps all the way to the
back
well at this point of time you probably
should realize that yes uh you change
the value but then the updates happens
far later on right asynchronously as as
we have this scene if you want to have a
reactive statements and you console out
immediately it does not update similarly
because you haven't updated the Dom so
any changes right now happening right
now uh the Dom hasn't updated yet so we
haven't really actually called
input.value Equals value internally
within swelt yet
so the only way to wait for it to happen
before we restore back the selection is
to
use tick
so we come over here import tick
and I'm gonna come over here and I want
to wait for the tick so I can't use a
weight unless I make my function async
so come over async function and wait for
the tick so wait for it to update the
thumb so internally this will be called
to update of down value
and then we restore the input selection
and start and end
so let's see how what's the end result
of this right so I'm going to type ASDF
ASDF okay okay I think I'm gonna
type A so that it's more obvious I'm
going to highlight this 3A I'm gonna
press Q right now Q you see the cursor
is still maintained at where I was and
press q q
and that it is that is what we are
achieving so tick allows you to wait for
Dom updates to be applied so it returns
a promise so that when this promise
resolved all the Dom updates has been
applied and then you can do something
with it so you can
um
check any value of the relatively
declared variables or you can make some
changes to the Dom
or you get any updated value of the Dom
right you can probably instead of
getting selection of the inputs you can
maybe right before you make changes
check the scroll position of your
elements and then you add new items
updates and wait for that update to
happen without all the updates to finish
before you say restore the scroll
position or something like that right so
tick will be very useful in that sense
I'm going to talk about components and
props
you probably have seen me done this you
have seen me adding a component into
another's wealth components and I
promised you back then that I would make
another video to talk about this in more
detail so the time is now I'm going to
talk about components in more detail
so here I have a component called
app.velt and I have another component
called component of sprouts bad naming
but bear with me so here
um to use these components what I do is
I need to import from this file right
this Rebel allows us to create multiple
this attempts and this is actually
multiple
files in your file system if you are
developing locally so each of them are
named dot swelt so you have to import it
to use in your components so you can
come here and say Imports component from
component
that is welt svelte
so uh one thing to take note is that
you're importing from a default export
so this is one key thing about uh file
is that your component itself will be a
class and then it will be an export
default so you import it from export
from the default exports and to use it
you use it like any other elements
you're getting buckets and there's a
component so a different one thing to
differentiate between what is a
component and what is an element because
you could write something like this and
how does felt knows that what whether
this is a component or an element so the
differentiator is that component
starts with a capital letter and element
starts with a lowercase letter
uh so I I believe this is quite uh
prevalent in other Frameworks as well
anything that starts with a capital
letter is always a component anything
that starts with a lowercase will be a
elements
so this is how I use my components and
I'm not sure you're paying attention to
me speaking or you actually are looking
at the screen because at the screen
right now you already see a component
right this is the components that I've
written over here if I change it uh say
hello hello
then yeah you can see that over here
reflected over here this is the
components I can create multiple
components if I want they will be
created this way
and there's no limit in
um your components where how many top
levels elements right there's no such
thing right you can have multiple divs
as you want come over here I have like
two divs three divs okay I think I don't
think we can see a difference let's say
one two and three you can have men as
many divs as many top level elements in
one component as you want there's no
limit at all what's what's the point
right so here you have components four
components and create this
then having a components you know uh
element in your component having a
nested components in your components is
not that fun at all if you just show
like content that it has right you can
have Logics in your component itself
but what's great about what's what's
more interesting is what if you can pass
the data
from
I would call this the parent components
to the child components right I call
this a parent and this component is a
child because parents bear a child right
so any anything that is used inside is
called considered a child component by
this current component which is called a
parent so you can pass data from parent
to the child
how pass it by what I we called it a
props
so same thing as how you will pass
things uh attributes to elements you can
pass attributes to components and we
call it props right we don't call it
attribute to call it props so you can
pass something like over here I have
name right so I can pass name to
the component as props
and same thing that you need to remember
as well is that same as how you can
write attribute shorthand you can have
shorthand for props as well so this and
this are the same if the if the
attribute name and the value variable
name is the same you can do it this way
so how do I receive it within the child
component well um of course probably I
have something like a variable right I
need to receive it into a variable and
how do I make this variable a props well
you
use exports so use export let's name
then this way
um
this way what you define is this name is
the props so you have to follow exactly
the name itself right if you come over
here and say Nami
then this is not the props that you're
passing in you're passing in something
else so you can only part you need to
make sure that this name and this is the
same
okay
and once I do that I can come over here
and use it right I'm gonna say component
uh I'm gonna put it a div so that you
can see
clearly right so as a div components and
a name so I pass wool for the first two
cases and over here I didn't pass it
because I call it Nami Nami something
else I don't know what it is and this I
didn't pass anything so I get undefined
as well right it does not have to be a a
variable you can pass it with like a
string
right this sorry this works as well
so what if the case that you didn't pass
but you want to have a default value so
anytime when you don't pass something
but I want to show a default value what
do I do
well it's like defining a variable like
right now you are defining a variable
what do you do to provide default value
for the variable before you do some
changes well you
said something right so you come over
here and say uh default uh say svelt is
amazing
then this will be the default value and
as you can see over here uh the last
component does not pass in anything
that's not pass in name then the name
will have the default value which is
spelled is amazing it is amazing it
isn't if it feels amazing click like on
the video
so we've seen how you can create props
you can have default value of the props
and one thing I want to show you is a
lot of times we are lazy uh we are lazy
so we like to do things lazily so what
if I have over here is this component I
have two props like spot let name and
then export let email
so can I have default email address as
well blah.com
and because I say email right
and I'm lazy in a sense where uh what if
I have an object
that has name
uh little and email
.com this is this is not a real email
don't email me to this address so what
if you have this object and you want to
um
add it to your components you would have
to basically come over here and say
object.name
equals to object dot email right this is
this is what you have learned so far
this is what you have to do
but humans are lazy and lazy humans come
up with lazy ways to work around things
um
if you imagine if you remember uh cases
where you if you have no object and you
want to copy some of the properties to a
Target object you can spread the values
the properties of the object over right
so if I have a Target
and I want to copy all everything from
here I can do a
spread
all right so same thing goes same idea
goes I can come over here and copy this
because I'm going to prove it it's the
same thing I can come copy this and I'm
gonna paste it in over here so this
spreads the object into the props and as
you can see uh let me comment this out
this is the ones that we already spread
the objects into the props and so it has
name and email so it's spread and you
get name and email over here
of course you don't I think this is a
bit ugly to me it's hurting my eyes
usually I write it within just one line
so that it looks concise and compact
so I can come over here and write this
you can spread props so what we have
learned so far components Imports
components default exports
you write props
how do you create props exports syntax
allows you to create props and then
default props as long as you provide
Define the problems with a value that is
the default value if the props is not
passed in and we have seen how we can be
lazy spread the props into the
components using this syntax where you
spread like an object right like how you
spread an object you come over here and
do the same thing three dots and it's
spread it
so we have learned about how we can use
Elements by passing in attributes as
well as how to add event listeners to
elements and in the last video we
learned about components we learned
about components can be used almost as
the same way as elements and you can
pass in props almost as the same way as
you can pass in attributes to the
elements so can an component
attach any event listeners
well we'll take a look in this video so
over here I prepared an example I've
created a component called profile uh
and I pass in props just like how a
processing attributes I pass in props I
have a name called Lee how which is me
and then I have a status which is a
status that I'm currently learning
svelte okay so in my components I
declared two props name and Status
that's how I pass that in
and I also have this button called uh
skill points it's a local state skill
point and I have
um
buttons that I can increment or
decrement my skill points
so if I click you can see my skill point
is increasing or decreasing not quite
sure what to do with the skill points
yet but uh that that is how this
component works so if I want to know
when my skill point has changed
what should I do if I want to know my
skill point whether my when my skill
point has changed from this parent
component from the app.spel what should
I do
well
um one way is I can firstly I of course
I need a callback function so that I can
do something when that change so I can
define a
on skill point change
and hopefully this is some sort of event
right maybe like skill points the new
skill point
and why I need to what I want to do over
here is just to console it out so that
you can see that it's it's being called
so I'm gonna say on skill point change
and then my new skill points so how do I
pass this function into my components
well you can pass a
anything through the attribute through
the props so it could be a string it
could be numbers and it could be
functions as well no one says that you
can't pass in a function as a props so
you can come over here and say maybe on
skill point change
and pass in my props
and because this the props name and the
variable name is the same I can actually
use this prop shorthand or the attribute
shorthand
so of course I need to do Define these
props or else I can't receive it so I'm
going to find this on skill point change
and I need to use it as well I need to
come over here and call this with the
updated skill point value
so come here and say skill point
and I need to do it for my skill point
over here as well
okay looks good so uh let's come over
here and take a look at the console
so if I change something you can see
that this function is being called right
that that's good
because if you take a look at this you
say okay this has to be called every
time skill point uh exchange actually we
can use a reactive statements right no
one says you can't do that so I can come
over here and say uh on skill point
change skill point so this statement
let's take a look what when will this be
called whenever on skill point has
changed or whenever skill point has
changed exactly what we want so we can
come over here
click click click click you can see that
this is being logged out whenever any of
it has changed
okay so far so good
yep but what if I come over here okay
I'm not sure whether you like the butts
but but is how I segue into uh what I
want to share next so if I come over
here I have another profile
um
call
me again and learning
component events
okay but this time now for this profile
I don't want to know about when the
skill points change right I can know and
I can just don't care about it right um
not all the events I want not everything
I want to know right so for this case I
don't want to know but then because we
kind of assumed that on skill point
change is a function because we call it
no matter what then uh that that is a
problem to us and we kind of have to so
the way to work around this is we have
to check uh
if type of is a function
then we call this right so so there's
actually there's two ways uh I jump the
gun too fast but actually there's two
ways to work around this right first is
every time we want to call this on skew
Point change you check whether it's a
function if it's a function then you
call it another way that uh you if you
assume that it's either always a
function or it's just that not being
passed in then you can have a default
function over here default value for
on-screw Point change right so if it's
not passing then it's always this
fallback function and if it's defined
then yeah you can call so if you know
that it's either passing and always be a
function or not passed in then you can
do it this way
so two ways that you can do right
every time when you call you check if
it's a function or secondly it's you
provide default a fallback function so
that if it's not provided you can you
can still call it you you can still you
it's fall back to a function so it can
always trust that it's always a function
um yeah so nothing wrong about this
but as you can see we kind of couple
strongly about assumptions of skill
points change has to be a function right
or else we have to provide a fallback
function
um but if you take a look at
um buttons and all the Dom elements you
have
usually it's it's very common that uh
the function the events itself is
optional right it's not all buttons you
have to listen to on click on or not all
inputs you have to listen to on input on
change on anything right so it's very
common that you listen to events only
you I when only you are interested in so
that should be the same case as a events
from uh components right it shouldn't be
like this where you you have to always
assume that within the function a
component itself always assume that it's
always there and you can always call it
as a function you should
it's it's more of the other case where
you should assume that any events that
you're going to come out uh it should be
optional to be received on the other end
so I would
kind of prefer if you check whether this
is being
defined and only then you call it
um of course there's an even better way
to do it which is to use a component
event so let's take a look at how you
can uh
dispersion component event so before we
dive into how we can take a look at how
it should be written instead from from
the outside right instead of passing it
as a function
right it should be more like an event
listener so instead which we can listen
to events so I'm going to come on event
and pass in the name of the event so I
can come up with any name but now I'm
going to call it as a skill point change
as the name of the event and I can pass
in this function instead right this is
to handle when this event has it's been
this patch it's over here I'm not going
to listen to so I'm not passing it in
and here I can so it's it's an optional
thing right when whenever you do this
you know that it's kind of an optional
it's like event listeners for your
elements
so how do I make my component to able to
dispatch this event
I can come over here and I need
something called uh event dispatcher so
I'm going to come here and I'm import
create event dispatcher
oops
and this uh this is a function that
creates the event dispatcher so let me
call this function so this function
itself the create event dispatcher has
to be called during a component
initialization meaning it has to be
called at the top level when we uh so
this all these are going to be called
during the component initialization
right so you have to call it at the top
level you can't create event dispatcher
within say within a function right that
does not work we're trying to call it
here and you try to decrement you'll see
that your through an error it says that
function called outside component
initialization
well why is this so well this is because
uh when I call when during component
initialization
svelt's uh knows that okay I want to
initialize this component this instance
of this component so I it turns it's
it's remember okay this is the component
I'm setting up and then
Whenever I Call this function so this
function itself uh you import directly
from spell right so this function itself
has uh itself
kind of like stateless but at the same
time it's it's when you call this it
will reach your asphalt hey what is the
component that you are currently
initialization initializing right when
because this function is not coming from
anywhere within this component right
it's not some some function that pass it
in so the this function within this
function itself has asked well okay what
is the component you are initialization
in initializing and then you know okay
this function okay I'm gonna register
I'm gonna get something from this
component right so you get the dispatch
function you get what is the component
that was initializing at that point of
time so you get this dispatch function
and then you can dispatch events so
dispatch events is like how you would
dispatch an event on your elements right
element can dispatch an event so so that
anyone from outside can listen to it so
get this dispatch function
and I'm come over here
so whenever skill points change I want
to dispatch a new event so there's two
parameters first is the
um first is the
the name of the event so I come over
here I I kind of assume that I'm gonna
listen to this event called skill point
change right so I copy this and I'm
gonna paste this in so this is the name
of the event
and then uh Skip and then the next thing
is the I'm going to pass the data
whatever I'm gonna call with uh with the
events so uh okay so I don't need this
on skill point change anymore and then
remove this
so let's take a look over here
over here when I change something okay
you can't see it because this is no
longer the new skill point if uh because
okay so if you inspect this you could
see that this is actually the event
right and uh okay I think as always I
told you don't take my word for it so
you should always inspect element and
take a look
so go to combo console and clear
everything and I'm gonna click over here
you see that this is a custom event an
event has this property called detail
and detail is the data that we pass
along with this event
so I'm gonna close this and I'm gonna
say events.detail which is the data that
I pass in from here so this is the event
detail you can pass in anything I can
pass in a string a number an object an
array and anything that you can think of
so events are detail over here and now
if I decrement you can see that it still
works you can have on skill point change
and
print out the skill point right the
current skill points so this is a way
that you can't dispatch an event from a
component by creating event dispatcher
and then dispatch the event
and as you can see how we work through
then and decides that okay we need to
use an event dispatcher is realize that
this way when we do it this way it kind
of decouples uh from the user
perspective the user of this component
versus the internal of the components
right you right now it decouples where
you don't assume that this event is
always being listened by the user it's
not always being passed in you don't
have to always pass in a function we can
always dispatch an event and anyone can
listen or not it's optional right so you
see that both we can click on both
both components skill points we can
change the both skill points but it does
not throw an error if I'm not listening
to it it's optional so it's some at some
sense it's it's being decoupled already
whether you're listening or you are
dispatching it's it's the couple
so that's why we and so to use this
events listener you add event listener
as the same way as adding event
listeners to your elements add on skill
point change
uh you pass in a function just like how
you would and you can pass in data for
your event so this will be the data if
you don't pass anything it will be
undefined don't take my word for it it
should be undefined in the event the
detail and let's see oh wait what
okay so right now if you look at this
statement this patch uh what what are
the dependence right the dispatch all
the skill points uh this is a string so
this if this change will so right now if
I change skill point it will not
re-evaluate these statements so uh one
workaround is I can add I can call this
skill point
and then comma so that this whole
statement will be evaluated when skill
point or dispatch has changed so if I
come over here and then you can see that
right now it's okay that's why I told
you not to take my word for it it's now
instead of undefined if you don't pass
anything it's now
all right so you your event or detail
will be now
um and if I change it back now you will
see that
uh it's it's it's the value again so
that's that's how you create uh events
for your components
in the last video we talked about
component events and in this video we
are still going to talk about component
events because there's one thing that I
didn't mention about in the last video
uh which is I feel it's important and
you should know about about component
events which is about event bubbling so
event bubbling it's it's not a concept
in com it's a concept in elements events
so if you have a element like this over
here as you can see when I click on any
of the buttons element button one or two
and the events will bubble up to the
parent so if I even if I click on the
buttons and I don't uh the events will
be bubble up meaning uh any of the
parents that listen to the event should
be able to uh listen it should be able
to trigger the events Handler even it's
uh even if it's on a parent level right
so this button when I click
um if it has an event listeners it will
be handled and then it will bubble up if
it's not if it's not prevent uh
propagation then it will propagate up
right it will go to the parents which is
this div and then go to this parent and
then in this parent you have the event
business uh registered you you are
listening to on click so the on element
button click event listener will be
triggered and therefore you can console
out the value of course it's still the
target the events Target the the
elements that is this uh The Click is on
is this two buttons so if I
um check the data set dot value which is
the data value attribute over here I can
get button one or two right so if I
click on the element button one or
button two you can see that this is
being triggered and you can get button
one or button two
so this is uh events bubbling in Dom
elements but what about components if I
have an app I have this parent component
um listening to this component button
click right so if I look into parents I
have another component called child
looking at child I have another
component called grandchild and in the
grandchild I have another component
which is okay no it does not have so it
has two buttons same two buttons I have
button one and button two uh wait hold
on button two does not have one click
let me add it in
so button one and button two have two on
click event listeners and over here I am
dispatching component events I I use
create event dispension to create a
dispatch and I dispatch component button
click event
and I pass in the events uh I pass in
data like pattern one and button two so
that
the component uh when I listens to it I
can get event or detail and will access
the button one or button two
so will this event when I click wallet
bubble up to the parent which is this
child component to its parent which is
this parent component and then to its
parents again which is this
app.component and receives it from here
and the name is the same and then you
get handle over this on component button
click
callback function Handler functions does
it will it work well let's see let's
click
well it does not work okay that that's
why we make this video because I'm going
to tell you how you can make it work
so um
so first and foremost I have to tell you
unfortunately
component events does not bubble meaning
it does not go one left it does not go
through all its parents and then bubble
up all the way to this app.spel right it
does not bubble all the way to this uh
parent component over here so what I can
do instead is a workaround sadly it's a
workaround so I have to come over here
on ciao I have
um I'm dispatching an event from this
grandchild right so I can definitely
listen to this event called a component
button click
I can listen to this so I can handle it
over here and come over here and create
this event
so if I come up here and I say in ciao
does felt and take a look at event dot
detail
hopefully this works if I click yes you
can still see button one button two
right so if I once
to Bubble Up to the parents
like bubble it does not bubble right so
if I want my parents which is in this
parent that's felt to able to listen to
this event I'll have to dispatch this
event myself so I have to come over here
Imports create event dispatcher
whoops
and I am going to create this dispatch
function
oops
and then I'm going to dispatch this
event okay so I'm going to dispatch I'm
going to use the same name so that the
parent can listen to the same name as
well and I can come over here and pass
in the same data which is the event or
detail all right so we're going to come
over here paste it in uh comment okay I
can still leave it in
so with this in place I can come over
here to my parents and listen to it I
can listen to this component button
click
event
console
in parent dot spell
and events.dto right let's see so I
click yes my child receives it and then
I dispatch the same
it's not the same event per se but I
dispatches another a new event with the
same events name and the same data so
that in the parents I can register I can
listen to that event
I can log out uh the data as well so I
get the same data so in order for my
app.velt over here to listen to it I
need to do the same dance again I need
to come over here copy this
paste this in
I have this patch come over here the
scratch the same event so I'm going to
dispatch the same events name which is
component button click so that in amp
does felt I can listen to it alright so
the moment of truth let's click the
buttons and now you see on component
button click logs out the data right
finally after passing one by one it's
it's like running a relay marathon where
you relay this you relate the events
from the grandchild to the child to the
parent and then all the way to the eye
dots felt
so if you look up this on this Felts
website or documentation it's called
event forwarding you have forward the
event from one place to and to the
parents all the way to the its parents
to its parents and and therefore you you
achieve this event bubbling effect that
you would get it normally in a Dom
elements
of course this is uh this is
this is a lot of keystrokes to type so
uh sveld comes up with a shorthand right
everything that is annoying a lot of
keystrokes we have short hands for it so
if you are listening to this event and
you are going to dispatch the same event
right your dispatching the same event
you can come over here
and just do this instead so you can
remove all this
and there you go
so you click still works right you still
dispatch all the way so you you listen
to the events and dispatch the parents
and the uh like forward it right so it's
the same uh thing that we've written so
far except that so so let me keep this I
commented out so that
you can compare so previously is you
have to register your own event
listeners and you do a special own now
you forward it by just doing this so I
click again everything works you forward
all the way to its uh parent
so there you have it event forwarding
shorthand and this shorthand actually
does not just apply to component uh to
show you that this actually applies to
elements as well so if I come over here
and I will do this then this is actually
the same shorthand of
um having adding a
on
a shorthand of so previously we were
doing okay let me let me copy this and
so that we can comment it out
all right so previously we were adding
event listeners to on click one and then
dispatch this event so if you do this
then this is the same as dispatching the
same the event of the same name right of
this name so this is the same as doing
this
uh on on click on the button so you can
listen to so we if we want to fold all
the way to the to the top we do this
come copy this forward it up
and then come over here those felt and
let's listen to this
so I'm gonna whoops what's going on
so I have my inline event handlers
okay it's a bit hard to read so I'm just
tap in so I have my invent inline event
handlers and I'm gonna come over here
and console log on click in at dots felt
and I have
yeah and there you go and let's click on
the click me too right on button on
component button click and click me one
which is on click in app.spel
so we you can use this shorthand on
elements as well on element
um on
element events as well Dom events as
well uh it will be the same as how
writing this right so this code over
here it's not evaluated we are not
passing on click one to anywhere right
so this is just to demonstrate that if
you write this in state and dispatch
click then it will be exactly the same
as using on colon click shorthand
so when would you use this on Dom
elements well usually if you create a
component that is kind of like a button
and you uh button with a different
styles or you come up with an inputs but
input with a different styles or
different behaviors small Logics and you
want to Bubble Up the Dom events to the
parent as well so that if I come over
here have a custom button
and I kept my button over here as I say
a custom button and I want to forward
this Dom event on click Dom event to the
parent as well so that I can import
custom event a custom button and listen
to click event then I can do this right
this will save me time of having to
register event listeners and then
manually create event dispatcher and
dispatch the same uh create an event of
the same name
so today I'm going to talk about
installing your elements with class wait
I thought we learned about this before
right in this example you we we talk
about how you can add a class and then
you can add a class selector in your
Styles and then boom you apply the
styles to elements right what else to
learn about
well that's right have you learned about
a conditional class
well that's not that hard either right
um if you come over here if I have class
over here I have a profit where if a
profit is negative I'm going to apply a
negative class if it's positive I can
apply a positive class so a class
attribute is is a you can pass in a
string and within string within this
string you can have curly bracket so
anything within color brackets is you
can pass in any JavaScript expression so
I can come over here
um
I'll check whether the profit is next
time zero then apply a negative class uh
if it's greater than zero I use positive
class
um
yeah that that's that's it is there
anything else you want to show me
well it is can you make this more
concise well of course there's a little
way to write this uh you can okay so if
it's profit less than zero I use
negative and I can combine these two
expressions together
um is that what we are looking for so
it's like this then I can be like this
uh
right yeah can you make it more concise
and easy to read well yes kind of uh
maybe I can come over here I can define
a class
or
so class so this is a profit class
and I can use I can apply this over here
and then I can add this as the string to
my yeah to my class so that I can change
whatever string it is is that it's well
well we've seen a lot of different ways
of writing right so there's no a perfect
way of writing but today I'm going to
share with you one thing one tips which
is to use a class directive yes class
itself can be attractive as well so if I
come over here
uh let me undo a bit and if I come over
here I've written this a class
let me back it up even more I I have
these two conditions over here and you
can immediately see that negative class
should be applied when profit is less
than zero and there's a nice way to
write this to express this
um in using a class directive so same
thing I same thing as what we have over
here I'm gonna copy this first I'm gonna
use a class directive so as a directive
is anything with a colon right so I
write class and then a colon and I can
pass in the name of the class so the
name of the class is called the negative
and it passing a condition for this so I
can come over here and write a profit
Less Than Zero so this thing this whole
thing class colon negative equals to
profit less than zero it's the same way
of writing expressing this but I find
this is more ex
is more expressive it is it expressed
more to me where it says that uh if this
Cloud uh negative class apply based on
this condition rather than you have a
ternary Expressions that tries to return
a string from your JavaScript
expressions and we kind of have to
figure out like what that string is by
reading this and we figure that oh it's
either a positive string or an empty
string and and then what is the
condition and I find that reading this
this writing it this way is is much more
readable I'm gonna come come over here
and convert this to class positive
with the condition for the class
positive as well so I can write it this
way now so I have class negative profit
less than zero and plus positive plus
relation one so let's try it still works
I always try don't take my word from it
always try whether it works or not
okay so I have one more thing for you to
try as everything goes where we like to
have shorthand
class directive also has its own
shorthand and I
hopefully you can guess what it is it's
basically it's like this uh if you're if
this condition so this condition can be
any JavaScript Expressions right what if
this condition is a
is a variable if I write negative over
here as a variable and I declare a
negative
as a relatively declared variable so
this the value of negative always change
when whenever I change the profit
um
then I would end up writing this right
class color negative equals negative and
since this class name and the variable
name the condition variable name is the
same I can omit this I can write this so
class colon negative it's equals to let
me copy the previous one and then
comment it out so that you can do a
comparison you want okay
paste it over here so this is equal to
this is the same thing so let's try it
out right it works so if you have a same
condition name as a class name then you
can do this shorthand
and there you go a class directive
hopefully it adds a new way for you to
specify what's the class of the elements
um instead of just having to
concat strings to form your class names
so hopefully you learned something new
and I like to see you applying this in
your in your swell components
we are going to talk about bindings
what is binding well we shall see let's
take a look at one example that I
prepared for you so over here we have an
input and and a variable called value so
this is a state where we can change the
value of the value variable and we show
that value variable on the screen over
here
so we add input events on the input so
that we know whenever we type something
like this we this will be called and
then we update the value of the value so
this will pass this value into your
into the input itself so that it's
updated and also it will show it on over
here on the screen
so every time when you want to add event
listeners from an input and then uh
update a value of a variable and then if
you want to
somehow change the value and then get it
reflected onto the input so when I say
we get it reflected is what if I over
here I have a button
and whenever I click on the button
uh I want to change the value to see
ASDF right so I can type over here every
time I hope come over here I change the
valuable available valuable variable
call Value and get it reflected and I
can do the other way around which is I
click click me after the value of the
verb the variable of the the value of
the variable value and then get it
reflected on the input so I click you
see it's updated to ASDF instead so
there's two ways of updating this
variable value one from the input events
or two is
by just changing it directly
and this is this is very common pattern
that you would come out to control your
inputs and so so that's so uh svelt
comes up with a
um directive that handles this so that
you don't have to come over here Define
the event listeners Define a variable uh
I mean you have to Define a variable but
like you you can save time typing all
this and just do this one thing instead
which is
bind that bind directive that's why the
title of this video bindings bind and
then I need to bind what
I'm going to bind
um
the value of the input right so
inputs.value is the value of the input
we over here we read this value from
here in this event and then we pass this
value in in this variable so uh so this
two way we we want to read and write
also right so we want the value property
of this input and bind with what we're
going to bind it with a variable call
Value so I'm going to copy this variable
and pass it in here
so I can remove all this at once so this
and this is the same
binding is to re receive an event
listeners to uh get the value of this
input and assign it to this variable
call Value
and also this is also doing this where
whenever the value of the variable value
has changed we're going to update the
value property of this input
it's it's it's a bit mouthful so let's
let's try to change this I'm going to
call this a
full instead so that it's it's
so that you can differentiate where this
is right
okay come over here up here all right so
inputs you read a property called value
okay you can do this now a real
political value and then over here you
want into full and then you want to set
full into the value the property called
value it's the same this is the property
name this is a value you read it to the
variable called Foo and if you've
changed full we want to update it back
to the property called value so I come
over here I can type as you can see uh
this is this
okay I I should comment this out so only
have this by input that has bind so when
I type it will get the value of the
input so this is no longer in use right
just just so you know
a type of value of the input value of
the input comes to variable called full
and
so you see full reflected over here and
if I click okay let me type more and I
click on this button I change the value
of full it should update so this full
variable should update the property
called value
so there you go so binding we bind a
variable a property called value to the
variable called full and it works two
ways it's a two-way data binding
changing in the property will update a
variable changing the variable will
update the property
and
and if your variable instead of calling
it full you call it value instead let's
come back value value call it value
instead then you can have a shorthand
right the property and a variable name
is the same then you can wow
omits the whole thing so this and the
above is the same right so I'm going to
change this so that you you have a clear
value so this and this is the input bind
value equals value and bind value is
exactly the same so let's type and see a
change and you change okay
and you click on you update variable
called value it will update it backed to
your elements a property of the element
so there you go binding on elements
can't you do binding with components
well yes you can as well you can imagine
uh
instead of attribute instead of the
attribute of the elements you can change
on the property of the component the
props of the component and so I have a
component called components I'm going to
impart this over here
and in this component I am going to use
it over here and comment out everything
that I'm not in use
so this component has a
a counter called count and I have a
button that just increments discount
value
so to to listen to uh discount changes
we we maybe we can add event listeners
and then uh so that I can update a
variable over here so I can come over
here have a variable called count
and I can uh to count equals count
okay so this is a shot I can do a
shorthand Chronicles count
uh I can have a button that changed this
value
whoops
because 999
so I can have a button that updates
account value
and whenever I change okay I need to
also have a
event right so I come over here this
patch count
change
foreign
Imports
create event
dispatcher
from sveld
and create event dispatcher
so every time counts change I'll
dispatch discount change event
come over here uh on wait wait it should
be on a component
on count change
uh whoops I receive an event
let me get it to a new line so that you
can really carefully clear
right on count change you have events
and the count will equal to event dot
detail
so over here
you guys do think whenever we change
inside oh click me uh increments I'm
gonna name it differently so if every
time when you increment
um
this will be called this event will be
called and I need to come over here and
show you that this value is updated
so every time it's called I will get the
latest value of the count and it will be
reflected on the screen over here
right and anytime
and and when I click on this button I
want to update this value count to 999
so when I click this
it'll be 999 and this value will be
passed in so this count will be updated
right so if I increments yeah and you
get received over here so can so it's
it's kind of the same as your inputs
where you events happening you update
the value and if the value
changes you update the property of the
attributes of the elements so I can do
the binding for any props in fact any
props so this props is called count so I
can come over here and bind
bind count to count
second comment okay so this
whoops let me comment this and just
leave this for you
so buying counts to count
is again exactly the same as distance to
events of the variable accounts and
whenever count change update the props
call count right so this is the same as
above so I try over here you see it's
the same
the same behavior
and in fact since this variable and the
this property of the component is the
same as the variable that we're going to
assign to we can use the binding
shorthand and just write this
increment and click me increments click
me so here you go bindings for elements
as well as components
today we're going to talk about bindings
wait we talk about bindings
but there's a lot of examples a lot of
things that you can cover about bindings
and I'm not going to cover all them to
be honest you should learn yourself and
I'm going to show you where you can read
about them so over here I am at this
result tutorials so as well prepares as
well and the main official docs it
prepared a very amazing tutorials step
by step you can come over here to start
from the day ones both of the things we
have covered
um and what I'm going to show you now is
you come over here and you look for
bindings and you see text inputs this is
where it starts and from this drop down
you probably have seen that you probably
will see that there's a lot of things
that you can do bindings with right text
inputs numeric inputs check box uh group
inputs text in text area select content
edible editable media Dimension this
components a lot a lot of them some of
them I'll cover for example component
bindings and like text input element
bindings I have covered some of them
but some of them I would not cover you
can explore yourself so I'm going to
show you how you can explore yourself so
you choose one of it say I'm going to
come over here in numeric inputs and it
will show you that it will tell you
things that you need to know about for
example if you have a numeric input then
you set type equals number or type
equals range then you will mix it make
it into a numeric input
which means that the value will become a
number before assign it to a variable
um so buying value takes that for you
so um it will show you for example uh in
this example over here uh some example
that has prepared but I believe we don't
have bindings here and if you click show
me you replace the code with bindings
and then you see that uh everything
works now so you can compare the before
and after you can reset and show me to
compare yourself quickly toggle and see
what's the difference and then play with
it right change this this is a ripple
the Sim Ripple that I've been using all
the while so you can play around and
learn about it
so today I want to cover is group inputs
because I find that it's slightly
um different uh it needs more
explanation hopefully you are smart
enough you don't need my explanation but
I believe uh maybe with my explanation
or maybe some people might need it maybe
with my explanation you make it clearer
all right hope I do that for you if you
feel that I have make it very clear
comes up comments share this video out
to everyone else right so
um I'm gonna come over here with a rebel
that I have prepared
uh so one is group inputs right so group
inputs
um it's actually mean it actually means
that you can bind a group of inputs with
a binding group
so this binding is called buying group
and what you do is you can bind two
kinds of inputs with this only two kinds
it's either a radio button or a check
box button all right so review button is
one that you usually see with a circle
where you have to choose single option
and check box is usually uh when you see
there's a square boxes where you check
and uncheck you can have multiple
choices
so what this uh buying group is does is
that instead of making your own group of
checkbox by setting them the same name
you should set them the same name but
um besides just setting the same name
what else you can do to say collect all
the values from this inputs together and
assign it to a variable
what you can do with is you use a verb
you use bind group
so say for example if I come over here I
have already three check boxes uh value
one two and three
uh what you usually do is you okay I
should remove this sorry let me remove
this first
what you usually do is you should come
over here and name it uh say
Foo
all right sorry I'm better naming this
has come a full full and then you just
use radio for now radio radio radio
so with the same name you expect that
you can only choose one of them
right
um
if I create one more four
you expect them to to only choose one
and how do you bind the value of this
group uh to a variable right I want to
bind it to a value you can't say because
radio usually you have a property called
checked so do you do like buying checked
but this will only bind the checked to a
variable and bind the value of the
checked off like this want input how do
you bind
a group of inputs because it works
together you want to say this growth
input I want to know which value is
being selected
so what you do is use binding group in
States so I can bind it to a variable
over here I'm going to say uh come
create a variable call options
uh come up here say options
select the option so if it's radio then
you can only choose one option
and so I'm gonna uh come over here and
bind it to option so one so it should be
naming is important I'm gonna use a
single noun
right I'm going to use a singular noun
and I'm gonna paste this bind group over
here
mine group oops sorry
mine group now this variable now becomes
sorry let me uh
I have my camera just block my view so
I'm going to resize this a bit so that I
can see it clearly
so if I select you can see that the
option the current option selected will
be assigned to this variable call option
alright so it depends on the value so
what you have to make sure the value is
uh
not you have to make sure but whatever
is Select whichever radio input is
selected the value of that variable uh
value of that input will be assigned to
this group variable called
option all right so the option variable
will be assigned to whatever input radio
button that is being selected at the
moment
um so this is a binding which means it's
two-way if I come over here and
initialize with say three it should okay
with a string three you would expect
that this ring 3 will be selected by
default
um and if I come over here I have a
button uh resets
okay I'm gonna this function will will
try to set uh option
to say four
right I change change and I say click
this oh sorry I click once and I click
reset I'll set option value to 4 and 4
is selected right so I can bind Group
which is the group of inputs uh what is
the value of that group of inputs uh
with buying group
and it works with uh check boxes as well
so I'm gonna come over here comment this
out so that you can play with it later
on
and come over here and paste this and
I'm going to replace all this with check
boxes check box check box check box and
checkbox in most cases check boxes you
have multiple selections right so most
likely you what you want is more of like
an array of selected options so you use
arranged it and for the sake of naming
it should be a plural form so it's
options so I'm going to change it to
options options options options
um and just to show it nicely and join
with uh and a comma right and a space
so whenever I click on select select and
unselect you see that uh it will add all
of the selected options to this variable
call options so it's an array it will
add more items to that array
and because it's a two-way binding I can
change this up value of options I can
come over here where on click on this I
will select uh one and four
right so I can select something I can
select two and click reset I'll select
one and four and four one will be the
value of the options
so buying group allows you to bind a
group of check boxes or a group of radio
inputs uh where checkbox when you're
buying group you bind uh you you
expect to pass in a array as a variable
right because you can select multiple
inputs select multiple check boxes so
all the selected check boxes the value
of them will be uh will be the value uh
will be they will collect all the values
of the selected checkboxes into an array
and that array will be assigned to the
variable that you are binding with
right um
so say if I have now if I have two
variables I have options and options two
come over here and have another variable
now this will allows me to
um have collect the options to only bind
to the
the
up checkbox three and four so anytime
when I change the value I check on it's
not changed I check and uncheck the
value of three or four it will collect
them and then assign it to this options
to variable and then you will see
whether options to what what are the
inputs that is selected by options two
right and it works two ways so whenever
you change this variable
programmatically then you will reflected
by uh all the variables all the inputs
boxes that binds group on that input so
that's all hopefully that is useful for
you when you want to have a group of
radio boxes or check boxes reminds you
of using buying grouped to bind them
today we're going to talk about another
type of binding which is bind this so
what is buying this well we shall see in
this example over here over here I have
prepared a component which has an input
and a button
so over here if I type something in my
input yeah you got that something from
the input
um oftentimes when we write this we
assumes that a cell wall understands
this component goes through some
compilation into JavaScript and what the
JavaScript do is to create that input
element and inserts it into the Dom
um yeah and most of the time you don't
have to care about that element itself
you don't need to know like what you
don't have you don't need to get the
reference of the elements because if you
want to manipulate say the value of that
input you use a bind value to bind the
value of the inputs and you control from
there and most of the times you just
want to control the value of the input
or maybe some validation which you can
pass in Via other attributes
but if
for some circumstances you want to get
the reference of the element then you
probably would want to use this which is
the bind this
so buying this allows you to bind a
variable
so let's say I'm gonna get I'm calling
I'm creating a variable called elements
and I want to bind this
this input so this stands for this
reference of this input to this variable
so buying this is actually one way
binding you you do this you will bind
the reference of the inputs to this
variable but it does not go the other
way around you can't go the way where
you say sets update the value of this
variable and hopes that it will
somehow reflect on this element no it
does not work that way you can't say I
have this element now and I want to
create
um say a button element and hope that
with this binders I'll make this input
into button no it does not work that way
it works only one way input when it's on
the screen when it's Felts created and
added onto the screen then bind this
will uh will bind the reference of that
input element to this variable called
element
so um hope that you hear the keyword
over there when it when the spell mounts
these elements then you will get this
right so which means that if you want to
access the variable right now if your
console log element right now at this
point of time you probably will get
undefined
and when does it being defined well it's
being defined when spells creates this
element and mount it onto the Dom so if
you come over here on Mount so on Mount
is a life cycle that will be that allows
you to register a lifecycle event when
um when element is mounted or when the
component is mounted then I can call uh
at that point of time
the elements should be available
uh you don't have to worry about on
Mount we'll talk about it later but as
you can see over here uh I can say type
of elements and you can see it's it's
something it's object right
um so the spell ripple does not allow me
to print out elements reference but if I
come over here and
uh open up the elements tab you will see
that it is
console.s and input right the reference
of the input so what can you do with it
so let me comment this out what can you
do with it well you can do something or
you can since you access the reference
of the elements now you can do anything
with it you can say reset the value of
the input which conveniently we have
this function called reset and this is
what I'm going to do I'm going to say
reset
I'm going to reset it to just an empty
string okay so if I come over here I
type something
and at this point at this juncture you
can see that element has mounted most
likely the reference to that input is
already assigned to this variable called
ambulance so if I come over here when I
click reset it will oh sorry this is
elements not inputs
all right at this point most likely the
element is pointing to the input so when
I say if the element dot value equals
empty you expect that this you will
reset will clear some of these inputs
right so when I click it it clears up
right so
um this is what you can do with uh
reference to the elements so anytime
when you want to get a reference of an
element you use buying this
and as a lot of things in this world's
components work similar to elements so
if I say you can use bind these two
elements you can use bind this to
component as well so if I come over here
I prepared a component so I'm going to
import it let's say import component
from component dot spelled
and then I'm gonna create this component
uh over here
and okay I'm gonna still keep this
variable called element but you know
that I'm going to bind this to a combine
this component right so this element is
going to point to the reference of the
component so we're going to say bind
this elements
again this is a one-way binding so uh
you you only get the reference of the
components on this variable when this
component is mounted on the screen
you can't say the other way around where
uh changing this variable in hopes that
change something on the component itself
but of course this component over here
that I'm going to show you now
um have uh variables right uh States
it's called count so when I click this
button it will increment the count and
also it expose a props right so Props
can be variables can be functions uh in
this in this case the props is a
function
um why I say you can be anything it's
like you can come over here and do this
uh it's it's like a props but it's a
function right uh this is same as this
is similar to this right you're
exporting something like a props which
is a function
so uh you can come over here and get the
reference of this component which means
you also uh you get the reference of
this component which means that you can
access all the props from this instance
of this component
so anything that's exported can be
accessed say for example if I exports
the count as a props and if I come over
here
and I say console log
elements dot count
uh okay so two right now you click you
expect that oh what
ah sorry
so I can't really read it like this
except unless I pass in this flag
over here
so don't worry about uh spell options
accessors this is something we will talk
about later on but as as the warning
shows it's clear enough you just copy
paste this thing in and now you can see
that we can get uh we can console out
this count over here right a basic
explanation of what this is is that it
allows us to compile this component in a
way that you can access props uh with
this uh directly with these accessors uh
using like getter function to get the
props value right
um of course however uh if you look at
functions you don't need that you don't
get use accessors like Getters to get
the value of the props you call the
function directly so over here in States
I could replace this with elements
dot reset
and we export this function called
resets which it will resets accounts to
zero
so if I click a few numbers over here
and when I click reset it will get it
will use the reference of this component
and call a method on that component
we'll call the props function which is
this reset over here right and so I call
this reset and this will be called this
function and you will set the counts to
zero so when I click reset it will
resets the value to zero and when I
click now it does resets to zero and
there you have it uh why if you ask me
why you need a reference of a component
this is the reason you can access to any
methods of the components then uh you
you
um unlocks yourself not just control the
components by its props you can also
control the components via its methods
you can export more functions more
methods from this exports a lot of
functions which will be like a methods
of this component and once you get the
reference of a company you can call all
these methods and it will in some sense
control your internal state right
so in this case if I want to set the
counts to zero I need to have a props I
need to pass in count it goes to a
variable somewhere and any different
counts and then you set it to zero right
and
and if I have more than that I have a a
group of props then I would have to
coordinate them out here but if I get a
reference of this component and I can
call a methods to do all of that at once
then
wasn't even isn't that great
right so buying this allows you to get
the reference of the element or the
components that you're binding right if
you use other elements you get the
reference of that element you get a you
use it on a components you get the
reference of the component
and when do you get the reference you
get it when that element or the
component is mounted it's created and
mounted by its felt
and this binders is a one-way binding
which means that it will when it's
mounted it will update the variable but
updating the variable itself does not
reflex does not goes back to change the
elements or component itself
let's talk about component life cycle
events there's four life cycle events uh
there's a on Mount and on Destroy and
then there's a before update and after
updates
so let's take a look at some examples on
how you can use them
so over here I've prepared app.spel and
I have a component
so in this component I have a import
unmount on Destroy before update and
after updates from svelt so each of in
each of the life cycle I try to comment
a console out the lifecycle name so in
the console you take you you see that
um when you when you first Mount Your
components there will be three events
fired uh before updates and then on
Mount and after updates so do notice
that before updates and after updates
will be fired even if you are
uh just mounting your components
and on Mount will be fired when you try
to Mount Your component right right
right after the all the elements like
the buttons over here is being mounted
then unmountable fire and after updates
will fire as well so if I come over here
in the components and I try to add a if
statement if condition
and if I try to have a checkbox that I
can toggle on and off the condition
checkbox
buy and check
then if I turn it on you'll see that
it's called mounts and if I turn it off
you'll see on Destroy being called
okay let me try that again like clear if
I turn it on before updates on Mount and
after updates and if I turn it on you
see on Destroy
and within a component itself I have
prepared a buttons which will update the
count over here
so if I click onto the button right now
then I will update the account and it
should kick in an update cycle so if I
click here you see that before updates
and after updates although you can't
really see the timing that when this is
being called but according to the Spell
documentation it says that before
updates fires right before you update
the Dom
uh and then after update fires right
after you up the Dom has updated
and in the docs it says that it will
after update will fire once right after
the Dom uh is updated so it has this
word once and I was curious like why is
it so and it's because if you come over
here in after updates you could possibly
go and update the state again
and if this happens this actually kicks
in another round of updates on your
component and this could lead to an
infinite Loop if it's not carefully
handled and I'm and somehow apparently
swell handles it by make sure that after
update only called once throughout the
whole updates right so if you kicked in
another update cycle in the after
updates uh you will go
updates again but then after update will
not be called again so
uh I'm not quite sure whether this is
this makes sense to you but for S5s I
can see this does help prevent infinite
Loop recursive calls so the cell version
that I'm using right now is is 3.35 so
this Behavior stays at this current
version so if I click on
over here you can see that before
updates on Mount after update and this
kicks in another round of updates
so you you see that before update being
fired so if I click click me again
you'll see that before update after
update and before updates being called
uh yeah so this is something
um weird but of course I wouldn't expect
you to actually change the state in
after updates that is
um you shouldn't do that
effects
so that that is one Edge case that I
want to point out over here and you can
see that I'm calling this component uh
calling all this lifecycle methods to
register the event uh to register a
callback so did you call this on mounts
or any of this uh and you pass in a
function so this function will be called
at the right point of time and you can
only call you can only do this
registration during the component
initialization
what that means is that you have to be
written at the top
uh when at the top level when you're
trying to execute this this whole script
over here so if you do it something like
do it slightly later for example if I
say set timeout
and call it at the next timeout
then what you have actually is an error
it will say that function called outside
component initialization you have to
call it during the component
initialization
um but that does not stop us if we say
if we come with a function over here
full
and we make sure that we call the food
during initialization of your function
which is calling it at the top level
over here then of course there's no
error right so it's not about where this
amount has to be it's more about when
you should call it you should call it
during your component initialization
this is because whenever a asphalt
component is initializing your component
sorry spell is initializing your
component
it knows which component is initializing
so so you're importing on Mount on
Destroy before update you know that
you're importing this function this
function has no idea uh it or rather
these functions are so called uh is is
importing from sveld right so you it has
to know that what are the current
components being initialized
so you have to call it during
initialization so that it knows that oh
the current component is being
initialized is this and I want to
register this this event this amount on
destroyed to this components but once
it's finished in installation that then
you couldn't find that component anymore
and therefore you get this error of you
have to you can't call it during after
you have to call it during component
initialization
uh so one last thing that I want to
share is that one great example that you
can one great use case that you could
use uh when it stems out from this where
you can actually call this somewhere
else meaning actually you can have a
function say full right in this case and
save it somewhere else uh some food.js
and you export this function
and so for each of the components that
wants to do something during our mounts
for example calling on Mount you can
import Foo for all of this components so
so there's ways that you can reuse
lifecycle logic
so you call full from here you can have
multiple components and import full and
when you so you you have to call it
during combination component
initialization initialization but then
this will make that all any component
that you call this will have a one
callback registered for on Mount and it
will which is to print out the on Mount
during on Mount
right so it's a bit mouthful but yeah
uh so one example I can think of is to
have this function called Mac updated
Mac updates
uh so uh let me show you how I can use
this I can import
let's let's remove this I can import Mac
update
and
call it over here and this function
actually returns an action
curious why right so I'm going to say
action so this action can apply to any
elements
use action
and you'll see that my element will have
a outline uh drawn on top of that
element right this is this is done by
the action but anytime when I change
something it turns red the outline turns
red so there's no way that this action
will know that something has changed
right because there's no way this action
we are not passing any parameters to
this action so there's no way that for
you to know
but one curious point is we are actually
creating this action on the fly over
here this Mark updates so over here Mark
updates I actually call the before
update so I'm gonna so any for any
component that I call this I'm actually
registering something in the before
update so that actually I know that some
this component is updating
and what I do for the action is actually
just add this element that I apply the
action to to a set so that every time
when something has updates I draw and
read outline to that element to all
these elements so that that is one
interesting use case of uh where you can
have before updates or unmounts being
called within a function and you can
reuse Logics of them right it does not
have to write you don't have to write
this within the component itself you can
write it in other functions but make
sure make sure you call them during
component initialization
in the last video we talked about how we
register component lifecycle events such
as on Mount
on Destroy before updates and after
updates
we talk about some of the do's and
don'ts about registrating them for
example you have to call them during the
component initialization we briefly
talked about when they will be called
but today in this video I want to dive
slightly deeper into the on Mount
component life cycle so let's take a
look at the two examples I prepared for
you for on Mount so over here I have my
app.velts that renders two example if
the show is true so I use a checkbox to
turn that on and off
so what other use case of a good example
use case of using on Mount well I can
think of two but of course there's a lot
more so the first one is I use on Mount
to set an interval right so you you
wouldn't want to kick off this interval
of like uh some events that you're doing
during interval this should be only
triggered started when your component is
mounted onto the Dom right over here I I
set an interval on every second so that
I can see the counter increase by one
every second and then the second example
that I can think of is using on mounts
to fetch data so if you use a server
side rendering and a client-side
hydration kind of model where you want
to fetch some data in the client side so
mainly usually because you want this
data is less important it's it's
probably showing up later on so you you
you are able you're okay to fetch them
later on in a client side then probably
you can add it in the on Mount uh life
cycle right you you wouldn't want to do
it
um in like component initialization uh
and because that will be actually being
triggered by the server side rendering
right during server side rendering you
you would want this to only happens in a
client side then probably you add this
fetch within on Mount
if it's purely client-side rendering you
don't have any server side rendering
then uh
um yeah you can fetch this during
component initialization because the
time difference isn't that much and then
probably you can even like fetch make a
network call way before your component
is mounted so that when it's mounted the
data Maybe it's already there
so uh on Mount so remember uh you don't
take my word for it that I say that on
Mount will not be fired during server
side rendering uh remind me later on I
will show you uh we have to try
everything so that you don't take any
word from anyone right but let's take a
look at these two examples so when I
turn on this flag uh you should be able
to see the counter is incrementing and
also I fetch this data
um and then also have because on I
either the console log so on every
interval you see that the console is
logging in the log but but
if I turn it off
see that this is still running
you're still running 33 94.5
because we didn't clear the interval
this is another source of memory leak we
set an interval to run on mounts and
then we didn't clear it up and the next
time when we Mount this component again
we set off another timer and we turn
this off see that there's two run two
timers running at the same time now so
we need to remember to clean it up
so how do you do that uh in on Mount
maybe we can uh take this interval
instead of setting it over here we uh we
we Define the interval ID on top so that
on Destroy
we have to remember to clear interval
interval ID
let me save this and hold on let me just
pass it over here we save this and
refresh because the old interval is
still running so if I come over here
and I turn it on
console is running and turn it off
it's gone right that's great we remember
to clean up uh whatever we set it off
during on Mount because this is a bit
um
wordy like you have to remember to do an
on Mount and on this right path and
because this is a very common pattern
that we usually do uh if so actually
well provides a way that you can do it
all of this within just one on Mount
event life cycle Handler
so what you do is you re you can return
a function in on mounts and this will be
called uh when you this will be called
when the component is destroyed so you
can have the interval ID over in within
on Mount and clean it up at the same
time within the same event handler so
you can save a few keystroke you don't
have to import on destroy you can even
you don't even need to define interval
ID on top you can do this and
hopefully it's more concise so let's
let's try this out turn it on
console
and turn it off it's gone right so you
can return a function in uh in the on
Mount event handler so that it will
clean up it will be called when the
component is destroyed so they will do
the cleanup necessary
same thing goes for fetching
um if you Fetch and your component is
destroyed you don't really need the data
anymore then probably you can use a bot
controller and you return a function to
I bought the fetch so if I take a look
at the network tab
over here clear this up turn on and turn
off immediately you see that uh wait
hold on I think this is returned now
let's let's do it faster let's turn it
off you see that this is being canceled
right because you don't need this data
anymore
uh yeah so remember to do remember to
clean up whenever you use on Mount
anything there's a lot of things that
can be cleaned up so remember to do that
right so timeout intervals fetches uh
there's a lot of things right so that's
there you have it
um on Mount and remember to clean up so
before we end this I promise you I'm
gonna show you how to run this in a
server side rendering uh so I'm gonna
save this and I'm gonna download the
projects and then come over here and
compress this
allow me for a while we're gonna run
this with my code editor so I have vs
code open and come over here most likely
I need to install something
right so this one I'm Gonna Change it to
server side rendering so we're going to
come over here SSR
wait no
right I think it's the oh generates
called generate
and come over here let me know install
my dependency
and build my code
okay so actually this is not gonna work
because we're gonna compile it as a
Services rendering so I'm going to come
over here at dot render uh props empty
props I'm going to come up here let's
have the HTML I'm gonna just cancel it
out
and build this again
and I'm gonna run it
oh man what did I do
build this
and run this
yep you can see my HTML is up and you
will notice that
okay so we haven't really console out
anything in on Mount so this is what I'm
gonna try see whether this online is
being called
uh we can default to true so that you
will show the example one and two
okay let's let's build this again
and then run this
and you just as you can see over here we
did not run anything we don't see
anything on on Mount right so this zero
is this count over here so we do render
this uh this image over here is the
image
and we didn't see any on Mount so on
Mount is not fire during server side
rendering
hope that uh hope that's clear
today we're going to talk about if logic
block
we have seen how we can use Dynamic data
to present uh onto the templates in your
swell component but we haven't talked
about how we can based on a certain
condition show or hide a certain content
so this is what we're gonna do today
so over here I have prepared some
examples for you as always
so here I have two buttons one uh called
condition
the second button is also called
condition right but they are controlling
different conditions so let me name it
better so this is condition one and this
is condition two
so as I click on each of the buttons I
add event listeners so that it will
toggle that condition so if it's
initially true then it will turn to
false if it's initially false returns it
to true alright so as I click you'll see
that it turns from True to false false
to true
so now with all this set up we're gonna
see how we can based on this condition
to show some content
so firstly first is that to write this
if block we use uh we we start with a
clear brackets and then a hash and if
so this is how we start the if block and
then we type in the condition so this we
are going to use the condition one
and with that to close it we use curly
brackets again and then backslash if
so in between you can pass in any
content right so I'm going to say any uh
condition one is true
so if the condition if I turn toggle on
toggle off the condition one you'll see
that this will be hidden but when I turn
condition one to true this will be
should
so anything uh within this
block of uh if condition
uh will be shown based on the condition
itself so the condition is any
Expressions you can pass in any
Expressions so I can see
um say condition one and condition two
so this time round if I turn on any of
it it will be hidden but if I turn on
both then it will be shown right so this
will be based on both the condition and
condition one and two
so anything here can be a expressions
right and
um so again so to recall we start with a
hash if and then we end so if a slash if
so this marks the beginning and the end
and as what we will do in JavaScript we
have if we sometimes like to have else
right if certain things do this else do
something else so um same thing goes
with the logic block as well we can have
an else condition so if show something
else show something else so over here we
can type else but this time around when
we see else we are going to start with a
colon sign so curly brackets again and
then colon else and then close your
curly brackets
so else uh I would say either condition
one or two is false
so as you can see if I turn on it will
see either one of the condition is false
uh if I both is true then uh it will it
will show the first content
okay so now I'm going to tell you
there's actually a pattern there's a
pattern in logic blocks so so you learn
the pen this pattern now it applies to
other logic blocks that we're going to
talk about in future the pattern is this
uh when you want to start something you
start with a hash sign so curly brackets
hash sign and something right in this
case we are learning about if then we
will start with a hash if
to end that we will have to use a slash
if right so this marks the beginning and
this marks the end and anything in
between anything in between you use a
colon sign so in this case we have colon
else we can have colon else if as well
right in JavaScript we have if else and
then n right you can have if else if
another condition else if another
condition and else an N or without else
as you can see right you can have as as
many else if or else in between
so the same thing goes with uh spell
logic blocks you can have else if so
anything in between of the if you use a
colon right so else if and then you can
type anything you like so in this case I
want to say uh condition
one or condition two
so again this is whatever you type over
here can be any JavaScript Expressions
it could be condition one or condition
two it could be a function call right
maybe I'm going to say check
condition one
two and I'm going to Define this
function
on the top so I'm going to say check
condition one
oops
condition two
and return
all right this this works as well we can
if we can pull this function uh extract
this into a function and call a function
over here
right and then probably over here I put
some content so you you can you can see
really if I don't put anything spell
actually will complaints like oh uh you
you have nothing over here right uh so
uh
so that which means there's rooms to
improve in this code itself we probably
don't have to check this condition uh to
put an empty maybe we can have else an
alternate uh condition and then put like
over here instead right we can compact
this instead of leaving like one
condition that has empty block
so uh over here I'm going to say
condition one
or two is true
all right so now if I turn you will see
that it will change the wording and if
both of them are false then either is
false right I think now it should say
both condition one and two is false
right so you can play with this uh
however you want right so logic blocks
um so logic blocks itself uh like any
other elements is felt they can Nest
itself as well so I can come over here
and I can Nest again so say for example
I have condition three
uh right and I can come over here and
Nest it at anywhere I like I can Nest it
over here say if condition three uh
another content
all right so if I you can see over here
and I can put it over here as well if I
want I can have as many uh within a Blog
I can have as many number of elements I
want so I can have one div
oh in fact I can have two divs if I want
to uh if any content I like right I can
Nest conditions and I can keep nesting
them and the ones that I can't do that
right so uh the sky is the limit you can
you can do as as however you want the
sky is the limit you can come you can
just treat a logic block itself like an
element which can have children and so
you can Nest uh have like logic blocks
and then element and then maybe logic
blocks again and an element and then and
all the way down to Nowhere right so
so there you go here you have a if Logic
box for you to show or hide content
based on the condition right based on
certain Logics which is the if the
condition is true then you will show
something if it's false you hide it and
we've seen how you can start and end a
block and we see the pattern over here
where to start a block you use a you use
Clear brackets and a hash sign and to
end it you use the same name right so if
you start with a clear uh you should
start with if then you have to end with
an if block and this time around when
you end you use a slash and anything in
between say else if else you start with
a clear brackets and then a colon sign
today we're going to talk about each
logic block
in this example I use I have a list of
colors and I want to show all the colors
in a list
so what I do is I come over here I
create one list item by one one by one
so I show like The Colors the I use
index to get the first color the second
color and the third color but when I
need to add another color say I want to
add yellow
then I have to come over here copy and
paste
uh change this to three and to show like
the the fourth color
so is that a way to
reduce this so that we can just write it
once and some way to Loop through all
the colors and display it on the screen
well there is right there's the point of
this example that I want to show you is
there is a better way of doing this
which is to use the each logic block
so before we go dive into the each block
I'm going to draw a comparison for uh
from JavaScript on how you would Loop
through a list of colors and do
something with it right so we're going
to compare that with our each logic
block so that you can see the
similarities so that you can draw the
connection between them okay
so over here I if I'm going to look
through the colors uh usually there's a
few ways I can use a arrays or forage
right I can use arrays.forage
I could use a for loop with index
to Loop through
uh length
look through all the colors
but my favorite is if I just want to get
the colors I don't care about index I
would use four cons off Loop which is
four color
off colors
for off Loop right so in this fall off
loop on every iteration what I get is
the color so I uh so in this example I'm
gonna just console out what is in the
color and you can see from the console
let's read green blue and yellow so
every iteration I'll print out that
color at at this point of time right so
the same thing goes with each logic
block to start the each block so I I
think I give a big hint for you the
block name is called each and we've
learned previously how to start a block
you start with coming with a curly
brackets and a hash sign
and then the name of the logic block
right so we're going to use each logic
block so we're going to type h
and before we type further uh the way we
end it is to come over here
slash H right you start with a hash and
you end with a slash
so how do you Loop through an array
using each logic blocks well it's kind
of a bit uh inverse of how you do with a
fall off Loop right you start with
the erase the name of the erasers so
each of the colors
and then you use S so each s is a four
off right so for each of the colors as
as a variable so I'm going to say color
so over here I have access to the color
so it's so you can see this is kind of
like with uh
inverted right u4 item off an array and
you each the array as the item
so in each of this content over here you
can treat it as each iteration what you
are going to show for each of the
iteration
so for each of the iteration I'm gonna
show a list item which is this one so
I'm gonna copy come over here and paste
it in
and I'm gonna use the color that uh in
in the current iteration so which is the
color variable
right so now I can remove this and you
can see immediately that uh green blue
yellow is how I would it trade through I
print out red green blue yellow I use
each block it will iterate through all
the colors and it will show in other red
green blue and yellow
all right so that is how you use each
logic block
so
let's move on to the next thing right so
um over here right now I'm going to
change a bit on my array I'm going to
come up here and change slightly to
include uh do not just use a string but
an object because so that you know in
each item I can not just telling you
what is the name of the color
I would also tells you like what's the
hex uh representation of the number of
the color so for red is f zero zero
for green it's a
um
zero
green blue F0
for blue it's gonna be uh
red green blue so zero zero f
and for yellow this is a tricky one I
don't really know the hex of a yellow
color I'm guessing it's gonna be a red
green blue green and blue zero FF I'm
gonna I'm just gonna guess but let's see
how it is right so uh we have a list of
colors uh which is object and you have a
name and a hex right as you can see here
we are we are considering our object and
if we show an object directly on the
screen it's just gonna see the string
representation of it right you just cast
it into a string right it will be
similar as you call string with the
color this is the same thing but what we
want instead is maybe for now we're just
just gonna show the color the object
itself so I'm gonna use json.swing G5
so that you can see the resemblance of
this in the console and this in the
screen
so with a for Loop uh sometimes I'm
gonna cheat a bit instead of I can say
let's not do the cheat first right so if
I want to access the name of the color I
will come here and say color.name all
right I mean again I get all the colors
and I can get color dot hex I get all
the hexa representation of color so the
same thing goes I can come over here and
say color dot Nim
right again I'm going to see red green
blue yellow and I'm gonna color I'm
gonna add a Style by color the item with
the hex right so I'm going to say color
and then color dot hex really okay so
this is definitely not yellow I can't
remember what's the yellow
oh yeah okay ff0 ff0 yellow
so this our style the item with the hex
of the
uh using color.x and color name right
same same way how you would access it
using a for Loop but sometimes I'm
getting lazy right uh getting lazy
that's why I'm going for because
sometimes I am lazy and I I I know that
I don't really need the color I want to
destructure immediately of this
array so how do you do destructuring
right destructuring you can destructure
it like this and you can name out the
properties of of the item right so
previously we have color right color has
two properties name and hex so I'm going
to say name and hex so I can use it
directly from here
all right as you can see again in the
console you console out red and the hex
value in each iteration
so can I do the structuring over here as
well well yes you can so I'm going to
destructure so
um let's do type I'm just going to copy
this and paste it over here so now I
have name and hex to use it I will
replace this with a hex and this is name
and again nothing's changed but we have
changed our code so this shows that this
what we've written previously and what
we're writing now is the theme right you
can you can do this you can destructure
directly in the each logic block and it
will work
so if I come over here again if I want
to add another color name it goes black
uh this color itself
does not have any hex value
so you can see if you print out is
called undefined because you don't have
any hex value so if you inspect over
here you probably will see that the
style color will be undefined so uh
sometimes you have that what happens is
that you want to have fallback right you
fall back to some other things over here
I'm gonna just say a purple
just so that it's it's obvious right so
the fallback for this is you can do it
this way right you fall back to a purple
color
uh but this is this is uh falling back
on the usage of hex right when you want
to use the hexadecimal representation uh
you want to use it you say okay if it's
defined yes show me this value if not uh
fall back to purple but what if you want
to provide like some sort of uh
default value when you're declaring the
variable hex over here right here we are
this declaring name and hex in a
destructuring way and we can provide a
default value by say a hex equals to
purple
like this so what it means is that if I
remove this if hex is not defined it
will be purple
right so black you have a hex called
Purple
so how do you do this over here you can
do it the same way so I'm gonna just
copy
so to show that it it's the same thing
come over here and I can remove this you
can see really again
uh it's showing purple color right
nothing's changed because it works
because it works that's why uh nothing
has changed so
um so here you can see we are drawing
very closely to the four cons off loop
with the each logic block except that
you start with a four the item of the
array but in each you use each of the
array as item so anything over here
um you can write anything that you write
over here can be just copied over and
paste it in over here and it will work
as you would expect and whatever inside
the content will be
evaluated on every iteration of the loop
just like how you would do something at
every iteration within this block
so you have access to name and hex the
same way as here as the for Loop right
so and as of the for Loop you can Nest
it right so I will come over here and
because I'm lazy to come up with a raise
uh I'm I'm gonna Loop through the hex
string itself so can I say a character
uh of hex
so if I console log
you'll see that it will Loop through all
the characters of the hex
all right so same thing uh over here if
I I can come over here and add this uh
block but I need to write as each block
right so I'm gonna say each
and we copy the array first s and then
the item
every time when you start you need to
close it so I'm going to come here and
close the block and what are we going to
do in between okay what are we going to
do in between is we're going to create
more items right because I am dim and
can't think of anything uh so I'm gonna
say character
uh and you can see you are looping
through all the hexa characters of the
hexadecimal uh representation of the
color so you can see we draw very close
comparison with the four off loop with
the svelt logic uh each logic block we
are going to continue to talk about the
H logic block
in the last video I've drawn comparison
with each logic block with the four cons
of loop
um we draw we've seen that they have a
lot of similarities on how you use it
use them except that they are in a
mirror inverted ways of using because
you use four an item of the array but in
each use each array as item
but in this video I'm going to show you
two more things that you can do with
each block that is
not available in a far off Loop
so are you ready let's take a look what
are they so the first thing is
um each block allows you to get the
index of the phone of your item right
the current so as you iterate through
the item uh you can specify the index of
what you're iterating through
so I can come over here uh to get the
index and come over here after the each
array as item
and then I will type a comma
and I can define a name for the variable
to get the index so over here I can get
this index called a
I
uh index
I name it index so to use it I can come
over here and let's say index name Dash
Index right as you can see now read
index 0 green is index one blue is index
two yellow is index three four and so
and so forth right you can get the index
of the current iteration which something
you can't do it with a fall off Loop
well you can't do it for off Loop but
you can do it with a for each Loop so
one is for each right so you can come
over here uh colors for each
and you pass in a function over here and
in this function you can have the item
itself again you can do similar things
and you can have comma and then you type
in the second parameter is the index
right so this now this each logic block
is actually more closely related to the
four h Loop where you have an array
forage and then the item comma and then
the index over here
so for on each iteration you get the
index uh this the value variable so you
can Define any variable you like the
name any variable name you like and it
will be shown over here right so this is
the same way you get index for your each
block so which is something you can do
with four off Loop right so that is
number one
and number two is
what if your array is empty
right in this case uh both of these four
Loop or for each Loop will not do
anything because the array length is
zero
right so if I
comment everything array is empty you
don't do anything right you don't
console anything but what if I want to
show something when it is empty I want
to fall back to say
okay my list is empty just show one item
that says list is empty what should I do
well
in ish logic block you can have else
interesting right because else is not
just for the if block right if else else
if but this is also this
um this you can use the else when each
has no item right so you have
um so how do you add the else
as you have learned in how you add else
in the if logic block anything in
between you start with a column sign
right so I'm going to curly brackets
colon and else
so over here else you can put in item
that says uh
um anything right I can say uh the list
is empty so you can put in the content
that that will show only when the list
is empty right as soon as I add
something back that this content is is
not going to shown anymore it's hidden
right this will only be shown when
the list has no item right when the list
link the length of the list is zero
so here you go two things that you can't
do with a fall off Loop that you can do
with each logic block
first you can get the index of the
current iteration
second you can show something when the
list is empty using else
today we're going to talk about key h
block
what is kit each block
well it's like a ish block but with key
but what does that key do well we'll
learn about it in this video
before that let's take a look at one
example so over here I've prepared an
example which
again we look through a list of colors
so I have three colors red green blue
and I have a button to add a new color
so when I click on the button I'll push
in a yellow and hopefully you'll see
yellow added to the list
so under here I add I Loop through the
colors uh with the least color and then
I yeah I show what's the color it what
what's the color right now right so when
I click you'll see one new color added
at the end of the list
so what happens here if we investigate
this what happens is that svelt will
actually Loops through the list all
right so previously the list only have
three items now you have four items so
you will look through a list and compare
one by one the color and the index
well it does not really compare the
color and the index it Compares what is
being shown on the screen and what it's
going going to show what is showing and
what it's going to show right so right
now uh the first item is showing rate
and we're gonna show red as well so
nothing to do and second item is showing
green and we're going to show Green as
well so nothing to do uh third item is
blue and we're going to show Blue as
well so nothing to do over there and
then we don't have any items left but we
still want to show one more item which
is the fourth item is yellow so we add a
new item at the end of the list and show
it uh add it as a list item and the
content is yellow and there you have it
right so if I come over here and I
inspect
elements uh we're gonna see uh close uh
a little bit closer and what what is
happening right so gonna reset this uh
I'm gonna inspect again so before we
inspect I am going to use the
developer tools to save the reference of
the list item so that you can know that
whether what I say is true right what I
say is that you will compare compare
compare the first three items and then
the fourth item is is newly inserted
right so I compare reference and see
whether do I remove any of the elements
or are they the same reference so I'm
going to save it
um over here so I'm gonna say a uh okay
I'm gonna name it better right so the
first uh first item equals to the
current element I'm selecting
so this this one the rate and highlight
the second one and the second item is
zero
and third item
so first second and third okay and now
I'm going to click the button to insert
yellow into the list
okay if you notice over here as well uh
it flashes something over here right I
don't want to restart because I have to
retype everything but
rewind pause this and Rewind you can see
that uh it it flat the fourth item
flashes and nothing flashes on the first
three item because you don't have
anything changed all right so now
interesting thing happens right we want
to compare the item so if I come over
here this is this current item and we're
going to compare first item is it equals
is it is a reference equals the first
one yes it is so we are not we're using
the same element okay that's good
let's check the second item uh and let
me highlight the second
right and whoops right it is true right
so the second item is equals to the
second elements over here
let's highlight the third element and
let's type third item it is true as well
so that's great and the fourth one uh no
one is
um we don't have that fourth item yet so
it's it's a new item so we can't compare
with any of the elements right that's
great so
um what happens if right now instead of
pushing yellow at the end of the list
I'm gonna insert yellow and say the
second position so I'm gonna use spice
instead
uh zero uh so the index I'm going to
insert it in the second index
I remove nothing and then insert yellow
right so if I oh sorry splice
so I click you'll see yellow inserted at
the second position well it's
third in a second it index or it's a
third item right
okay so let's let's come over here and
before we do that let's restart again
before we do that I'm going to keep all
the reference of the elements
and let's guess what what's gonna happen
right now all right so we're gonna
before we do that I'm gonna say first
item
oops highlight the second item
and then highlight the third item
all right so first second third you can
see it it's also how when I hover it's
also highlighted on the left on the
Ripple over here
right so as I click what happens right
so this is what I'm going to explain
what happens and we're gonna see whether
it it matches what I explained right so
I have red green blue three elements and
right now I'm gonna render four items
right and I'm going to insert yellow at
the third position so you're gonna have
red green yellow blue so compare the
first element and the first thing I'm
going to render right first thing I want
to show is read and read okay I'm gonna
not go into anything I'm gonna see next
thing right the next thing I have on the
screen is the green and what I'm going
to show is green as well so nothing's
changed okay that's good third thing
that I have on the screen is blue but
what I'm gonna show is yellow so instead
of uh inserting yellow I'm gonna change
the blue color to Yellow right blue to
Yellow because that's the third item I'm
going to show
and then fourth item I don't have
anything I don't have fourth item
element on the screen so I'll create one
new element called blue and then I
insert it on the screen right so
that that's what happened right of
course in my mind when I do this you're
gonna say like isn't shouldn't the
better way or what I want is more like
keep these three elements and insert
yellow and new elements as yellow in the
third third position rather than you
know change the blue to yellow and then
insert one at the last it shouldn't that
be the way well it's not really and it
trust me what I say is what's actually
happening and I'm gonna show you I'm
gonna prove it to you right now then
click on the buttons and you'll see
yellow on the screen now and again if
you haven't noticed on over here on the
right you can backward a bit and you you
will notice that both of these elements
flashes right flashes means that
something has changed right the the
Chrome extent developer tools will flash
on elements when it's changed
so we're gonna come over here and do the
element uh reference comparison right so
I come over here and say it is the first
item equals to the current element well
it's true yes
and the second element is the green
color one I'm going to come over here
and compare is the second item equals
the current yes it is and I'm gonna
highlight on the third one and say is
uh is this the element equals to this it
is true again right but previously
remember third item shows the color blue
but now it's showing color yellow so
it's reusing the same elements but then
change the text and for the blue itself
we recreate a new ones this one is not
equal to anything else so it happens as
I what I said right it will compare one
by one and if it's different you will
update it and if you have more items at
the bottom you will add it in
right so in general uh whenever the
length of the array changes
um whenever the array changes in general
what happens is that swell will go
through list one by one and compare what
is on the screen and what is going to
show Even if you rearrange the things it
will still go one by one in order and
update the text or the contents
according to what it's going to show
right it does not know whether it does
not have no idea know what idea
whatsoever about how you rearrange the
item right you just go one by one
compare and update compare and update
and at the end of the list if you have
more items then they will be created and
inserted into the Dom or if you have
less item then the extra items will be
removed right that is what what happened
so uh again to prove this to show you
this is what actually happens I have
another component over here this way I
can show you that the component will
actually tells you that when it's being
mounted and what it and it will console
out the color of the element that is
provided to this component itself all
right so I can come over here import
this component
I'm going to show this component in
States
I'm going to pass color
so on Mount you see that I will Mount
red green and blue right you can see red
green blue
okay and I have another variable that's
called initial color which will be
computed will be stored the value of
color and the initialization right
during initialization uh your storage
and it's it's not a reactive variable so
anytime when you change color this will
be stuck at the initial color you you
pass into this component
and as now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to insert yellow in the third item
as soon as I click that you see that a
long blue right it inserts a new item
inserted is actually a blue color
instead of yellow although we insert
yellow in the middle it does not matter
it will only check like what we have and
what we're gonna render we have the
extra item and that extra item is the
fourth item which is blue color so as
you can see here it locks out blue
instead
and then one thing you can see here is
that the third item although the color
right now is yellow but the initial
color is blue right this tells you that
previously this is blue and we change it
we change the color property to Yellow
right to show on the screen but this is
purposely designed such a way that it
still show you that what was the initial
color right so they will swallow go
through the list updates every element
in in order and then anything that is
extra it will be inserted or anything
less than it will be extra extraneous
elements will be removed right spelled
has no idea whether you insert something
in between or rearranged order
rearrange my hair as well so
is there a way to let svelt knows that
you want to rearrange the item right
I've said so many things so that you
know like how it works and so that you
can know that you make a conscious
choice to know that okay
I know it's felt you have no idea that I
rearrange but can I tell you that
some odds can I tell you that
a way so that you know that when I
reorder something you know when I
reorder it well can you well that's the
point of this video we're gonna do a key
each block and a key
you can think of it like an identifier
for the elements because anything can be
anything over here can be a as your item
uh element item of your array right so
as well has no way to know that whether
you rearrange or you just modify one
property of it right if it's a string
yeah sort of you can compare the string
but if it's an object how can I know
whether do I use like object reference
or like how can I know right so you can
provide a way to tell us about that okay
this is this property or this value is
the key you use this key to compare if
right now if I show a list of elements
each of them has its own key and anytime
when uh
and and then when I update something you
compare I will also use I for each of
the things that I'm going to show will
also have a key and you compare the key
first so if the key shows uh so if the
key appears previously but now it's in a
different order because it's showing
early on or you rearrange it somehow
then you know that this element should
be shuffled onto the top rather than you
know compare one by one and update
element one by one right so how you
write that key well you come over here
each array as item and then you can add
index as well uh whether you have index
or not is up to you but to provide a key
what you do is you use a bracket
and inside bracket you can write any
JavaScript Expressions again any
JavaScript Expressions you can call a
function you can have a plus you can
like adding up multiple elements or you
can do whatever you want any JavaScript
Expressions but of course make sure that
it evaluates to
uh something that you can store in a map
right of course you can store anything
in the map but I will suggest that you
know put in some sort of strings or
numbers or that's that kind of thing
something simple right don't put uh
because you smell will have to hold it
in reference in a map and you you
wouldn't want to throw everything in
there
uh so over here I
um of course whether is there a
performance penalty uh you would have to
test it out to know for sure but in most
cases you just need something like a
string right in this case uh we have
colors and we can use the color itself
as key right so that I know that okay
red green blue right if I insert yellow
in between uh yellow should have a key
of yellow as well so you know that blue
uh the key blue is still there right uh
it's just like Shuffle to the bottom so
that
um
we know that okay we compare the key
first right all of the item is still
there but then yellow is a new one so
you insert yellow in and then we push
the blue down at the end right so that
is
um
what will happen so I can use a color as
a key so uh so to show you I'm going to
say key is color
I will comment this for temporarily so
you have red green blue and the key is
the red green and blue you can have
anything as a key in this uh in this
example I'm just use I'm just gonna use
the color itself as a key okay
um so I come over here
uh now do the same thing that we have
done earlier on I'm going to skip the
reference and then we compare the
reference right so in this time round
we're gonna see what we what we're gonna
happen is that
uh you will compare the key first right
so right now you can show red green blue
you have three keys and when you insert
yellow you have red green blue yellow
you have four keys right so you will
find every time when you render uh you
see red the key is red fine where is it
and then if if it appears at the bottom
you will move it to the top right and
then I'm gonna use green and find
through the list where is the key which
one which element has a key green insert
it there right yellow do you have
anything that is yellow no that will
create one and then blue do we have any
elements that is blue yes we will insert
that over here right so things will be
reshuffled
uh so if I come over here and I keep the
reference uh so I'm gonna keep the
reference first so I'm gonna say first
item equals this right first item equals
this
second item equals uh highlight this on
and third item equals to this
all right it's first second third and
now when I insert yellow
uh if you bank was a bit you'll see that
only the third item flashes right the
fourth item will be shift downwards so
let's compare whether the reference uh
of each of the elements has changed
right so if I come over here and say
first item equals to the current element
yes it's true right we will use this
second element uh
it is true as well
and let's look at the third item
third element
it is false right this is a newly added
newly inserted element newly created and
newly inserted so yellow is something
new
uh and then but you compare the fourth
one and you see it's true right we reuse
this right we reuse blue so blue is
shifted downwards and we insert yellow
in inside
right so if I come come over here and
use a component in the States you see
that okay initially we are say red green
and blue right we are mounting green and
blue and when I click uh to add a new
yellow insert a yellow in between and a
third item you see that a new component
is created which is colored yellow
and now as you can see also the asian
color of that is also yellow right this
is a newly created component inserted
into the list right so if you uh instead
come over here if we do something like a
reverse
uh colors dot reverse
uh you see that when I click uh again
it's also yellow is created and even
though like we should reshuffle
um we're gonna reuse all the elements
elements will be just Shuffle and
it knows uh it use the key to look up
for from the previous render version to
find out where the element is and then
insert it in order of what you're gonna
show next
right so
um why is this important well this is
important uh in a few ways in two ways
first is that you reuse uh the element
reference in ways that you are expecting
it to right you don't updates uh the
elements one by one to change this right
so if you have a huge list which you
want to insert something in between
right uh so if you don't have a key each
map you what would happen is that uh you
compare and from that item onwards you
always have off by one error where all
the elements have to update it's update
to new value because you know something
has inserted below and you shift down so
you compare the uh for example you
insert at the second position then the
third item is equals the old the old
second item is equals to the third item
and you know third is equal to four
fourth equals to fifth it always have to
update itself because you know the value
is different
right so uh having KH allows you to
insert anything in between but still
keep a reference keep using the same
reference instead of updating of course
there's a penalty in terms of space you
actually have to keep a reference uh
using a key uh you have a map to keep
keep the key with uh reference to the
elements so that you can reuse that
elements right so that is like a
changing
sorry you are trading a space with like
time efficiency right
um of course however if you are using
components where it itself has some life
cycle methods where you know when
companies created like in an example
we've shown you use unmounts and when
you update it you use like before
updates and things like that well you
and and probably you want to make some
API calls or make something when the
properties has changed well in a list in
a context where you use it in a list
most likely you want to uh you know if
if the item is not changed you most
likely will want to use the same item is
like if something is inserted in in
front or reshuffle you most likely want
to reuse the same data for the component
rather than you know update the comp
data for each of them so that it matches
the New Order right in that case you
want to use a key each block
and lastly there's also one reason you
want to use a kit each block is when you
add transitions or animations when you
reshuffle the items uh this is something
we're going to learn later on on how to
add transitions or animations when you
add something to the list but here here
is how it will work with no with them
right you need to know uh you need to
keep the reference of where it was and
you have to move it up instead of just
updating the value right if you update
the value then there's nothing to
transition or animate about right so you
need to keep the reference you need to
know that okay I'm going to reuse the
same element but previously it's at the
fourth position now you have to shift to
the first position and while you move it
over you need to add some animation
that's how animation or transition will
work with a key each block
um so
uh there you have it a key each block
and I hope that I explain it clearly
with you uh and if you're not clear
enough uh watch the game watch this
video again and play around with the
reference or life cycle so that you can
clearly see the effect of you know
whether you're updating an element or
reusing your elements or create a new
element right especially when you insert
something it should be it should it be
created or should it be updated on on
existing elements in the video I share
with you the differences between each
block and a keyh block in particular how
the updates right so
um in the video I try to explain to you
with a lot of hand gestures and I'm not
sure whether you get it or not so in
this video we're gonna see how key each
block is different than each block
true visualization right so this video
is going to be visualized I have
prepared a very simple example with a
very nice slides so let's take a look so
here is my slides key each visualization
so let's first talk about how each block
updates so here I have an array
four items right each with ID and name
and here is my code where I use the each
block where each array as person
and in each iteration I will render I
will have like a list item which uh
inside that will have a person.name as a
Content as a text content right so what
you get is like this
uh Alfred Bob Danny and Elliot right so
we look through the we look through all
the persons within an array and then
there we have for this item
so what happens if I add a new item so
here I add the third item in in between
uh the first two so right I insert one
item and the third position
and what see what happens so the first
thing that's going to happen is uh
internally so what I'm going to show you
next is um what's it's gonna happen
within svelt conceptually right it does
not happen one for one because you know
uh spelled May optimize the
implementation but conceptually it
happens like this right so that if you
get this idea clearly then probably most
likely or not um it will not change
right the concept the concept behind
will not change
so what happens when you have this is
what we will what we need to prepare is
what the end result would look like
right so
this is like the target result this is
what we're gonna We want to end up with
so what happens is then we actually
iterate through the target result and so
right now we are looking at the first
item which is Alfred and then we compare
with the first item of the current Dom
right what we have currently on the
screen versus what we're gonna end up
with so if compare the first item with
us for the Target and first item for the
what we have currently right it looks
the same uh the text content is the same
as well so we move on the next one so
the second item uh second iteration we
have personal name which is Bob uh and
it's exactly the same of what we have on
the screen so we move on the next one so
the next one the next personal name is
actually Charlie right in our array the
third item is actually Charlie but what
we have on the screen is Danny so
Charlie is not equal to Danny so we
change Danny to Charlie so so over here
after the titration after your updates
it looks the same now so we move on the
next one
next one we have Danny because the
fourth item is Danny right now and what
we have on the screen is Elliot Danny is
not equal to Elliot so we update Elliot
to Danny and then we'll move on to the
next one so the next one is Elliot's but
on the screen we only have four of these
items so what happens is we create
another one create a new item and name
it Elliot and we insert it in the screen
right instead in the Dom and there you
have the end results
so five items as you can see over here
in the process we update two list items
and insert one at the very end right
although we conceptually we know that
when we look at the array we know
actually we added only one item and
there's no change right we insert one in
the center but in terms of operations
that swell does to updates
um the Dom to match up what we want to
render in the end we actually end up
with two operations two updates
operations and one insert uh operation
at the end of the list
so let's take a look at another example
which is to remove an atom item right
now if you have have a notice we remove
the second item right second item is Bop
but we remove it now so this on the top
or the bottom right corner is what is
the target what will end up to look like
what we want to end up to look like
so uh
once you have the target we again we do
the same operation which is We compare
item by item right the first item is
Alfred uh first item is Alfred in the
screen the same we move on the next one
next one what we have on this on what we
want to render is Charlie but on the
screen we have Bob so we're gonna rename
that we're gonna update that list item
to show Charlie in the states and then
we'll move on to the next item next item
what we want to render what we want to
see on the screen is Danny the third
item is Danny but what we have the third
item is showing Charlie so we'll update
the list item change it to Danny and
we'll move on we have Elliot but Danny
is not Elliot to updates Elliot and move
on uh now we reach the end of the list
of what we want to render but we have
some extra list items in the screen on
the Dom right what we do is we remove it
right no extra elements so we remove
everything and this is what we end up
with although by comparing the array we
know that we remove the second item but
if you look at the the target results
and try to update the current Dom
towards that Target results what we do
end up is we remove one item and modify
or update three this item so that is
what happens under the hood right that
is what happens
so
is there a way that we can tell svelt
the engine tell it that okay actually
you know what this is what actually
happens we remove only one item and just
do that right or tell it that okay we
don't we we only insert one item in this
in the middle of the list just do that
can you do that well we can we can do
that by using a key each block
so what KH block is different from
normal each block is that
we add this bracket and in this bracket
we have Expressions telling um spells
that for each of the item within a list
one is the key it can be anything it can
be any Expressions but whatever it
evaluates into what you see is that okay
right now we created four elements and
for each of the elements we also
evaluate its key so we have we use the
person ID as a key so on the screen we
also have we have the key as one two
four and five right so this uh this
represents the key of each of the item
and let's take a look at what happens
next so what's happened next is that we
insert a third item right into the array
so this is what we will end up look we
will end up what we would end up what we
want to end up with right five item each
of them with the key which is calculated
evaluated on the right
so what's next
what's next is uh svelt will actually
first go through the the Dom go through
a current Dom go through all each of the
item
and use the key
as a key use the key as a key of a map
we will create a map use the key as a
key of the map and then each of the the
value would be a reference to the actual
elements on the Dom
so this is what we created we have a
four entries in the map one two four
five each of them is pointing to the
elements on the Dom right so if you
compare this item and this they're
exactly the same so this is construct
conceptually what happens it may
differ a bit on what actually happens
under the hood but this is what happens
conceptually right imagine when you have
pH block what will do every time we want
to update we will create like a mapping
of a key to the actual elements
and then let's take a look at what we're
going to do with that mapping so first
is we're going to go through the Target
and we're gonna go through one by one
and then compare the key uh component
key
of that element and then we see whether
we have that element on the screen or
not
right so we we have the first element is
Alfred and we look at the key the key is
one we go through look at the mapping
okay mapping one has Alfred right so the
the content is the same okay let's move
on
so let's look at the second element on
the target results we have Bob which is
the key too let's take a look do we have
key two yes we have and content is the
same so we don't do anything
right next is Charlie Charlie is key
three do you have a key that's number
three in the map no we don't so what we
do is we create one and then we
create that at least element called
Charlie and then insert it into the
mapping right so this will be inserted
later on right this is something we need
so we created one list item and let's
move on We compare the fourth element
which is Danny key four do we have key
four yes we do next we have Elliot's key
five so do we have uh
key number five and Elliot yes we do in
the mapping yes we do okay so we are
done with the targets and let's take a
look let's go through the target again
which compares to the results right this
time around we just look at the key
right we have created all the elements
for all the keys that will end up to be
right in the Target result we have
already created all of them in a Target
in the mapping right uh things that are
keys that already exist will also be in
a mapping so we already have all the
elements we need
so now it's just go through the list for
example we look at the key one compare
key one okay and then we look good and
since it's already there so we remove
from the mapping right we don't need it
anymore let's go for key two key two on
the results okay that's correct now
three key three right the the target one
two one is key number three exit at this
position right now but what we have at
the position right now is uh not key
three is is four right so what we do is
we insert it the key number three inside
this results
uh and then we move on right next is key
number four we have uh right now we're
also seeing key number four in the
results in the current Dom which is
correct then we move on key number five
we look at the Dom key number five which
is correct okay and then that's all and
we take a look at the mapping we have
almost every elements all the elements
is being used up so which is good and
let's and we can call it a day
so uh hopefully you can see that what we
have go through so far is we only create
one list element and then we insert it
into the right position and left the ref
rest of the elements untouched
right this is by by doing the way we do
it do this is by marking each of the
element with a key and then we use the
key to compare whether that element
exists or not only we create elements
that if the key does not exist
right and we when we want to update we
also compare elements based on the key
so if uh if the current existing element
is the same key has the same contents
then we don't have to update them
let's take a look at another example
when we try to remove an item right so
over here we have remove bulb just like
how we did we remove Bob the second item
in the ish array each logic Block in a
previous example
so let's take let's do the same thing
again let's go through right now on the
screen we have five elements with five
different keys and what we want to end
up is only four elements with four
different keys
so first thing first is we go through
all the elements on the current Dom and
then build this mapping right so we have
five elements so and five different Keys
one two three four five
and now stick let's go through the
Target and see uh go through Key by key
element by element and then see whether
it already exists on the mapping or not
right so we look at right now the key is
one uh there's already a mapping uh
there's already an entry with a key
number one in the mapping contains the
same so we move on
three we have key number three in the
mapping content is the same so we move
on okay number four we have four in the
screen mapping is the same in the
mapping content is the same so we move
on
key number five the same
we move on right
now
let's take a look at now let's go
through a Target go through each of the
keys again and go through
um the re the current Dom right so first
element is key one and what we have also
key one okay so we can strike that off
from the mapping
second element is key three and let's
take a look at currently we have key
number two which is extra Okay so it
does not mean that we're going to remove
this immediately but we're gonna take it
out from the Dom
right and then yeah take it out from a
Dom that's all right so here we call it
slightly different just just to let you
know that this is something uh it was
there previously in the current dome but
we've taken up temporarily right now
so with that taken out let's take a look
at the next element the next element is
key three on the Dom which is map which
maps with what we have and then so we
move on right key four we want key for
next and we have key for in a Dom let's
move on we want key five next and we
have key five on the Dom which is great
so uh we have all the elements we have
all the elements in the targets and
let's take a look at what we left in the
mapping these are elements that we are
not going to need it anymore because you
know we have showed up all the target
results so these are extra elements and
we're going to remove it so so we clean
it throw it away
so we clean up the mapping by straight
away and that's all so by the end of end
of the whole
update cycle what you see is we end up
with four elements with four different
keys right that element is removed all
right so operation wise what happens on
the Dom is we remove one element and
that's all we didn't update any elements
and only remove one element which is
what we want
let's take a look at a last example of a
key h block update
here if you take a look at the array we
swap the second and the third item right
so right now the order will be Alfred
Denny Charlie Elliott
so we have what the target at uh we have
our Target Alfred Dennis Charlie Elliott
key 1435 and what we have on the screen
is one three four five
right so first thing first we create a
mapping out of the edges current uh Dom
so we have all the keys and the
reference of the Dom elements on the
Stomp
and go through and we go through each of
the key by looking at the elements uh
finding the key where the Alfred uh so
where the key number one is as is in the
mapping it does content elsewhere is the
same okay we move on camera four and
this is in the mapping contains Danny
Danny the same key three Charlie Charlie
the same we don't have to update
anything Elliot uh key number five is
Elliot and we have key number five for
the mapping and Elliot Elliott is the
same we don't have to update anything
that's great and now let's go through
this again
um by just looking at the key right we
have key one we have key one on our
first elements on the Dom that's great
let's move on we have key four on the
what we want is key for and what we have
is key number three on the screen okay
that is not correct so we're gonna
temporarily take it out
um take it out for now and let's take a
look at the next element on the screen
which is keynote 4 which match what we
want right and
that is that uh so we can strike that
off from the mapping and let's take a
look at the next elements we want to
render which is key number three
and what we have instead is schema 5 on
the screen which is what
not what we want but let's take a look
at the mapping right mapping wise we
have key element key 3 with a Charlie
right a reference to a Dom element
called Charlie so we insert that in
I will insert that in
and since we insert it in then we are
good and we move on to the next one
right so we look at the Target we have
km5 let's look at the Dom right now also
key five so it's the same and that's all
all the elements we have already we
already go through the target results
all the keys are there and we call it a
day so that we have it
um so key each update also will help us
rearrange item right we you see that we
take it uh took
um the element Charlie out and insert it
after Danny right uh this is how what it
will happen conceptually but
um in terms of like what actually
happens under the hood whether we remove
Charlie and innocent after Danny or
maybe the other way around where we
actually uh remove Danny and insert
before Charlie that is uh that is
implementation detail you don't have uh
it could be optimized uh different ways
in future so we're not going to say that
that this is exactly what happened but
conceptually what you see is that with a
key you know that element has been
rearranged and the only operations you
need to do is to pull elements out and
insert it at the right position and that
will be it
right so we have seen three different
kind of operations uh adding removing
and rearranging items and we have
compared that with how uh it will
how how the update operations is done
for the each block we see that there's a
lot of updates if you don't have a key
and we see that if we have a kit each
block uh the up the update operation
should be slightly more so-called
optimized of course uh in terms of less
updates on the elements but of course
you trade it off with having more memory
consumed because you have to have a
mapping of all the keys versus the
elements and go through a slightly
longer operations of comparing elements
with the key and the mapping and
rearrange items right so
there you have it there you have the
difference between uh each block and the
key each block with visualization
so today we are going to talk about how
you can fetch data in svelt's components
and how you can use a weight block to
make that make your life easier
so
let's take a look at an example that
I've prepared for you
so over here we have a app.spel
component which we have a list of breeds
okay only have three
but the reason of using uh uh so this is
these are dog breeds right and we have a
we have a select a drop down uh elements
and we use each block we learn about
each block and here we are using it
right now right we learn and we use
apply what you've learned
so we uh we use each block to Loop
through all the Brits and we create
um an option element on every iteration
and we use a value over here
and we bind value right you learned that
before if you haven't even know how to
use it links on the descriptions to that
previous video that we have talked uh
discussed previously
so you bind the value of the select
element with this variable called
selected breed
so these are dog breeds and the reasons
you are using dark bridge in our example
is that we have this API called doc Co
or doc API sorry docso doc API
uh this uh
API will return us a list of
docs or random or it can return us a
random dot images based on the breed so
this is the API http.co API breed breeds
image.com random
so we are going to use it to fetch
random dot images over here and so so
let's take a look at how we can do that
so first thing is every time when
selected breed has changed we can call a
function to fetch uh our dog images
right so uh we're gonna have a variable
called image source so this is a
variable that will start the image of
the dock and we're gonna display it on
the screen so we're gonna come over here
and say image
source is the image source
and of course we need the L alt which is
a duck
picture
right
sorry dog I'm gonna say dot
and now we need to function to update
this variable so we're going to create a
fetch
dot image
and we're gonna pass in the breed
and we're going to call the API over
here so I'm gonna say French I'm going
to use the window.fash API
uh pass in the grid over here
breathe slash images at random oops
whoa hold on
fetch okay
so this will return us as a promise and
we have a promise we're gonna say dot
then so the promise will return resolve
with a response so the response itself
will have some methods and one of the
methods that we're going to use is
called uh Json so this will
uh pass the body of the response and con
as if it's a Json object and then will
return us another promise
and This Promise itself will have the
body right so if you take a look at a
doc API uh if you okay let's see the
documentation it says that
uh the
API will return an object which contains
two field right the message and the
status which it says whether it's
success or not so message we're going to
come here and say so this will be an
object right and object.message
is gonna be the image URL so I'm going
to assign it to image source equals this
and we're good
of course uh what if the API fails then
or any of the steps that above feels
then you will need to catch them right
so you to catch a promise you use dot
catch
and this will give us an error object
and what should we do with an error
right for now what we're going to do is
uh we're going to have a variable called
has error uh and initialize with false
so every time we have it we're going to
say it has error is true all right so we
can show some generic error message
so every time we start fetching we're
going to reset this to false so this
will be reseted every time we fetch a
new DOT image
so uh come over here and we say if
has error
then I'm gonna say we're gonna show like
oops
something
wrong
right
and we only show image if
a
if there's no error right so if else
there's no error then we're gonna show
the image
but then you see that uh before we
finish anything the image is uh
we haven't have any image yet right so
in this case okay we need to call the
fetch right so uh we want to call this
fetch dot image every time when a bridge
change
so we're going to use a reactive
statements if I haven't know what
reactive statement is again videos on
the description
we have done that previously so we're
going to cover this in this video I'm
gonna say uh fetch dot image we will
breed
selected
breed so this statement will be
re-evaluated every time when the Brit
has changed or the fat stock image
function has changed right this one we
won't change it because we initialize
once and we didn't update this variable
so so far from what we can see over here
is every time we change selector this
one should be called right and true to
that every time we change something it
will be called
uh but when we change something uh we
see that
while we're fetching we didn't reset
this image source right
that's why you can see that it's showing
a previous image until the the response
is back so what happens if we come over
here uh
what we should do is come over here and
we should reset it right to now
right so every time when you change it
is reseted and then you see when it
returns from the API response and then
only you show the image of course it's a
bit
ugly if you show an image with no sauce
right and usually what when that happens
is actually when we are fetching
something right we can have a flag
called it's fetching
so initialize is false
so every time we call every time we
start fetching we're gonna say it's
fetching is true
and we are done uh
and when we are done we say I'm going to
set it to false right and we are done
it's either we have a
uh resolved or we have catch right so we
can actually do that called a finally
this is at the end of everything right
either we have an error or either we
have finish uh resolve either we have
resolved with a value or we have
rejected the promise has been rejected
with an error finally we will still be
caught right so this will sets the is
fetching to be false
so uh now we're gonna come over here and
say if it's fetching
then I'm gonna show loading
and else only we are going to show the
results
this is fetching
right
seems like the finally is not being
oh wait it does
right so loading and results loading and
results
so here you see how we can
fetch a new dog image every time we
change the bridge
so this is how you're gonna fetch data
in as well components
but this is troublesome right because
you you have to maintain the state of
whether it's still fetching or not or
whether it has error or not and and turn
on and off that flag to signify whether
you are fetching or you finish fetching
but you have error or you have finished
fetching and you don't have error and
you have a result
right and this is a very common patent
and we come out with a way to write it
easier easy more easily right
so the way of writing it better is using
a width or chip block so width is like
how you would await a promise
so talking about awaiting a promise
right now what we do over here is more
of like a promise chaining way of
handling promise right an alternate way
of doing this of or writing this let's
say async uh wait
using a weight
we're gonna use a width to do that right
so this uh this function and this
function is going to be the same uh in
terms of the execution but one of it is
using a weight and one is using a
promise chaining right uh it's just
difference in terms of style on how
you're going to write them so you can
await a promise
and every time when you await a promise
what it returns is the results so over
here what we get instead is the response
and with the response we are going to
call
response.json which also returns as a
promise so we await for that
and what we end up getting or what we
want to get is the object so let's see
equals to oh wait over here
and with the object
we can assign image source equals to
object Dot message
which is what we have done over here so
you can remove these two lines
and if there's an error we want to catch
it so we can write wrap the whole thing
with a try catch block
and catch it with an error and over here
what we're going to do is call has error
equals to true
and with a try cash flow you also can
have a finally
and this is where we're gonna pass the
finally in right so finally it's
fetching is false
okay so there's a reason why I try to
rewrite this whole thing in a try cash
block
because
um this is how an awit block would look
similar to this right a width is using a
weight it's similar to a weight in
JavaScript
so we overall over here what we are
waiting for is a promise right uh these
two are actually the promise uh we we
have two promise to wait right we wait
for the first to finish and we wait for
promise to resolve in a Json object and
we use that results right this is where
we actually use the results so uh to
make it clearer I'm gonna re copy this
and
into another function I'm going to say
uh
get random talk image
okay so here I can rewrite the whole
thing with this
breed
so always get random dot image breed
give me a response okay so you should
give me an object and object that
message is the image source
okay so now we are closer to how what we
want to write in the end in a weight
block right so let me collect some of
the code that we are not going to use
right now
right so the first thing of how you
write an awits block is you use you
start with a hash sign and you start
with a width and and whatever you do you
also have to remember to end it with a
slash and a weight
so over here the first thing we're going
to pass is is the promise and the
promise is this this is the promise that
we're going to wait for and this is the
results right so we're gonna wait for
this promise
come here wait for this promise
uh and we're not calling Bridge we're
gonna selected breed okay
and review for this promise and and then
we have a den which is when this promise
resolve what we get over here is the
object so we can copy object over here
and with the object what we're gonna
show is we're going to use object a
message as the image source all right so
we're going to copy this
paste it over here and we also have our
image so you can copy the image come
over here replace this with the image
source
okay
and over here we also do a catch right
if there's an error so cache is also one
of the uh thing that you can have in a
weight block so you can catch an error
and the way of handling it is to so when
this is true we're gonna show an error
message right so we're gonna copy this
and paste it over here oops something is
wrong and now when we are waiting when
we're waiting we show a loading right so
this is what we're gonna show in States
so we when we are waiting we have
loading and when we have results we're
gonna show the image and when there's an
error we show up something is wrong
so now as we change you'll see that we
have loading okay let me commence this
out so that you know we are not looking
at this uh we have loading and we change
we have loading and then we have a new
image
right and if you come over here and if
we purposely change something right typo
and what you get is oops something is
wrong
so uncomment this we have our dog image
back and so you can rewrite this using a
width block and what we end up is we can
throw all of this away we don't need all
of this anymore right we don't need this
uh don't do this all of them is we don't
have need to write them anymore just
need a function that returns us a
promise
and we can call that function over here
if you don't want you can come over here
you can have a variable called Promise
or any variable name you like right so
this will get evaluated every time when
selected has changed and can use this
promise variable to replace this as well
so now it is the same so which means
that a weight can have any Expressions
you want as long as that expression
itself is a promise and there that and
and you go right and every time this
expression This Promise changes or any
Expressions we even hear changes
that returns a different promise then we
will have to relay the whole logic block
where we will show loading and then we
resolve will show the results
or if there's an error we show the cache
block
so uh let's take a comeback and take
another look at the code over here that
when we use an awaits block
right so over here we instead of getting
object a message over here like this
using a property reference we could have
um this structure it right we could have
Destructor a message out of it using
object destructuring and just assign the
variable directly right you could do
this as well uh and which block you can
come over here and destructure it if you
want
uh it's the same
right and then
and the next thing I'm going to tell you
is that some of this block
can be skipped right the promise can be
skipped the result can be skipped or the
error handling the error block can be
skipped as well
does that mean well that means is that
what that means is that you can skip it
so uh to skip bits you don't even need
uh to write that block at all you can
come over here and say await promise
dance and then you show the results
immediately right there you go you can
skip the results right or you can have a
you can have loading but you skip the
whole results
right you skip the promise you skip the
loading you can skip the results or you
could skip the error handling as well
right uh let's see you can just like how
you would await promise dent
what you can do over here is also you
can avoid promise catch
and do it this way as well right so in
this case our promise has no error has
no loading State you see nothing
right
so these are other forms of the obit
block where you can have part some of
the blocks uh be omitted because you
don't have if if you don't have anything
to show right uh this would lead to
other interesting pattern for example
you can use a width block to show only
the loading State and when some so you
can have a component called loading
components and only
only render something when the promise
being passed to you is in a loading
state in a pending State and whenever
it's resolved or rejected you'll show
nothing right so you could have some a
component that like that
so uh in this video we learn about how
you can use fetch in as well component
and we've seen by moving things around
we slowly comes into weight and how we
write it using async with syntax and we
realize that actually we can have even
easier to write an easier way to write
it or a similar way to write it in a lot
a weight logic block which kind of match
the a width in a JavaScript block so
we've seen how we can use a weight block
and we've seen how we can omit some of
the blocks if you don't have anything to
show
so today we are going to talk about key
block not key each block is a key block
so we've talked about a few logic blocks
about if each await and today we're
going to talk about key
so what is the key block
well have you ever have this
scenario where you want to
recreate elements or components when
something has changed
right it's not like you want to it's not
if where you because of the condition
you want to show a height it's more like
if this condition is if this variable
has changed I want to recreate component
recreate the components or recreates
elements
uh sounds vague right who would want who
wants to do that well I will show you an
example and you understand why before
that let me show you uh how to use a key
block
all right so over here I have one
example a very simple example uh I have
an input and I have a buttons so input
is something I can type and buttons is
when I click it will increments the
count
sounds simple right okay so what if
whenever the count changes I want to
recreate the input
okay don't ask me why but what if I want
to do this right so if I want to do this
what I can do is I can come with here
and say key
so every time when you have a logic
block you start with the curly brackets
and hash sign so this logic block is key
so we're gonna save this and we're gonna
end with key
and uh in the logic block we say key and
then we write an Expressions so this is
uh kind of like your reactive
declaration or reactive statement right
you can put in any kind of Expressions
uh you uh you treat it like like a
reactive statement so any variable
within that expression changes this
whole thing will be re uh created so the
input will be recreated so I'm going to
pass in count so every time when I click
uh the number increment the number and
when I change count this input box is
recreated so how do you know it's
recreated uh when I type something right
and I click this you see that when I
type in is it's gone right actually I
didn't really I didn't go and change the
value of the input but rather that
inputs the previous input with all this
value is thrown away and a new input is
created in replace of uh replacing this
current input right so when I click I
create a new one and replace it that's
why you don't see anything
so this is the key block let me clarify
a bit uh if uh when so the key block
will whenever the expression has changed
and the value of that expression is
different so it depends on two
conditions right first is whenever the
expression is changed it will be kind of
you will re-evaluate the expressions
like your reactive statements and to
compare the result of the expression and
whenever the result which is the value
of the expression is a change then the
content inside inside the key block will
be recreated right all the so if you
have input here the input will be
recreated if you have a few divs or
contents for example here I have another
count and a divs uh all this will be
recreated
so what what is so good about this uh
like what is the purpose of having this
uh key block right so one thing uh I can
show you which is based on something we
haven't learned yet but I'm gonna show
you which is if which is to add
transitions so transitions so let me do
like a fade transition
so for transition uh transition is like
an animation where it it applies to
element when it is created and added to
the Dom or when it is destroyed or
removed from the Dom right so this
animation will play uh when it comes in
or you will play when it goes out so I
can add an animation to fade in when uh
when this div is is is created so now
whenever I increase uh the number over
here you see that this div is destroyed
and created right because discount value
of count is changed has changed so this
div will be recreated every time and
therefore you see that every time when
it recreates you replay this uh fade
transition that's why you can see that
it's it's come fading in every time when
you change the value
so this is probably one of the use cases
that you would want to use with key but
there's another case where I feel it's
even
um
it's not just about animations there are
cases where you want to recreate
components so over here I prepared
another example where over here you can
see that this looks like a chat app
where you can click on different users
and you can type message try to chat
with the person right right now you're
talking to Charlie or Ben or Dawson
right so of course you see but you over
here you see that does not really work
over here although we have a list of
names and whenever we click on one of it
we will change the selected friend right
I use each block I use a radio box to
buying group we've learned that before
uh and we right over here we pass the
selected friend to this component called
chat
so in a chat component what we have over
here is a
um yeah we we have a props called friend
and we read out the name uh we have
chats and we try to load the chat what
we don't what we didn't do over here is
that whenever a friend change we
actually have to uh reactively update
all the different inner states right for
example over here the name name is
initialized whenever we create a chat
component and whenever this props change
we actually never update this variable
name that's why you see talking to name
is always the same person even if I
switch to different people so I can I
can use reactive uh statements that
already declare the name every time when
I change right I'm talking to band I'm
talking Alfred I'm talking Dawson all
right same thing goes with messages over
here when I type something what you
expect is whenever a switch to different
users you want to
um
I'm going to clear this uh this this
import input over here right so this
input uses a buying value to bind value
of the input to the variable called
messages which is initialized to be
empty string makes sense fair enough but
now we kind of have to you know whenever
a name change name exchange we want to
initialize something right so we create
a function called init
and or or reset right we want to reset
uh so we create a function called reset
let me let me write it over here reset
so I reset what I reset do is it will
send message to an empty string so
hopefully when I type something and I
switch to different user it will reset
by
setting an empty setting message to
empty string right and as you can see
over here also one thing that is
important is the chat message where when
I switch to different users I need to
load a different uh
a lot of different chat messages so I
need to come over here uh instead of
calling it over here I need to
paste it in the resets right it's it's
kind of like reset whenever you change
the name
right it sounded weird when you change
okay maybe when you change friend
whenever the friend has changed we'll
call reset right although we're not
gonna for now we are not doing anything
yet but probably we will use the friend
uh okay maybe we use a friend's name
uh to to load the chat
so when I switch over to band you see
that it's loading uh a band's message as
usual Dawson you'll see that it's
loading a Dawson's message
but if I switch quickly
you see that it loads Charlie's and then
Benz and Alfred and then Ben and because
it's the same components over here uh
when when and and our logic is quite
simple we just call this load chat every
time when we change the friend
and whenever it's come back it will
update the chats right so uh you can see
if I change quickly I'll update the load
chain will be fired a few times
subsequently very fast and whenever it
comes the first one comes back to update
the chance and then the next one will
come and updates right uh so this one
whenever we change when we call this
function every time we we kind of have
to actually cancel the previous one
before we so it's like a reset your
reset we need to cancel previous ones
before we
um
load a new one so this is something we
need to do as well so there's a lot of
things we need to do like reset things
whenever we switch uh to a different
friends when you're looking at a chat
app and actually you know what there's a
very simple way of doing it right we'll
learn about key and I say that whenever
the keys expression has changed
you will recreate right you destroy the
elements and recreate elements or
destroy components and recreate the
component instance so this is actually a
perfect
scenario or use case to use a key
um I let me let me undo all this right
let me undo all this but I say let's
name equals a friend's name uh let's
message to be an empty string and then
we call a load chat right we call a
little chat over here so this is a
perfect simple component where we don't
have much Logics over here uh everything
is is uh the initialized over here at
the start and all the states are
initialized to the style we don't really
handle whenever like we don't really
care whether a friend handle the case
where a friend has changed and just
treat that we just assume that it's not
going to change right in this component
so so the logic within the component is
much simpler and when we come over here
we can actually use a key block
to say that
whenever the friend has changed
we want to recreate this chat component
right whenever it's changed we recreate
so things that you initialize whenever
it uh will be kind of re-initialized
because you you destroy this component
and create a new one right definitely
you will have a new brand new component
with everything initialized and initial
initial States right so your code over
here is much simpler you don't have to
care about whenever friends change you
want to do something you can initialize
all the things you want and the thing
that you need to do is just just throw
it away and recreate a new one right so
the state over here that we in this
example is much it is fairly simple
right only a message fetching some data
and that's all but if you have a
slightly more complex
more complex components where you have
more
uh in more states that is uh defaults to
different kind of values based on
different kind of props and things like
that uh an easier way for you to is just
to destroy the component and recreate if
you want to reset the whole state right
rather than having a function that tries
to figure out what to reset and what not
and handle all the things right so
that's why there's this logic block
called key which really helpful when you
want to destroy uh whatever elements or
components within a block whenever an
expression the value of an expression
has changed and this is useful when you
want to reset everything within the
component or elements or you you just
want to recreate elements because you
know that you have an uh you have
transitions applied to elements so that
they can replace
or whenever it's coming in
So today we're going to talk about
context so what is context well context
is a way for a component to pass data
to all its children components always
child components all this grandchild
grandchildren in plural grandchildren
children any component that is within
this parent component will get the data
right it's a way for you to pass the
data to all of them
so if you pass data from what we learned
previously is you can pass by props
basically you have to pass one by one
but context is a way that you can set up
and all these children components or its
grandchildren components will receive
the data
so to see how we're going to do this how
we're going to use this context let's
take a look at an example that I've
prepared for you
so over here
I have app.spel
which uh shows a parent component so
this parent component is what we're
going to focus on right this parent
component has a child one child
um and this parent component will shows
a the child and pass the color called
red
right so now we have a child component
which has two grandchild
and to so to pass the data down we have
to pass this color to when child a and
grandchild B because we need both of we
need to color in both of the components
right grandchild a uses the color to
change the color of the text so as you
read when child B use the color to show
data right show show the color as a text
so you can have uh as many components as
you want over here right say I'm gonna
have another child child two
which uh I'm gonna create right now
but let's color and I'm gonna say ciao
two
the color
and maybe add some weird text over here
and we're going to import child too
so come over here and say import child
two from ciao to
and I'm gonna use child two and also
need to pass in the color red
right invalid tag name ciao hold on what
is okay child two ah okay this is
uh okay
so you see the parents so once okay let
me I I have two color rates over here
let me just make it nicer I'm gonna
declare a color called red
and as you can see if I want to pass
down the color
I need to do it one oh on All My
Children components and for each of my
children if I if it has a grandchildren
I will have to pass it down to each of
them as well so that uh so you can see
over here let me adjust this you can see
over here a parent has two children
child and child two and two
grandchildren grandchild one a
grandchild a grandchild B and you can
see we have to pass the color down layer
by layer to each of the components
so
alternate of doing this is to use get
context and let's take a look at how we
can use get contacts to do this instead
of having to pass down color level by
level
first thing first is I'm going to import
get contacts
from svelte
and I am going to
sorry set context so the parent will set
the context and all the child or
grandchildren that needs this value will
will use get context to get it from them
so I'm going to call set context
and I'm going to pass in two parameters
so set context takes in the first thing
is a key and second thing is the value
right so you can actually pass in any uh
you can have multiple contacts for one
component and it depends on the key of
uh what value you want to pass in right
so when you call get context in the
child you will get contacts with the
same key so they can get the same
uh some key of the context right so over
here since we're going to pass colors
we're going to name it color as the key
of the context and the value of it would
be the color rate
all right so I don't have to do this
anymore I don't have to pass Carl to all
my child
right so let's see ciao I I don't really
need color over here as well so can I
remove this and I'm going to pass it to
grandchild a
because you get it from the context
for childhood who we actually need color
right so the way we get it is we're
gonna say Imports gets context
from svelt and we're gonna get contacts
I'm gonna pick in the same key so the
parent use color so I'm going to use the
same key over here
so um
so they will return me the color so I
can use the color right now right so you
can see it's updated to color to red
so um in internally context is like a
map and this is the key to the map which
means you can pass in anything uh that
you can pass as a key to a map right so
um if you worry about getting conflicts
then probably you can pass you can you
can create an object right and and pass
and use that object for example I can
come over here and say a context
I can create a
key
so this is
a
an object that you created and you can
import this and use this key in your
contacts
right so because
um
so because the data itself is the the
key itself is by reference because it's
a map it depends on the reference of the
key then you can instead of worry that
maybe you know what if someone else have
this context name color will I get
conflict and this way you kind of can
ensure that this key will always be
unique right because this uh if you if
Because unless you get a hold of the
reference of this object you'll never
create an object that has the same
reference as this let's kill it over
here so I can actually come over here
and do this instead
right uh now you see it's not available
but I can come over here and import key
from Context
and replace this you can see now I I can
read it out again right setting with the
same key and this key is an object
reference and I'm going to get this from
there so I can and as soon as as long as
I ensure that the key reference is is
unique then I can make sure I I
basically I'm sure that I don't get
conflicts with naming keys with your
contacts right so let's let's finish
this let's come over here grandchild a
and you know import get from the context
so actually I can copy these two lines
these few lines
which is to get context import get
context from svelt and then import the
key and then I use get contacts with the
key to get the color
all right let me copy this over for
grandchild b as well replace this you
can see now grandchild B is a
also get the value rate
all right so all the children components
grandchildrenal components will get the
same value from the context
right now I'm going to create another
component called a parent
2 that's felt
and in this parent two component I am
actually going to import this a
grandchild a grandchild a from Grand
ciao
and I'm gonna show you why in the moment
but I'm gonna come over here and
uh
do this and I am going to import parents
two
in the apps that's felt
so grandchild a okay the now you okay so
the grandchild actually gets contacts
and from the parent
and use it as a color for the text right
so the context over here for parent uh
this parent is that the context value of
this key is the value for this context
is red right so all grandchild a gets
the value called red and then set the
color as red
but the grandchild in these parents too
uh receives nothing in the context so
most likely what you see if you try to
console out the color
you'll see that one is red and one is
undefined because you didn't Define the
context uh within this for for this
component uh grandchild a right this
grandchild a lives within parents too
and lives within which lives within app
and app does not set any contacts parent
2 does not set any context so it does
not get any value from the context
so we can actually come over here and
set it up so we're going to say import
sets contacts
from svelt
I'm going to say set contacts okay I
need the keys I'm going to import the
key as well import
key
from
context
key
and I'm going to say blue
right as soon as I do this you can see
this screenshot a which is in parents 2
which sets up the context which value is
blue and then now I get it and I can't I
install it as blue color right so one so
it depends on where grandchild a is
located whether it's within the context
of the parents the first parent then you
get color red which in the parents two
you get color blue
and context itself can't override each
other so say for example
the in this example we see that parents
creates a context right uh which is
color red and now I have child which I
have grandchild a and grandchild B right
let's let's also import
uh grandchild a
okay
in the uh in the channel 2 I'm going to
use it over here
so this is still within the context of
the parents which which has the color
red right but what if in the child who
I'm going to set a new context here I'm
gonna import this
okay I'm gonna set a new contact with
the same key right so although this uh
grandchild uh this child 2 receives a
context from the parent which is the red
color but from this channel 2 on below
it will set a new context for all the
children and grandchildren and this
context is going to have a value called
Green
right as soon as you do this all right
let's let's
all right it does not matter the order
but as soon as you do this you can see
that actually the order mentors okay
let's just do this you see that
everything below
color is going to be green right
grandchild a is is is Green Oh although
it's within parent
B uh sorry parents the first parent
right it says read but then parent
inside have a child to child tools
that's a context called Green which
overwrites it right so how do you think
about this is actually you you try to it
it matters on where grandchild is being
created so it looks up to the parents
right so the parent has uh the parent
has one A Child two child who has
contacts then you will use that one
right if it does not you go up again one
level and see parents parents as
contacts yes and then you use the parent
one right so as soon as it finds the
value then it will be override
overridden right
and apparently the order of set contacts
and get context matter
right so I think in in terms of
implementation it's a very simple map
right so if you set the value first for
this context then any time later on when
you're trying to get context from this
mapping it's actually being uh
overlapped overwritten right so now you
get contacts it's the value called Green
rather than red but if you get first and
then you set it
later on then you get uh this still gets
the one from the pattern which is
straight and then this will over
override it and become green
right but this will only override for
all these children right it does not
matter if you come over here and say uh
grandchild
sorry I think it should be come over
here and you know the order of child one
or two uh it does not matter right
because uh this will only override for
itself and it's all its children right
so whether it's it's sibling it's uh
whether the siblings whether you you
override the context first for yourself
and then you know whether does it affect
sibling well it does not
so here you go having a context where
you set up a way to pass data to all
your children and grandchildren right
um there there's a few rules on how you
use this basically first is that set
context and gets context has to be
called during component initialization
meaning right here right you can't call
it later on for example sets timeout
you can't do it like this right so this
is similar to a common life cycle
methods you can't call it outside
component initialization because this
function itself needs to know what other
com what is the component that is
initializing right now and then set the
context to that component so you can't
do it inside set timeouts same thing
goes with great context right so that is
rule number one and rule number two is
that it's not really a rule but it's
it's if you take a look at here you get
context this function will be only
called during initialization meaning
uh this value will only be read out
during initializing this component right
meaning again meaning if this value is
like a state where you change it
dynamically it won't reflect over here
right this this you reach up once so uh
it won't change later on if you change
the value of the variable in the parent
today we're going to talk about how you
can communicate through the context
in the previous videos we talk about how
we can use context to sort of pass the
data to all your descendants all your
children's or your grandchildren's
components and today in this video we're
going to talk about a more in depth
about how to use context to communicate
between the ancestor the parents and all
its descendants
right so today we're going to focus on
two directions of the communication
first is how you can send data from the
parents to all its descendants and of
course we're going to talk about how you
can from all its children's and
descendants send data updates the parent
right so we focus on two-way
of course the first way from parents to
all its descendants we kind of have seen
how we can do that in the
um
in the last video when we talk about
context but there are some more things I
want to add on so let's take a look at
this example over here
just my mic
so in this V in this example we
have an app component
and within the app component we have a
parent component which uh shows two
children component one child one and
child two uh in terms of code they are
pretty much the same it's just that you
know uh just want to create more
children over here I could have
um actually on a hindsight I could have
just used the same component and that
does not matter actually
uh nonetheless just leave it here
nonetheless uh what we can see over here
is
we want to pass the color the color
which is red we set context over here we
pass down the color from the app and you
see that we don't pass it through the
parents so the parent does not know
about the color at all it does not pass
like from children to all these
grandchildren but rather we set this
context in app thoughts felt and all its
descendants for example in child one and
two we can actually get the color by
calling get context
over here we can get the color
um color and now you can see that the
color is red so you you see the red
color
right so all this set context and get
context is called during the component
initialization let me reiterate it's set
context and get context it's being
called in the component initialization
meaning once this is initialized uh you
set you call this set color now right
now uh you basically set this color to
context right uh later on if you change
it anymore it does not matter right you
only call this function once this is a
variable uh and you pass in a value so
you pass by value because it's a string
is passed by value this value is already
in the context there's no way they can
change this value anymore unless it's an
object you can't change the object but
you can change its property right and
over here the same thing as well in the
ciao once is being uh initialized where
this function get context is called you
read this value out from the context you
have this color and that's it you can't
do anything you can't uh basically this
this is done right you you read this
value anything change in the context
somehow by whatever means it does not
matter anymore because you read this
value during initialization and that's
it right you don't call this function
anymore right if this color is a value
it's like a string number uh or Boolean
then that's it if it's an object the
object reference does not change anymore
but the property could have changed uh
you could have maybe set timeout or
interval to to constantly read the value
and see whether it's changed right it
could change because you can change you
can mutate an object a property value
so
uh and that's what we are going to do
actually because right here I have an
input call which is a type of color
which is a Color Picker and I want and
binding is a variable called color so I
want to change the color
I change the color but it does not
reflect over here
right so there's two reasons first is
this set context is set is called once
and that's all right so if you
um try to change the color it does not
matter to this anymore
so one way I can do is a probably I
would say two ways one is
maybe pass an object so I'm gonna say uh
uh a clear object called color object
and the value of the color J is called
color I'm gonna say rate over here
right so I pass this object down
and when I bind I actually use color
object
dot color
right so when I change I actually change
the color object the color okay I need
to change this as well
so you see that this is this is changing
on real time
and then children I can read out and
this is an object right so what it means
is that I'm gonna say color this this
guy context returns me an object
and I can get the color
from color object dot color
right this gives me the color so I can
change
um still it does not reflect but in
appearance I have a checkbox that I can
show and hide component if I unhide and
I show again now you see these values
updates uh there's no updates actually
because you you show you hide it you you
destroy the component and when you show
you actually recreate a new one and give
you a new component when you initialize
it reads from the context and you
realize that okay this object value okay
Char one this object value uh the
property the object itself the reference
of the actual cell is still a Sim but
then the property value is different
right now you read a different value
from this property and that's why you
see a different color
actually why I'm gonna remove this file
because I'm gonna change one for now so
just
but hope you get this idea right so you
you can change the object and now you
get it updated but if what if I want to
change this color and I want to see the
sorry
I wanted to I want to see the color
change on real time as well
well there's a few ways you can do one
is um in future videos you'll probably
see this I'm gonna talk about store and
you can actually pass a store
over the context and you can have a
reactive context via the star
right without learning about that we can
create like a simplified version of it
which is
um
I can say that let me think
okay
I can passive create another function
and this object is not just about the
the color itself I can also have my own
methods which is say I'm gonna have this
listener kind of mechanism where all my
children can list register itself to
listen to it so that okay so we're gonna
add uh listen let's say listen to color
change
all right so they can listen to it and
when the color change so that they can
notify it and read the latest value out
of it right so I'm gonna pass in a
function and here I'm gonna
um maybe keep a list of all the
listeners so I'm gonna create a set new
set
uh this set is going to call color
listeners
so I can come over here and add the
function in
and every time when I change the color
right every time I change I probably
will have to notify them so I can come
over here and say uh color object
uh dot color
so this is a reactive statement every
time this cloud has changed I would have
to
execute this statement so this
statements what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna say a color
listeners.4 h
listener and maybe I'm gonna just call
this with the new color
right this is a
so I'm gonna look through the listeners
and call each of the function with the
latest color right whenever the color
change so this is a reactive statement
and when does it uh execute re-evaluated
it will be Revisited by when all of
these variables has changed right so
what are the variables over here color
listeners is one color object is one
listen is not because you create a
listener over here and that's all right
so colorlessness has changed our color
object exchange we will um
uh revalid this statement but because
um over here we only call them add
method so add method does not cause a re
and method is neither like assignments
or updates uh
Expressions so basically this statement
over here
um
will not Trigger
re-render or revalue this statement
right but that is okay that that is uh
what we want actually as well uh so
let's after once we implement this
listen color change gonna come over here
and say in
well let's see if the color object has
another method right at listen to color
change and this can pass in a function
and the function itself
returns us a new color right new color
so what we can do with this is probably
we can set colors length so color equals
to new color
let's see oh this is color object
so as you can see now if I change my
color
you can see the color has changed over
here as well right because every time we
change the color we'll call The Listener
and you can
get notified when the new color is
changed and we update the color States
within this child one component right so
um when you pass data down it's only set
up during the initialization right so
the value that you pass in will be there
during this like when you it will be set
during initialization when you call set
context right so if you pass a string a
Primitives like string numbers booleans
then they will be
there will be it you can't change it at
all but if you pass in a more complex
objects like objects or arrays then
you can still mutate them although you
can't change the reference in the
context anymore but you can still mutate
them right and then during on the other
hand get contacts will be called during
initialization so
um if you if you destroy and recreate
you will you call this function again so
if you pass in uh objects during uh from
a context then if you mutate the object
when you call when you initialize the
object a component again you probably
read the latest value of the object
right but you still read the same object
reference right that you can't change
that anymore
so if you want to uh so-called
reactively updating the context value
and get it updated from the child then
you probably have to set some sort of uh
pop sub mechanism where you have a
publisher of changes and listeners
subscribers or listeners to subscribe to
the changes right over here we kind of
manually implement this and there's a
lot of things that we didn't handle for
example we didn't actually uh do a
cleanup so this listener will only
listen a function and we didn't clean up
right if you uh if we
a few times actually create a multiple
of child ones functions over here and we
actually didn't which are added to this
set and we didn't really remove them at
all and this causes some issues like
memory leaks uh which can be easily
handled if we are using store we should
be covered in future videos right stay
tuned for that
so we've seen how we can use get
contacts and contacts to pass data from
parents to the child right now we're
gonna take a look at a different
direction from children from all the
grandchildrens and children from
descendants to send data all the way to
the parents and usually when you want to
send data from a child to parent in
normal way what you do is you use a
callback or you event listeners or
callback functions right that is how you
pass data up if the parents want to know
something from you you want to pull
something from you maybe they can use
like a binding to binder one of your
props to a variable to the parents
variable so they can reach so that you
can update this uh parents States from
the props from your props but the other
way where you want to actively pushing
data from the children to the any
children to parents usually you uh you
still you you're taking a function where
of course you still have to get the
parents to pass in the function but then
you can call all this function anytime
you want to identify the parents that
hey I have something has changed
so this is what I did for the counts so
in in child one I have a buttons which I
use a component event and also about
forwarding events when you don't know
about forwarding events from components
probably you can watch my previous
videos so links in the descriptions as
well so this is to forward the event I
followed a click event to the parents
and parents forwards click events to
each parent which is the app which
listens to this event and registers
these events to on click so every time
when click happens or increment accounts
so when I click any of this button it
will increment account
so this is this is a lot of things to
set up right uh child have to dispatch a
component events to the parents parents
would just listen to it and dispatch and
to the app app has to do it as to
register it right if you add a few more
layers to the parents each of them have
to kind of forward the events upwards
which is a bit tedious
um it's just it's not like it's a bad
idea maybe you you want it that way uh
there is reasons where you want to do a
component event forwarding but in this
case we actually don't want it in this
case we want a very simple setup where
um I want my I want to create I want all
my children to tell me if they want to
click something right so what I can do
is
um I can set set up a context as well
okay instead of context
call click
and I can pass in this on click function
over here
right so this what this means is that
any children Within Me
can read this function called on click
via this context called click
and they can call them call this
function anytime they want
so um with that I'm going to come up
with you in a trial and I'm going to say
I'm gonna come over here and
get that function right so on click
uh get contacts click
and I pass this function to my own click
okay and now I can actually remove the
parents component for event forwarding
can also remove the event listeners from
over here
and let's take a look at what we have
right so we get the click function for
context and we call it right and lo and
behold it still works right now you
don't have to care about how many layers
in between all the children or
grandchildren all your descendants can
actually read these functions that you
want to call back and call them at any
time they want and you can actually pass
data up if you want to right so for
example if over here I say a on click uh
I can if I say I wanna uh uh maybe like
a Delta and so that I can increment my
accounts by a certain Delta right I'm
increment by one increment by two or any
numbers right then I can convert here
and do that if I want to right so this
is Click me plus one
and I can have a button called click me
plus two
which increment by two
and see if I click the number one I
increment by one click number for two
increment by two right I can pass any
kind of data up this this is now the CH
all your children will be like you're a
publisher of events and the app can now
change rules to become like a subscriber
of events I want to subscribe this
function called click anyone's can just
call this and notify me something has
changed right you can any of my children
can let me know when something has
changed this is the function to call
right I have set this context just read
it and by design of context uh what so
amazing is that your child one can be in
and different parents right it could be
with under this m.cell it could be maybe
under app2.felt as long as they provide
this function called click uh this
context called click but uh have a
different implementation of it it does
not really matter for child one right
where you are underlying where uh
no if you under okay which component
you're under then you will call which uh
which contacts you're under with then
your call which function that context is
set to
right so that's all for this for today
so we have learned about how we can
communicate uh from parents to children
via contacts
where you see a parents two children by
how we pass data out and we also see how
we can pass data from a child all the
way to the parent
today I'm going to share with you all a
concept in svelt which is the star
in particular what is a store and also
why do we need a star
is felt
so to explain this it's easier to look
at an example and so let's take a look
at this example that I've prepared for
you
so over here you can see that there's a
sample component in the app
and in a sample components we have one
input and a heading
which tells us the value of the value
variable so over here when we in the
inputs we have want input events
listener so every time when we type uh
the it will trigger input event and then
we will use the value of that input to
updates the value variable over here so
if I type something you will see that
the value changes immediately
right so within a sprout uh components
you when any variables is like a state
within a component right when you change
it uh you the reference of that variable
will be updated immediately
so you can see that changes on the
screen immediately right but what
happens if we are going to break this
input and the
heading one into two components and how
do we share
um variables or States across components
right so firstly let's do that first I'm
gonna say uh inputs component
and I'm gonna have
heading component
so on the inputs what I will have is
just the inputs
right over here
and in a heading I will have just
the heading right so there's no callback
function so just a heading
so how do I share this value with this
value in the input over here how how do
how do I Bridge them together so that I
can share the same variables or States
across the components
right so
um if you know about
uh props probably you can pass it in as
a props from one component to another
component
um but what if in our case the
components are side by side like a
sibling how do I pass one State's inner
state within one component to another to
its sibling component
um probably you might think of maybe we
can lift the state up we can define a
variable called value over here
in the parent com in a common parent
component and we can pass this value
down to the output so the inputs will
change this value and you pass that
value to the output yeah you can do that
but what if I have a few other
component
when
in this case when a
contract for example to show that this
may not seem as easy as you think
for example if I have a parent component
that renders the output
and then have another grandparent
component that renders the parent
and finally you use the grandparent
component in
in the common
parent right so this app right now
app.fl component is actually a common
ancestor right they don't they are not
exactly the input the output and input
is not exactly C blinks right now it's
like a nice
or nephews
grandchildren right
uh yeah so so how do you pass the states
do you pass one by one level by level or
you create a context over here and share
it across well you can do all that but
you might think one question is that
does the app does fail should the app.fl
knows about the variable value
right because over here it acts like a
mediator or ancestor that tries to
mediate all the verse all the different
states across all the children or the
grandchildrens
like a hub that controls all of them
right is that uh does this app does felt
component should the app.strual
component knows all of this should it
control all of this or is there another
way or an alternative that you can do
well we do not have to share
um the states and across like the
component hierarchy you can have it as a
separate file
so maybe I'm going to call this as
data.js
I'm gonna move this to the front because
this is the
thing that we're going to focus right
now
so why not we have this data.js that
exports a variable called value
as well as a function that we can update
it right spots a function that we can
update the value
right and in this case what we can do
here now is that you can come up with
the inputs and we can import updates
from data
and we're going to call this update
instead
and in the output we're going to say
import
value
from data
and use this value in States
right so now we can still share across
um we can have a common file that does
not that is beyond the app component
hierarchy and all these components any
components whether it's it's your
sibling your grandchildren your niece
nephew or your grandparents all of them
can just import this file
and you can share the states within this
file across all the different components
that scatter across your application
right so here I import the updates from
the data for in the input so that we can
update that variable and over here in
outputs we can import the value and
hopefully it's changed right so let's
try it out type the value
oh so the value does not update
well
why well that's because uh this data.js
is a Javascript file uh it's not and
it's felt component so the variable when
you update it is not reactive when you
try to change the value over here yeah
it's changed it's updated but it's not
reactive over here in this output of
swelt does not know that the value has
changed it will not
re-render or update the value over here
it does not know that it's updated so
what can we do
well again we can use like a
subscription model
um
like an event listener kind of style
where we can subscribe to the changes
that's happening within the data.js and
then what is when there's a new changes
uh we try to re-render ourselves right
so what we're going to do here is I'm
going to have a function called
subscribe
and we can take in a function that lets
us know let us know that what are the
functions that you need to trigger a
call when something has changed
so um right now I'm gonna have a
variable called subscribers
and a subscribe method is nothing but
pushing it uh pushing this function
burst dot push
into this subscribers list and when we
have an update we're gonna do is we are
going to notify all the subscribers that
hey this value has changed the
subscribers start for age
function we'll call
function all right I'm going to three
I'm going to call each of the function
tells them that hey uh the vet we have a
new value
so over here in outputs Source felt we
can call subscribe
and we can sub call this function to
subscribe to change
um
okay
so over here what should we do
right one simple way we can do is that
instead of using value directly so over
here what we know is that here the value
definitely has changed but how do we
tell that this has changed or what we
can do is that we can say value equals
value
okay that does not work because you can
assign to the value so maybe we can have
a variable called underscore value
we can use it here
actually use it here as well
and let's see so we type
yes let's change right we subscribe to
the data over here and when there's a
new value of the data
we get notified and then we update our
internal state which is the underscore
value variable and when it's the
internal state has changed this will be
re-rendered will be updated and you will
see the change reflected on to your Dom
immediately
so
um the concept of star is
this right uh you can have a variable or
like a data or some sort of states of
your application that is not uh
presented with that is not uh part of
your app component hierarchy it's in a
separate file right which you can import
across different components it does not
matter whether
all the components that's importing it
are
siblings or nephews or grandchildren's
or grandparents it's not a matter of the
how their
importing hierarchy within the component
app component hierarchy
right and then you provide a way to
change that value
and then to know that when is the value
is updated provide ways to subscribe to
it to know that the data has changed
so that uh you get notified right so one
thing we need to do over here as well is
that when we subscribe we also need to
unsubscribe right so there's two ways
one is you export another function
called uh unsubscribe
right
or and then so here is that subscribers
dot supplies
subscribers Dot and next of FN
okay we can remove it
are an easier way of doing this is that
instead of creating another API we
return this function immediately from
the Subscribe method
right so here what we can do over here
now in output.s field we can't import uh
on Mount from sweld
which we can subscribe to uh
during on Mount
and one cool thing about on mounts is
that you can return some a function
during in the on Mount which will be
called when this
component is unmount right so or when
the component is destroyed so here we
can return this immediately which is to
return the unsubscribed method so that
um
this function will be removed from the
subscription list or else if you
um still have still being subscribed to
it then you know you this will always be
called whenever the value is changed
although this component is no longer on
the screen and then it tries to update
some sort of component or it will create
some sort of a memory leak because
you're trying you're still trying to
update a component that is no longer
being in use right so it has to be
retained in the memory
so one way you can do it is doing like
this right it's on Mount and then return
a subscribe
so uh in essence this is a very uh this
is a concept called store in svelt you
can Implement a store like this yourself
or you can use some built-in uh store
Creator function that is provided by
swelts
let's talk about
um built-in shell store function right
these are built-in functions provided by
salt allows you to create store easily
right in the last video you've seen me
create like a subscribe function a
method and update methods and then we
manage our subscribers manually
you don't have to do it your own there
is a built-in's felt functions that you
can do so how you use it is that you
import them
from
asphalt star
so there's two uh two apis one is the
writeable and another is readable
right and as the name suggests a
writable star is read and write
that allows you to read and write and
readable store only allows readable only
right so both of the store has a method
called subscribed which is pretty
similar than what we have over here
that allows you to subscribe
um
to subscribe if the store itself has
changed so to create it what you can do
here is that let's Value Store
okay I'm gonna yeah Value Store equals
to writeable
and then you provide a default value so
over here I'm going to mimics this so
I'm going to say empty string
okay and I'm gonna export this right
and actually I don't need all of this
I'm gonna comment out
and when I come over here in the input
so I'm going to import the uh
value Star right
okay Value Store
[Music]
over here
so to update it there's a method called
set so I'm going to say values value
star dot sets
this value
right and then let's take a look at a
over here so now we don't have value And
subscribe we only have a value store
what we can do here is
um instead of Define it now over here we
can Value Store dot subscribe with a
value
I'm going to update value equals value
over here
same thing it returns an absorb scribe
method a function so I need to return it
over here
change it here like this and yeah we are
done
so let's try
something over here see it's updated
it's reactive so uh using writable and
then passing the initial function allows
save others a lot of time implementing
ourselves uh previously we've seen that
we have to implements like a update then
subscribers And subscribe method all of
this is done within a function called
writable and this is so much easier
right
So today we're going to work on readable
Stars
so you may ask like if the star is
readable only
which means you have no way that you can
update it from the outside then how does
the value of the star changes
well we're gonna look at it right now
so over here we continue from where we
stopped the last time
so just a reminder previously we have a
writable star which is going to be
updated by calling the store.set so over
here I'm going to type something you
will see that we update the store value
and then to listen to what uh when the
storm has changes we use the Subscribe
method to subscribe for the store
changes and the Callback function will
be called with a value that the latest
value of the star
so right now instead of writable we are
going to change it to a readable star
and with a readable star there is no way
you can call the set
right it is undefined it's not a
function so over here what we're gonna
do is gonna
removed it remove this input components
for now
right because there's no way they can
update the store from the outside
so with a readable store the first
argument at the same as writable store
is the initial value so over here if I
change the elliptical value to hello
then you can see initial value is hello
right now
and then one thing that is slightly
different or with with the writable
store is that the second argument is
actually something that you need to do
because without that you have no way
that you can update the readable store
no way that you can update the value of
the star so the second argument which is
optional for writable star is mandatory
for for
I mean there's no error but
it does not make any sense if you don't
provide it right so
this function is called
um
a start stop Notifier what does it mean
is it means that this function will only
be called when there is someone
subscribing to the store
right if that's so imagine you have five
people that's kind of subscribe the star
from the Zero from nothing from zero to
one uh from from no one subscribing to
someone subscribed then this one should
be called but then if you subscribe it
multiple times this function will not be
called anymore so it's only at the edge
of no one subscribing to someone
subscribing
and this function within a function you
can return a function
so imagine this function is like your
cleanup function you want to clean
something up so this function will only
be called when
from some subscribers maybe like one to
become zero subscriber then this
function will be called so it's a
cleanup so when when it reaches no one
is subscribing then this one uh this
return function will be called
right later on we're gonna look at uh
we're gonna see we're gonna console out
and prove this uh it works as I
explained right
so this function takes in one parameter
which is set
and this set is the same sets where you
see in your readable store basically in
a readable star you have a way that you
to set the value of the star this is
exactly the same one right so if I come
over here and I say Set uh world
you can see that initial value is hello
and then you set it to world right maybe
it's too fast your eyes cannot catch it
it's okay we set the timeout
over here
for one second I'm gonna call sets from
here
so one second later it turns to whirl
right hello world
so now you see it right
so uh as anything goes when you try to
set something up like set timeout you
need to clean up right what if uh right
before you even like trying to set the
world
um
everyone subscribes from your store no
one cares about whether your timeout
triggers right so you need to clean up
so when you set a timeout you need to
clean up so I'm gonna say uh timeout ID
over here
and I'm gonna say
clear
timeout
over here so now I want to show you uh
the point that I was trying to make so
over here I'm gonna console out uh I'm
going to say start
right so you only see one starts uh
right because we only have one
subscribers over here but what if I
remove this
then this never
started right the store itself has no
subscriber then it will not start at all
but if you come over here value
store.subscribe
when I'm passing a function over here
okay
um there's an arrow over here it's okay
let me save and refresh
yep I think the error is gone
um yeah so probably a bit error that
what happens just now is that we as this
whole code is executed as I type right
so I think when I type this is not a
function so it it creates you'll see
that error
and because as
uh every time we start we every stroke
that we type in we create a new timeout
that's why that error keeps popping out
so now I clear it it should be gone so
as you can see it says start and if I
paste this multiple times you can only
see one start
where if I remove all of them
no start right comment only one starts
okay so no matter how many times you
subscribed uh it only have the start
only call one so this you can think of
it as you only need to set it up only
once so uh that that creates the value
of the star
and if you subscribe then unsubscribe
them
answer
right uh
one two
see
three
four
I call all that I'm subscribed uh one
okay so this function I'm going to say
console.stop
and if I call unsubscribe once it's not
going to call two it's not gonna call
um tree still there and let's remove the
last unsubscriber and then you can see a
stop if I comment one of it you only see
start right so this tells you that this
will this function is like setting
setting up the store and only will be
called when there's uh starting that
there is one at least one subscribers
and then the subsequent subscribers you
will not see this being called and when
you tear down uh only this return down
function the function and return will
only being triggered when all of when
there's no more subscribers left right
until the last ones unsubscribes uh this
will be called
right so you can use a readable store by
this way by creating a function and you
can use this set to set whatever the
value of the readable store is
so in the previous videos we talk about
the writable and the readable stars and
I told you that in this video I'm gonna
talk about what makes the two of the
Stars similar
which is both of them actually follows a
strong contract so what is a star
contract
well before I deep dive into what is
this contract itself let me show you
something that um a secret syntax that's
felt provides
that leverages on this store contract so
if you have a star that follows the
contract you can use this secret special
syntax to get the value of the store
right so let's take a look at this
example that I prepared over here
so in this example I have two stores one
is a readable star which is star one and
the second star is a writable star star
2.
right
over here I have an inputs box which I
um imported the store tool and use the
store.set to set the value of the store
and over here in the output of spelled I
basically on the mount I subscribe to
both of the store
and then as the value changes I assign
it assign the store value to the first
value one variable and a value 2
variable right and over here you can see
the value of the Star by value 1 and
value 2 over here
um so the first star is a readable star
which the value of the star is being Set
uh via the set interval so every one
second you will see that the value will
be incremented by once
and for the star 2 we set it in the
inputs box right so when we type
something
we will set the value of the star over
here right like this
right and as I mentioned both of this
star follows the star contracts
and because of that we can use this
secret special syntax that provides
which is a dollar prefix variable name
right so what does that mean so if for
example if this star 2 follows a star
contract instead of just using a star 2.
sets and a value
we can use a dollar prefix of that store
value and we can assign variable
to its direct the value to the variable
directly right so dollar prefix of the
store variable so this is a special
variable
um that you can't Define anywhere
um so if you have a variable like this
basically you are referring to the store
but the value of the star and you can
assign value right trade it as a normal
variable you can assign
value to that store like this so is so
let's just try it out right so over here
when I try to type something
as you can see this behaves the same as
store tool that sets the value right so
instead of sets value we use a dollar
prefix of the variable equals and your
assign value to it to that variable and
it behaves the same
right so is that all that
um a star that follows a store contract
can do
of course not right over here
um this is only when we are trying to
set a value right how about over here
when we're trying to subscribe to a
value uh subscriber value of the store
right if you if the star one or Star 2
follows a star contract
uh we can directly access the value of
the star using a dollar prefix variable
of that star right so for example over
here I'm gonna say
store one so this will get the value of
the star of star one and use a dollar
prefix right so this is a shorthand for
a lot of things right first thing is
subscribes to the store so it does this
it subscribes to the store and then this
variable dollar prefix store one will
always have
um
will always be the updated value of the
store
and also when you unmount it it will
also unsubscribe from the store right so
it also does this thing when you return
the unsubscribe function where you
unmount right so it does three things
subscribe to the store and then this
variables the value of this variable is
always updated as the value of the star
and then when your component is
unmounted it will unsubscribe from the
store as well so you don't have to write
all this to clean it up you can directly
use a dollar prefix star 1 to access the
value of the star
right over here let's do this as well
store two
and as we type you can see the value of
the store is updated and reflected
immediately right so now we can say
goodbye to subscribing to the store on
Mount you can even remove the on mounts
and yeah everything still works fine
right so this is the power of the store
contract if you follow the star contract
anything any variable that follows a
star contract you can access the value
of the store via a dollar prefix syntax
and then you can set the value of the
Star by just assigning it
right so what is the star contract
so listen carefully right so as a star
um probably you have known you need to
have
two variable one is uh two methods one
is the subscribe
and another would be okay so I'm gonna
call it star tree
another would be the sets right so set
is for you to set
the value of the star and then subscribe
is to subscribe from it
right and as we create this and we as we
use the store
probably when you call subscribed you
probably will want to pass in a function
right the function that
uh a subscriber function
and this subscribe method should call
this function immediately synchronously
right you need to call it call the value
of this call this function with the
value of the value of the store
immediately right so right now I call it
immediately right you cannot say uh set
timeout
and then
you know call it later uh in in
the next take or next timeouts and
things like that no you can't you need
to call it immediately right you need to
call it with the current value of the
store or maybe your initial value or all
these things you need to call it
immediately
and then the Subscribe method should
also return a function
that's unsubscribes this function from
the subscriber list
right so one way you can implement it is
probably create an array called
subscribers
and then whenever you have a function
you're gonna push it in to the
subscribers list
and then the return function probably
will have to remove it so subscribers
dot Supply subscribe person and next of
FN
one
right so your subscriber method again
let me recap text in a function and you
need to call the function immediately
synchronously
and then this subscribe method should
return a function that unsubscribes this
function
right and then when are you calling
these subscribers when are you noticing
notifying them it's up to you right it
can be uh maybe like you have a time
timer for example over here maybe you uh
say set interval
and maybe it's a set interval for
one second again and for every one
second we'll Loop through the subscriber
list
subscriber of subscribers
and call them
with the value of the Star right so over
here I'm going to call
um
uh uh let's see probably let's create a
variable called uh I I mean okay let's
let's just create a
use the time so this is the time right
now
right so I'm going to call this
so uh so this star tree follows a star
contract which we right now kind of
Define the stock contract for the
Subscribe method
uh which is sufficient enough that we
can call store tree with a dollar syntax
and as you can see over here
this star tree values is updated on
every second right this makes your star
tree as your start three variable
follows a star contract now you can
access the value of the store via dollar
star tree
right and what is the value of the star
well that will be whatever value you are
going to call with the subscribers right
this function is a subscriber you call
it with empty string and the value of
the store is the empty string if you
call it with the current timestamp then
the current timestamp would be the stop
value
right
and if you're trying to access it try to
set the value of the star using dollar
star tree equals something
then the sets method will be called with
the value right so uh yeah depends on
what you want to do with it right you
can call you can set a value of the star
and then notify all the subscribers that
is one way so for example let me show
you for example if I sent and say
subscribers uh let's copy this for over
here
for each of the subscribers you're gonna
call notify with the new value
right and as I okay let's see
we have a button on click
um click me
right over here
when I say star
3 equals
um hello
right so whenever I'm type I'm click on
it the sets function will be set method
will be called and it will notify all
the subscribers telling that okay this
value of the star has changed to this
value whatever you are passing in which
in this case will be hello right so when
I click hello
right uh it's it's updated immediate uh
reflected back immediate because this
set interval is still happening right uh
if I remove this
no longer see anything it's not going to
update as a timestamp so when I click me
it will turn into hello and it will stay
there right
so
let me recap on the store contract you
mandatory as a store if you want to
follow a stock contract you would need
to implement it's an object that you
need to have a method called subscribe
it takes in a function and you have to
call that function immediately
and then that function is your
subscribers right so
um you can return a function to remove
that subscriber
and to notify whatever the value of the
store is you have to tell the
subscribers right so you have to notify
all the subscribers that a value has
changed
optionally you can Implement a sets
method which takes in a value which is
you want a value that you want to update
your store with
right so to kind of reflect that to tell
everyone that your store value has
updated you also need to notify all the
stores uh subscribers right whether or
not to notify them is up to you right
you can batch them you can
asynchronously call it after maybe after
you set everything and yeah on the next
kick and things like that but
the outside world would not know what
the value of the store is until you
notify them
right so this sets method is optional
because for example as you can see
readable store does not implement this
you can't set the value of readable
store because this set method is not
there
but the Subscribe method is mandatory
right as soon as your variable follows a
star contract
what you can do is you can use a dollar
prefix of that variable to access the
value of the store as well as using
assignments like this to set the value
of the store
right so if this is the star contract
so in the previous videos we talked
about how we can use store
to manage applications state that is not
constrained by the component hierarchy
of your application
and what makes Stars different is that
um if the star follows a star contract
we can use the dollar prefix variable to
access the value of the star and
automatically subscribe to the store and
unsubscribe when the component is
unmounted so in this video I'm going to
talk about some of the application State
Management libraries out there in
particular how are we going to use them
in a svelt application
if we can make them to follow the star
contract probably we can use the dollar
prefix syntax with them
So today we're going to look at one of
the state management Library which is
Redux
right Redux has been well known in a
react World where you use Redux with the
Redux binding that allows users to
connect and map the property from the
store State into your application props
right and you can dispatch actions to
which will be run through a reducer
which will create a new state of your
application
right so in this video I'm not going to
talk particularly in how we're going to
use Redux
uh like it's not a relaxed beginner 101
video but more of how you can make Redux
to follow the store contract and you can
use a dollar prefix syntax uh in with
the Redux store
right so over here as you can see we
have prepared some simple code
to use reduction spelled I have a Redux
file which I create a store from the
Redux package so over here I use patch
processors to define the process
environment because it it reads that but
once you run this which once you define
this variable process in the window even
if you remove it it will not cost
anything because it's already defined
right but you have to have it in the
first run
over here I use crit store from Redux
package and I Define a reducer function
which this function will tell takes into
parameter a state and action which uh
depends on the action you will Define
the next States right this will return
the next state based on the action and
we take this reducer and we pass into a
great store
which over here will return us a new
store
and we're going to use this store uh
there's two apis from the Redux store
the first one is the get state so if you
call get State you get a current state
of the store
and if you call subscribe you can pass
in a function to be called whenever the
state has changed right uh it does not
takes in any parameter for the Callback
function so to get the next stage you
basically have to call a store or get
State again to get this current state
right so these are the two apis State
guested and subscribed and then uh one
more is the dispatch right so here you
can dispatch actions so this action is
the one that's going to be passing over
here which if which over here you have a
switch case to decide what's going to be
the next state based on this action
so here I have two function stored
decrement and increments which I
dispatch a decrement action and
increment action
and over here I show uh I'm going to
call this decrement when I click on the
minus button and I'm going to call the
expression increment action when I click
increment here you will see the state of
the Stars changing because we have this
subscribe method over here which will be
called and then update the state
variables every time when the state has
changed so as you can see over here the
Redux store does not follow the spell
store contract
in a few points right so firstly is that
the function that you pass into the
Subscribe method should takes in the
value of the Star right you shouldn't
call
another EPA to get the state of the
store or which in this case is the value
of the Star right
and secondly
um
when you call subscribe methods this
function does not being called
immediately
that's why we have to manually set the
state of the store by calling store like
a state if you don't do anything
the state will be undefined because this
function will not be called
synchronously immediately when it calls
subscribed that is required for the
store contract
so we're going to fix that we're gonna
wrap it with another object that does
all this
right so
um I'm gonna keep using this star
variable over here but I'm going to come
over here and do the changes
right so over here I'm going to say uh
star uh Redux star
which is we call it create star
and then we're gonna
return a new uh sveld star that follows
a spell store contract right so here I'm
gonna have the Subscribe methods and I'm
gonna also have all the other apis that
Redux stores provides right so I'm gonna
spread this out Redux store and then
subscribe subscribe sticks in a function
which we're gonna call with Redux store
dot subscribe
um right
I'm gonna call
let's see the call with this function
that's it no we're gonna
call this and then for each of them
we're gonna call function within this
new function that we're going to create
right over here I'm gonna
call this function with the store dot
get state
so that the function itself right now
um
is being caught with the state of the
star
also we need to call it immediately when
we call it subscribe so I'm going to do
it here as well
and similarly Redux stored or subscribe
returns us and unsubscribe method which
is good because we can return it
immediately so that we can subscribe
from the store
and now this more or less follows the
spell store contract so I can return
this
and since it follows that contract
let's see spell store it's not defined
ah okay it should be Redux store Redux
store since it's follow the store
contract what we can do here now instead
of calling State and all this
gonna say comment this out I'm gonna say
dollar star
right now
uh this will give us the state or the
value of the star which is the state of
the redox star
right so when you click increment
decrement
as you can see it it works immediately
right and good thing about this is that
if you unmount these components we will
unsubscribe it as well because if you
follow spells store contract we will do
that for you
now as you can see it's it's much
simpler in a sense where to access the
value of the star you don't have to call
subscribed unsubscribed take care of
subscribing as well as store against it
all of this is being handled with just
one dollar
prefix variable right of course you may
think or you may ask me all this
complexity is being hidden but it's
still being done somewhere which is
being done over here which is like a
wrapper to make uh your Redux store to a
spell store right yeah maybe
you're right but we can I mean this is
pretty standard we can make it like a
function and we can call it like make
uh Redux store spell
into spell store
and I'm gonna pass in Redux store over
here
and I'm gonna copy all this in
I'm gonna call return
right this will return me
a new uh spell Star right so I can call
this
over here like this
let me so that it's easier to read yeah
so I can do this over here right now
uh right
nicely formatted
yep as you can see over here
this still works fine perfect so now I
have this function I can just call with
any Redux store and it will mix me a
spell store which follows the star
contract
so before I end this actually there's a
better way of doing this if you are very
familiar with Redux you probably would
know that Redux has an API call and an
answer
right and an answer is the second
parameter or the third parameter that
you can call
uh with when you're creating a Redux
store
right
and this enhancer
um
it's like a higher order function that
will text in the create store API and
returns a new create store API
and we can
have this uh
we can do all this in a real enhancer
and just pass it in as an enhancer in a
create store API right ideally similar
is just using a different uh using a
Redux API to do it instead of having to
wrap this
um make Redux store with your new store
right so let me show you how you're
going to do this so we're gonna say
it's felt star enhancer
which takes in a great
store API
right and then you need to return a new
create store API which is uh texting
reducer and initial States
so create store API texting reducer and
initial state
right so over here we're gonna call Star
equals to create store API with the
reducer and initial state
and then we can make we can return this
which is return this so this is a new
store we're going to create that
enhances the existing Redux store so
this is a Redux store
I'm going to enter format this nicely
here
Yep this is a spell store enhancer and
we can use this over here
by calling create store
with the enhancer
right and yeah and we may try to do this
it still works fine as you would expect
except that right now we're going to use
an enhancer instead of yeah wrapping the
create store with another store right
all this
um this is I would I would prefer doing
this because it
follows more of like a Redux API style
where
yeah it already supports so why not use
it use it right
so yeah if you want to take a read on
this Ripple the links is in the
description
I've talked about how uh spell store
allows us to share application State
across components without having to
worry about the component hierarchy
and this actually is a problem that is
being trying to be solved with all those
application State Management libraries
out there for example Redux valtios and
many many more if a star follows a star
contract we can use dollar prefix
variable to access the value of the star
this saves us time in terms of having to
set up boilerplates to subscribe and
unsubscribe from the store if you can
make the application State libraries
that we want to use follows the store
contract then we can have a very
simplest experience using them in
spelled application right so in the last
videos we have talked about how we can
make Redux store a special store which
if you haven't watched it please click
on the link on the top right corner
and in this video I'm going to take a
look at a different application State
Library which is valtio right so valtio
is a proxy based uh State library that
allows you to wrap an object into a
self-aware proxy according to them which
you can subscribe to any changes made to
that object right so
so you can have a subscribe method that
listens to any changes and when that
change you can get a snapshot of the
object at that point of time
right so subscribe unsubscribe pretty
much the same of the store so let's see
how we can use it in Asphalt application
so over here I have set up an example in
code sandbox
because of some package issue it's a bit
hard to set up on the spelled Ripple so
I do it on the code sandbox right so
over here
I have my app.spel and the data.js so in
the data.js I create a proxy State using
proxy from valtio vanilla so this let me
zoom in a bit I mean hopefully that you
guys can see it clearer
so proxy
well taking an object and create a proxy
state
which allows you from this data where we
import from f.field allows you to change
the data like this
immediately right you can change this
data any way you like count minus minus
count data.com equal to something
however like
and to know that when this data has
changed use a subscribe method from
value vanilla so I use a vanilla version
because by default value supports react
but this is like the core of the value
which just subscribed and snapshot and
proxy
right so subscribe allows you to
subscribe Adidas state
uh proxy state so we pass in the data
and then or it will have a callback
function so when when this function is
being called we know that the data has
changed so to get the snapshot off the
states
we use a snapshot so we pass in the
proxy State and then gives us a snapshot
so every time when you change because
snapshot it gives us the snapshot so
very simple way of understanding is this
is that snapshot shows the exact point
of like what is the value of
the states so we use Snapshot to read
the data from the states so we use
Snapshot accounts over here on
Assumption of the text over here
right and when in whatever we want to
manipulate data we just manipulate data
directly right so over here we have a
button that on click you say dot dot
counts minus minus decrement it and
data.com incremented and snapshot
account over here and then we can also
bind data.txt because using bind we are
going to set the value of data or text
directly
um
and then
yeah and read the data text value from
it so this makes the binding works as
well so if we type something the
snapshot will always get updated because
of this subscribe method and you'll see
the snapshot of text reflect over here
same thing goes with counts increments
and decrements
right so if you take a look at the
Subscribe method of the data
well it does not follow the store
contract right
um so three points about the subscribing
right so first thing is that subscribe
is an API so
it's not an object data does not have
that subscribe methods so probably we
have to create an object that has this
subscribe method so point two the
Callback function does not calls with
the
uh
state of the Star right you have to call
an API to get the states right and then
point three is that this thing uh does
not call this copy function immediately
right it calls
so you have to initialize the data of
the snapshot over here yourself
right so
because of all these three points we
kind of have to make it have to turn
this data into a spell store following
the store contract
so over here let's see what we can do
over here so I'm gonna Define a function
a util function I'm going to export
function to
svelt star
right
and then taking the proxy state
and we're going to return an object so
over here we are not going to change the
star so we just make it readable which
means we only need to implement the
Subscribe method
subscribed takes in a function
which in this case we should subscribe
directly to the
proxy and return the Subscribe good
thing is that it returns an unsubscribe
method so we can return it directly as
well
so over here I'm gonna take a value then
FN and I'm gonna get the snapshot of the
store so snapshot let's say uh subscribe
to the proxy state
and then I'm going to call this with
snapshot of the proxy state
right and we also need to call this
function immediately so I'm going to do
it over here as well
and here we have it so we're going to
import this function from data
and we're going to pass I'm going to get
a new star
uh snapshot star
equals to do cell star and then data
and then since this star follows the
star contract we can use dollar prefix
to assess the value of the store so I
don't need Mount I don't need to do it
or not anymore dollar prefix Value auto
subscribes when the command component is
mounted and unsubscribes when the
component is unmounted so we can remove
all of this
uh remove on Mount as well and remove
all the Subscribe snapshot everything so
now I can use dollar prefix over here
snapshot.com
snapshot.tanks
right and let's see it still works right
it works fine as it's supposed to
right so
this is how you can convert a value
proxy States into a swell saw following
the star contract
so one great thing about velto star is
that you can uh any sub property or
nested objects of the value store is
also sorry of a value proxy state is
still another it's another proxy state
right so which means that you can
actually subscribe to parts of the value
store and ignore the rest of the things
right what I mean is that for example
over here
say for example I have a dollar prefix
which is a reactive statement where I'm
going to console out every time the
snapshot store has changed you're gonna
see uh sorry let's see this
change
so every time the snapshot star values
changes I'm gonna call this console log
over here
okay so when I
every time when I change something you
will see that
your console out over here
change your console out over here
and if I type something over here it
will console up as well
right I'm not sure why it's consoled
twice Let me refresh this
probably it's of the Hot Wheel loading
let me let me refresh
and at the same time let me disable the
heart reloading
configuration
sandbox config
hot reload okay
save close
come back
sorry for that
okay I have my Applause felt and data.js
collapse this
let's see yeah whoops so so it's still
called toy
is it something wrong with the
subscription let's see
it's supposed to
okay
yeah only called once right
when I change when I change the text you
will see the console out when I change
the account you'll see the console out
right because you're subscribing the
whole
object right which contains both the
count and the text but we can actually
subscribe to only one of it right and
that that is how
a value star works right I can say the
count snapshot
I'm going to say data account
and over here I'm gonna
console.log
change
right because of hot reload hard reload
it has to refresh itself every time so
let's save again
refresh
or proxy objects ah I think I know why
okay so I'm Gonna Change uh because this
is a primitive so it can't do well with
this let's say uh count
value zero over here and we are going to
change counts.value
instead
okay
let's see
Okay so
okay by default we have a snapshot
change and count change right so if we
change anything over here
you'll see snapshot and the count
snapshot has changed so we kind of
monitor that anytime when this uh when
we change the count of value these two
will be executed because the whole proxy
state has changed right but if we type
over here you see that only the snapshot
store has changed but not the count
snapshot because you just subscribes to
a part of it which is only the count uh
sub object right so whatever whenever
the text is changed we don't care about
it so this is one great thing about
velto you can subscribe to a partial
object of the whole entire proxy store
because
some the proxy state is made up of
smaller proxy States so some object is
also another proxy state right so one
great thing about using valtio so would
you consider using velto with swelts
comments down below I would love to hear
your thoughts about it
svelt star allows us to have a state
that does not binds to the hierarchy
component hierarchy of your application
you can have a spell store declared in a
file and we can have all our different
components imports from it so different
components irrelevant on the hierarchy
within that application can share the
same States
right but spell store itself has is very
flexible it does not care about how you
update it or use it right it's a very
simple construct that allows us to
subscribe to the changes of the store
itself and get updates from it and
because of the star follows a star
contract we can have a very simple
dollar prefix variable syntax to access
the value of the star and auto
subscribing to the store itself so that
whenever it's changed the value the
value of the variable will get updated
itself
so if you are coming up with a more
complex application and you are thinking
about using some other libraries like
State Management libraries or state
machines to control your States
then you you might think that maybe if
that's the case then are we losing out
I'm not able to Leach on uh using this
dollar prefix variable syntax well maybe
not as long as we can make the library
itself follows the store contract then
we can actually leverage this on the
spell dollar prefix syntax to subscribe
to the value of whatever libraries that
you are using so that you can have a
control in terms of how the state
changes from one to another yet at the
same time when you're using it you can
still use a dollar prefix syntax to get
updated every time whenever the state
has changed so today we're going to look
at one state machine library that has
gained some hype in the JavaScript World
recently which is exit
so right now we are looking at the
GitHub page of X dates says that it is a
state machines and state charts for the
modern web
and as you scroll down below you'll see
that it has a lot of sub packages such
as the finite State machine for x-state
utilities or hooks for react for View
and testing libraries and inspection
utilities
and a lot of templates that you can get
started with as well as the x-state with
spell template over here let's take a
look at on the docs or apis so over here
we have open up X States apis you can
see a quick start guide will be
installing exit and creating a state
machine uh so I'm not going to delve
into how you're gonna do that
but uh so we we can start with uh
defining the state machines and then we
interpret the machines which when you
run starts it will give you a service
where you can send actions
um to to stop to transition from one
state to another
and you can and then this service you
can based on the service value you can
know whether which state are you at
currently right now right so I have
started this I've copied all over this
into a spell code so over here I have
data.js which has defined the state
machine and have started the machines
like the docs have said uh specified
and over here with toggle service it has
apparently a subscribe method which give
us the current state
and this States uh so we assign the
states to the the current state
and so we can use the states have which
has methods like matches to tell us
whether it matches whether the state
currently is an interactive or active
right as well as it has like uh it
returns enough subscribe methods and
to sense actions with toggling the
service like send toggle and stuff so if
we take a look at this toggle service
variable does it follow the spell store
contract
well okay let's see so first of all it
has a subscribe method check once
and the function within the Subscribe
methods has one parameter which is the
states which is the state that it will
you get check two right
then if you can see here the Subscribe
method this function get called
immediately right so I I just do this I
don't have to initialize the value of
States but right over here when you
console out you can see the state
already which means the moment when you
call subscribed this function will be
get called and it will update the
variable States
right check 3 which means
um yeah it the the function itself will
get called synchronously immediately
when you start subscribing it
right then this function variable itself
when you call subscribe it should return
a function
uh which is the unsubscribe which you
can call to unsubscribe uh the service
check for basically as the basic
mandatory of get of a star contract
having the Subscribe method that
fulfills all this check which means it
is following the star contract
what does that mean means that actually
you can use dollar prefix syntax of this
toggle service and actually gets the
state value immediately right so over
here instead of state which is the value
from this state we can use toggle
service
but with a dollar prefix which is
getting the value of this uh the service
or the states of your ex State service
right and let's try and see everything
works still still works fine which means
that we can remove all this code
uh remove on Destroy remove all this
and everything still works
as expected
let's see let's refresh yeah everything
still works so very simple nothing much
to do for using a x-state uh install
because the exit service has already
been following spell store contract and
that's so easy to use sexted in svelt
so in the previous videos we have seen
what is a store and how do we can create
a custom source and we have seen
examples on how we create custom stores
out of application State libraries out
there we converted a Redux store
um valtio States state machines ex State
machines into svelt's custom store
and today we're going to look into how
we can actually convert Dom events like
a state of a Dom events into a svelt
customs Customs felt store Oswald custom
store well I'm not really sure which one
is grammatically correct but anyway in
this example I'm going to show you is
we're going to use Mouse events so every
time when you move your mouse you
probably want to record the mouse uh X
position and Y position right so you
probably would have
um
and event listeners as you can see over
here we use a mouse move event listeners
and we use a client X and client y value
and we'll assign it to a variable X and
Y over here
right and we use these two variables
over here where we trying to say show it
on the screen or you can in the other
hand maybe use like a reactive
statements where you do something with
the X and Y position
right so in this example we're going to
look at how we can
um instead of having to have like X and
Y variables you try to extract out all
this into a field store
because as you can see over here it
behaves pretty much similar as well star
um for example we when the component is
mounting we listen to something right
it's akin to spell store where it starts
or subscribes to something
and as we unmount we unsubscribe
unlisten oops this this should be
removed even listeners so we are remove
event listeners which akin to
unsubscribing from a spell store
right and over here whenever there's
something change we update the variable
X and Y
so it could be like a value of your
store which probably have X and Y
properties so your store is like an
object which have X and Y properties so
every time something has changed like a
mouse move then the X and Y value should
updates and you should get no about it
right so that is pretty much like a
spell Store where the value is updating
every time something has happened
so we can encapsulate this logic over
here into a svelt store
so that you can reuse this you don't
have to always like declare X and Y
variable and then write all this thing
over here and hopefully it updates X and
Y variables and do all this stuff we can
take all this and convert it into a
spelled store so that's what I'm gonna
do over here right now so I'm going to
create a new file called Mouse position
dot Js
and I am going to copy all this over
here right now
so we don't have an on Mount but we have
a move event listener
and yeah we have all this
uh remove so we're gonna take care of
when to call this remove event listeners
right now
and I think we can start with
uh creating a star right A Star is an
object that follows the store contract
uh you can have subscribe method
as well as the sets methods in our case
we don't have to set anything right the
set is we don't allow anyone else to set
the value of the store which is the X
and Y position of a mouse no one says
that uh you only updates it so you only
reads from it so it doesn't implement
the sets when you do the subscribe so
we're gonna pass in a function and we're
gonna need to call this function
immediately with like the value so value
over here I'm going to say mouse
position but we're going to Define this
we're here right now
so I'm going to say mouse position
whoops
uh so I'm going to initialize it with x
equals to 0 and Y is 0 at first
right and then something something
happened and when that happens okay I
think we can add event listeners over
here
Mouse move and then
uh move so move it's gonna copy over
here
move
right and then we should return a
function to unsubscribed right so return
a function so this function should
unsubscribe from yeah the doc body so
let's say remove event listener
we're here whenever we have X and Y
position we are going to call the
function again to update right I'm going
to say uh
X
is the event client X
and Y is the event client y
right let me remove all this clean this
up I think actually we might not need
this variable over here I'm gonna copy
all this over here right now remove this
uh remove this as well and I'm gonna
call this with uh the default uh it may
be initial is the X and Y is zero right
okay and I think that's done so let's
export default
a star
and let's import this star uh so let's
see
it's Mouse position
from Mouse position
and let's remove all this you don't need
any more
and since this is a star
it follows a star contract
we can use dollar prefix of this to
access the value of the mouse position
as you can see here the value has
changed can move around yeah you can see
it it works right
so um and good thing about it is that we
can have another component say over here
I'm going to say uh ciao
from ciao
dot spelled
I'm gonna render this component over
here
create a child or spells
and we can also subscribe to this uh
Mouse position store over here I'm gonna
say children
uh create a line break over here I think
it's
yeah I'll create a div to wrap all this
thing up
and yeah
both of them works fine
uh that's yeah sorry I have my camera
over here so it blocks my sights but
yeah as you can see over here it works
fine right except that if you actually
scrutinize this
probably even ask me like every time you
subscribe you listen to the body uh you
listened to event listeners every time
you subscribed wow um isn't that a lot
of event listeners
um yeah you're right every time I create
a new event listeners I create a new
move function so
there is uh there is as many
um Mouse move event listeners as num is
the same number of how many uh new
subscriptions I have so over here I have
one in a child and one in the app.spel
so there's two I create two more smooth
event listeners so is there a way to
improve this I mean yes we can do it one
better as in probably we can say for
example collect all these functions and
then we only create event listeners once
if it's the first time subscribing so
let's let's Okay let me type while I'm
saying all this so that you can have a
better understanding of whether uh grasp
of what I'm trying to say over here so
probably I have a variable called
subscribers
um so every time when I subscribe I will
gonna
what I'm going to do is um I'm gonna
push this function
that push into function so every time
uh subscribing I will
add this new function to the array right
over here I'm gonna have a variable
called Mouse position
so this is like telling me the last uh
I'm gonna say this is like the last
Mouse position
right so I'm going to have uh so this is
so I'm going to call this from here
but we're going to update this mouse
position later on as well so this is
kind of like the last Mouse position
right and over here I'm going to move
this uh add event listeners into
um
a function on its own
so I'm going to say setup uh setup event
listener
and I'm gonna say uh remove
event listener
so over here
set up okay so I'm gonna have a variable
called uh is set up equals to false so I
can call this setup event listeners
multiple times over here
but if it's already set up
then I will not do anything I'll return
immediately but if it's not then I'm
going to set this as a true first and
then we're gonna set event listeners uh
to listen over here
um so this is like we only set once uh
if it's not set up so you only have one
event listeners listening so on a move
event what I'm gonna do over here move
as I am going to visit this text in an
event
I'm going to Loop through all the
subscribers
for each subscriber
okay so first thing is I actually need
to read out the X and Y position
so over here I am going to update the
last Mouse position
now x equals to this
and last Mouse position dot y equals
this
so the next time when you subscribe
later on you don't get zero zero again
you get the last Mouse position uh that
we have collected so far
um so over here I reset it and so for
each subscriber
is a function that we push into the
array we're going to call it with last
Mouse position
okay so that is it for move
and when we want to remove event
listener uh is we're going to call this
every time
when uh in the return function right so
this it will be called as many time
um
as many times as you unsubscribe so
first thing is we need to remove splice
uh
subscribers dot index of
the function
uh one item we remove that one item and
then
um if okay if if only when we have no
more subscribers
and then we remove the event listener
right so in this case remove event
listener will be
document body dot remove
event listener Mouse move move
right so now if you look at this code
now again
we are subscribing uh we're only setting
up if once once it's set up we are not
going to set up anymore I think we need
to also okay over here we're gonna say
setup is false since we already tear it
down so when you set it only once so how
many times when you call this setup in
event listener doesn't matter we only do
it once when we add event listener once
right and tear down we're gonna check
only if the last one is removed we don't
have any subscribers left only we remove
event listeners so we are going to tear
it down and then we see the setup is
false so that next time whenever we have
a new subscribers we're gonna set it up
again at event listeners right so over
here now Mouse move still works but
Mouse move only will only have one Mouse
moves event for this entire store
and yeah this is quite lengthy code if
you ask me
so is there a better way of doing it of
course right I've been setting up all
this just to tell you that actually you
don't have to write all of this because
this has already been done by readable
star all this setup like setting up
event listeners if only setup only said
at once and things like that should have
just been already written up all this
logic has already written up uh by the
readable store you don't even have to
maintain like the list of subscribers
and push it in and stuff like that so
let me show you how you can do it
instead so import readable
from svelt Star
and in States so I'm gonna remove I'm
gonna comment only so that you know if
you want to read this code uh The Links
of this Rebel will be in the description
so that you can still read all this so
I'm going to remove comment out and I'm
gonna create a new one spot default
readable and this is the initial value
so when we say initial value is x is 0 Y
is zero
and then this is a function
where it has a set
parameter so uh as I've said in the
readable store video this function will
only be called whenever you have only
have when you are starting from zero to
one subscriber you will be called and
then you can return a function
which will be called whenever
um
The View you you your subscribers is
removed unsubscribing from until zero so
when you have zero subscribers and the
return function will call exactly as a
logic that we have mentioned earlier on
so over here we can copy like uh this
over here event listeners at move
and remove event listener click here for
remove
and lastly for the move events copy over
here
whoops
uh we we need we need these two and we
don't have to Loop through all the
subscribers because the sets will do it
for us to go set why
is this but we call a set with an object
which as the X as the client X and Y has
the client why
right we call this sets it will handle
everything for us we don't have to worry
about it
uh let's see what's wrong over here okay
this right set has handled everything
for us we don't even need to manage the
subscriber list everything is handled
and as you can see here everything work
still works fine as previously
right so I'm Gonna Keep both of this
code over here for you to have a read
links in the description
so yup you can use you can convert a Dom
event uh anything that you are listening
from a Dom events like a mouse position
scroll position or intersection Observer
whether it's observing or not observing
the values of it everything any
snapshots of like the Dom events can be
used as a store value and you can
subscribe to it like how you listen to
The Domain listen to what the value is
right so with by making it following a
stock contract uh by implementing
yourself or using the readable
this allows you to use the dollar prefix
variable syntax to read the value of the
star and take care of all the
subscription from the store itself
today we are going to look at one more
Library which is emergs so Emer allows
us to make
um
an object to become like an immutable
object allow us to work with immutable
states with very convenient API
so right now I'm at its um documentation
it says that it's based on a copy on
rights mechanism I'm not really sure
what it means but a basic idea is that
you have a current object
and then you can apply
um changes to a temporary draft so over
here you have a draft object which you
make changes on there you can make
mutations but it will not affect your
current object and then once all the
mutations are complete you can apply all
them and create and gives you a next
state
so current and next are immutable you
don't change them and you only change
the draft
so this allows you to make changes make
mutations uh
easy mutations while still keeping
making sure that current and next are
still immutable
so um
let's take a quick look at like the API
of emerges so over here you import
produce
and you have a base state
and you call Produce with the base stage
which in this case is the current state
and then it gives you a draft state so
you can make changes on the draft States
anyway you like for example pushing a
new item to the array or marking sump
object as done
and when it returns this whole produce
when this function ends will be and then
it will be returned by this produce will
gives you a new next state
and you can ensure that the base state
is unchanged everything in base state is
still the same everything in the next
state is already changed so if you keep
the snapshot of pasted and next state
you kind of able to time travel to the
previous state or the current state
so we're gonna take a look at how we can
use it in the svelt and I have already
prepared a simple example over here
uh in the spell repo
so over here I have a state with two
users user one and user two which has a
different first name and last name so
um and over here I when I'm gonna change
the name I use emergency as produce
so I said produce if the current states
and then I give us a drop State and I
can mutate to the draft State anyway I
like it
and it will return me a next date
ah so same thing goes with all the last
name and over here I copy and paste all
this for over four inputs and as you can
see here
um over here I'm going to show the
states
um user one or user 2. first name and
last name so when I type something see
I'm gonna say hello then this will be
changed immediately right
and because it's immutable
you are not if we keep a reference of
the previous state
and and then the next current states
actually there are different objects
and so if you compare for example
previous States equals to current state
what you can see is that so initial
initially it's they're all true but when
you change something you can see that
the previous state and the next state is
two different objects we are not
mutating on the same object compared by
reference the I3 difference
and one great thing about Emer is also
that it will make sure that if you're
only changing user one
then only a new object created for user
one but the user 2 reference since we
are not changing it is still referencing
the same object so previous state user 2
equals the current state user 2 is still
the same right so if I change anywhere I
like this is still true and if I change
user 2 you can see that now user 1 is
always
the same right the reference of the
object is still always the same
so uh this is this is Emer
and let's take a look how we can make it
converted into a spell store by
following a spell store contract
so first thing is I'm going to create a
function
uh
let me see
get Emer
star
and I'm going to pass in an object
so over here there's two things one is
actually
um the draft
right the draft State and which we can
change it directly and the next thing is
the base the states
so it feels like there's we can have
like a tool store approach where we have
a draft store and a current store uh the
state store
so if we can make if you can have a
draft as a store you can make changes to
it directly
and then for the base store the states
actually is another store once when we
are done with all the changes we can get
a new state and this will get updated to
it
um it sounds complicated I'm not quite
sure but let's take a look over here
right so
um how do we get a draft so from what I
can see over here let's take a look at
all the apis
there's a create draft
uh probably you can use it we can use a
create draft let's take a look over here
create drafts
so you can create a draft along object
you can make all the changes we want and
then we call Finish draft which returns
us a new hopefully this is a new user
right which is a new state okay so let's
let's create two stars so first is the
draft
star
which is an object and the state star
same object so a star is an object that
follows the store contract and if you
can still remember the store contract
says that uh you
need to implement the Subscribe methods
which takes in a function
so I'm going to implement that
and the Subscribe method should be
called the function being passed in the
Subscribe method should be called
immediately
so over here I'm going to call
immediately but I haven't figured out
what to call or what value to be passed
in
for the states I think we just call pass
in this right
um and then for the draft okay so let's
probably let's create a variable so
let's Stitch equals to object
and let's uh draft equals to create
draft
object or hostage
I'm going to import create draft
from Emer and also finish draft
so since I will use State variable I
just used States so this is the draft
so the function has to be called
immediately
and then you need to return uh
a function to unsubscribe your store
so I need to return a function
which means that I need to keep track of
the function so probably let's create an
array over here uh so draft Subs
cribers
we make it a set so that it's easier to
retake it and remove so same thing for
the state subscribers
so I'm gonna say uh
add function
and over here I'm gonna say dot delete
function
so same thing goes uh come up here oops
uh State subscribers
now return the function
that I
delete the function right so okay so we
we have a subscribe method taking a
function call a function synchronously
written the unsubscribe method all right
everything looks fine and then
um optionally optionally you can have a
set step set method so I'm going to
implement it for this draft because we
can set something on the draft so value
so hopefully this is like the new value
but
um I'm not quite sure uh so a new new
draft right
not quite sure how we're going to use it
for now I'm gonna say to do
uh but we're gonna not change we're
gonna not allow to set anything on a
state uh because it's suppose it's meant
to be immutable it's meant to be uh
readable only
so okay we are done with here I'm gonna
return this to written an array of uh
State star
and the draft
star
so outside over here I am gonna
um since over here is gonna call this
States and draft
and I say create email
star
Okay so
um so we still use this over here
um so to get the value of the state
probably is like dollar prefix because
it follows
I think I named immerse store
because it follows a store contract we
can use the dollar prefix variable to
access the value of the star
so over here we can access it with that
dollar States same thing goes from here
and here
and over here what we want to do okay
here I think uh State as well
but over here what we want to do
differently is that we want to actually
use the draft store
to actually change it so uh we use do
this over here
I think we remove this as well
right
um over here as well uh draft store
over here
okay draft star
um
[Music]
let's see
I think this is irrelevant now let's
let's uncomment this for now
uh okay let's type something
updated because we changed the draft so
this is uh hopefully this is going to be
called so I'm gonna say console log
value over here
this is being called
uh I think it's an object it's a draft
object so that you can see it but it's
being called so over here what we need
to do is that we will have to
um
finish the draft and then get the new
States but not immediately we can do it
in a debounced way
so which means is that we can allow
uh
setting multiple times over and then we
update the states at once right so we're
just gonna set like a set timeout
uh set timeouts
and over here we are saying uh finish
draft
value
okay so this is this should be the value
so this is the new state so when I say
State equals to this
and then draft since it's already
finished we're going to create a new
drop so uh draft
here state
and then
um
I need to
notify all the subscribers I'm going to
come over here drop subscribers dot uh
for each
and call it with the draft object
and do the same thing for the state
subscribers
call it with a new state
and
we want to debounce this right so okay
so timeout we're gonna say say let's say
for 500 milliseconds only we change it
and we want to debounce this meaning um
if you type it multiple times We're not
gonna like five times we're gonna not
set five timeouts and Trigger this like
in sequence five times we're actually
gonna cancel the previous timeout so we
type five times and then only the last
one will wait for 500 milliseconds and
then trigger so all the changes are
batched in one time one go
so over here I'm gonna get the timer ID
equals now
so if timer ID
then we got clear timeouts so this is
going to clear the previous timeout
and and then if we successfully trigger
a timeout then we set it to null then
we're not gonna clear timeout right so
here I'm gonna declare the timeout ID
and let's take a look at what we have
done so far so over here I'm going to
change something and in 500 milliseconds
this is going to be updated so if you
feel it's a bit slow it sets it to 100
sorry
and let's type right it feels
immediately
um so what we have we achieved so far we
make it like a store uh contract that
allows us to use the sets method to like
update the draft immediately
but what's good about using email
um does it like justify all this uh
boiler extra piece of code
so I'm going to show you something
called immutability right so for example
um hopefully because that over here when
we see that if after updates the
previous stage is not changed then
uh user if boosted for user one is not
changed you can see that it's it's not
updated right so over here what we want
to do something similar as well gonna
say uh
previous state is equals to the value of
the state
and come over here uh we can compare it
again
and we can see that
um
because of immutability this is not this
is referring to the same uh still
referring to the same object this is
false this is true so which means that
this object itself is not uh
create a new object right the reference
of the object is still the same
but because of how uh spell works if you
have a reactive declaration and if you
try to console out say uh state
user one
this is gonna be called every time even
if you're not updated in you are not
updating it right you kind of expect
that this
since it's the same uh you shouldn't
console out anymore
right but because of how this felt works
is that as long as the states is
the same is different then this will be
called
so because this is always going to be
false if we're going to update something
then
yeah then it's too bad for us
so we can use something called derive
from spell star which we can
try to
the revenue store
out of the current store
so for example I'm going to come here
this is a lot of
boilerplate code
um it's
uh it's meant for just for your example
education purpose
um you you shouldn't you don't have to
do this for a very simple application
but just bear with me let me show you
like what this will leads us do
all right so over here I can create two
derived Stars so if one is the user one
I'm deriving from the
the store uh the states and then
can return the value which is
state.user1
so this gives us a new store which is
the user one it's a derived star so this
is giving us a new store uh by creating
like uh coming out from deriving from
another store which is the the hosted
and give us the state DOT user one
right and so this user one is another
store and we can create another store
called user2
and over here let's try console out
again
so in this time round you kind of hope
that
uh this shouldn't be
user one shouldn't be called again when
if you are updating user 2 and user 2
should be called when we're trying to
update user one so let's see is that
holds true so I'm gonna type something
over here
but two bets uh user one and user 2 is
still being called
um
uh yeah it so it's kind of like
what's the point like even if you know
that user one is still the same object
you like by using email we make sure
that it's exactly the same object we
don't change it we don't mutate it but
it's still that uh it's still telling us
that
uh either one has changed
well that's because by default uh
spelled allows you to mutate objects
directly does not know that you are
trying to do something immutable so any
changes to an object uh anything that
they assume that has changes to an
object is a change and you will try to
console this out right meaning even if
it does not actually check whether it's
a strict referential equality it just
says that oh if this is object then I
assume that this has changed because you
cannot mutate it and the object
reference is still the same and we have
no way to know that whether it's a
change or not so any object when you
kind of feel that it's changed and
because in user one is it feels that it
has changed because state has changed so
user probably has changed and because of
that uh we're gonna re execute this
statement
and we do it for this as well
and I have said that this is because uh
you can uh spell assumes that you are
trying to make things uh you're gonna
try to mutate an object
and if you can cancel that we're not
going to mutate any objects whatever we
do over here we're gonna make any state
changes over here uh gonna be immutable
then you can use a strict equality
referential equality to compare an
object if it's exactly the same uh
assume that um no changes has to
be made don't have to assume that uh
yeah you can assume that no
changes has to be made you don't have to
do that weird uh stuff that assumes that
as long as an object you kind of assume
has something has changed so what that
means is that you can use you're trying
to tell felt it is immutable and how do
we do that we can use a Spell option
called immutable true
this tells felt that any changes made in
any states
it's going to be immutable so you use uh
so if user one uh this reference if
they're referring to this like and I
read changes when you see on user one if
they are still the same exact object
triple equals the same then
it has no changes because if you're
going to make a changes it's gonna be a
new object
so let's come back over here and let's
try to type something
Mary can see something's different now
when you change on user wants user 2 is
no longer console log anymore if we
change on user true we don't see any
console log on user 1 anymore
right
um
so image.js has helped us to create an
immutable a new immutable object
um over here
and because of email JS we can still
make changes like they are immutable uh
because we are mutating the draft object
we are rotating the draft state
and whenever uh once we have changed
something on the draft States uh the
sets method of the draft store will be
called
and we debounce it
um just for performance sake we debounce
it and once uh and then we notify that
okay uh all these changes that you have
made on the draft State should be
applied and
uh use it as the should be applied and
then you
create a new immutable state right so
this is like finish the draft and create
a new immutable State and because it's
immutable we are not changing the
previous state uh the reference if
there's changes the reference to that
object will be there will be different
because we're going to create a new
object
um so over here if you change user two
you only see console log of user 2 user
one is always the same reference object
it's no changes
uh so you don't see a console off right
there
and and then
and we also have to tell svelt that we
when we make changes we actually make
make changes immutably so by passing in
options called immutable equals to true
so
um before we end this let's make let me
show you one more thing that you can do
with Emer which is in Emer uh you can
have patches
so to enable patches we need to enable
it first
it's gonna come over here and paste
these two lines over here so we enable
patches
and with patches we can
uh
when we we can apply patches
right what that means is that
um I think in the finished draft method
finish draft method we can we actually
can pass in a callback
and there's there's uh two parameters
one is the changes one is the inverse
changes
so changes is that the changes that
you're gonna you can apply to which is
the changes that is going to be applied
to and inverse changes is uh changes
that you can
unapply the onto the states so we can
apply patch on the next date with the
inverse change will give us the previous
state
so this this can actually helps us to
create undo and redo kind of uh
interaction so I'm just gonna save just
the inverse changes
and I'm gonna come over here and push it
into undo list
so I'm gonna have a variable called undo
this
on an array
and in the draft you can provide more
methods right so you uh as long as you
fulfill a store contract you can
actually Implement more methods it's up
to you as long as the Subscribe is there
follows a song contract and optionally
set method is there and follows the
store contract that's good about uh
that's that's good enough
so we can have an undo method
and this undo method I'm gonna check if
undo list dot length
which means there's something to undo
I'm going to call undo.pop
and do list of pop
and I'm going to apply the patch so
apply patches
apply patches onto the states
with the undo
this should give me a new Stitch which
is still immutable uh so can I say State
equals to this
and I'm gonna say draft
equals to create draft from the state
and I notify all the subscribers
so I'm gonna paste this over here
okay and let's try to use this undo
method
so we're gonna come over here have a
button
on click
undo
and I'm going to come here and say uh
draft dot undo this time around I'm
going to call it on the draft store
itself right uh if the dollar prefix is
getting you the states of the draft but
we're not going to get the value of this
the draft store we're going to use the
draft store itself we're called undo
so over here we have an undoom button
now so if we type something
the changes has been made type something
changes has been made and then we undo
oh wait undo is not working hold on
apply patches is not defined sorry let's
let's come back over here and import it
okay so make some changes applied make
changes applied undo undo
you cannot do and and yeah you can apply
patches
um from your JS it will create so when
you do when you use image yes you can
make changes on the draft
States itself are mutably and then when
you finish it when you finish drafts it
gives you the next state immutable next
date as well as the changes you can you
have made in these drafts and you can
apply the changes again or you can
inverse the changes
right there's a lot of more advanced
stuff that you can do with Emer which is
probably very Advanced where you you
when you're dealing with some sort of a
complex kind of state
so I don't recommend you to immediately
jump and use this in a very simple
application but as your application
grows you have a very big object and you
want some immutability in your States
then probably you can take a look at
emerge.js and take a look at how we can
use Emer make it like a store contract
and use it in svelt using the dollar
dollar prefix variable syntax
and today we're going to take a look at
one built-in method from sveld that
allows us to quickly create another
store from existing stores
so the way for us to derive stores from
existing stores that you have
so self provide us with this method
called derived and we're going to take a
look at how we can use this methods so
let's take a look at an example that
I've prepared for you so over here I
have a writable star
and I create a writable store with
initialize with a value 10. and I've
bind the value of the star with an input
with the type number so over here if I
change if I move the number along you
can see that it's updating the value of
the star using the dollar prefix syntax
because the writable stores uh matter
from spell implements the store contract
so we can access the value of the store
using dollar prefix variable of the
store variable name and we can do it
over here as well
and bind will set the value so the the
store the writable store also follows
the store contract for the set method so
we can set the value of the store
directly from this bind so that we can
update the value of the star like this
right so if you change the value of the
store you can see that it's updated
immediately
so right now I'm going to show how you
can use the derived method from spelled
so same thing as sorry same thing as
spells writable imported from svelt Star
so it's a name it's called derived
and over here how we use derived is you
can write for example new
num equals derived and pass in the store
which is in this case is num is the
store
and we can pass in a function so in this
function we can we will have the value
of num
so the this is the value of the star so
if you can you can see here the the
variable over here we kind of prefix it
with dollar but it's just any name so
any name you like it's easier for us to
think about value of a star is prefix if
dollar and star itself is without the
dollar sign
right but this itself can actually be
any uh any variable name so uh just to
demonstrate I can say
haha okay and over here I'm going to
return a value for this derived star so
um this derived star will subscribes to
the store and anytime every time when a
star value has changed this callback
function will be called and the value of
the store will be here hardcore haha
variable and then we're gonna return a
new value for this derived store it's
going to say uh return haha
times two
so this is always two times of the value
of the store of num so if I come over
here and I
because derived follows a store contract
whatever returns from derived followers
of store contract we can get the value
of the star using a dollar prefix
variable as well so you can see over
here this right now has a value of 20.
so I'm going to say num times
oops
2 equals to this and when I change the
value of the num star you can see the
value of the derived new num star is
also updated immediately
so uh where can I read from like apis
for derived so you can find the API for
derives in over here in the docs you can
see over here derived
um
so there as you can see over here
there's actually a lot of different kind
of uh whoops let me Zoom it in and yeah
if you take a look at the docs right
there's actually a lot of ways that you
can define derived and
at first glance you may see me it's a
bit overwhelming so let me break it down
to you so that it's easier for you to
understand all this right so
I I you can think of it as
um
you can think of it as a two by two
variants I'm gonna have I'm gonna write
it all of the variants over here so that
it's easier for you to think about it so
first is whether you derive from one
store
versus derived from multiple Stars
and then uh in in either case you can uh
get the derived value synchronously
or
get the derived value asynchronously
okay so what does it mean so let's take
a look at the first two component uh
combination so derived from one store so
in this case derive actually derived
from one store right so we only have one
store called num and then we derive from
just one store uh and then it says
derive multiple stores which means that
actually we can derive from multiple
stores so let's do that so let's create
another store called num2 in this case
uh initial value is 42.
and we are going to to have another
input
that binds to num2
and now I can derive from the num and
num2 stores so instead of taking it as a
instead of taking it as
just a store the first argument for
derived can actually be
an array
and so you can pass in as many stores
you want so I can have num and num2 two
stores right so over here if you have
two stars then this variable the first
uh parameter over here will become an
array now so this is the value of the
first star and then the value of the
second star
do note again this variable name uh can
we can name the variable name any way we
want this is just that a convention for
us that tells us that this is the value
of the star instead of the star variable
itself
right so right now I'm gonna say
um this this new value the derived value
for a new num2 would be num times num2
and if we come over here
I think let me rename it better so
that's less confusing so this is I'm
going to call this multiplication
and this is a double
of num
right so double of num we're gonna come
over here
and multiplication
let's come over here and let's let me
another div
so num
times num2
equals to
the value of the star multiplication
as you can see here uh whenever I change
this value of star this derived store
value will get updated immediately right
I'll change this the second store value
also get change updated immediately
right so this so you can derive from one
store or you can derive from multiple
stores
so from all the examples we've seen over
here so far is we return a value
immediately from the call from from the
second parameter right but then there's
a case where probably you may want to
um do something like do something
asynchronously and then
set the value of the derived store later
on for example over here I'm gonna have
this called uh this new store called
delete num
so this delayed num is special in a
sense where every time when the num
store value has changed
uh we were gonna update this delete num
the value of the direct num store but it
will go it will be updated uh in one
second later
so how you're gonna do it is
um
the same thing we have in function and
then the first parameter is the value of
the num star
and then if if okay so let me show you
uh
uh so by the previous we want to have
like the the value of the delayed num to
be set as the same value of the num
store but only delete one second right
so if I come over here uh
okay
delete
I come over here uh if you see right now
right now we return this num directly
right so if we change the value you see
the value is updated immediately
but if we now start to take in a second
parameter you see that this becomes
undefined immediately
why when you pass in a parameter called
set right now uh this is this derived
function is assumed to be asynchronous
and when it assumes to be asynchronous
it no longer look at what is being
written from this function anymore
right this is important right so once
you take in a second parameter it no
longer takes into account of what
returns from this function as the value
of the star no no longer right so now
the value of this uh derived star is
still undefined and if you want to have
an initial value you can take it over
here as a third parameter so I'm going
to say uh not set and you can see this
is the initial value right whatever
written here is not the value of the
derived store when you take in a second
parameter if we remove this
then you can see that immediately this
is synchronous and then we just take
whatever from here as the value of the
derived star if you're taking an
apartment second parameter sets this is
asynchronous whatever written is not the
value of the derived star and what is
the derived store the initial value will
be this the third parameter for the
derived function a derived method and if
you want to set the value of store you
have to call the sets
so here I call sets again now the
initial value is not set but then we
call set immediately now you can see
that this value has updated to this 10
right so if I come over here
the 10 14 15 uh we this function will be
called every time and the value of the
store will be
uh updated by calling this sets right
but we say we want to delay the value
right so what we can do over here now is
we can set timeout
for example one second
and we want to set the value of the star
one second later on
so by default initial value is not set
but once we set the value for example
right now we want to update it okay
first is let's see the initial loading
so focus on the delete uh over here
once we refresh the initial value is not
set and then one second later it turns
into the value uh over here where we
call sets and whenever we update the
value gets updated one second later
right
and remember that whenever we say we
want to use set timeout we need to
remember to clear the timeout because
what if no one is subscribing to this
store anymore or the whole component is
being unmounted you wouldn't want this
timeout to still be triggered and then
call the sets for not for nothing right
no one is listening anymore
so here is the Thing Once you add the
set parameter whatever it written if
it's a function it should be the cleanup
function
so this is kind of similar with um if
you have seen previously how we a
subscribe method where you return in a
subscribe method of following the store
contract whatever you return is the
unsubscribe it's the cleanup so we're
going to do the same thing over here so
I say clear this is a timeout
ID
and I return a function called
clear timeout
timeout ID
so this is synchronous this is
asynchronously
so I'm gonna to demonstrate that this is
actually being called I'm gonna console
over here hi
uh the reason is uh if we're gonna
update this value of the start very fast
then most likely is that before we the
set timer is being triggered it's going
to be clean up and then we have a new
set timeout later on
right so if I change this very fast
you see that uh instead of going from 10
11 12 13 change to 13 immediately so
right now I'm gonna go from 13 to 10.
you see that it does not go step by step
because every time we
update the value the cleanup function is
being called will clear the timeout and
then the new set timeout is being
triggered
Heights
so as you can see over here as well the
highest being consoled out many times
when I update this so this is a good way
for you to clean up the timeout because
it's no longer in use and
so that uh you
so that uh you can clean up and remove
any unnecessary sets store value
so
so I've said that this is a two by two
Matrix that means is that
um
you can derive
from multiple stores asynchronously as
well right so in these two examples we
derived from single store synchronously
derived from multiple stores
synchronously we can also derive from
a single store asynchronously and
derived from multiple Stars
asynchronously
so over here I'm going to create another
delete multiplication
and over here I'm gonna copy this to
and now since we are passing an array
this will be an array of two value
num2
and I'm going to return the
multiplication num 2 over here
so we're going to look at the value
delete
foreign
so if I change this this will get
updates one second later and change this
as well this will go updates as well but
one second later so you can derive from
one or multiple stars and you can set
the derived value of the derived star
synchronously or asynchronously
we've been talking about stores over the
past few videos
and don't you find Stars a bit boring
and dull like whenever you set a value
you just change to that value does not
moves to that value elegantly
right when I in this example that I
prepared over here I have a writable
stores that is initial value is zero and
whenever I change it it just change that
value
why don't it like move slowly from zero
to one instead of just changing from
zero and then one
wouldn't be better if we can have a
special kind of stores where whenever we
try to increment it it moves slowly from
one to two
like and showing the values in between
like 1 1.1 1.2 1.3 more form by five all
the way to two would that be
more beautiful and elegant
right so today this is what we're gonna
do now create a custom store
that allows us whenever we set the value
allows us to uh the value of that store
itself will not go to that value the
target destination value directly but
rather it will slowly move to that value
and we're gonna do it right now
so over here
I have my boring dial star called value
created using writable
I'm gonna create a new custom store
and I'm gonna use a
function called twin
initial value
and then uh
and I'm gonna use this to create my
create a store for myself so I'm going
to replace it with uh twin uh replace
the writable to twin
but over here I'm returning nothing so
nothing is not a store whatever store
has to follow a store contract and a
stock contract dictates that it has to
be an object and an object has to have a
function a method called subscribe
which takes in a function
and you kind of have to call the
function immediately uh like say FN and
then call some value right so I'm going
to call the initial value
uh immediately
and over here I need to return and
unsubscribe methods
right so that I can unsubscribe from
this custom store
so over here as I've shown you many many
times in the previous videos where I
need to push this function into an array
we have to keep track of the uh all the
list of some sorry subscribers and then
remove it from that list in this
function so today I'm gonna be a bit
lazy and actually a bit more efficient
which is actually you don't have to
manually write this subscribe method to
maintain a subscriber list we can create
say uh I'm gonna create a store called
uh using writeable
with the initial value
and then we can cheat a bit by using the
Stars subscribe method instead
so this way you can delegate all that
responsibility of maintaining a list of
subscribers returning and unsubscribe
methods and everything to this store
and if you want to notify all the
subscribers that a new value that you
have then what you need to do is to call
store.sets a value and this will notify
all the subscribers the new value
So today we're gonna cheat a bit right
so over here I have a subscribe method
and I also need a set method and I'm not
going to use a store.set directly
because we want to do something
different over here for the set method
of our custom store so I'm going to call
sets and a new value
so over here
I need to
slowly move my value from the like the
value of my write-up of my star slowly
to the new value and it takes time take
some sort of duration uh probably we can
make it like a parameter over here say
duration and let's give it a default
value so here I'm gonna say one second
so at least I don't have to pass it in
the default is a thousand uh
milliseconds
and over here uh what we can do is we
can
use something like maybe like set
interval so on interval uh maybe we can
have an interval of say
100 milliseconds
so on every 100 millisecond we do
something
so um
so we can keep uh we keep updating this
on every 100 millisecond we keep
updating our store to a value
um and then we have to calculate the
value here okay
so every we we have an interval of
upkeep updating the value and of course
we need to know when to stop so uh when
we call set we can get the starting time
equals to date dot now
and we can get an ending time
equals okay starting
start time and end time
so this will be the start time
plus duration
so in the set interval we can check that
maybe let's get the current time
it goes to date dot now and if current
time is greater than
the end time
that we know we need to end this
interval
so here to end it we need a interval ID
interval ID
so copy it and clear time interval
the interval ID and I need to return so
I don't need to do whatever I'm going to
do next
so over here
uh if it's not ending if we are still
looping we need to know what is the new
value uh what is the value like the
intermediate value that we need to set
to our store
so let's do the calculation
so we need to use something like a ratio
We compare for example uh the current
time
minus the starting time
uh divide by the ending time minus start
time so end time minus start time is
actually the duration so I'm going to do
it by duration
so how long we elapse from the starting
point over the whole duration will be
have to be equals to how long uh
well it goes to the
the
value that we want us
um
the uh
[Music]
the
well equals to uh the same ratio will
equals to the the value that we want to
set value to set
minus the initial value
over
over the new value minus initial
value
right so
uh how long it elapsed over the total
duration will be equals to uh how how
far from the initial value over the
distance total distance uh that's new
value over the initial value and we need
to calculate the value called the value
to sets so we need to do some aromatics
to move this around
um so I can shift this new value minus
initial value over to the other side so
this will be multiplication
let me repeat that with a bracket and
then value to set will be uh
and then we shift the initial value over
as a plus
so this whole thing plus initial value
will equal to the value to set so over
here I can copy this value to set and
then put it as the
the value that we are calculating over
here
cons value to set
so this is the value that we need to set
and so I'm going to set it in
and foreign
let's have a try
right so now I'm gonna click increment
you see that the value slowly moves from
zero
to one it's not going to set
0 1 directly right we slowly moves from
zero to one
and now we click again
whoops it starts from zero again do you
notice that let's try again uh
let's let's clear this
so the first time starts from zero
to
okay almost one point nine so this is
something we need to fix uh and then
when we click again
it goes from zero again and all the way
to 1.9
uh what's wrong over here
let's see ah okay so there's two things
to fix right first is
um whenever we increment it always
starts from zero counting from zero
again
and that's because we keep using initial
value over here
once we have set the star like once the
value has reached the new value we
should update this initial value to the
new value right this will be the new
initial value
so over here I am gonna come over here
current when we hit the ending this is
when it ends I'm gonna say initial value
it's equals to the
um new value
so let's try this again
zero plus all the way to almost one so
this is something we haven't fixed yet
and when we increment it moves
continuous moving right from one all the
way to almost two and then we click
again it moves from two to almost like
three
so when I say almost it is almost
um so to make this looks nicer uh this
is and this is actually because the time
um our interval is not always in like
uh milliseconds it actually sometimes it
offshoots a bit and sometimes it's less
a bit so probably when you reach the end
uh uh maybe the the last time you update
is not yet three and then this time
around when you offset uh overshoots a
bit we don't really update the store
anymore so the here before we end
actually we can do one more update which
is we're gonna set store dot sets
uh to the new value
so if we do this right now
I'm gonna try again
it always ends nicely at the Target
value
all right so one and then now in
increments all the way to two if
decrement two all the way to one nicely
done
let's set this slightly longer duration
and let's try again
it takes five milliseconds or five
seconds but if the Midway if we try to
decrement uh you probably see something
as
the value it's it's jumping a lot
it's jumping a lot from uh if you can
okay let's let's try
let's try Plus
uh minus equals 10.
so when we
go this it slice tries to go from 0 to
10 and then we try again
oops
uh you
you see that it's jumping it's trying to
update like it feels like there's
multiple things trying to update
um
our
value at the same time
let me do this I think it's easier to
demonstrate it this way where we have uh
where this value is over here so that I
can click on the minus or plus easily so
if I click decrement it should go to
negative and I should click plus you
should go to positive value right and if
you click this and we try to do this you
see that it's still in negative and it's
like flipping from negative to like
I'm not sure positive or something
um
so what's what's the what's my point
okay so my point is whenever we change
halfway we can we have to actually
cancel this interval and then moves to
the Target new Target value from there
on
what that means is that uh this
shouldn't be uh in the interval ID
shouldn't be a variable inside here
anymore should be
declared outside
and when we have a new set we should
actually if interval ID
we need to clear interval
ID
and then start from there
so I do clear over here I also need to
just to clean up this set interval ID
now and then return
so let's see minus and I Plus
uh
no it seems like the new one does not
takes in effect at all
um
yeah what could be wrong let's see
stand Arrow I see an error clear
interval Ido clear interval no wonder
okay
so plus minus
Plus
and then minus you can see that the
number
jumps uh if I do minus now it jumps to
zero and then slowly moves down and I it
does not continue from where the current
number is actually uh you you could you
could kind of feel that
uh we're starting from negative 10 to 20
right anyway plus immediately it still
said it's trying to move from negative
10 to some other numbers instead it does
not
um
hold on this to be fair this should be
plus 10 okay so for example what I'm
trying to say is right now it's zero and
quite a click decrement
-10 it slowly moved from 0 to negative
10 but in Midway if I click plus it
should be moving from zero to
it it feels like it's going to move from
0 to 10 instead of like halfway
2 10.
um so let's let's
see that again so I'm moving halfway
which is negative five and I click plus
it jumps from zero all the way
to
a new value
so this new value is actually
correct in a sense where I actually
click plus 10 when I add negative 8. so
negative 8 plus 10 is 2 plus 2.5
something right so if I move over here
it slowly moves to negative eight
maybe right now negative four and I'll
click it moves all the way to negative 4
plus 10 is like six ish but then it
moves from
uh the two instead of like negative four
so what's my point my point is that
um the initial value
has to be always updated has to be
always updated so that whenever we
cancel and we start from there on this
initial values should be the latest uh
should be calculated as the latest of
the value to sets
but we shouldn't um
affect this initial value uh we
shouldn't change this initial value
like this like I shouldn't say initial
value
to Value to set
we can't do it like this way because
um this will affect the formula or value
to set again because this the the range
from new value to initial value will be
wrong we still need we still want the
previous initial value before we we
cancel and then we
um
I guess you try to get what I'm trying
to say
so over here there's a few ways to do it
so first thing is
before we start over here before we
clear interval
we can get a hold of the value like the
current value
so for example instead of having set of
a uh like constant uh this as a local
variable I can have value to set over
here
and over here if I try to set against
which if I clear interval
then
this tells me that okay I need to
interval ID equals to know this tells me
that uh previously the value to set is
some sort of value and I need to
I need to update it
uh I need to update the initial
value
to Value two sets
and this reminds me I need to do this as
well over
here actually okay we have done this
right
so this will be slightly correct so
let's try again and see
so we move halfway to three to four or
five and then I click it slowly moves
down from three to one all the way to uh
just now was what seven or eight ish and
then minus 10 is like roughly 2.8 ish
right
so
few we have with with me a lot of code
over here it looks very complex
right but hopefully you get the flow of
this if we want to make a variable
slowly move towards the target this is
what we would have to write
or no
actually this twin
is actually provided it's actually built
in from svelte you can use it directly
although it's not from the store
but it also still implements the stock
contract
so it's actually from svelt motion
so I'm not gonna remove this because
maybe you want to take a read what we
have accomplished so far but let me
comment it out
you can use twin
API does not change but as you can see
oh okay ignoring the moving faster parts
we it's not using an interval it's using
a request animation frame which is much
faster uh as in we can make it fast as
well if we have like a smaller intervals
as well right but ignore the fact uh it
still works The Way We Were designing
right so in this does not the second
parameter of the twin is not a number
it's not duration but an object where
you can pass in a duration
so let's pass in like five
millisecond again and take a look at the
problems that we're trying to solve just
now right move halfway and I kind of
remove it continues from there instead
of jumping here and there all right I
think spell does a very good job in
handling all those edge cases
and if we start from zero it also nicely
lands at
instead of having all the decimal points
right that is something that we've done
over here as well make sure it nicely
set the value at the end of the time
so um let's take a look at the docs for
twin
and see what else we can pass it in
so twin takes in not just duration it
takes in also delay easing and
interpolation and delayed cells is
pretty interesting
because for example if I say a delay of
say one second okay maybe two seconds
and I change takes two second delay and
then slowly move up and when I click
minus it does not change immediately
except two seconds later it's slowly
going back right uh two seconds later
then two seconds later it's only
decreased back so it still takes in it
still moves from where it is at at that
point of time but it takes delay of two
seconds
and then here you have a easing easing
is a function that you can control how
much uh what's the rate of moving from
the initial point to the final point
and it interpolates which is how
um
which is depending on what kind of value
you have you can interpolate it
differently right for example if you are
you can use Queen with colors as well
you can twin between colors and you also
can twin dates and time and a lot of
things you can try that out
so beside twin uh spell also provides
something called Spring so spring is
also something like twin except that it
moves like a spring it it has like uh so
let's let's replace this
and let's take a look at the value
so let's increment you can see the value
is incrementing a bit like a
like a like a spring and you can't tell
that from the number itself so what I'm
going to do now is I'm gonna use
um
a colored diff so that you can visualize
it better
so style equals to say background red
and then with one PX height
5px
and front Okay this is a bit short
that's 10 PX
at 20px okay this is this is more like
it and then transform
scale
and I'm going to use
the spring value
you can see it does not move
directly it has some kind of springy
feeling to it and if you if you can pass
in values like uh stiffness to control
the spring itself
so here if I say
stiffness equals to zero
oops see
is zero to one right
I'm sure too stiff moves one
um if we move to like 0.8
um 0.4
you have different kind of uh okay I
think we need to add some dampening
damping
so that's
if you have more damping it will have
more springy feeling a less stamping you
have more
springy feeling it does not
and like the movement does not and
immediately and if we have like a lot of
damping
then it will less springy
right so you can play around with this
value
but the point is as well provides two
billion function spring and twin which
allows to which returns an object that
follows a store contract so it's still
like a star
but when you set a value to the store it
does not does not update the value of
stock immediately but it slowly moves
from one value to that value
um through some sort of twinning
interpolation and some springy feeling
so in the last video I talked about
custom stores in which the value of the
star slowly moves from the current value
to the Target value that you are setting
it with I explain how you could write
such a star and in the end of the video
I show you that you could actually use
the building methods from sveld like
twin and spring depending on what kind
of a movement that you want to
um in that video I didn't explain in
depth about how uh what are the possible
ways that you can use twin and spring in
which it does not do them justice so in
this video what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you how you can use twin
and spring and make full use of them
so the first thing I'm going to share
with you is Twin so let's take a look at
this Ripple that I have prepared for you
so over here I imported both twin and
spring but right now we are looking at
Twin first
so in Twin uh so right now I am not
using anything I'm using a writable
so when you have a writeable when you
change the value of the star where you
try to assign a value to it it will turn
into that value immediately by itself
right so there's no move there's no
transition from the current value to the
Target value
but if I import twin from swept motion
and I use that instead of writable
now as I change the value you see that
it
slowly moves towards 20 right and I
change to zero it will turn to zero
slowly so here is so the second
parameter of twin
is actually options that you can adjust
the tweeting so first thing is you can
adjust the delay so for example if I set
delay in milliseconds like 500
milliseconds then the value does not
change until 500 milliseconds later
next thing is duration
if I set the duration to be 5
000 milliseconds which is 5 second then
it will take one two three four five
okay
my counting is bad but as you can see it
takes five SEC whole second to reach
from 0 to 20. now next is the easing the
easing is
a function that describes how the number
uh the acceleration the rate of the
number changing from the current value
to the next value so if you don't pass
it easing then the value is moving
linearly which means it moves in a con
it in it moves in a constant speed but
if you can pass but if you pass it in
custom easing for example right now I'm
going to import cubic in
from svel easing
now you may not notice but the number
actually increased in an increasing
speed
right it stays at for example right now
I am at 20. you'll see that it will
stays at 20 okay let me remove the delay
but you notice that from for example
from 1 to 20 you see you see that the
number stays at one to two a very long
time and then it starts to accelerate
and moves faster and increase faster and
all the way it shoots up like a curve
over here and a rich 20 probably a very
short time from reach from 15 to 20
right so pay attention
right it stays at one for a very long
time and then suddenly it shoots up and
then it hits 20. so you can control all
these different kind of easing using a
different easing function
so the next option we have is called the
interpolates
before we move into interpolate let's
take a look at what actually what are
the type of values that you can pass
into twin a store right now in most of
my examples you see what I've do have
done is I twin from a number to another
number so I I start with the initial
value if it's just a number and then I
set it to another number but it does not
have to be just a number it can be other
data types for example it could be
um an array of numbers so I have to say
0 1
0 50.
and I want to
interpolate to I want to set the target
value to be say 100 and then maybe zero
right 100 zero
if I click this you can see that both
numbers will change
together at its own speed
right so 0 moves to 150 will move to
zero so if I remove the easing and delay
let me just comment them out you can see
that it's it's
both numbers are moving right towards
their Target number in five seconds
so you can have a number you can have an
array of numbers
and then the next thing is what you can
have is actually object
where the values are numbers
so for example I can have an object say
a is zero B is 50
is 100 B is 0.
so all the property value has to be and
oh sorry
let's see how should I do this
um because this will be interpreted as a
Expressions which I don't want so
probably I will use HTML and let's do
this instead
okay
so
um
I change so I have a proper object with
two properties 0 and 50. a is zero B is
50 and I change both properties will be
updated at once right
so um you could have
more properties right
but then
oh because C is not there it is
undefined initially then you have error
but right now if I set C to say 40
hold on hold on
um this is not okay I think I made a
mistake over here there should be null
and two so that this is multi-line okay
let's take a look at how these three
property uh interpolates to each other
right just to make it clearer let's
update the button as well the button
text although it does not make any
effect so right now we change from 0 50
40 to 100 0 30. right so you can see
that all the numbers is being
interpolated at the same time
okay so besides object where its
property is numbers and arrays which is
item is numbers can actually have each
of them nesting each other so for
example I can have array of numbers over
here 50 and turning into 30 70
see it still works all the numbers still
changing
or I kind of array of objects over here
instead
and maybe another item equals to 40 and
here is a equals to 30
change all the numbers are still
interpolating correctly so as long as
the number of items matches uh the
number of properties is the same and
each of the property has the same type
for example number matches with number
array matches with array
um the built-in twin function will able
to handle all of them nicely
right and lastly it's not just about
numbers it can be about uh time
so if I have new dates over here and new
date uh say
zero
right and I change you can see the time
will moves
um
well will between as well
so numbers dates object with keys is
numbers arrays where it's proper uh
sorry object where it's value is numbers
and array in which the item is numbers
and nested of either nested object array
array nesting with object what else
um basically I think that's all so if
you try to change it to string and try
to interpolate you can't interpolate
string
so that's where the
that option called interpolate comes in
so interpolates
um
is of option allows you to
add more features to Twin to tell them
okay I'm getting a number I am getting a
string and here's how you can twin them
so here's how you can interpolate them
so for example let's uh make our example
simple I start with a string which is a
and I want to move I want to set it to
Zack right I'm gonna say A to Z
so I change I can't interpolit string
value so over here I can Implement a
function called interpolate
which is a function that takes in a
which takes in A and B and returns
another function that takes in a t and
then returns something that you need to
implement over here
so what's a b and t so let's print this
out and take a look so a b t
so a is actually the starting point B is
the target point and T is the value from
0 to 1. so as you can see here a is z
because you start with
e and then B is actually exact itself
and then the t is the time from 0 to 1
uh so which is the position where like
you are currently at from 0 to 1. so it
will start moving from zero and all the
way to one
right so for example right now I want to
Twin from A to Z then what should I do
well probably I can do something like
this where
I can maybe interpolate in terms of the
characters so for example Ace chart code
at zero
is a number right
a code
and B code
sb.char code at
zero
and then I can interpolate between these
two numbers
so I will say uh result code equals to a
code plus b code
all right sorry it's a b code minus a
code
um times t plus a code
so we get the difference between a and b
and then we type so uh if it's zero and
then we plus times t and n plus a code
so a code uh if a t is zero then what
you get will be just a the value of a
code right but if T is one which is the
target value then
um this will be B code minus equal plus
a code will release you to B code right
so this is uh standard format of how you
would write interpolation
so with the chart code we are going to
convert it back to its own character so
a chakra has to be an integer so and we
are going to round it so math dot round
result code and to convert it to a
character I'm going to say a string Dot
from Char code
I'm going to return this whole thing
and let's see we'll change from a all
the way to Z
right
um so if I change this Z to A okay so
and change a to z and then change it
back to a
it's cool right so you can write your
own interpolation
um as long as you follow this uh
function
so let's summarize what we have learned
so far
um we have seen how to use the twin
method to create a twin star
so the first parameter is the initial
value and second parameter is the
options in which you can control the
delay duration easing as well as
interpolation
we have seen what can be supported by
the built-in twin what can be
interpolated by them and we also seen
what how we can write the custom
interpolation function so next let's
move on to the spring methods so let's
allow me to copy this
and let's take a look at the spring star
so again uh spring is like a writable in
which you can change its value but by
default when you change the value it
moves it changed the value directly so
if you use spring instead
then your value have the value changes
moves like a spring
and a spring has actually properties
like how stiff the spring is and how
much resistance the spring has so this
two value is being summarized by
stiffness
and damping
so for example if my spring is very
stiff which means that it will snap back
to the Target value very quickly
so for example let me just uh choose
average value like a 0.5 and maybe
damping is also 0.5
let's see how it what we get
so if your num if the stiffness is if
you have a higher value in terms of
stiffness the the value will snap to the
Target value faster so let's see if I
starts from 0.2
you'll see that you will move slightly
slower
and if I go for a higher number like 0.9
then it snaps to the it moves faster to
the Target value
of course it will move faster which
means that it will also overshoots and
then snaps back like a spring
and then damping which means damping is
a function for uh slowing things down so
it works in an opposite pair of your
stiffness so if you
um if you have a very small number
for example 0.2 which means that um
uh it will it will decrease in terms of
velocity slower so you will see your
spring your you will see a spring moves
oscillation a lot oscillate oscillates a
lot but if you have a higher number for
example 0.8 then your spring will not
oscillate that much and then settle down
faster
so these are the two values that you can
play around with spring
and over here we set the value right so
when you set the value you'll move to
that Target value but sometimes you want
to move to that value but without but
without
um springing to that Target value
so how you would you do that so you can
do that by uh coming back to the sets
method
so value dot sets
so if you write dollar value Sim
variable over here where you assign
value to 20 it actually means value dot
sets 20. uh but you can't uh in this way
of writing you can't actually specify
the second option arguments if you have
so here we we fall back to value.sets
because we want to pass in a second
argument and the second argument that
you can pass to a spring store is first
is an object and the first is you can
have a property called heart goes to
true
This Heart
indicates that you want to move to that
Target value immediately without
without making like a spring where it
Springs to that value for example you
have moved to 60 it's like a spring 80
and then 40 it's like hard jump to that
value
and opposite of Hearts what you get is
um soft
so value dot sets 60 soft
so you might ask like uh if you already
if you already like if you assigned a
value it's already moving like a spring
to that Target value right then what's
the point of having to pass in soft well
um I'm not
able to show you a particular in in this
example I probably we can't really see
the difference but then the difference
is this when you said soft you actually
tries to maintain the speed of the
moving value for example if I'm moving
to from from 0 to 100 and then I quickly
click 60. it will maintain the speed
to reach you will maintain a speed and
instead of
setting 60 as a Target value and trying
to snap to 60.
and
how long do you want to maintain the
speed will be this value that you pass
into soft
so this soft actually tells you zero to
one you can pass the value from 0 to 1
indicates like how many seconds it takes
to recover to turn back to become a
spring
I know it's a bit abstract and
personally I also can't tell the
difference visually but that is how it
works
so um
so for example if I say
um I want the
I want I pass in zero which means that
it does not take it takes zero time to
convert back to a spring and which means
that this actually is the same as
calling value equals to 20. right value
sorry value equals to 60. so setting
soft to zero is three the same as
setting value to 60 without passing any
soft because uh you you take zero second
to recover back to become a spring
right and if it's one then it takes like
one second
so that is it's that is all the options
that you can pass in for spring so let's
summarize about spring is you can
control the stiffness and the dampness
of damping of your spring she controls
how much how much it will spring and how
much it has resistance in slowing it
down
right and then you can have options like
hot and soft to control whether you want
the Springs to kick in when you change
the value or you want it to be disabled
just for the moment
in this video I'm gonna bring in a
concept from functional programming to
allow you to create more stores
using uh function pure functions right
and this concept is what I'm going to
introduce you is called
higher order Stars
so what is higher order Stars so if you
are familiar with functional programming
uh terminologies you know that higher
order functions is a function that takes
in a function
and then return a new function which the
new function is being enhanced by your
function
and probably if you're familiar with
react or other component libraries
you're familiar with this concept called
higher order components which means that
your function take it takes in one
component and return a new enhanced
component
and I'm going to borrow this concept
this idea of higher order function I'm
going to bring it to store
so right now I'm going to share with you
a few uh higher order stores
which is a function that takes in your
store and then return a new enhanced
store so you can do cool things with the
star
so are you excited
let's jump right in and take a look at
this example that I've prepared for you
over here
so if you take a look at this code right
here let me zoom in a bit so that you
can see the text clearer
I have a mouse position which is a star
if you have followed me on how you can
create a star using dumb events this is
exactly the same code that I have
written over there
um links in the description if you want
to watch that video
so um I use this star
and I assign it to a variable so you
don't have to I mean right now I'm going
to assign it to this variable called
position so position is actually equals
to Mouse position
um you don't have to do it you can use
the mouse position directly if you want
to as well but just bear with me for now
so this store
the store value itself has two property
it's an object and has two property it
has Y and X
so when I move my mouse the X and Y
property value of this star will updates
according to my store a mouse position
so over here I created a div which is
really in color uh 100 times 100 in size
and then make it a position absolute and
so that it has a transform that moves
based on the value of the star the mouse
position star So based on the X and the
Y value so right now if I move my mouse
you can see that this box is following
me around with my mouse so
um so as I move my mouse the value of
the star is updated and
the code over here subscribes to that to
the value of the star so that it always
gets updated so over here you always get
updated value of the X and the Y
position and you can also see it over
here where I print that both value out
in
in the Box over here
so um so let's let me introduce a few
higher order
store that I've prepared ahead of time
so the first one is called the bounce so
the bounce is a function and takes in a
star and it's going to return a new star
so over here I use derived to do that
so I use a function called derive and
takes in a star and derive metal will
return me a new store
right but then this the bounce itself is
a fun it's a high order star it takes in
a star and return me a new star so what
this derived method does is that it will
um
I will set timeout
um so that it uh it will debounce the
value of the star so the the starter is
text in by this the bounce function
whenever the value has changed it does
not change the return star value
immediately you only updated in maybe
after 100 milliseconds if nothing else
has changed right so you make a lot of
changes at once it's not updated until
uh 100 milliseconds after the last
change
so to use it you can import
the Bounce from the bounce
and since this is a function and it that
takes in a store and returns a new store
I can do it like this
all right so you see that this is still
a star you don't have to change anything
we just wrap your store with a function
which is a higher order store function
and this will gives us a new enhanced or
a customized store
so with this the bounce what you can see
is when I move my mouse it does not move
immediately but uh the value of the X
and Y is being the bounced
right
so it feels a bit weird but it it is how
the bounce work but probably what we
want is not the bounce but throttle or
throttle means is that for every
so whenever you have valuable changes
you don't
um you limit the changes to happen only
maybe uh once in maybe 100 milliseconds
so you have changes that happens very
quickly in successive that does not
happen only the value will only be
throttled to only change in every 100
millisecond
so we're going to use this throttle
function
apparently we haven't implemented it but
you can see immediately the the ID of
high order star is texting the store and
returns a star
right so
um I can so I can easily replace this
like throttle
with throttle and replace this function
I still get my star I still get my store
and I don't have to change anything else
so
um I can
and good thing about because of the
functional programming idea I can change
multiple star
at once for example I can debounce and
then throttle and yeah this still gives
me so this gives me a new star and then
the bounce will give me another new star
and I the the position is still a star I
can still use it like a star
so yep so let's since I haven't
implemented throttle let's do that
together
okay so here I have my function a star
I remember the last time we used derived
to derive the star
um I'm gonna do the same thing over here
as well so I am going to import derive I
find that derive is a very uh great way
to create a new store out of an existing
store
so that is what I'm gonna do it over
here as well
so derive
from the store and it takes in the value
and the sets method
and over here
I am going to take I'm gonna know like
what take note of what is the time right
now so now it's equals to date dot now
so I also need because of throttling I
need to so the idea of throttle is that
things happens at most uh at the the
value the the star changes happen at
least uh 100 milliseconds apart right
that that amount of time is something
that we can control but it happens in uh
in a fixed interval so to to have this
kind of fixed in the bowl we have to
know like what is the last time that we
have changed the value of the star so
this is the last uh I need to derive uh
declare a variable called last time
uh that we just change the value of the
star
so if last time
is probably undefined
it's not
it does not have a value or
now minus the last time
is
more than 100
which means that either case so if
there's no last time we need to change
set the store right now because it
hasn't been set before and it was set
before then we only set it again if the
time right now is more than the last
time
so over here I'm gonna say uh set value
oh sorry value
and last time and then we need to update
the last time so last time it goes to
now
or else we're not doing we're not doing
anything right let's try and see
so yeah it's it's slightly slower it's
following around but it's slower it
updates slower so we have like some sort
of throttling happening right now so we
can compare you can have two divs uh so
I'm gonna create another div
um so here is the throttle position
which has the color of maybe blue uh set
it uh 120
uh this should be negative 60 60 okay
and let's create a new star let throttle
position equals to throttle Mouse
position
so we can remove this for now
and let's see so with throttle you can
see that it does not update immediately
all right
and however it feels like
um
once we stop uh if it's just recently
updated the last value is not being
updated uh
to the store as well so probably we want
that to be updated as well so that you
know it does not stuck at like uh either
like it still honors uh last few changes
that's made but then still within the
interval so what I'm going to do here is
I'm gonna set a timeout if
uh it's not changing I need to set a
timeout and probably clear this if uh if
there's new changes coming in
so I'm going to say uh set timeout
which is let's say also 100 milliseconds
and if this timeout triggers I'm going
to call set timeout with the value
um over here I am going to get the timer
ID
I remember remember that when I say
derive uh if it's a synchronous mode you
can return a function that clears that
does the cleanup so I'm gonna do that
over here now so I'm return the function
that say clear time out with the timeout
ID
if it does not return a function so if
it's in this if case it does not return
the function it's okay as well we'll
handle that but in if it's the else case
return the function so when the next
time this async this function has been
called again uh as well clean it up
first by calling this function first
before executing the holes it will clean
the previous return function and then
run the script again
so let's try again so at least I think
right now you can see is that uh even we
move very fast the
um the last value is still being updated
uh like even if it's not like even if
the last update happens uh right just
right after the last star changes we're
still gonna change it um uh 100
milliseconds later
right I think it's a bit abstract to
understand the bounce usually uh if you
are not familiar with the uh sorry
throttle if you're not familiar with
throttle uh
you can take a look at maybe like some
diagrams of throttling and you can see
over here what throttle means is that it
will ensure that uh events events happen
at a fixed interval right so this one uh
what happens over here and then if like
a lot of things happening at once only
this this interval is fixed so that it
will it will just show like the last
value over here and then show this last
value over here right
so
um yeah if you are you if you are still
confused you can comment down below and
I try to probably find some link uh to
help you with help with help you with
right so
uh as you can see here I have other uh
high order stars that I want to share
with you as well so another one I can
think of is actually called a read-only
high order star
so for example if you have a star that
you can change the value with for
example right now I'm gonna create like
input box
buying value with a value star
and you want to create a new store
which is called read only value
but somehow uh the user of this store
does not know and still binds it to a
input and you want to actually want them
like no don't do that right uh so let's
see so for example right now I have a
writable
star so that's our writable spell star
and declare like a value equals to
writeable
let's
read only value equals to value
yep so for example okay let me hide this
two box first
for example I have uh value is a
writable star so when I change something
should change and I want to pass this
store around to anyone to subscribe to
it but I don't want them to actually set
the value I just want them to able to
subscribe to it and just read only
right so if you pass this store as like
a variable and if you assign it to a
variable called read only value and you
expect it to only read only and then you
are wrong uh because they actually can't
set the value so this this variable is
being used by this second input and the
second input tries to set the value and
actually manage to set it
so if you want to prevent that
you can wrap this door with um
instead of writing your own trying to
come up with a custom store you can
write a higher order Stars so that if
you have a lot of similar use case not
just for this store and a lot of other
stores you can take in the store and
then pass it into this higher order
store and this higher the store will
make sure that whatever store you text
in will become a read-only store so you
will return a new copy a new star that
is read only and without touching the
existing star
so this year I um import read only from
read only
and I'm going to call this read only
with the value
so this will return to me a new star so
I can it's still able to subscribe to
this the value star but if I try to
change over here although you don't see
it immediately but you can see that
there's already console error that tells
you that the value your unable to set a
value of a read only star
uh you still The Binding still works is
just because the uh in uh we we don't
really we don't really do a uh because
an area has already thrown out so right
now you are changing the value of the
input uh but after that the input will
try to set the value store and there's
an error and it does not come back again
to reset the value of the inputs that's
why you still see the values there but
actually an area has already thrown and
uh error has already happened
right so read only star and how you
implement it
you don't always have to use a derived
to create a higher the star or custom
store you can create your own for
example in this case I only need the
Subscribe method from the store so I say
subscribe it goes to the store subscribe
but
um to to give up a better to give out a
nicer error I also implement the sets
method that it throws an error whenever
you call it so without it I will still
it will still it is still a read-only
store for example when I said something
it is still a read only store except the
error is slightly different it says read
only value.set it's not a function
so to give a meaningful error I say I
still implement it and say it will throw
in an error so that you know that you
have done something that you shouldn't
have done
so lastly I want to show you is called a
spring higher order star so
um you've seen that we're able to
throttle the value of the position
so let me comment this out and let's
come back to this two Box Thing
right you see that we have able to
um
passing a throttle and then throttle the
position right
um that's we that's not so we we doesn't
have to limit ourselves with like things
like the bounce throttle or delay we can
do something like a spring and this
example I'm going to show you
particularly and we can write it out
together because it's I find that it's a
bit interesting to think about this
so I want to implement uh spring higher
order uh
star
so such that I can call Spring with the
value I
the value of the uh to pass in a star to
the spring higher the star and returns
me a new star that is hopefully well the
value of the star will be springy
so over here
um
I am going to imp I'm going to use the
built-in spring
method from the spelled motion
so hopefully you have watched my
previous video about spring and twin I
leave the links to that video in the
description
so over here I'm gonna import
spring
from svelt motion
and over here
I want to implement a spring store I
want to return a new spring store
um
yeah I want to return a new spring store
so I need to create a spring store first
spring star it goes to spring
and
the initial value of this spring should
come from this star
but we can set it later on so so for now
I'm going to say undefined so if it's
undefined or now it will be now
undefined and when you set a value it
will not like spring to that value like
the first value that is not null or
undefined will be
um will be set it directly so there's no
springing from undefined to like your
number
so over here I say I'm gonna Define some
like properties of the spring for
example stiffness probably I'm going to
go for 0.6 damping maybe on like 0.2
thing
so that it's more springy so that I can
see the effect
and over here if I return spring store
directly
um
written spring store directly
you we still haven't have a way to
update the spring store right you have
ways to subscribe to it but you have no
way to update it
and I don't want to return spring store
directly as well because
um that in that case springstall will
have both uh subscribe and a set method
and I only want people to subscribe to
Spring store I don't want to set the
value of spring store and yeah it should
be a read-only thing as well
so I can say uh subscribe for now
it goes to springstall.subscribe
um over here
I need to subscribe to the store
uh to the original store and I'm going
to have a fun whenever something has
changed I need to use this value to set
the value of the spring star so over
here I'm going to say um
spring
store.sets
so let's try uh
whoops it's not work is it working is it
not working
yeah it is working it is very springy
it is very springy
um I'm guessing shouldn't need throttle
for now
let's take a look at how it will
it's still very springy
uh oops yeah very springy so I'm gonna
reduce this spring uh maybe like damping
increasing the damping so that it it
settles faster
right
so uh if you take a look over here the
code you may notice that we subscribe to
the store but we do not unsubscribe from
it
all right this is this this will lead to
us always subscribing to the store even
if say for example we are no longer
subscribed
uh for example this function written the
Subscribe method should returns an app
subscribe and over here we should
um unsubscribe uh if it's we should
unsubscribe from the store as well
and if we do something like this uh so
if we come over here
and have a function
subscribed to it
and let oh this one also have to be
unsubscribed from Star
you can do something like this right
so that we unsubscribe from both
subscribe from store and um subscribe
from Spring
yeah
but this doesn't
this isn't
exactly correct as well because if you
take a look over here
um this unsubscribes it's just
unsubscribe from
like once instance of unsubscribing so
if you have multiple
people subscribe like multiple cases to
sub subscribe to the the return store
for example you have five cases of
subscribing to it as long as one of it
unsubscribing from this store uh we uh
immediately unsubscribing from this uh
the initial position store
you cannot subscribe from
this spring star is okay right because
you still have four other people
subscribing to it and receiving it but
you shouldn't unsubscribe immediately
from this
um original store
so we can't really do this we want to do
this we have to
um maybe Keep A Memory of reference
counts of how many functions that we
have and only unsubscribe from the store
if all of them is being unsubscribed
which means we have to manage again come
again to manage the number of functions
that is being subscribed being
subscribed to the to our to our store
and yeah so so that is something we
should probably change to
but I have an idea over here we can
define a readable star
so if I say okay so that let me type it
out first I can use readable
from svelt Star
readable
um I can have undefined first and a set
so over here
this function of the readable star
will be caught only once when someone is
subscribing to it and you can return a
function if that will be called only if
all of the subscribers unsubscribe from
it so probably we can set up the
subscription of the store over here
instead
and I'm subscribe it from here only in
here
right we answer we subscribe we only
subscribe once when there's someone
subscribing from this readable store and
unsubscribed immediately
uh unsubscribes when not immediately but
only when everyone has unsubscribed from
this readable store which is great right
and which we probably should return this
readable store instead so
yeah but then how about over here
um so when we subscribe
to the store and we should also uh have
this in here as well right we should
also subscribe from the
uh spring star subscribe so we should
also subscribe to the Sprint store
and since uh when whenever the spring
store has changed should update the
value of the readable store as well so
instead of function this is actually
sets so this set will notify all the
subscribers that uh the spring star has
changed and oh and then notify all the
subscribers of the readable store
right so over here I copy this over
and I think this is much better
implementation than the previous one so
I'm going to remove this
and I'm gonna clean up over here a bit
and here we have readable and Spring
right so if I move along
it still works
pretty much the same we don't really
test out the unsubscribing parts but
based on the logic that I've walked you
through I hope that you understand uh
where I'm coming from and why is it so
right if you are not sure comments down
below you can ask questions and I love
to answer them okay
so finally we have seen uh various kind
of high order stars like throttle the
bounce read-only spring
and
if you uh being inspired by this video
and you think that you also want or you
already have some sort of some higher
the stars that you want to share
comments down below I want to see them
and if they are good I'm going to share
them to the World on my Twitter account
and probably I will want to also make a
video out of it right I want to learn
from you as well
so you have seen how we can create
custom stores and it's felt out of
popular state management libraries such
as Redux State machine exit value and
you're seeing how we can create a
immutable
star using images
and there's one Library although it's
not entirely like a state management
libraries but it has helped us with a
lot of event streaming uh which is rxjs
so today I'm going to let's take a look
at how we can use rxjs as a store in
spelled application
so um I'm actually very new to arcgs and
in fact I haven't really used rxjs
before prior this recording this video I
have done my research it's just solely
because of this video because I know
some of you have been using rxjs and
wanted to see how you can use rxjs with
spells
um so if I do anything wrong please
comment down below and let me know about
it okay thank you
so rxjs so rxjs provides us like
observables that you can subscribe to
and get the value of the observables
and that actually the concept of debts
actually very similar to cell store
where you can subscribe to the store and
get the value of the store
and you can subscribe from it
so if you take a look at observable and
the stock contract
you'll notice that observable actually
kind of follows the spell store contract
so what that means is that if you have
an observable
you can use the dollar prefix value
variable syntax to access the value of
uh the all the the values that is being
generated out of the observable
so let me show you an example over here
I have a rebel so now I want to create
an observable using from event
so from event allows us to create
observable from an event listener so I'm
import from rxcs and over here I'm going
to create a mouse position observable
so over here I use from events say
document and then listens the mouse move
even from a document
and immediately uh if I do something
like this
Mouse position
merely I can already get the value uh
all the events from Mouse move
observable so it's it's mouse event but
there's nothing uh it's it's like the
event itself so if you want to actually
get the client X and client one of the
mouse move event
you will have to pipe it through
um
rxjs operators to maybe pick up uh pick
up some X and Y position right from the
from the event so for each of the events
I'm going to call map so map is an
operator from arcgis
um so
I'm pretty new to this uh I've tried to
do my best on researching this if I'm
doing something wrong let me know in the
comments right so our shares operators
so I'm using map and oops sorry from and
I need to map the events to maybe an
object so I'm going to say x is
events.client X Y is event.client y
so I pipe this event to the mouse
position and now let's try and see what
happens come over here okay object
object so I'm gonna say uh instead I'm
gonna say Json or 3G file to see the
mouse position
so when I move around you can similarly
that this is like um
a star you can subscribe to it and it
also returns and subscribe unsubscribe
method then you cannot subscribe from
the store so basically it's
it works out of box right what about
using rxjx with shell you just work out
on a box you can use it immediately
so um you've seen how we can convert an
observable to a spell store basically
not really convert because observable
has already implemented the spell store
contract so you can use it like a
spelled store
using the dollar prefix syntax to
subscribe automatically subscribes and
unsubscribe from it and get the value of
out of the observable events
but now we're going to look at a flip
side of it
for example if you have a spell store
can you convert that to become an
observable well of course the answer is
yes I'm going to roughly show you how I
would do it
again disclaimer this is my first time
doing this uh if you have a better way
of doing it or better API that I don't
know of let me know comments down below
right so here I'm gonna say uh from uh I
have a decline function called tool
observable
and it should take in a star and I'm
gonna return a new original observable
so I can create Observer a new
observable using the Constructor
observable
and for each of the Observer
um
we need to subscribe from the store and
for each of the value coming out from
the store we are going to call Observer
dot next
with the value
so
um I think I need to return this
unsubscribe method so
um so the observable can be upsubscribed
from it as well if you return the
unsubscribe method if you can from uh
from for each of the Observer
so I can convert a star to observable
right so here I've created a store using
a mouse position it's the same event but
it's it's using it's creating a new
readable store which is a custom so we
can create a custom spell store out of
the mouse position
uh you should watch the video on how I
created this links in the description
below
so over here I'm going to import that uh
Mouse position store
and actually over here I also need to
know that I need to import this
observable right so over here I'm gonna
I have my mouse positioned as a store
okay Mouse position star
I would do to create
um
observable out of it I probably will
have to uh call observable
the store and since it's observable we
can subscribe to it and take a look at
the value out of it right so here I'm
gonna say value console log value
so this is now an observable
uh we can see the value out of it and to
prove that this is already an observable
we're going to use pipe like one of the
rxjs operator again over here so I'm
going to say pipe it to see um this time
I'm going to use a new operator called
plug so I can just pick one value out of
the uh
uh objects so this object the store
gives us X and Y value so here I'm going
to plug just the X
so if I move around you'll see that only
the x value oh I think I forgot to
unsubscribe that's why you can see the
console again Let me refresh this
uh
whoops
yeah so you can see that the x value is
coming out from the console
so here we're here um
I am going to so this is like the X
observable uh using I'm gonna say x
dollar
uh and I'm gonna create another
observable called y dollar equals to two
observable
Mouse position star
dot pipe and you can plug just a y
property
and finally we are maybe going to create
a news uh new observable by zipping this
to where these two observable into one
let's say sum of X and Y equals to zip
maybe X and Y
and pipe it so I'm gonna use map again
over here I'll become an array of x
value and Y value and I am going to
return the sum of both
X Plus y so again this are all
observables right to prove that this is
observable you can do all the operators
from observable uh from arcgs
finally this is an observable which
means it follows a store contract and
you can still subscribe to it but here I
am you can see sum of X and Y so as I
move along you can see that over here
you can see the sum of X and Y being
shown over here
right so that's all for
um rxjs with svelte star you can uh this
rxjs observable is already following the
swell star contract which means that you
can already Subs subscribe automatically
subscribes from it using a dollar prefix
variable syntax
and it's and also actually we can also
in this video I've showed you how you
can convert a store to come observable
so that you can play around using all
the observable rxjs operators to play
around with all those events and then
finally because it is a store you can
use it directly again so instead of you
know coming out with your own derived
and uh deriving like custom store uh
deriving store from an existing store
you can convert it to our xjs maybe it's
easier for you to play around with it
using all the rxjs operators and then
finally it is still following a store
contract so although essentially it's
observable but you can still subscribe
it like a store
so today I have a challenge for you how
to make a Class Property
to be like a star
so the question is like this I have a
scenario where I have a class called
clock
which has a property called time so this
time right now is the current time but I
have a function called tick that will
update this property every tick so I I
can call this tick function tick method
every time every second or every few
minutes uh that does not matter but
every time I change call this method I'm
going to change this property called
time
and what I want is that I want to
subscribe to this class property I have
so over here I am using this clock I'm
creating a new instance of this clock
and every interval I'm calling a tick
method right every one second for now
and I over here I want to have I want to
always show this clock time I want to
show that it's uh I want to so I have
two places one is in a reactive
statements where I'm assigning this
clock time to a variable and hopefully
this variable can
uh this this hopefully these statements
will be reviewed re-evaluated every time
when the clock time has changed uh of
course right now it does not uh because
if I uncomment this you notice that
actually we are calling a tick method
every second but you only see one
console over here which means that those
Felts not all the variables over here
say this is a assignment so all the
variables on the right which is the
clock uh has not changed so far right
which is true because we haven't changed
the clock variable over here time yeah
time is being assigned over here so all
as well I can see is that the clock has
not changed and therefore we are not
going to this is not going to be
re-evaluated every time when you call
the clock.tick
same thing goes if I come over here and
say clock the time instead
um again this clock is this clock
variable has never changed so we are not
going to
update this text over here
um but how about when we assign it to a
variable I'm assuming that the time
proper clock does not change is okay but
I'm assuming the time variable should
change I'm I guess this this should
change right because the time variable
is the time property is what we are
changing so far but again Phil does not
see that so it does not know that
um every tick you update this property
does not know when this is updated
there's no way to know
um so
what should we do
so to know a variable
that has changed is either whether the
variable is being defined as a top level
variables in a script tag which is like
a stitch to the components yes there's
ways if your update is those variables
spell would know immediately but over
here clock is a class it could be
written in a separate file or it could
be written in your M plus field but then
all this property is not a top level
um top level variables in a script tag
therefore it is not a state to the
components and therefore spell has no
way that to know that day has changed
spell the compiler will not analyze
until that level to know actually this
property has changed there's no way to
trace this you can change this variable
everywhere right if you pass this clock
um because plus this crop clock instance
to anywhere and you call the tick
function a tick method uh the the
variable will change in terms of
compiling time you in in terms of the
compile time there's no way to trace
that deep to know actually all the
places where you call the tick method
and therefore end those kind of
reactivity over there unless you trace
it unless you use some sort of runtime
method like a proxy to to to figure
those things out right or maybe like
some sort of dependency tracking but
here so what we left over here is of
course yes you can use some sort of
dependency tracking Library memory
to to help us with this but in this
video we're going to take a look at how
we can use store to help us right so
star I can see two ways to use a store
to to help us out in this scenario
so first is take a look at so to
to come up with this tool to come up
with that two ideas that I have is it
stamps up with this statement time
equals clock dot time
and as I explained earlier clock has
never changed so spell
treat does not treat this as something
that will ever be re-evaluated anymore
so there's only two ways two methods
that you can do over here right first is
that how about we let sellout knows that
clock actually is a star clock is
something that you need to subscribe to
right that is that is possible right so
one is you make a clock like a store and
a store with a property that has a Time
so over here you you kind of subscribe
to the clock right that is one way uh
way number one and don't worry we're
gonna explore both of them we're gonna
try both of the uh idea that I I can
think of for now so first is you treat
uh clock as a star okay second way that
I can think of is how about we treat
time as a star so what I mean is that
say for example let's come up with
another reactive statement uh or not
maybe we have like a Time store variable
equals to clock Dot
time
okay and what you have here instead is
you are consoling
the Time store
so this is a
you can even do chords right this is a
variable but this is a store variable
which means that this can be subscribed
and the value can change so if you do
this over here we are telling that
thanks spelled that okay this is a star
subscribes to it you if it if the store
value changes then you have to run this
again so the way you probably would want
to use is come over here and do this
right you come over here and write time
star
so this is Method number two
all right time star
so let's let's write the method number
one as well here is the clock
the time right
so if you
if you take a look at how I come up with
this you notice that the initial code
the initial code that we have
time equals the clock but time I'm
looking at this statement time equals
clock on time and this if you want this
to be reactive to be something like a
store that you can subscribe to then
there's only two possibilities right one
is the clock itself is a store or
secondly is that the clock the time the
time is the star
so that's why first one is I retrieve
the clock as a store and we do this so
that we can subscribe to the cloud and
secondly is we treat time as store so if
you get the time out as a variable then
we can subscribe to it all right uh do
not do know that uh although time is a
storm we can't really do like this
because
cloud.time is not a uh you have to
Define this as a property and again this
does not mix well things that it is a
star uh spell only looks at the variable
over here right so if we assign it to
something else and we now itself is a
variable then we can use a dollar uh
that variable to subscribes to it okay
so let's start with the first
idea right clock as a store
so what is a store
is a contract where star says that any
variable that you can treat this as a
store when it implements this method
called subscribe
and of course if you want it to be
readable you want the store to be able
to be updated then you implement the
sets method right and the Subscribe
method itself takes in a function which
is to be which is like a listener a
subscriber and you have to notify that
function every time that you something
has changed
so um yeah and then that function once
you when you call subscribe method you
should return also a function to
unsubscribe to the store right so this
is the score contract we've explored
that and you can find this video in the
link in the description or even in my
channel say what is a store contract and
you will find that
so let's start with
implementing
clock itself the class itself as a store
right so this clock is a class right and
all these are the methods so what we can
do actually uh very simply is to
implement this subscribe
methods once you experiment this
subscribe method you
clock this is another subscribe
you can already treat the clock as a
star right so if I come over here and
comment other things away
is not a star with us wait wait I do
write subs or Subs
cribe right now you see that this is a
subscribe and you need to return a
function
written
a function to unsubscribe now you
right now you implement this immediately
you are making this clock
instance This Cloud class instance a
store
so what do we notify what do we send
this clock right so
um we can come over here and record down
all these functions subscriber function
uh Subs function and we need to tell
them the value right I need to tell like
a value for example time okay I I can do
it two ways one is I pass it with
everything I have for this class so
every time this class has something
changed uh yeah I would have to notify
the subscriber
um with the entire thing so whatever I
get from this whatever is treated as a
store value from this store variable is
the whole class instance
okay so if I do this then it can get
every anything I have so it's not about
time it also have this uh tick
you do this
hold on what's wrong again subscribe
subscriber okay
yeah you can also call Tick over here it
will still work right so it will
the store value itself is the class
itself right everything you see there is
is a value so that is one way of course
if you want to limit whatever you can
subscribe to like you limit only the
properties that you can get then maybe
you can create an object instead and
just pass down properties that you want
to be accessible from the store as a
star value so I'm going to pass just the
time this Dot time
and now you see that clock.tick is not a
function it complains because whatever
is treated as the store value is
whatever you pass it over here so you
only has the time
right so it it kind of
I'm not sure about you it really depends
on what you want right so this may make
it a bit less intuitive because you know
clock itself has all this time and tick
method but once you treat it like a
store then the store value only have
time
property so it's up to you right so for
for Simplicity I'm just gonna pass
everything like I'm just a password this
over here so that I don't have to write
so many things over here and now uh I
also need to
record the subscriber down so that every
time I call Tick I also have to call the
subscriber
uh this right I have to come over here
to get this reference and call this this
right so probably I would have to do
things like uh maintain a list of
subscribers
and over here I'm gonna push this this
like subscribers that push subscriber
and over here I'm gonna Loop through
desktop subscribers
dot push
uh sorry the forage
for each of them
I'm gonna call this right every time I
tick I will have to come over here and
notify with a new value and immediately
you can see now I this is updating uh
even
here even here hey sorry yeah even here
it's it's it's being triggered right you
can see this has been controlled out now
this is great except that it's undefined
because this is Tick so I'm gonna change
it to time you can see that this is
being called with a new time every time
now right we are making our clock
a star we're making a clock class uh
instance a store
because this is a lot to implement
um although it does not seem that way
any uh and we even forget to how to
implement the unsubscribe which is we
have to uh subscribers and supplies and
gets the instance to remove it
subscribers
ah that index of subscriber
and we need even to need to remember to
clean it up right this does not look a
lot but there's actually an easier way
to do this which is to use a writable
store so we can use uh inbuild Stars
writable for example
and we can rely on them to to handle all
the subscribers for us so what we can do
what we need to do now is uh just create
a store first up front so I'm gonna say
this is the store okay writable
so what you pass in is the value of this
store right we're going to pass in this
and
over here in the Subscribe method we can
do is we can call it store and then we
say a uh subscribe we can call this
subscribe we can delegate this to our
store uh object over here it's called
subscribe and subscriber I'm gonna
return this right so the store helps us
to do the subscriber it also returns a
function to unsubscribe so we just
return it directly so all of this being
delegated to this writable store that we
have over here
okay then the next thing is ah man I
forgot
probably there's too many stores running
that's why because we forgot to do a
cleanup so I'm going to refresh this
page now so that it does not it stops
consoling
right okay now uh and it stops because
we haven't notified uh
our store that something has changed I'm
gonna come over here
uh now we don't need subscribers so we
come over here and we notify our store
so we're gonna see this store and sets
this right so we're gonna set whatever
is the updated value right so now you if
we are using this as the value of the
star then we use this if you were
thinking of doing this like the time
then you have to write this over here
like this right so it's up to you
whatever what what is being what is the
value of this store so I'm gonna be lazy
and write this and that's all and you
can see now it's nicely done
uh my star is ticking this is the this
is the
um
uh we treat the clock
instance as a star
okay so next we're gonna try a second
method which is to treat just a property
itself as a store
so over here I am gonna pause it for now
I'm gonna uh let's see not pause it I'm
gonna copy all this and create another
file clock
so that
um the link of this Ripple will be in
the description and so that you can
compare this to uh implementation right
clock 2. so I'm going to replace this
I'm going to replace okay no I don't
have to replace let's say import Clock
Two
from two
okay and uh for the time being and stop
ticking so that less noise over here
and then I'm gonna use my clock to
I'll create a clock too
clock2.tick
and now we want to figure out how to do
this which is
get a property and treat it as a store
so
let's see so we can use the same idea
which is to use a writable but itself
has to be a star right so this time
actually has to be a writable star
and now every time we tick we're gonna
say this dot time dot sets
right so every time we tick I'm gonna
update this writable store over here
so over here uh Cloud Dot
climb store
oh hold on clock that time oh this
should be Clock Two the time is a star
and now if I uncomment this you see that
this number is updating every tick
because and over here you can see this
is being consoled
out on every tick because yeah this
itself is a store now so what does that
mean what that means is that if I clock
that clock to the time if I get this
this is no longer a value I can't read
this value now I have to treat it as a
store and I have to either do this to
get the value of the store or I have to
import the get
from svelt Star
to get the value out of this time
variable over here like I have to get
the time
to actually read out the value
because it's no longer it is it is no
longer a property uh no longer a
primitive it is an object right even you
can't see it over here
so
um
that's great
um depends on your use case but to me I
feel like we kind of gain something and
lose something at the same time I want
this property to be a Just A Primitive
number
but maybe we can have some sort of
convention to tell
um
to to kind of tell the user that maybe
this is
a very primitive value which is a number
but if you do something like this right
this should give you the store that you
need
or maybe even like this
should give you the star that you knit
right so what that means is that
actually uh this has no special meaning
until we give it to them right so uh
what this means is that we can actually
have time as a normal variable but we
also did find another proper another
property called maybe time dollar is
equal to writeable uh this dot time
so every time we change the time maybe
we can come over here and say this
dot time equals to the date now
and we also update this star over here
and say this dot time
so now this is not a sub something you
can subscribe to but rather this is
something that you can subscribe to
so uh so I I kind of uh
I have
yeah so it kind of allows us to a
have a flexibility of you know just use
it as a normal value or have it
especially right have some sort of
special thing that is like a special
property that is like a store that you
can subscribe to so user can use both of
them if they want to so here I can still
console
hello
time
primitive
I can have still console it as a number
and if I want to subscribe then I use a
subscribable property right so this is
this is your this is up to you this is
how you design your components
um yeah so before I end this I'm going
to say that this star is created every
time when we create a clock even no one
is subscribing to it and we can actually
um
change this slightly we can add slide uh
if this is a bottleneck that you
encountered and realize that hey I
shouldn't create this store every time
when I have this clock instance because
no one is subscribing to me and if you
if you know no one is actually assessing
this time Dollar property if you notice
that then maybe some you can optimize it
this way I'm gonna show it how I I would
do it so first is I
i instead of doing this
I I can have like again like us
more of a private property called uh
time star
uh yeah so I haven't defined it yet so I
just wait so I'm gonna have this private
property called time and that that
starts with a pro underscore but at the
same time I look at a gather for this
class called time dollar
right so this is the geta method so this
tells us that if I call this right it
means that I'm reading the time a dollar
I'm gonna read I'm reading this time
Dollar property out from this class all
right so uh that tells me that okay if
someone is accessing this meaning
someone is interested to the store and
someone wants to subscribe to it so only
then we we create this store so I will
do here is that I would create a store
and store it somewhere which is like
privately so this this is the variable
that I'm gonna start this is a state I'm
gonna start in it so I'm going to come
over here and say uh if this dot
underscore time
uh it's already defined right so it's
like if this is not undefined
then I'm going to return this
immediately
or else I am gonna
uh create this right so maybe I can do
the other way around if it's not defined
yet
I can create this this dot underscore
time dollar equals to writeable this dot
time so I want to create this writable
store only when I'm assessing this time
Dollar property of my class
only created and when in a tick method I
will also if this
time
is not undefined and I only do this only
when it's already defined I only update
it let's say this dot time
uh dot sets this the time so I only
update this store create this store only
when it's needed and only update the
store when it's created so this way you
kind of uh
delay the creation of the writable store
if it's if it is a bottleneck to you
right so that's all that that we have
done so far uh how to make a Class
Property a store or how to make how to
subscribe to a class property right you
can make the class itself a store and
you kind of subscribe to the class
itself so that whenever the property has
changed you kind of know on the know
about it or you make the Class Property
a store and you subscribe to that
property right so we've explored two
different methods and I hope that this
opens up the possibilities that you can
do and if it if you quit something so
amazing that you want to share paste
your link to the Rebel or your project
in the comments and share it to the
world
hello I'm Leo so today we're going to
talk about how we can create a store
that allows us to do undo and redo
right so we have a store that stores our
data and we can make changes to the
store so presumably you have history of
the changes that you are making and then
right now what we want is that we want
the ability to undo the changes or we do
it after you click undo right so here I
have done a basic setup I've created
something like a mini calculator where I
have an input field over here
and I have ADD button so I can type a
number and then I click add or add the
number 10. and then hopefully I can type
say 50 and add 50 to it to 60. so what I
want to do is that uh this is
implemented as a store and I want to
have the undo or redo ability in the
store that allows me to click undo and
jump back to 10. and then redo will jump
back to 60 because uh yeah because we
created with 60 first and then undo back
to stand and then we back jump back to
60. so to create this kind of stars so
how should we approach this so that's
what we're going to talk about in this
video
so
um
the thing about how we can create an
undo reduced store right we want to
think about the undo redo mechanism
right so most likely you will have an
array that stores a history
and that history could be of two kinds
right so that defines uh that determines
the two different approaches that we can
look at for this video uh for this
problem right so the two approaches
would be first is that we have a history
we have an array of actions so that the
array of the history array records every
action that you are making right so
hopefully uh when you do Undo It means
that you are reverting that actions
right so the action will probably have
two different kind of methods or maybe
the action itself uh is is designed a
way that can make changes to the store
in one way as well as reversing the
changes right advancing like applying a
changes and reversing the changes right
so you have a array of debts
record then doing undo or redo BS
straightforward as
applying the changes or reversing those
changes
right so that is one approach and we
shall explore that later but let me tell
explain like the second approach right
the second approach would be
the history array starts a snapshots of
the value at every changes so every time
when you make changes you store the
snapshot of the value that you're
storing right so when you and so when
you make new changes you store again a
new snapshot so you have a history of
snapshots of your value the star value
and doing undo or redo will be
um reverting to that snapshot right so
you'll be kind of like setting back the
value of the star to a previous value or
previous snapshots and then redo will be
setting it to a new snapshot but of
course the act of
um
and do what we do shouldn't like
affect the history itself right so
setting like doing undo will be setting
your the star value to a previous
snapshot but that shouldn't uh set the
store value is in a sense where it's
like setting a new snapshot right that
is just reverting snapshots that's all
it doesn't touch the history of it at
all right so probably so we're going to
explore these two approaches
uh this will most likely will be like a
live coding kind of way of explaining
things so you will see like my thought
process along the way on how I'm gonna
tackle this so I've laid down my two
um General
approaches two way of thinking of it and
we shall take a look at both of them
right so this video
may be long so I will try to put in some
landmark in the
um in the YouTube video so you will have
like sections if you want to jump on the
first approach or the second approach
right so before I get started if you
like this video or you think that this
video is going to help you a lot please
consider to like my video as well as
share it if you are at the end of the
video if you think it's it's great right
so liking my video will definitely help
me as well as you because anyone who
likes my video will give YouTube an idea
that this video is great and it will
share and recommend to more people like
you and more people like you will able
to see this kind of video and help them
right and in return may help you right
so
let's see the first approach so the
first approach we're gonna do
is we're gonna so here we have a simple
store where every time when I add
something we are actually
changing the value of salt right we say
store plus equals value where we change
the star right so what we want to do
here is we want to add
an array called a
history
okay so remember this approach number
one
um I'm gonna create a new file called
approach
1.js so this approach number one is
we're gonna uh start a history of a
star history of actions
applied to the star
right so
okay I think I should do it this way I
should import
something from approach one so this
approach one let's see we're gonna use
meeting how should I do this
okay someone could use a concept that I
introduced previously it's called a
higher order star so it's a function
that sticks in a store and create a new
store so this star hopefully will gives
you a
um
and enhance ability uh to the existing
Star right so much like you learn about
in JavaScript where you have higher the
functions which is a function that
returns a new function I'm probably
taking a function and return a new
function right so how the star sticks in
one store so that star itself can be any
kind of stars can be a readable can be a
twin star can be anything right so we
don't care about what is that store
under the hood but we just add we're
just gonna wrap this door and add two
more abilities which is to do an undo
and redo right so here we're gonna
export this function uh which is our
higher order store function I'm going to
call it approach one right so it takes
in a store and hopefully it returns a
new star
right so a star is
a normal object any object can be a star
as long as it follows the spell store
contract which is to have the Subscribe
function that takes in a function and
return an unsubscribe function and the
function will be called with the sort
value right every time when you change
the function should be called to notify
all the subscribers that a new value has
changed right so you have to follow the
store contract which we're gonna
Implement implement store contract over
here
okay so here I'm gonna take it I'm going
to import approach one
from approach one
and here we have our store right so
we're just gonna make this star a
undo redo Star right so we're going to
create uh we're gonna say undo redo
redo star
it's gonna be approach one wrap around
with our existing store
and hopefully this function will return
to us a new store with with the same
store ability but with two more
functions which is to do undo and redo
so we're gonna use this undo reduce
store instead so everywhere here we're
gonna just use undo reader star
and in
and over here one click
for undo and redo we're going to call
undo from the under region store and
redo
right so we haven't implement the store
contract that's why it says that under
review store is not a star with a
subscribe method and we're gonna
Implement stats right so first thing
first we can
um
we can still use the underlying store
subscriber method over here so subscribe
can still be the store subscribe
okay and Set uh is something that we're
gonna overwrite right set
value
okay
and then we have the undo function
method and the redo method over here
okay
so first is we need to have a history
restore history of actions that is going
to be applied to the store right so I'm
going to create this history array
um okay so now we are doing a history of
actions applied to the store
so which means that we right now because
of this design we can't do this and do
resistor plus equals value anymore right
because uh if you just do this we're
gonna setting a new value to the store
but we didn't tell the store that how we
are going to do a reverse action of it
right so
um
of course of course there's a lot of
ways to um
yeah so we can't really do we want to we
can't write this straight away but we're
gonna write it in a way where I say
um I'm gonna say undo redo store
and then
um
I'm going to call let me think of a
okay I'm going to call it do action
so I'm going to define a function called
do action which
uh we're gonna have
two methods right as I say it's either
you apply the action or you reverse the
action right so it's apply
or reverse
right so apply and reverse so do action
so now we we change this to
um a method called direction that does
that that takes in the object that you
would have to apply this this object
itself is like an action right which is
something that we're gonna store in the
history
so it has two methods in this object
which which is to apply something or
reverse something right so say for
example here I this should text in like
the value of the star of this undo
register so apply meaning we wanna here
we are adding right so apply is to uh
at at Value right we're going to return
a new value of the star so we're going
to add this value and reverse it is
actually going to be subtract from it
right so written is value minus
this
uh this value from from it right so you
you apply or reverse so we have to do
this kind of pair of course you're
saying wow this is uh this this is
ugly right this this way is a bit ugly
to write this
um so this isn't an action object that
has two methods right apply reverse and
a lot of times if you look at libraries
like um or best practices of when you
see how people use Redux and Redux like
um libraries you'll see that they have a
function that creates this object itself
right so that function kind of abstracts
away a bit of this ugliness and makes it
more easy to every time when you want to
add value it's not gonna write like this
object
right so this is an action object and
the functions usually is being called an
action Creator right a function that
creates that action
so I'm going to call I'm going to create
this function just to show you how that
function usually look like so we're
going to call x a sum right uh which sum
takes in a value so
this should create this object right so
I'm gonna
create this
object
so this value comes in over here right
so so to call this we're going to call
do action and sum with the value
right uh so hopefully this looks less
ugly-ish
right
um I guess we have problems with
okay having a
I'm gonna call I think this is a bug
from svelt said that does not allow
dollar value in an argument right that's
just me removed it okay so
this function returns a
object right so we're going to call this
to return us that object so this is the
action Creator I'm just gonna add this
in the comment action
greater you probably see this kind of
action creators a lot people think it's
a boilerplate kind of age I think but
here we want to because we want to have
like two kind of two methods where we'll
apply changes and reverse changes
probably we're gonna
have to create this kind of object that
we're gonna push it into the history so
so this is something that we kind of
have to do right history of actions
right that's what we're gonna have of
course you can't
um
uh hide this somewhere else right you
can have maybe
um like storing this part of the
definition of the store itself and then
maybe over here instead of directions
you maybe you call like the sum
of value something like this but having
like this action is defined in green
within the store itself right so the
star kind of know that okay it has a
function that calls sum that actually
does that pushes this object
uh this this object this ugly object
here into the history right so over here
we're going to do something more generic
we can say just like do action and push
the whole action into the history
right so this is about the boundary of
where you abstract things out whether
you keep more push push more of that
detail into the story self or maybe just
like expose or have a more generic and
expose that option to to the user
right so here we are calling do actions
so maybe do action meaning we are going
to have a do action method instead of
value and this is not value anymore this
is actually
uh
action right we're gonna do this action
so first thing is we're going to push
this
action into the history right so we have
a list history of actions and of course
we want to do this action right so we're
going to say action dot
um
action dots what's that apply
action.apply
and we're going to apply the store value
right so what's the value of the star
well we would have to say import and get
rom spell store you get the value of the
store
right and then this will return a new
value
new store value
and this new store value we're gonna set
it back to the stock right store dot
sets new star value
because this is
um
um a lot of line of codes and maybe
slightly unoptimized because every time
you get store when you use get it's what
it does under the hood is trying to
subscribe to the store and grab the
value and then I'm subscribe from SQL
right so we can work around we can have
a much concise way of actually
expressing this right which is to call
Star dot update
the star value
okay so this is the value
and over here uh we are calling action
to apply with that value
and we are returning immediately
so returning immediately which is to set
this written value as a store value
right so this replaces these two lines
right so we don't even need to get glue
the cats over here
right so we have history the push and
now uh undo is nothing but history.pop
to pop up the action
okay and we have this so we pop up the
action we're going to do is action dot
reverse
right so we're gonna copy do this like
store the update by using installer
reverse instead of store.apply
so I'm going to copy this
okay
so let's let's try this out
right we have we're gonna ADD stand
I'm gonna add 20
we have 30 so we have and then let's add
30 to get 60 right so we have we start
from 0 10 20 0 10 30 60 right when you
click undo we jump to 30 and undo we
jump back to 10 and do we jump back to
zero okay so um
uh a great thing about using the
higher other star is that instead of
having to just use writable we can have
actually
twin twin
star it's spelled motion
whoops
Twin Star
right so now we can add
you can add 20
okay at 30
and we can still do undo undo and undo
right so
um it doesn't we don't really care
what's the underlying implementation of
a star it can be a twin it can be a
spring story it can be readable anything
you depends on what you want but the the
key is we are adding this undo redo
ability to your store that allows us to
change the value right however if you
right now we want to implement this redo
we realized that
um
it's not as straightforward as this it
is anymore because we pop out the action
right we pop up the action meaning the
exchange is no longer in the array so
right now if you want to do a redo
um
we kind of we want to do a redo
what other actions do we do right so
meaning we can't really when we do undo
we can't really pop it out because if we
pop it out uh this this action will be
dis be used and then discarded after
this action this this methods and with
no way to redo it unless we maybe
collect this undo action right but a
much easier way to do this is actually
maintaining a index
like what is the sorry
zero so what as in what is the current
index which is what is the current uh
history right so it starts with zero and
the history itself should actually start
with the current value of the Star right
so here we're gonna just get the first
initial value when we create this new uh
approach one undo redo Star right so
let's add Bank the get
Okay so
here we do action what we want is that
we want to
forward this index and we say history
index
is equals to the action
and we're gonna
get
the this one
history history index dot apply
the value
right so undo will be actually
decrements the index history index
and then
uh again same thing history history
index
to refer to that action and then reverse
it right and then redo is actually to
increments again back again
and this time round is to apply it right
apply that action
uh of course there's one thing you we
kind of need to take care of here right
so when you do undo a few times and then
you do
um when you want to make a new changes
you actually want to discard the the
rest of the undo uh whatever is undo you
can't do a redo anymore right you want
to remove all the undo actions all right
so that is what we need to implement it
but before that let's let's just try
this out first right so we add 10 we're
at 20
we had 50
right we undo back to 60 undo back to
ha
so something is from over here let's
let's see what's wrong
so let's ah okay reverse is not a
function so I think we need to check if
we
greater than zero
only we can do undo
right so
um
uh I think this is sure this is not a
start we need an action right so sorry
no idea why I wrote that line okay so
um
while we still have it uh we just keep
increasingly this one should just start
with negative one right so index is zero
and then action okay so greater than
zero
while we still have something on the uh
history array we just decrement and then
apply that okay so let's set with 10
Rich 10 and then it starts with 20 which
30. and then 30 which 60 right undo
okay undo should
bring us back to 30.
and then undo should bring us back to
if something is wrong over here right so
let's let's take a look at it 10
and okay let's I think
let me change back to a writable
so let's start with 10.
and then 20
and 30.
I undo should be
ah okay okay
so
we should
okay I think I got the logic mess up
okay so here we are while we still have
history right greater than zero right
greater or equal to zero we apply the
current action
right because the current action is the
one that is pointing at the history
index we could apply the current action
as a reverse and then decrements the
history index
right so
yeah so if you are at zero you apply
that zero actions reverse methods and
then you decrements to negative one and
then therefore you can't do an undo
anymore right so we have 10
20.
30. undo is 30 and do a stand and do is
zero okay that's right correct so if we
do redo
again we should
apply the current let's see
no no so redo is because undo will move
the index back right so redo is we will
move forward and apply that action so
we're gonna say uh yeah move forward and
apply that action but we have to make
sure that if history in next is less
than uh
history dot length minus one
right so because the last index that you
can get is history length by the minus
one right so if uh you the most you can
increment is to that place right so if
you're less than that you still can
increment
okay so at 10
30. right undo is 30 undo stand reduce
30 redo is 60 and then you can do and do
a read yeah you can redo animal unless
you undo right
um so why sit before that before we
train out and fix things around is that
when we do action we also make sure that
uh if we have undo previously we want to
remove all this undo history when if we
do a new action right so what I mean is
that say we redo is 60 right so you undo
30 but right now if you add say 40
we should not allow any more reduce
right we should all the reduce should be
nullified
right so in this case what we're going
to do is uh once we increment a plan
action uh we should also add another
check which is uh to remove everything
all the history index above
all the history Beyond history Index
right we remove all the past histories
right we of course we can overwrite this
but then whatever is beyond that it's
going to be nullified
and thus we don't allow any reduce
anymore right so see for example I do
add 10
30 I will do undo and then we apply say
right so now if you do redo it jumps to
60 which doesn't really make sense right
because 60 was like the
then we should be a redo again so here
we're gonna uh remove them right so
we're gonna do for Loop uh a very simple
follow-up to go through everything and
remove everything
um I think I'm just gonna use a
instead of for Loop I'm going to use a
while loop to say while uh okay I'm
gonna say let's I equals to history
in next start
um
index plus one right we're going to
remove everything
okay I don't know so while
um say history index
is less than the history Dot
link
minus one
right so this means is that once this
line it says that um
history index should be the history
length minus one right if you are less
than that meaning we have still a lot of
histories in the history array we should
remove them the way of removing is going
to say history.pop it's gonna pop out
from the end of the array
right so while history length minus one
yep correct so let's try that out so
we're at 10
20.
right 30
could you undo twice back to 10 I'm
going to add 50
and now I can't do redo
oh wait you can't tell the difference
okay hold on let's let's uh say let's
let's restart everything again so can I
say start with 10
uh 10 again and 10 again so we have 10
20 30 undo undo and then now we're gonna
add 80.
right so if if this works I should not
redo back to 30 right so yeah if I click
redo nothing happened but undo will
bring us back to 10 and we do bring us
back to 90. right so here we have our
first approach brush number one which is
to start a history of actions an action
is um this is nothing but an object
right it's nothing but an object that
has apply method as well as a reverse
method right so we have this kind of
object with apply and reverse we store
them in an array of history as a history
so every time when you want to undo it's
going to be calling the reverse method
and you want to make changes you're
going to call the apply method right so
undo is reverse reverse and then redo is
apply apply apply again right so you
start this history of actions and there
you go there you have a history under
redo kind of star right and we say that
creating this object this actions is is
uh it's a lot of boilerplate then maybe
instead of like having to create this
object every time maybe you create a
function that's called an action creator
that creates that action for you and
maybe this makes the code more slightly
concise and easy to understand and you
could Define this action right with
inside this store itself like say maybe
have like uh maybe like adding this
whole thing like sum in here foreign
which is to do like this dot do action
to
to do this action itself right you can
have this built into the store then
you'll be able to just like like calling
the
sum itself instead of having to call
like the do action right you you can do
that
uh you can you can do that uh it's it's
up to you on how you designed your store
like how you abstract out the
functionalities of your store
right so yeah we've we've seen how we
can do the approach one which to have a
history of actions let's explore
approach number two which is how we're
gonna have a history of
star values
so if you like
how I approach the approach number one
so far uh don't forget to smash the like
button because that is very important as
I said it's important to you as well as
the me so that we all know YouTube knows
that this is a good video and you will
try to
um
promote all to more users so that they
all all of you will enjoy and learn more
together and grow together right so
let's take a look at approach number two
approach
2.js
same thing uh I'm gonna create a higher
order store
so I'm going to copy some of the things
over here of course maybe we don't need
this
all right approach number two
it's a star history of star value
snapshots
right so the way of implementing this
would be uh every time when you set a
new value we are going to a
so a new value into the history and
every time we do undo is to
reset uh set the store within with the
previous history value or on whatever is
the value inside that you store in the
history stack all right so here first is
we're gonna again create this uh I'm
gonna have the similar concept over here
history history index
um here we're going to store a snapshots
of the store right so we're gonna I
think the first item you can have in the
store is the value of the star the
current value of a star so history Index
right now is is zero
okay uh next thing is
gonna have same thing this is gonna be a
star
and copy some of some of the things that
we've done over here
uh subscribe okay and do uh maybe we
don't need uh this is to be determined
right but the idea of History index is
still valid
uh redo this is too still to be
determined by the idea of not going over
the array is still valid
right so we have our new start approach
number two
um I think I should just copy this whole
code over here and say app
one right so if you want to play with
this Ripple you can look at the link in
the description right so I'm not going
to remove like modify this code this is
app one for approach number one
okay so right now we're gonna import
approach number two
create a new approach number two undo
redo star
and this time round we don't need uh we
can't do this directly because we're
gonna just set the value right we what
doing this is to call undo reduce store
with a DOT sets method to set a new
value to the under redo star so the
magic itself will lies within the sets
function right so here we have a set so
let's write set
okay set will be called with a value
okay this will be the new value
right so we want to store a history of
values right so here first thing is we
say history
index increments when I say history of
History
index would be the new value
and now we want to set this value to our
store as well so that's whoever is
subscribing to the store this so This
return store is still using the same
store subscribe right so the subscribed
subscriber of this doll will get the new
value out of it so we're gonna say star
dot sets uh new value
okay so this is actually the same of
writing this let me just do it like this
for now because later on you will
realize that we are making a lot of this
and we hope uh we're gonna do this all
over and over and maybe we can make this
into a function right abstract this out
right so
um
for undo
undo will be take a step back and sets
the store to the previous value right so
here we're going to say his story again
history minus minus is correct
um but we're gonna do it while history
index is greater than zero because we're
gonna
take the value from history after we
decrement right and we're gonna copy
this because we're going to set it
backed
and over here
redo will be playing the history next
right so uh while history index is less
than length minus one we incremented
correct and then we're gonna set the
value of the Star right so you realize
that we're going to do this over and
over maybe maybe we can't make it a
function we're going to say update star
uh I'm gonna paste this in and I'm gonna
replace it over here like this
right
place it like this
okay so we have all this and of course
one last thing that we did for the
previous approach is that when we
increment and we update the value we
also need to remember to clean up all
these three right so what we did over
there was to say while it's less than
that we're going to pop the history all
right so we're going to do that as well
and let's try this out okay so
let me say 10 right if not 10. we have
another 10 okay
now we undo we're going to jump back to
20 and do back to 10 and redo 20 reduce
the 30 right undo undo and we add 80
and now we can't redo anymore but we can
still undo undo or redo redo right so
there you go have a history of
values like the snapshots of the values
of the store
ah so before we end this there's a cache
on this approach
oh there's a cache on both approaches
depending on how you design the the
action of approach number one
which is that what if we want to
um
star instead of storing numbers
primitive values like numbers or strings
we want to have a store in the stores an
objects right what if we want to store
an object why does that matter well
because object itself is mutable right
you can mutate object right then
oftentimes we are so used to in spelled
we assigned a value to the property of
the object right to the store right that
actually mutates up Star right so let me
so so if you are storing a snapshots uh
yeah I think that will mainly affect
approach number two which is if you
store snapshots of the store and you're
storing a reference to the store itself
right and if you mutate that up star
object the value the star value objects
every time when you changing it starting
a reference ejectories storing the same
reference over and over and over again
and in the end you are not uh when you
want to try to redo it or undo it you
realize that
there's no effect because you are still
storing a steam object reference right
because all along when you make changes
you are actually mutating the object
right so to demonstrate this let me show
you what I meant right let me change a
bit on the code itself right just make a
very simple change let's just say
writable is a value it's an object with
a value
property value zero right so here we
I'm going to have two uh
two ways of displaying the value so
first is we're gonna sleep stringify the
undo redo star so this shows us what is
in the store itself right now and here
we are uh getting the value itself right
so
okay so now we have the star value right
so every time we increments we are we
need to
plus one of the value
right so technically this is the changes
that we just need to do right uh because
this will still this line itself will
still call the sets method of the undo
reducer to set the new value of the star
because in this case the star itself is
the value of the stars is not change
uh the reference itself is not changed
the value in inside it has changed right
the value the store value dot value has
has is
updated right so uh let's see right so
when we add this is this has changed
we're at 10 you see that it comes 11
we're at 20 it turns it to 31. and if
you when you want to undo it you realize
that it's not possible
it's not possible at all
so what is happening right as I
explained this is because everything
within the history is still
um record is still
everything within the history is
referencing the same object to just show
you one more step that this is itself is
true I'm gonna create I'm gonna expose
the history out I'm gonna say this is a
writable Pro okay import writable from
spell star
right and so I'm going to make history a
writable store as well
uh I'm just going to create a new
history right
the ball
okay sorry history star
and I'm gonna have uh
uh property called history that returns
history store
and everywhere we will change the
history which is over here only over
here I'm gonna set
uh which is called histories start or
set
history
okay
so here we have it and here right now
we're gonna just have somewhere to show
you the value of the star
gee fine
uh okay so this is the
history
but history
and this is a star so we're gonna say
star
okay I'm gonna add a new line
so this is the history I'm gonna add 10
whereas that I'm pushing a new value to
the history but then because both of
them are referencing the same store the
steam object both of them the value is
updated right if I do this you realize
that
uh we are update we are pushing another
same reference into history so undoing
itself does not have any changes it does
not have any effect at all
right so uh
yeah
so what should we do
so one way is I say we're gonna save the
snapshot so snapshots of the objects
inside the history array right so
um getting a snapshot itself can be as
can be a very simple straightforward way
of doing it would be using the Json
stringify or Json parts a combination of
both right so if we turn the whole star
value into a string and then convert it
back to an object what you get is a new
object of whatever the the store value
is right this is a new object so we
store that new object into the history
so every time when you make changes it
will not affect uh
huh
it will not
affect the sorry
you're not affect the reference within
in the array right so
I'm gonna so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna say json.35
uh
okay I'm gonna create a new function
instead
so sometimes this has been called as as
like clone cloning the object right a
very uh a fastest way of cloning the
whole object out right which is to
convert it to a string
and return it and then pass it again to
return back the object itself of course
this is this has his drawback for
example this has uh this
uh there's a cache on this clone
function which is it only works with
object that has no cyclical reference
because if you have a cyclical reference
a string G5 will not work it will break
and also it works if the object itself
just a plain Json object because if you
stringify you can't specify functions
all of them functions now undefined
things like that will be gone right so
you have your own drawback over here
and then lastly of course about
performance whether it's it's puff it's
it's performed the performance is good
if you just like if you have a very huge
complex star you want to stringify it
and pass it again the stick uh is the
performance okay well it's it's it
depends it it's Dependable right so I'm
going to just show you like a simple
straightforward way of doing a cloning
first and then I can and then later on
I'll suggest some alternative of
um using the idea of immutability to
reduce this cost of course immutability
itself introduce some sort of cost but
then if you have a more far more complex
big object that you want to get a
snapshot that you want to not mutate it
then you immutability will come in handy
in that case right so firstly we just do
a simple cloning because our object
itself is so simple right it's a value
right uh that you only have one property
called value and it's number right so
here I'm just going to call clone
the value of the star
and every time I push something into
this history I'm going to clone it as
well
right shouldn't you find it's not a
function oh sorry my spelling string
G5
okay
let's clear this okay so let's try this
out so now I
add a number right you see here this is
not
mutated right because we we actually
clone a new copy and store it into the
array and if we make changes again
hold on hold on hold on
ah okay I think this is
okay so we we clone it and stored in the
history but then when we call up this
story we are actually setting the the
Clone version
right
which is not what I uh and then if you
mutate that clone of the the Clone
version of it you are still changing it
mutating it right so uh I think over
here
um let's see it's starting free
okay so I think over here update star
okay so the update star actually okay
shouldn't we don't have to
um
you have to start a clone version in
history in this case right so of course
the first time we we started
clone so we are
not changing the first history right but
then after that we are going to every
time when we sell something we are not
storing a clone we just start the change
version but because we calling this the
Clone right so this is just not taking
care of the place where we just call set
also taking care of the place where you
do undo and redo right so every time I
undo redo we are pointing back to the
previous snapshots but then we are
giving a new clone to the store the
underlying store so that you whenever
you change
from the history again we're not
changing whatever it started in the
history you are changing from the clone
of the history
right so let's let's try that out again
so let's say that's that 10.
at 20 right and let's add 30. so we have
history of six or four four items in the
history and to undo
we're going back to 30 undo back to 10
and we can even redo undo and we can
even like change the value at 20 or
sorry actually at 20. undo and then add
right so this uh
this does not change the current the
state that I was changing right it does
not change this value 10 like just now
but it's created new it's actually
modifying a new clone and then updates
and then push that new value into the
history right so
um cloning it cloning object allows us
to create new snapshots objects that
because object is mutable and you can't
if you change the object if you want to
store it snapshots of objects within the
history and then make sure that each of
them are a different reference so that
you don't mutate the the snapshots that
you are storing in the history
so finally with as I said about cloning
I I mentioned about the drawback uh in
terms of performance things like uh
so and I suggested that we are going to
talk about immutability right because
immutability itself will allows us to
immutably change the object
uh meaning you when you make changes you
actually create a new reference of the
object you are creating a new object and
then we're going to store that object
into the store instead right so in that
case we don't have to do clothing right
every time when you make changes you
actually create a new reference of the
object and you just started a reference
into the store right so even and so so
you don't need to do a cloning right so
the immutability parts of the algorithm
of the library whatever you are using
will help solve that problem
right so a very simple way of doing the
immutability is to
instead of assigning a value directly
we're going to say
we're going to spread it out right so
we're going to create a new object
reference
and then value equals to the new value
right uh actually the new value will be
that this the Value Plus value
right
so this will create a new store a new
object reference I'm going to store in
the store and that way you don't have to
you don't need a clone function anymore
you don't need
uh
clone yeah at all and we try to run this
right that 10
at 20 they are all different it will
always create a new object before you're
calling a set to the store right so here
you will allows you to uh
um having a snap array of snapshots
without mute changing mutably changing
the star value of the in the history
of course you may ask me like okay how
about using libraries like images and
things like that where because uh
writing this
sounds easy if you have a very simple
object but it may get Harry if the
object itself is humongous right if you
have like a very nested object itself
then you have to keep doing this and
then maybe like a fool and then you have
to spread uh
undo redo star.full and then you because
you want to add a new value to full and
then you fool the bar you will and then
you have to spread it again and things
like that and in the end it just makes
the whole thing very messy and you will
just like to use emergency because that
allows you to assign uh make changes
more is more intuitively to just make
changes because image.js will create
give you uh the library itself will give
you like a draft state where you can
make changes to draft
States directly and then you can commit
that and then apply and return a new
object reference right so we shall take
a quick look at how you would pair this
with say image.js
so uh first thing is I'm going to import
produce
from email
right and actually I've created a video
about how you can use images with stars
and yeah you should watch that video if
you're interested like that will be a
full
length video about talking about images
and spell sore right how to make
image.js
into a spell store right but over here
we're gonna do a much lighter version of
it right so uh you have a function
called produce an image yes which uh
if you come over here how it works is
that you can call it produce with this
with an object
and it will give you a draft right a
draft the draft itself is actually the
the value itself but but the
implementation of it is like it's like a
proxy to the actual object right so this
object right the solve value is an
object and draft is a proxy to that
object so changes make to it mix to it
will be applied to it later on uh and it
will apply it in a way that it's done
immutably without changing the reference
of this right and so you return a new
reference new object reference in this
and you can assign it to the start right
so here every time when you make changes
you'll just create a new star reference
right so draft over here we're gonna
because the drop is the object itself
we're going to just say drop.value x
equals to Value right that is what it
writes
I mean uh
make it nicer
okay
right so this way is much nicer and
simpler to write right I I thought I
believe that you will agree with that so
let's try this try this out right let's
add 10 okay our process is not defined
so
because of how emergencys library is
implemented I believe it's it's
using like the process right so uh
process variable and it will be handled
by your bundlers but let's just Define
this first and then so that's so quickly
Define this would be uh going to the
sorry iframe that we are running this
and just Define this window.process
equals to f
uh which is an object I believe node f
is should be maybe I'm just gonna say
production
and this just need to do once
uh processes oh sorry hold on
uh
uh I'm not
I okay that's that's just not play
around with that let's just Define
ourselves in pots
patch
I'll call this patch
we know the process equals to f
node f equals to production
okay uh yep I believe we fixed it and
let's try it
okay find a full error okay there's some
errors while using with the
draft I believe uh
let's see let's let's try again
okay it works okay I I believe we
shouldn't return any value from that so
just make it a void
uh so here you see we
we just make it this way and now it's
very simple we just add something always
give us a new reference but from this
produce function now we can undo make
changes
and we do and do redo things like that
and it just works right so
um
if you want to start a history of
objects of snapshots of the store values
then uh if you're it's a store value
itself is primitive then it's simple for
you because you always store the
Primitive value but if your star
value itself is an object then having so
you then you would have to either one
clone it so that clone to always clone a
snapshots to store in a history or two
uh make changes immutably right don't
mutate the object itself so you can do
it yourself by using spread or use
libraries like images to help you to do
that
right so that's all from my video
hopefully this uh long winded video
helps you and makes you to learn
understand more about star itself in
general as well as like Concepts like
Hydro stars
um and undo redo kind of uh operations
and hopefully uh you learn a lot from
this video
today I'm going to share with you about
context in particular how to make
contacts reactive using Stars
so let's start I've set up something
over here I have three components app
ciao and grandchildren so app Imports
child and when there's a child child
Imports and uses a grandchildren and
grandchildren over here as you can see
all right so I want to use context to
share data from app to grandchildren by
passing ciao in real life you probably
have a very nested deep uh component
structure where you have multiple layers
of component and then and but then you
want to share data across
uh across like the parent the
grandparents and the grandchildren
component
um if you want
if you want your data to be irrelevant
of your component structure you can use
an external star but in this case we
want only all the grandchildren of this
grandparent component to have to share
the same data that's why we go for
context
so the way of using context over here is
you come over to app.silts and you use
set context from svelte
so it's a key and then value so you pass
in a key for this context and then the
value of
of the context value
so in this case I'm setting the context
name value and the value the value of
that context variable the context data
is called count
so initially I have counts equals zero
so I'm accepting a context of value of
value 0.
and in the grandchildren to receive it I
use get context and pass in the same key
in this case the value and I get the
count over here
so now I have two variables
um so to make to show that it works I
can initialize counts to 100 and now my
grandchildren when I received it the
count is value 100.
I'm sharing the count over here and I
have buttons to increment and decrement
the count
and same thing goes with the app.s felt
but context is actually linked up during
the component initialization meaning
when the component grandchildren is
mounted initialized the link from the
app and the grandchildren is being
linked up and that is when you get the
context
so get context will get the initial
value of the account which is 100 and
that and that is being linked up during
initialization so the value of the count
is that variable but then
um discount is a number number itself is
not
um say mute is you can't mutate a number
you get the value by value rather than
by reference so now we didn't
grandchildren if you're trying to
increment discounts you only uh it only
change within this grandchildren
component
same thing goes from app.felt since this
set context will be only called and
linked up at the initialization now when
you try to increment and decrement it
don't really change the context value in
the grandchildren
so two bands there are linked up at the
start but then it lost synced out of
sync so how do you make sure that it's
reactive in a sense where when you
change the value over here the context
the value of this so-called context is
always get updated like all the
grandchildren get updates when this
where when the counts value in the
grandparent has changed
well that's right you can use store
so here instead of
just defining the variable as a number
100 and can import
writable
from svelt Star
and make my account a writable star
so now I can um I'm still pass in the
store over the context but to show the
value I'm going to reference it using
the dollar prefix variable syntax now I
am seeing this count over here
and now since I'm getting a star to read
the value of the star I use dollar
prefix
and now uh although it's being linked up
at the initial initialization of both
components but because it's a star and
it changes to the star uh all both app
and grandchildren is subscribing to it
so both of them will know that whenever
this store has changed the parent in the
app will incremented it's it's being
notified on the grandchildren because
they're subscribing the store and that's
why the value of the star is being
update uh being showed over here the
latest value of it is being shown right
same thing goes with the grandchildren
when you click over here it's being
updated right on the start
so summary uh context is being set up
during initialization
and therefore value if you change the
value is not being the updated value
will not be reflected at the
grandchildren to make it reactive in a
sense where whenever you change the the
variable in the context in the
grandparent if you change the value and
you want it to be reflected to all your
grandchildren then you should use a
store in States you can pass the star
um over the context just like passing
any variables and hopefully your
grandchildren will subscribes to it and
get notified whenever you change it in a
grandparent
I'm going to share with you tips and
tricks to manage stores complex stores
in your spell application
I believe a lot of you love to learn
about this in fact the prepared content
the material of this video is it's been
very difficult not all problems can be
solved with one solution right different
applications different styles different
Logics
requires different
ways or methods to optimize them
um so I try to look around in the front
end wall try to gain get some
Inspirations from different libraries or
different Frameworks out there and try
to summarize a few points
I would say tips that you can use in
your application
of course you don't have you you
shouldn't apply all this
methods blindly to your application
optimization is a science you need to
First measure before you do anything
right you need to know whether there's a
problem to be fixed in the first place
so over here I have prepared an example
and hopefully that is real life enough
and under in this example I have two
main issues that we are going to solve
so let's dive in and take a look at the
example that I prepared for you
so over here I have
an app that is like a to-do list
so you can come in and type to do you
type a checklist say uh record a video
you can click add you can add more uh
edit my video
and let's say uh publish to YouTube
and oh what okay so something must be
wrong in the logic over here
um which we will take a look at what it
is but at the same time take a look at
here there's a nav bar and this is like
a notification that shows you what has
happened so far
and we have my username so when I click
I can change my username over here so
the house
it's the best
oh no the worst
okay I have fun uh so let's take a look
at in terms of code how how what how
this works so here I have a nav bar
in the nav bar I have a notification
components that shows the notification
and then I have my username and then I
have my profile so this edit profile is
a a buttons that will pop up and then
you make changes so anytime when you
make changes you see over here I uh edit
the notification so all the changes for
example edit profile or add to do I will
insert a new entry to the notifications
right so that the notifications you can
see that there's a new events coming up
right so all of this
the data itself comes from this file
called Data so everything in this
application is controlled from one store
one writable store which is in which is
created using a writable so I have a
list of to-do's notifications users so
users information
right so that's roughly about the
application itself
so at to do it's it's a form that you
can add to do and there's a to-do list
that shows a list of to-do's
okay so if you want to follow along
um I am going to share the link of this
Ripple will be in the description so
that you can follow along with with me
right so the problem that we face just
now right when I type something
and type something again
uh okay this time now it's it's it seems
like it's
there's nothing wrong but somehow in the
first time when I create some to-do's
it's like gone immediately
so
um this is a problem with having a
writable stars like this you have a
writable starts with a to-do and
basically you allow people to change the
to-do's anywhere right anyone who
Imports this will be able to change it
we change it uh over here in the to-do
list where we feel where we come over
here and we
you know Mark some to do to be done over
here on the other side an attitude we
push into the list
um so it's part
so anyone who Imports this file can
change the to-do's so we kind of have no
um no way to enforce like what can be
done by to-do's right so
just previously we add a few to-do's and
suddenly the to-do's is gone uh it's it
shouldn't be something that is being
allowed so let's try to find out the bug
over here let's
say okay so whenever we want to change
the to-do's probably will assess to data
to Do's right so let's let's search for
this
um there's two okay there's only one
place that makes this change access to
data the to-do's okay so let's not
change in this file let's try to search
over here at the profile
uh no okay how about navbar
okay we we checked if the to-do's length
and then oh this will show the to-do
slang okay so this is filter this is
length okay oh everything looks okay
normal how about notifications
nothing nothing okay to do this
okay you filter the to do
um this is showing the count and then we
Loop through to those uh this is okay we
are removing something splice but this
is in a delete button so it's supposed
to just slice off one item
so I don't think that's about it let's
let's see data nothing wrong okay
nothing nothing's wrong over here I have
those Felts so nothing is wrong at here
so but then something is wrong right if
you if I try to add again
it's all gone something is wrong but I
can't find where it is so if your
application application is getting
bigger and bigger you have code all over
the place and you have a writeable that
is like this uh that allows you allows
you to
modify the two Do's within that writable
object any way you like
um
then you have a problem right this is
not about whether your right your to
Do's is like you can have a writable
that is an array
as a to-do
but if you pass this to-do store
anywhere anyone can change it anyone can
modify it as they want and it's very
hard to track that you it's not just
searching for to-do's to-do's can be
renamed you can change
um assign it to another variable and
then do something about it and subscribe
to the store and stuff like that you
can't really find out where is going
wrong
so
and this is not a new problem
when you have a big state this is bound
to happen because anyone around
every anywhere in your code can change
that state
in fact a few years ago I think many
years ago Facebook has come up with a
architecture to handle states which is
called the flux architecture
and pop you can take a look at this the
links will be in the description but
basically the idea is this
um you are the way that they want to
design is that they want to design a
single
directional flow of the data right so
you have your you have a store and then
store changes will go to your view that
is okay but then anyone can change the
star which is not so okay so we want to
draw the boundary we want to create one
more abstraction which is called the
action any time when you want to make
changes to a store you should
um make an action call an action
dispatch an action and then the action
itself will modify your star so no one
can modify a star except uh actions
right and I believe
if you are very familiar with a react
well this sounds very familiar with you
this is actually one of a very famous
implementation of this flux architecture
is the Redux library right every time
when you want to make changes to the
store you have to make you have to call
you have to dispatch an action and the
action will change the value of the star
and
the changes is being made in one uh one
unit of code which is in Redux is called
reducer but it does not have to be a
reducer but the logic is there anyone uh
the only logic to make changes to the
star is is contained in one unit and
anywhere else in the code if they want
to make changes to the store they will
have to dispatch an action and then if
you make the action easy enough to be
look for then it's it's easy to to
figure out where where went wrong right
so you can trace out where who is
dispatching this action and then figure
out why is this place dispatching an
action
right so we can
um
borrow this idea right
um maybe let me come up with another
example library that uh maybe some of
you all are more uh excited about that
which is a state machine library right a
state machine is also a state the no one
can change the state except uh actions
that's being done on onto the machine
itself right every time when you
um
make some changes you have to say Okay
based on this state that I am at right
now and these are the actions that I can
receive and
only when all these actions coming into
my action my state I will derive a new
state
and then again again right uh so no one
is modifying the state directly they all
make changes through actions and and
that is how you can make
um make like control your data flow from
your application you can control who big
changes right you buy your controlling
who making the actions
so
over here let's let's make a very simple
modifications to our code right now
right we we want to uh provide some API
to make uh changes to the to-do's so
that if you want to make changes to to
those you have to make it this way so
I'm going to provide some API for
example uh add to do
data and this is okay I'm gonna
call this
okay data right so
uh new to do
whenever I have a new to-do I need to
come over here and uh update data
so data dot to lose
data dot to those
uh new to do
right so I'm going to come up with a few
methods that that I approve of to make
changes to the to the to this to do
stars
and okay so I'm going to create more of
this
right and in the meanwhile
whoops
and in the meanwhile I and what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna freeze the to
do
I'm gonna freeze it so that this uh this
is just for for demonstration only right
I'm gonna freeze the to do such that
whenever I make changes I can't right so
you you have to call add to do in this
case so I'm gonna so this also I'm gonna
freeze it every time when I create a new
to do so I'm gonna come over here at to
do uh this is at the add to do stops
felt
over here I'm gonna say add to do right
this is something new
okay and
let's see add to do
foreign
okay this is working
okay so we are going to handle the done
and delete as well but I think the rough
idea is it's clear for you we are going
to
we we should have methods that um allows
us to modify the to-do's directly and
then only call this
um methods from outside from your view
so that you know that uh we have one
file that has we have one every
functions that modify the state of the
star in one place and everyone else just
call these functions right so so that
you you have a clearer control better
control of your stock your states of
your application
of course this is a very simple example
uh if you have slightly more complex
Stars more complex Logics I would
definitely recommend you to look at
State Management libraries and then see
how you can incorporate them using stars
and in fact I've created some videos
um
links on the description on say how you
can use a state machine Library exit
as a star or how you can use Redux as a
store right the ideas are the same you
they allows you to have a better control
of how your state changes from one to
another
of course once we've done like having
our state freeze right now we kind of
probably we probably have a better sense
of where this comes from right because
if I change right now if I'm gonna
change the state a few times you'll see
an error and let's just Trace where this
error comes from
um okay this is this is bad this is not
easy to trace
but because I prepared this uh
example I know where it comes from
actually coming from here see uh
somewhere someone just leave this code
maybe because of testing they want to
test something on the to-do's it says
that if notification link is three I'm
gonna
I'm gonna remove everything from the to
Do's uh so this is this is the
point right you could have a code
written anywhere like this and it's very
it will be very hard for you to trace
out where it is so I'm going to remove
this and hopefully we fix our
issue right when I'm trying to create
more uh it's not deleted it's not
cleared right now and we've solved this
so tip number one is if you want to have
a complex store store that has complex
Logics it's better to use some State
Management libraries or write out your
own reducer kind of thing or state
machine counting to to manage your store
or else it would be a very it will be a
huge mess if you allow anyone any
components to make changes to the store
directly
of course some of you may have
doubts or concerns uh
about using libraries like Redux right
uh I think that's that this stems from
overusing Redux right not all the states
are complex you don't have to use it
and every situation but only when cases
where the store logic itself is complex
then probably you that the idea the con
uh that reduction stock have may be
helpful for you
right and also one thing that stems from
that is a huge Stars right you typically
somehow we end up with right having a
very huge Redux stores in our
application as the applications go big
and this is something that uh
will have effect as well and let's take
a look at our example in our example we
have a data store that has to Do's
notifications and users
which means that anytime when you change
something like change the username
um you have to change the star and
change the star which means that the
whole star is being invalidated anywhere
that is subscribing install
will get notified and then try to see
whether they should update their
component right to to demonstrate this I
write a simple utility
over here called Mac updated and I
applied to all the components over here
so uh I have I've applied this Mac
updates for each of the components like
the nav bar the add to do the to-do list
and
um and also notifications and edit
profile so every time we make changes to
the States you see that it will turns
red
right it will transfer it every time I
add a to-do it will turn red on places
that has updates meaning places that
because add to do changes the data right
and anywhere that subscribes to the data
store
get notified and try to update its
content and that's where you see the it
will turn red outline
so uh if as you can see here if I open
turn on the
profile you'll need you only see that
this turns red because
uh this
this is controlled using a locals state
right show so only the local component
will get updated and if you come over
here you want to update your username so
this username is over here this input we
binds this to the data.user.name
meaning that anytime we change username
we have to update the data and the whole
data will be in will be updated and
anywhere there is that subscribes to
this data will get updated right so if I
type something you see everywhere turns
red time again all the places has a read
outline so that is bad right if you
imagine that you have a lot of
components that is
uh you have a lot of components then it
is just dragging you down and it doesn't
have to be this way right so let's try
to break this down let's try to make
user and
separate store because user itself the
logic of user does not got to do
anything got to do with the to-do's and
notifications you change notifications
or to Do's independent of your users you
don't have to know them together to make
changes so I'm gonna take out the users
in its own store and come out export
concern
user equals to this writable
and to use it I am going to come over
places that uses the user star say the
edit profile I'm going to import from
I'm not sure I can still use the data
but I definitely need user and come over
here and change it to subscribe to user
name
okay I still need data okay uh let's see
this should be user name
and I think at the nav bar I also need
user
and change this to user name
and let's see what happens right so if I
turn on and I'll change something
only the nav bar stands real because
only you you only because only the
navbar component is subscribing to this
user store and
if you of of course this is uh the the
highlighting itself is uh is saying that
this component itself will update but of
course uh my spell actually has
optimized that the update only happens
to the element that uh uses only the
elements that uses the information from
user and only when the information has
changed only this text elements is is
going to be re-rent uh updated by its
felt
but immediately you can see the changes
right you you can see that anytime when
you do something
um only the youth components itself only
has changed so that is tip number two
have your store small have a small store
Only Store
information that is needed for that
store and if you have separate concerns
then store it in a separate store
so that your component that subscribes
to that store only concerns to the data
that is needed for that store right in
our example we've seen users you don't
need to know about users exchange
anywhere else in the component then you
can have users separately as a separate
store
however if unfortunate circumstances
that you have you have to have a big
complex star for example in this case
our to-do list is big and complex you
have an array of objects an object can
contains a lot of information
and if for example in this case in our
nav bar take a look at our navbar
whenever we add a to-do it will have to
be updated because it updates the
account right every time we Mark
something as done it will have to update
itself as well
um so
uh
so that is an unfortunate circumstances
but there's something else we can do as
to help this to alleviate this which is
to use a derived star
so for example if I come over here I'm
gonna import derive
while I'm typing let me explain like why
this helps right so over here
um our inner com application over here
we are subscribing to the data because
we need the data to lose length we need
the length of the to Do's maybe the
length of the to-do's that is filtered
out for for those that has marked as
done and we need the length of
notifications but if you are changing
the to do right we just change the to do
anywhere
we still get notified that data has has
changed and events and when we check the
length and fill down everything and
check the length it's actually the same
number right of course uh spell will not
do any updates to your component over
here it will see that oh if it's the
same text value it will not update it
but then there's still update cycle
happening in your component which means
that if you have life cycle events uh
for example if you register before
updates or after updates in your
component they'll still be triggered and
run so what can you do
uh what we can do is we can create
derive store derive a new store from the
existing data
and if the derived stop value does not
change then there will no there will no
there will no uh update cycle happening
in your components so I'm going to
create a few star over here because we
have uh we have three three different
things right first is we have the to do
slang
derived from data and then data equals
to
data to reduce link
we also have a
uh let's see notifications
so it derives from data but then data
notification link
and then I have a to-do's done link
right
then link
the copy of this and paste it over here
so I'm going to replace them over like
this
to lose length uh okay this over here
to this line over here
notifications link over here
now okay let's see what what it's
missing
oh
okay so then if we come over here and
mark the do laundry as done
uh it's some it's not supposed to be
updated but I'm not sure you can see it
clearly so I'm gonna come over Mark
updated and make every element with some
margin uh let's see four pixels eight
pixels of margin right so then let's try
this again if I come over and click done
you see that this whole nav bar is not
rent uh does not go through an update
cycle right if I try to add a few to do
um come over here Mark has done this
does not go through the update cycle
because we are not updating to data the
data store we only are subscribing to
three stars the to-do link to do stun
link and notifications link
and when you click on the done button we
the length does not change yet so in
that sense uh nothing has changed yet uh
this the the uh yes they are subscribing
to the data and they are updating the
store value but then the value is not
changed yet so in this component when we
are subscribing to these stores we are
not getting notified therefore that we
are not going through an update cycle
um of course this may be a contract I
think
in some sense it may be up to over
optimizing but of course you have to
look at it by Case by case basis
and
and this example definitely is a
contrive example where we check about
the length sometimes we want to know
about certain to do item that is whether
it is um certain to do in this list uh
so sometimes you have a store that is an
array and then you want to check a
certain item within that array a certain
property of it whether it has changed
um yeah things like that right and if
you can create a derived star out of it
and only subscribe to that derived star
then although the derived stall gets uh
well we'll keep evaluating to get that
new value out of it but if the value
itself is a primitive and it does not
change
then the component subscribes to that
derived store will not go through an
update cycle right so when I say update
cycle is a cycle that goes through like
checking uh running through before
updates update after update lifecycle
and also checking through like what
other element uh what are the values uh
that any Expressions over here and check
the value see whether they have changed
or not
right so it does not go through that
um
of course
um you
so you you can also come out uh this I'm
not sure whether it rings a bell to you
but you can also have your star that is
immutable based star so I've done a
video uh links in the description as
well on how you can make your store to
be immutable so an immutable star allows
you to
um know what other things that will
change right so if you have a big
complex store that has unfortunate
situation you have to have a big complex
store uh immutable store allows you that
if you change one place then only part
of that store has changed the identity
has changed right it changed the
reference of the object so the rest of
the star you can still subscribe and
still does not get
um notified because that part of the
store has not changed yet right or you
can come up with a proxy based store uh
proxy allows you to change uh part of
the states object and you can subscribe
to the part subscribe so part of of the
state object and get notified only that
part of the things that you subscribe
has changed right so I've done another
video about using value is a proxy based
State Management Library so you can use
value to create your store so that
only if that part of the states that
you're interested has changed you get
subscribed you get notified and go
through the other Cycles if only
necessary right so that is three tips
number three uh have use some uh
immutable star or proxy base star or you
can come up with your own derived store
that only subscribes to a small part of
the store that you are concerning about
so that your component does not have to
go through update Cycles to
updates everything when the things that
you're concerning is not updating at all
it's not updated at all right so I have
three tips for you and hopefully that is
useful for uh as a serve as a good guide
for you to think about how you can
manage your store in a sprout
application and how you can optimize
your application
today I'm going to share with you how
you can get store value outside a
spelled component you may ask like why
what's the problem with getting a store
value outside of sveld component is that
hot well let's see at this example so
over here uh this is a disclaimer this
is a very contrived example just to
demonstrate you how difficult it is to
get the store value of sales felt
component right so over here I have a
star
uh created using a writable star
and in here to get the star value within
a spell component one and good what I
can do is I use a dollar prefix variable
to get the value of the Star right this
automatically subscribes to the store
and gets the value so the this variable
represents the value of the star
but then I also have a function called
calculate double value I pass in my
store and so this function I Define it
within
um a Javascript file so it's outside
this felt component so in this
function I want to get the value of the
star and then calculate the double of
the value of the star
but then how do I get the value of the
star if I do something like this uh this
does not work because it says dollar
store is not defined you can't do this
over here you can't uh subscribe to this
star value and get this variable defined
over here because this is outside of
swell component
so how do you get the value of the store
then
well one way is we can Define this
variable uh we just for the sake of
telling you that this variable is going
to be the value of the star I'm gonna
Define a prefix with a dollar but this
got nothing to do with the dollar prefix
variable in a spell component where it
automatically subscribes to the star
right so I Define this variable and I
can subscribe to the store
subscribe and then I will get the value
of the star over here right so I can
just immediately I can assign this value
to the variable called star
and since I get the value so this
subscribe method will return me and
unsubscribe function and since I already
have the value of the star actually I
don't really need to know what's the
next value I just need to know the
current value so I can unsubscribe it
immediately so come over here and call
unsubscribe
so at this point of time
um I should already get the value of the
store
in this variable
right so should but it it I there's no
guarantee right it depends on how this
store is being defined so remember when
I say in a writable store in the
previous video
um you when you call subscribe when you
put you when you define a subscribe
method you need to call the value of the
star immediately are you sorry you need
to call the function with the current
value of the star because us and
synchronously because or else this
function if it's not being called
immediately then then the store will
still be undefined so you have to call
it immediately so that you can assign to
this value immediately and then right
now you can already get uh use the value
of the star for example star times two
right so
luckily writable store does that
writable stores always give you the uh
always will call when you call a
subscribe this callback function will be
called synchronously Always to give you
the current value of the star
so uh this is how you would get the
value of the store at that moment you
subscribe it and then immediately
unsubscribes from it and then you get
the value of star
and actually there's something that I
didn't really talk about which is if you
come over here if I Define this function
over here in States
let's let's remove this I can't actually
um
gets the value of the star using a
dollar prefix variable as well so star
has to be a top level variable that for
example over here and only you can use
dollar prefix to access them
right so if you're trying to Define any
function any variable that has prefix
dollar it will you will get one and if
you try to access any variable uh that
is any store variable that is not
defined in the top level it will
complain as well because a spell
component can't really subscribe to this
automatically subscribes to this value
and then updates it because
uh you may just call this function once
and yeah things like that right you uh
there's no like automatically subscribes
and clean up uh that that ties to the
component life cycle because you can
call this function at any point of time
and how many however many times you want
right and every time when you call the
store value X the story will actually is
a different value
so to
yeah so over here uh this warnings just
tells us that we probably have to call
it a different variable name so I'm
gonna say um
prefix
and this will gives us the same value as
well
and finally if let me comment this out
and come back to the previous code so
finally one I one thing I want to share
is that
um this piece of code actually we
already have a util built in from swell
that does this this this whole thing
over here and it's called a get
so gets will do exactly what we are
doing over here
so we don't have to write it ourselves
every time so we can call up do this
instead and it will still works right so
get will do the same thing it will
subscribe to us R and then get the value
immediately and unsubscribes immediately
so uh here you go here is how you can
get a value of a star outside of a sveld
component
let's talk about the difference between
Star and context
well you know that I've made a video
about how you can pass star over context
to make a reactive context
right and some of you may ask me like
what is the difference between a store
and context right if you have a store
why do you need contacts or if you have
contacts where you store for example so
let's take a look at one example over
here over here I have a
app which has two parents right parent
one and parents two these two components
actually are the same uh yeah actually
they are the same right I just create
two of them for no reason
but anyway anywho uh parents one
uh imports from Imports the children and
these children with this child component
reads a context from the parents right
the parents set the context over here
called data which is a context data and
the child reads from it right get
contacts the context data we pass a the
data that will pass in is actually a
store so when you read this to get a
value out of it you use a dollar prefix
syntax to read the value of the context
um on the other hand also I created a
file called storage yes which Imports
the writable and create a writable store
and I import this um to parents as well
as the child so in the parents one I
import this uh the star data
and have a range inputs to kind of like
modify the value of the star same thing
goes for parents too
it's the same code right so I have two
inputs one to modify the data of the
context for these parents and modify the
data of the store which is from this
store file parent2 as well as a context
data where I have where it has one's
inputs to modify a data of the inputs
and once inputs to modify the data of
the store which is coming from this file
and a child uh both of them have a child
and the child component is the same
component which reads imports from the
store data and imports get the context
for context data and show both of the
value of the star and that's it
so um
so let's try to play things around and
see what happens right so if I change
the value of the Star right now
when I change it you can see that all
the all the instances that imports from
this store right pass one in front of
this file and two imports from this file
trial imports from this file so all of
them are reporting from the same store
instance and when one of the value of
when one of these instances changed the
value all the other instances actually
get notified and update the value itself
as well so you can see that the store
when it changed from the parent one is
the child within pen one is updates as
well and the parent two updates as well
oh sorry yeah updates as well and the
child within parent two updates as well
as well if I change from parents to same
things happens right all of them are
importing from a steam store
therefore all of them get notified or
get updated at the same time they are
all in synced
now take a look at context right so for
context wise I actually create two two
stars right I create one store for the
parents want
and send it to the context I create
another store for parent 2 and send it
to the contact so they are actually
different store
uh in child the child component is the
same where this in terms of code is it
is the same component file but imported
in two different places right meaning uh
where it's being imported where it's
being used then what kind of context
you'll get all depends on where it's
being used right so uh I uh so the child
is being used in pair one and parent two
then uh irrespectively they receive the
context from each of their parents uh so
if I change the parent wants context
value
you can see that the child in context uh
in the parents one get updates get
updated by the child and parents too
does not right does not know at all
because it's it's living in a different
context it's receiving the context data
from a different parent it's receiving
from these parents too so if I change
the value of the context in the parents
too then you can see that the child in
parents 2 is has has changed is changing
right but not the child uh the data in
the child in the parent one right so now
you see that there's this difference and
this is the main difference uh between a
context and a star
although so the star itself if you're
using the same instance of the store
basically you can make anyone anywhere
that's using the store to be updated to
be in sync at the same time
context on the other hand uh works is a
slightly different concept right context
says that for all the components that is
within my context will receive this
context we'll receive the data they're
going to pass through this context so
you can get the same data right so if I
passing the same uh if I create one
store instance that all of the children
will get the reference of that store
instance we're gonna pass uh if I'm
gonna pass this uh the instance of this
store from store.js then you probably
see that if I change all of the uh if I
if I if I pass the same Store contact
store instance to both the parent one
and two then you still you will see that
all the instances will be updated that's
not because they are you are not about
the context anymore it's about the store
instance because if they're getting the
same store instance then they're gonna
do it they are going to get updated at
the same time in sync right but uh for
for context it's more of where you are
living under right in this case we
create a different content store
instance then you are living in a
different context therefore you get a
different store instance and therefore
if you change from parent one to only
the child in the parent one will get
updated you change your parent to only
the child uh you know only the story
instance in the store in the child and
the parents two will get updated right
so so there you go so there you see the
difference between the store
and a context
and they are not like a mutually
exclusively kind of different therefore
you can actually use them together you
can have a store inside context to
create a reactive star
okay so here is the difference between a
star and a context
but some of you may still ask me like
hmm I know the difference but how should
I decide when should I use a store or
when should I use a context how do I
differentiate when or what kind of
scenarios I should use which of the
things
I know how it behaves I know how it
works but which one should I use
so here I'm going to share you a way to
think about how or when you should use a
store or when you should use a context
or when you should use both
okay so imagine over here you have a two
by two matrixes which is a two by two
different kind of scenarios that you can
encounter
so it depends on the data right the data
you you want uh on an excesses let's say
x-axis what you want is whether this
data is static or this data is dynamic
so static data is something that you you
wouldn't expect any changes but Dynamic
data is you you want this to be changed
uh during the runtime which is during
during user interactions where user
interacts and you want this data to
change
and on the vertical axis on the other
hand
you have
um
what I call a global data or a local
data so for global data it's it's not
about how pervasive this data is being
used it's more of uh this data should be
one and only one right this data should
be usually have one data for all of the
components or wherever you use it it
does not matter where you're using it
you're using you're you're gonna have
just one copy of the data and for local
data it's more of where you are using it
it depends where you're using and what
kind of data you're going to get okay
um so you have static Dynamic and Global
to local so you have a static local kind
of data or static Global kind of data
and you can have a dynamic local or
dynamic global data right so let's take
a look at
example right I come out I've I've been
trying to think about what is the best
example for you and I have been thinking
about this and coming out of like
different examples for different
scenarios
um may not be convincing because
sometimes this example can actually be
like be
become like be part of any kind of
scenarios right because for example say
for example a team it can be a global
team but it could still be a local team
right sometimes in your application your
some parts of it I use is using like
this maybe like a dark blue team and
part of it is like a dark green team
right you can have different kind of
teams within the com within the
application at the same time so team can
be a global thing it could be a local
team and team itself can be fairly
static for example you don't expect
users to change the team but it could be
fairly dynamic as well sometimes it
allows your user to change the team
um
uh from maybe the light team to a duck
team to a different kind of team right
so depends it really depends on your use
case it really depends on what your
requirement is determine it rather than
say a team should be always be like a
dynamic thing or team should always be a
static thing right so this is exactly
the example that will come up with I'm
gonna have a data called color over here
let's take a look at the first scenario
a static and a global data right in this
data.js I have a color so this color I'm
not going to use a star because it's
it's static right so for static data
you're gonna just Define this variable
it as it is Define it as a variable so
that you can use this variable across
components
um so I'm using this data in a button so
in a button I import this color and use
it and I also have this over here I have
like a game controller thing so in the
controller I also
um let's see right oh I think it's a
game ah okay I didn't do that so in the
controller I also import the color
right in the controller also Imports the
color
so this color is static I can Import in
multiple components and just use it
right and it's because if it's it is a
global thing so uh I can Define it in
maybe like a one file and everyone can
just import this file and use this data
right so static and Global right static
means that you would not use store and
Global means you don't have to use
context it does not matter where your
button or where your game component is
you just use this same color so you
import from the same file
okay and static locals so in this case
uh still color but it depends on where
the button is or where your component is
you may want to have a different color
right so all of this uh the game all of
the button you can see on the screen is
the same component it's this button
components so it depends on where this
button resides in the component tree of
the app component tree it shows a
different color it shows a different
background color so in this case uh to
do that I I'm using a context right an
easier way for me is to use a context or
I can have maybe like spot as a props
instead of getting it from a context
right so Props is your parents pass the
data to you context is a parent pass
data to all of you all those children in
this case I'm going to use the context
instead of props because uh the place
that sets the color is actually very
high up in the component Tree in this
case it's in the app and the app I set I
pass different colors to the game I pass
green and past blue that's why you can
see like there's a green game and
there's a blue game
and in the game I set context right I
set the context using the color from
this props so that all the elements
within this um
component for example a button over here
so game has a controller controller has
buttons so button reads this data from
the context and sets the color of the
button and one thing you can see here
also is that actually in the top of this
component we have the app which already
sets the color which is already sets the
orange color but then because of context
you can also override whatever is being
said and apparent right so you just look
at the most immediate parents to
determine what context color you're
getting
so here I am still part I don't use a
star because the color itself is is
determined by the component tree and
it's static I'm not going to change I'm
I'm not allowing user to change the
color right this color can be coming
from maybe say some configuration files
or maybe change of requirements or
coming from API but once this data is
once you get this data this data is
fixed you don't change this data by user
interaction then this can be a very
static data you don't need a store for
this
and for but for in our case we want this
data to be local Right Where You resets
depends where what color you're getting
so you are getting using a context to
handle it right so static means no store
and locals means we're going to use a
context
now last two
example right now we have a dynamic and
a global uh
component example right so this scenario
I have a Color Picker so when I come
over here Color Picker I change color
you can still pick that on on the right
right you see that whenever change these
colors are changing
all right so this the data itself is
dynamic although the color wise is is
global every buttons every controller
are changing at the same time so because
if it's Global I can Define it in the
external file I can Define it in in a
separate file but because it's Dynamic
I'm going to use a star so that I can
change the value of the star and all the
components that's using a Sim store will
get reflected immediately right getting
a data updated dynamically
lastly I have Dynamic and locals so in
this case let's take a look at the
example I have I have three different
kind of colors right different
components different buttons are getting
a different colors and they are Dynamic
I can change the color anytime I want
right I change this to be dark green or
maybe purple I can change this to be
blue like a blue I can change it any
color I want right so this is
uh Dynamic data and local data so
because of its dynamic
Behavior I will need a star
and because it's local I need a context
and therefore I need to use context to
pass down the star so here you can see
that I am now passing down stores and
I'm using the uh context to puzzle store
and I'm using a writable store right so
this all these three Color Picker is
changing this value of star
and all the components that is using the
star value it gets update dynamically
right and I pass the data through the
store through context so depends on
where my button is it will be reading
from a different context therefore
reading from a different store and
therefore gets a different color updates
right so this uh player one color will
not be updated if I change the first
Color Picker and and vice versa right so
here you can see four different kind of
scenarios by splitting by two by two
quadrant again static or dynamic no con
no star or with a star and Global or
local so not using a context or using a
context so I hope this can explain can
answer your question well
so today I'm going to show you what is
felt actions well spelled actions is
um essentially a life cycle functions
for your elements right so it's a very
powerful feature if you know how to use
them but before we learn about what are
the use cases that you can use actions
let's take a look at how you can write
actions
right so it's over here I have a rebel
over here
so um actions is nothing but a function
so I can name my functions any name like
I want so I can call it a
Lee how action
right
and I can use an action
on an element so any elements in the
screen so I have like a H1 over here I
probably have another H2 over here but
if I want to add an action on this
element I will use a directive use and
then a name of the action right so this
name itself has to be defined right it
can be
um functions that you define in a script
in a function you define in the global
scope as long as it's a function then
you define it somewhere the name then
you can use it
right so this function now we are using
this action right so this section itself
sticks in a couple of parameters and the
first one that we're going to look at is
called a node
right so if you console log over here
right now
what you will see is that
um you get
the note itself in this action right so
whatever elements that you apply with
the action you will get it over here
right like this right
and remember that say that it's like a
life cycle events for an action well
that's because uh when this element H1
is mounted on the screen onto the Dom
then this function is being called
immediately right so you have the access
to this Dom uh this node that you are
adding action to you can also access to
like the parents and everything else
right so it's like a life cycle you know
that this will be called when this
element is added to the Dom
right and to know that when it's removed
you can return a method call so you can
return an object in action and you can
return something called and within
object it's expecting to have a method
called destroy so this is optional you
can return this or not as you can see
earlier we didn't return anything still
works right so over here you can console
log something where it's destroyed
which means that
which means that this node itself is
being removed from a Dom
right so this will be called when it's
being removed so let's take a look at an
example of
um how this is being used right so over
here I have a checkbox
uh which which I check and uncheck will
show uh I use with an if block so check
and uncheck will show this div over here
right so in this diff I use an action
called action
so um this high should be called when
this div is added to the Dom and this
Destroyer should be called when it's
being removed right so let's see I'm
gonna Zoom a bit on the console and I'm
going to click so when it once I click
it's on the down you'll see that it's
called high with the note itself and
when I unchecked it was removed and it
will call the buy function right so this
way you can know when the element is
being added and being removed
right so early on I mentioned that
action itself has a couple of parameters
so the first one is a node which is the
element itself and it actually takes in
two parameters so one is the node the
second one is called the params
right so params so what params does is
that actually in an action you can pass
parameters to the next one you can do it
by uh some like this right so it's like
imagine this in attribute this is like
the value of the attribute so you can
pass in anything over here you can pass
in something probably like the name as a
variable you can pass it a string
because pass in a number over here I'm
going to pass it name right so here in
the console log I'm going to just
console log out params as you can see
really the name has the value of wool so
over here you can see wall in the
console let me Zoom it up a bit and you
can see it clearly
okay so let me clear this and run this
again
right so you can see the node and the
world over here
right so what you can do with it is that
now you have access on both things you
can play with a note right so for
example I want to say no dot inner HTML
equals params immediately once I run
this action you can see that the notes
in a HTML is changed to params right so
um this is this is very powerful and I'm
going to show you what you can do with
it in the next video so over right now
well what we have learned so far is that
actions is nothing but an action uh
sorry but a function that you can call
uh and it's like a life cycle method or
event for your action for your elements
so when the element is added to the Dom
you actually caught and when it's
removed the destroyed method we call
right and an action can text in the
parameters like this and it will be
appear as a second parameter to action
right and then you can play with
anything with the note and the
parameters you like
so in the last video I shared about what
is spelled actions right and some of you
may ask like for example you have a
variable then you pass in as a parmes of
the action and you want to change that
um the parameters and how will that
reflect how do you get that parameters
will be reflected in your action
right so probably a bit big but let me
try to explain this to you with um
example in this Rebel so over here you
have an input box
that is buying the value of the inputs
is bind to this variable called name and
I'm going to show a name over here as
well so when I type in over here say I
change the world to spelled you can see
the name changes to spelled right
and I'm using this name variable in this
action called the how action
right
but this action is being only called
once when this element is added to the
Dom right and the REM and the destroy
will be called when it's removed from
the Dom right okay but I want this name
variable to be always in sync with this
action
I'll put it the other way I want this
action to know that whenever these
problems change I'm going to do
something
because in this example in this action
I'm setting the inner HTML as the params
which is a string that I'm passing in
and it's only being called once when
this Dom is this div is added to the Dom
which is when it's say whoa when the
value is wool right but then
um when I change this variable which is
the pumps I want to get notified as well
right how do you do that
well actually this object that you've
written besides you can return a method
called destroy you can actually return
another method called updates right and
this updates methods will also will
contains the new params right so this
function will always be called
whenever this problems change right so
update because see I'm trying to say
updates and new params I'm going to show
you
over here right so gonna when I type I'm
gonna change something you're gonna see
that update is being called with world
one as I'm typing right
so this way I can change it uh I can use
this and updates my next demo if I want
to right so I'm gonna oh come here and
say this equals to new params
right so whenever I change
this inner HTML updates as well right
that's cool right that's slick so that's
that's that you have it right
um so let me conclude it even more even
better which is that an action is a
function that will be called uh when
your element is added to the Dom
right you can pass in the parameters
which will be the second parameters to
your action right if you if your action
returns an object and if that object has
a method called update that updates
matter will be called every time when
your palms change
and if that return object contains a
method called destroy that method
destroy method will be called when your
element is removed from the Dom right so
any of updates are destroyed or return
object is optional right once if you
have it you will it'll be called right
so it's very simple you to use an action
you call a use
directive so use a colon and the action
name equals to parameter right a
parameter can be numbers objects and
strings and so on and so forth
today I'm gonna answer a hypothetical
question what happens if felt does not
have a feature called sveld actions
why do I ask this question well because
um to me in my opinion the best way to
understand what a feature is how this
feature works is to think about what if
there is no such feature
right so there will be most likely two
outcomes right one is that you can't do
anything at all so which means that this
feature is necessary it's essential to
help you to achieve something without it
it's not it's impossible
a different outcome would be
um you can still do what you want but
probably it will be slightly harder to
achieve what you want maybe when you
want to write code you'll be more
complex uh more boilerplate code or
maybe you have to do a roundabout way to
in order to achieve something right so
which means that this kind of feature
actually does not change the essential
of like
like ability or possibility of doing
something but actually helps you to
accomplish something in a much simpler
or easier way
right so
so what about spelled actions is it like
an enabler enabling you to accomplish
something that is not previously
possible or it's like a facilitator like
allows you to accomplish something in a
much simpler and easier way to think
about well let's find out
so over here I have
um
a simple application
where basically I have an input over
here and a counter all right so if you
can as you can see over here this
counter uses an action called counter
so how it works is that whenever I click
on this button
we with the one the button with the
action applied when I click on it the
button will increment by once and this
number which apparently uh
coincidentally it's this number one
right so if you see that this number is
bind by this input and it's being passed
into this action so if I try to
increment this to say 5 then whenever I
click on it it will increment by five so
if I change it to 10 then increment by
10.
all right so this is
um so all this is the doing of the
action right so your action over here
let's take a look quick look at how this
action is being defined so this counter
action uh itself defines a variable
called count and it will update the text
which is to up to set the buttons in a
HTML to be the count the value of the
count
right and then it adds an event
listeners so whenever you click your
increments account and then update the
text
over here returns an object which has
two methods one is updates which is to
updates whenever the increments is
changed you will update to that new
increment so this uh if you remember in
the last video this is this parameter
that we pass in so we pass in this
number so that will be our increment so
whenever this change this update
function will be called which means that
your increment the value of increments
will update as well and the destroy will
remove the event listeners
right so we take a look again at this
function
I mean the the behavior of this action
isn't that complex right so it's like
once you have this um button you
probably would want to um add an event
listener and
and then uh probably you keep
um uh knowing that what is the value of
the counter and then uh probably with
which you
um whenever you increment you you
uh increments with a new number right so
I probably want to do now is to rewrite
this without actions right because we
are trying to answer like what if
there's no action so what would we have
to write
so yes if we don't have an action then
probably we have other things that is
available to us right
um we can use buying
this
uh to get the instance of the button and
we can use that to add event listeners
or we can also use
um on click to register for event
listener and then um
and then do the job right so what I'm
trying to do now is instead use bind
this the button
that I have a reason of doing this but
probably uh you will it will be more
obvious later on
right so if I use
okay so here I'm going to define a
button variable so whenever bind this
when this button is on the screen it
will make sure the ref this variable
will be updated with the reference of
that button
right which means that um
over here when we have like on Mount
we will have access to the instance of
the button right so over here we can do
the things that we have done over here
which is
um
register a non-click listener on the
pattern
and then
we can return
a function which is being will be called
when this component is being destroyed
um
with this remove event listener
right
and we're going to Define on click
which is over here we can copy it over
here so on click
uh we'll update account so we need to
Define count as well we're going to
Define it here
and you're gonna update text so we need
to Define update text as well
so we're just going to change this to
button
and then
lastly we'll import on Mount which is
from svelt
right and lastly we also need to call
update text to set the
text to one so count is starting with
zero right so now we are not using this
counter at all let me collapse this this
is not being used anywhere
um
and supposed to work but let's see
what is missing
okay increment is not defined oh sorry
so we need to Define a variable
increment as well
right so
uh increment should be equal to number
okay so now we need to update the value
of increments right so increments is
actually
um the value num over here
so probably we can
maybe do something like this
increment
equals number
okay num sorry
now in Click we can increment with
updates
it works right
so
not big no big deal right you can
achieve this without using action so
what's so cool about action right
well how about this okay so instead of
having one button we have two buttons
which both of them using
uh counter right
so I'm just use counter on both buttons
so
um let me comment out this first
oh nevermind let me keep this uh so that
this button still works so you the first
two button is the one that with actions
so right now if I try to click on both
the increments independently right and
when I change this both of them
increments independently uh the counts
within this button is not the same as
this right so
how do you do that with
um how do you reuse this uh buying this
button right can you do that well I mean
um so probably we instead of having one
button variable probably we need two
button variables and then probably we
have to copy this over
um and then replace all of them as
button two
right I guess that would work
so replace all of them as button two
um
and then counts probably you need
account two for button two
right on click as on click tool update
text tool
well
let's see what else is missing count uh
increment update text to
no update text 2 over here
um up to text to text to
on click two
this is two
I'm gonna have two buttons
right
um what else is missing let's see
button to count to
okay I think we are missing button
one
um not really oh okay so here instead of
returning probably we
have it on both sides
right and yeah we can do that as well
they're both incrementing
um
independently right as you can see over
here probably we have to duplicate like
the instance of the button in order to
like try to replicate this but if you're
using actions right um the but the
element itself the counts itself they
are all encapsulated within your action
so every time when you create when
you're using one actions all these
variables are locked in in the scope of
that action and it's only
um available for your instance of this
element so you can call it multiple
times on you can apply this action on
multiple times on multiple elements each
of them will have their own scoped
accounts update tags and everything else
right so
um yeah that is one thing that
it's a bit inconvenient if you are doing
without
um action but is that the deal breaker
well not let's see right so the next
thing we're going to do here is that
we're going to add a check box
okay so over here I'm gonna have input
called
type check box
let's say a show
a wrap it with a label
so
buttons
and over here I'm going to bind this
checked with a variable called checked
which I'm going to Define it over here
let's check it goes through
right and I'm gonna say
if checked
I'm gonna show this right if if check is
true then I'm going to show the buttons
if not I'm going to hide the buttons
show hide show and hide right
immediately you can you can see if I
checked and uncheck a few times
um
because this is only being executed on
Mount therefore uh as you can see here
once we recreate this button as because
we create a button without in a Content
the button is now without any content
right
um so probably something we can change
over here uh is
to use ons uh use after updates in
States
right probably that
would work
not really right so what why what
happened right so once you hide the
buttons so after update will be called
every time when there is a new uh when
there's an updates right so when you uh
so when you when you show the buttons
you'll run after update when you hide it
you'll run again and when this time when
you run again
um you are trying to run execute this
thing right which is button two and
event listener and button two now is
undefined because the button is removed
from the Dom
right so
yeah that is something that we probably
will have to take note of
right so we're gonna say if button two
only we add event listener
right and
if not so which means that button 2 is
hidden then we are going to remove event
listener for the button too
right and same thing goes for button one
and two button one right so over here uh
button button button
and as probably at this point of time
probably you might have already noticed
is that having returning this previously
during an on Mount is not that accurate
right because this button this actually
creates and removed
um on on change
which is right now where we are changing
something
which means that um
if we hide this button we should also
remove event listener from the button
but if we are using it inside and on
Mount it will only be in caught when the
whole component is being removed
so if within this component is still
here and you're just toggling showing
and hiding the button well it will not
call this remove event listener
right so that is something that you
might want to take note of
um probably you have already noticed so
can I remove this now
okay so show and hide right same thing
goes with the update text probably you
can't call it right now
uh we're gonna call it
only when the button 2 is available
over here as well
um button to
button one
all right show height
uh hold on remove your lens off now
okay so now
it's something uh
okay so now a button is actually
undefined when you you hide it right
which means that um
see now
we we if the button is there which means
that uh we want to add an event listener
right but when you hide it which means
that the button is right now is already
undefined so how do we remove event
listener if we can't even get the
instance of the button
well probably we can do something like
um assign the button on
the event remove event listeners as um
uh let's see
right so probably we can still do it but
I think at this point you notice that
it's not that easy anymore while having
let me comment this while
having um
okay let me collapse this and comment
this as well
while having actions everything still
works pretty much the same if I
change this they are still incremented
individually
if I change this
still works
right
still works perfectly fine
right so let's see should we continue on
fixing this
um I think we can still try a bit
so let's get back to just with one
button
and with that one button I am going to
uh resurrect this part of the code
so probably maybe let's don't do it with
after updates maybe that's not the right
um let's see whether it's the right way
of doing it
okay so imagine we don't have this right
just without this probably we can go
away with a lot of things
oh let's see event remove event listener
um count counts button button
okay
now click2 is undefined ah okay
and click
okay so I think we can still get away
with
um without remove even listener but
um you know that it's not entirely
exactly like the one with the actions
right and now if we try to increment
this
um
okay so see that this is not quite
working
um let's see what happened
oh
I think my whole screen hang
uh
let's see what's going on
probably runs into some sort of infinite
Loop somewhere
okay I think I'm gonna give up and I'm
gonna okay uh refresh
okay but it just come back let's try
again
no it died so
I'm gonna give up on this one let's just
refresh again and hope for the best
well as you can see over here it's it's
not that simple to do this without an
action right
um so probably it's for the best that
you have an action
um to help you achieve like something
such simple as adding an event listener
um and
exit page
having an event listener and then you
know increments whenever that this is
incremented right
so let's shall we just try one more time
this time around let's do it do
something different
I'm gonna
same thing goes we're gonna have binders
with button
this time around I'm probably trying to
probe it in a different approach which
is to use
reactive declaration
right so if pattern is
so this will be this will execute when
um any time went so I'm if I'm using a
button variable in here which means that
this whole X statement will be execute
anytime when this button variable change
so if button is available then we are
going to add event listener
right click and call on click
right on click then we're gonna say
buttons uh okay so we also need a
variable called count so let's count
equals to zero
and count should add plus num
and then we need to set the HTML of the
button equals to count
right so now uh we also need to do the
same thing over here
so now when we click
uh it will work right as we increment
this and we click again it will continue
to work then again the deal breaker
which is what if we have a checkbox
that was a true initially
and I'm going to say
okay have
new line up here new line over here
input type
check box
um
um bind checked
also checked
okay so now I'm gonna
and have an if statement if check
this show this
um and see what I can still increments
yep it works
I increment this number is still works
as fine
well
um
but actually not quite so if I console
log over here
on click
um
I'm gonna see it
oh wait yeah it works right so
okay
um
yeah probably this works now probably we
have to think about how we can remove
event listener
um which is over here
let's see
remove event listener
when button is defined uh but but then
but then you don't have the reference of
this button so what we're going to do is
that
um
we
I'm gonna use before
okay I'm gonna stop here because there's
no straight easy way if you as if you
follow with me so far you may really
realize that there's no straight easy
way of doing it uh without going even
more detail so probably I feel like
probably we have adding more Logics over
here and
and I think we have achieved our goal so
far is to demonstrate that how what
happens if you don't have an actions is
felt uh probably you have to write all
this uh
quotes just to achieve something where I
think it's much easier to reason about
and read about if you have an action
and so first thing is it's much harder
to write this second is that it's
um you can easily reuse this the same
action over and over and over if you
without it you probably would have to
copy paste your code multiple times
having multiple references of the same
uh having multiple variables reference
to the different elements
today I'm going to talk about how you
can use felt actions to integrate with a
UI Library
right so swell actions is a very
powerful construct in svelt as I
mentioned in the previous video If you
haven't watched them the links is over
here okay click them watch them right so
today I'm going to show you one of the
many ways of
one after sorry one of those cool ways
that you can use actions for which is to
integrate with a UI Library where it
does not have to be UI but it can be any
library but most likely you would want
to use it with a UI Library so what is a
UI library and that I am referring to
and how do you integrate it in svelts
using actions
okay so maybe let's let's have a story
first right so the background of this is
that maybe one day you want to build a
date picker right you know those kind of
date picker when you click on the button
you see a calendar you can swipe to look
at different months of the calendar and
then choose a few dates and then you
select a date
right
um probably there's a built-in one but
you feel you don't like the look or feel
of the browser defaults uh calendar
input date input you want to build your
own but you can't so you find you look
online Google you find some libraries or
someone recommend you this very cool UI
library that allows you to create a date
picker so because you're using us you're
writing a swell application
um will that work with svelte right I
mean usually if you work with other
libraries usually what you do is that if
you're using react you look for react
date picker if you're looking at view
you look for view date picker right so
is there a spell date picker and if
there's no and you find some date picker
it says that zero dependencies and
very good how do you integrate it with
svelt and today we're going to show you
how right so I'm I before this video I
Google around and I found this date
picker which says that it is
um lightweight and Powerful
lightweight and powerful and it's like
lean extensible and does not depend on
any Library which is great right because
which means that you just install this
you don't install come with all the
bells and results of every other library
is not the weight of all the other
libraries you just need this Library
that's all
so you'll look around and you see like
getting started which is how do you
start using this it says install this
library and probably add this in your
HTML
so to include the CSS and then to use it
you import flat picker and you wrap it
around an element and that element
itself will become a date picker how
easy is that so how do you do it in
sales actions it's Felts using actions
well uh so now first thing is I'm gonna
have like I should say we need an
element right so I'm going to use
probably a button
date picker
so now when you click on button nothing
happens right so next thing is we are
going to
um so to use this first thing is you
include this CSS right so this probably
want to add it in a hit of the HTML so
I'm going to use felt hit
angular copy paste this thing in
right the Cs is loaded you can't you
can't see it but it's there okay next
thing is we're gonna have a script text
and we're going to import flat picker
right one thing cool about this Rebel is
that you can import any Library uh we
will try to find it from the unpackaged
CDN where it will download exactly what
you would download from the npm right so
I have this flat picker and now how do I
um
integrate this with this button right so
one way you can do is you can bind this
button
and uh
and then when button is defined
probably you call Flat picker with the
button right
uh button so we're gonna say let's
button
right and that's it
so you click you have a date picker
that's cool
um now next thing is
um well I'm showing I'm buying this
right so
why not actions right yeah we can do it
with actions as well let's see how how
it will look like in actions right so I
can comment this out and I'm gonna
comment this out sorry let me copy this
and comment this out so that we can have
it compare side by side so now
instead of buying this I'm going to say
use date picker
and this will be a function
restricting an element
I'm gonna call Flat picker
elements right
this works as well
right nicely done so
um whether to use this or use an action
I mean it's pretty much similar is there
a difference well if you are thinking
about this question you should watch my
other video over here the link will be
over here which is what happens if we
don't have a feature instead called
scrapped actions how would you have to
go about it
right um it talks about how you have to
work around it and let me show you one
thing that it's not easily done if you
don't have action is that I can copy
this paste this in
I have two buttons with typical each of
them can pick individual dates while
having this I will have to Define uh two
buttons and then bind it to a different
button variable and do it this way right
smart much hassle
um
so I'm not going to do it anymore right
so I'm just remove this forget about it
and focus on this right
so next thing is let's see so let's look
at the examples and see how we can use
with this flat picker
and as you read through it you realize
that you can pass in some sort of
options
right some sort of configurations so
let's look at what is the configurations
so one of those configurations would be
say uh
let's see let's see
um
the previous Arrow
right um
wait let's see maybe Showman's number of
months to be shown at the same time
right show months
so
how cool if is if you can just pass in
an object in here instead and it says
show month is three
and how cool is that if you can do it
this way so this is config and you can
call it like this way
so the first button has show months of
three months second button has none so
probably by default is one so over here
you can see you have three months
this one you have only one
right three months one right this is
it's that easy right and this month
itself can be a variable right so if I
say inputs bind um
value equals to show months
uh type number
and show months is up say let's
equals to 3
use it over here
so if I change this I want to able to
change
number of months to be shown so let's
change to set one well it's not working
because you need to implement update as
well because you know this
variable is going this parameter is
going to be updated all the time when
you change it right so I'm gonna say
return
um
sorry return an object
with an updates method
so it's the new config over here now and
what should we do with a new config
right so let's see a flat picker
instance probably have some methods that
you can call say um to
sets options uh is there a setting
there is a config
configurations
set options set
okay sets option
right so I'm going to say uh this is the
calendar
and calendar dot sets
right so probably you have to read about
it in your UI library that you're using
and see what other apis I can use can be
used to uh
uh that can be changed and things like
that and you you can update It On Demand
using the update method right so now if
it's two then you will show two months
it's one then only show
sorry one month
right it only show one month
and if it's
um six then it will show six months
right it's it's it's highly configurable
and you can just change it at the whim
right you just do it this way
so one thing I noticed just now is that
probably there's this parameter called
open
and
close right so let's let's try core
methods instead in the update function
so what that means is that so let's say
instead of this uh I'm gonna have an
input called type checkbox
buy and check
equals to variable called checked
so let's
Okay so
I'm gonna pass in this as a parameter
instead right so this is like open
right so now this is also like this
value opened so you see if you change
this variable if open
then I'm just going to say calendar dot
open
so this uh this method is something I
read from here where you can call open
or close
um in the API documentation so probably
you have to
see what
all the things that you can do with your
UI Library so this is going to tell you
that okay see to show you that if I buy
this check and then pass it in over here
then now when I check and unchecked
basically you can control opens and
close right changing this or changing
this parameter and in terms will be
called this update function a method and
over here we can call methods of your
library instance right and in most cases
you probably would have to remember to
do to implement the destroy method
because in most libraries when you uh
when you remove these elements you also
remove this button element you also do
need to do cleanups right and probably
some libraries will provide methods like
destroy to clean like all the event
listeners and all the stuff right so
over here probably you will have to
remember to call calendar
uh dot destroy as well
um but we are not gonna demonstrate how
it will take an effect but trust me it
will work right remember to clean up
whatever you have set up so remember to
implement the destroy of your actions so
that it will clean it up
so um that's all for
Implement integrating uh UI Library
using swell actions with swelt right
integrating a UI library with felt using
stealth actions
so today I'm going to share with you how
you can use swell actions to reuse event
listeners to do so I'm going to share
with you three examples right so let's
take a look at
the first example
so over here I have an example and a
result
which you will see the example will be
on the left side of the Rebel and the
results will be on the right right so
what we're going to do here is that
we're going to have three examples on
using event listeners and I'm gonna
rewrite it to use actions to replace
them and that will be on the right right
so so that we can compare side by side
like to make sure that the effect still
looks the same but it's Rewritten using
actions right and you can then decide on
your own whether you prefer to write it
with actions or continue to use your
event listeners right no judgment over
here I'm just going to show you how you
can do it
so the first example over here let's
take a look at the first example so the
first example is called a blur on X
Escape right which means that I'm
informal type over here
type something and when I click on the
Escape key
the input itself will be blur right
which is it loses the focus and you can
you know like you don't see the blue
outline of that input anymore and the
cursor is no longer in there it's losing
focus so how we can achieve this is that
um you can there's multiple ways of
doing it right so one way I'm doing it
over here is that I'm having an input
and I'm bind the inputs to a variable so
the ref so this input variable will
reference to this uh input element and
then I have a key down which uh on key
down will listen to key down and in the
event handler over here
I will check if the key is escaped then
I will blur the input right so far so
good
so one of the things that I mentioned
earlier if you haven't seen this video
about why uh like what's so good about
swell actions you can click over here
the links over here is that one of the
things that you can do is that you can
reuse uh
it's it makes you easier to reuse um
actions on the same elements on multiple
elements so in this case if I want to
have multiple inputs and want to blur uh
let multiple inputs then probably I
would have to make it like input two
input 3 and you know uh probably over
like blood Escape 2 and 3 which
uh would have to blur a different input
right probably I would have to do that
instead to achieve this effect then as
you can see over here then there will be
um duplication of code over here I would
have to create input one input two and
input 3. all right so that uh I can
escape from the first input from second
input and from the third input
right so you know do I have to do this
well if you're smart enough you would
you might notice something well uh
you don't have to declare a variable
called inputs in order to blur each of
them well you can you can get like event
dot current Target
right and then you can just remove all
this and you can reuse the Sim events
listener get do away with this
uh bind this
you can still achieve the same effect
I skip I skipped and Escape right you
can still achieve that
do you need action
do you need it well um
yeah I'm not here to pass judgment on
whether you should use or not but I'm
here to show you how you can rewrite
this to use actions and then you can
reuse that action on multiple places
where you don't have to import or so
instead of importing this event list
Handler or writing it multiple times now
you are instead you are importing that
actions and reuse it multiple times
right so over here I'm gonna create a
result
one
last felt I'm going to copy this over
and I'm going to import from result one
instead
right so over here on the right is the
result
so I'm gonna change this to use actions
instead of event handler
right so over here I'm gonna say
function so an action is a function so
I'm going to say I'm gonna call it uh
blur on Escape function below action
and this function an action function
takes in a node
and param right in this case we don't
really need a parameter so we just leave
it like this
right and then what we can do next is
that it should
um
return an object which could be called
when you are updating the parameter or
you are destroying that element right so
right here we have if we were using
actions instead so I'm going to just use
Action Now use this
you can copy paste over multiple times
so if you use an action instead of event
listener then you will have to add event
listeners yourself
right which means that I will probably
have to say no dot add event listener
key down
and then I'm gonna have the same events
over here so I'm gonna copy this over
and have it here instead
all right so blur on Escape let me pass
it over here
I'm gonna re return a destroy
I'm gonna remove event listener instance
all right so this is the same way this
will achieve the same effect of using an
event listener instead right so let's
see whether it still works I'll click
Escape type type type Escape type type
Escape right so
um
yeah so over here example if you're
using an event handler now you're using
um
an action instead and you have to
register and unlisten the event listener
right so let's move on to see example
two
right so we're gonna change this to
example two and let's see what we have
for example two
so the second example over here is that
um we have
uh same thing goes we bind inputs to a
tree inputs element
and on key down I'm going to call next
on enter meaning when I type something
when I click on the enter key it should
go to the next input
click on the next inputs right so how it
works is that I bind these three
variable input one two three and then I
on each of the event handler when I
click enter I'm going to focus on the
next inputs
right so over here I'm going to do this
multiple times
um
is there a way that we can instead of
so in the previous example we see that
we if we we don't have to
create multiple event handlers when we
can somehow assess like the current
Target of the event so that we don't
have to reference any
elements that we assign outside of this
event handler then we can reuse this
event handler right so in this case we
are referencing input 2 but 3 in this
event handler and input 3 in on the uh
this event handler right so the first
second one is the focus and the third
one is that when I click enter because
there's no next uh event input then I
will have to blur myself right so
stay away that you can
um somehow pass this inputs as an uh
parameter of this event handler or
something like that right is there a way
well remember that action sticks in not
just the element itself also perms right
so probably you can use that instead and
probably with that maybe we can just
need one event handler so we're gonna do
that right now
two and I have copies it over here and
I'm gonna use reference to result 2 in
States
right so over here
I'm gonna create is called uh next on
enter action
that takes in the elements
and a param
so same similar things we're going to
copy one of the event handler
and we're gonna say um
elements that add events
listener
so copy this event name key down and
gonna call uh next on enter
so we're going to re rename this to next
on enter
and also I need to remember to remove
event listener because now we are adding
on ourselves then we have to do the
cleanup ourselves as well let's say
return and then call it destroy
I'm gonna copy this line
paste it in except that I need to call
remove instead of ADD
okay so with with this I'm going to say
uh okay so now we're going to change
this right we can pass it as a param
what it means is that now uh instead of
on key down I'm gonna say use this
I'm going to pass in as oh sorry
uh
over here use this I'm going to pass in
inputs two right which is that I need to
focus on input 2 on on next on action
over here gonna focus on
input tree
and over here we're gonna
just not passing anything so not passing
anything meaning you have to blur
yourself right so we can Define that
ourselves
um so meaning this will this uh input is
the params of that action so which is
this so now I'm going to say if param
then param dot Focus
right
else
okay now next so okay probably a better
naming would be instead of called Parma
gonna say next element
uh
to focus
it's going to say here we're gonna paste
it in place it in and then if not there
will be event dot current Target Doppler
right so now I can remove all these
three event handlers well just focus on
one big action that does a job right so
I'm gonna type something enter wait wait
wait not working uh event listener
next element of focus
wait
wait hold on okay so next element to
focus
next on enter
destroy element remove event is now
see okay so I'm gonna try and see um
console log next element to focus
which is undefined okay
over hold on so this one is input two
ah okay
so this action will is called on this
input on the
so now now we find the bug and then we
can fix it right so which means that
when you call this action we will bind
so the action
um is happen when you are mounting this
component which happens uh where so
initially which what happens is that the
when we are mounting these elements
input to 1 2 3 are all undefined right
and once we mounted all everything so so
this is being called on when we're
mounting it right so this is passing in
undefined over here
um and then after we mounted all the
three inputs we the bind this will
update the variable input one two three
to the reference of that elements right
but we didn't and this will be updated
as well but to get that updates we need
to call and up we need to add update
method over here
which is the
like we call next next element to focus
which is the next uh next element to
focus that pass in I'm gonna say uh this
equals to this
right
so now
probably will work
so I'm going to say enter it will focus
on next one right so this will since
this action uh on mounts you receive
undefined because we haven't defined
input one two three and once it's
mounted uh they call the action first
and then it's passing undefined right
and then The Binding bind this will be
will updates the variable one two three
to the reference of these three inputs
and then uh because input one two three
is changed it will notify these two
actions as well telling them that since
they have the update method it will call
it to tell you that okay what's the new
reference of this parameter right so we
have it we updates to this next element
to focus and now so we assign it to the
next element to focus so now the next
element to focus is updated with the new
reference
so when we type something and click
enter it will focus and then it will
blur right which works as expected
so um so a
so now using actions save us some uh
some code like we don't we can reuse all
the event listeners with one action
where we can have like variables passed
in like the parameters to the action
well
is that like a limitation of an event
handler well not
it is but not really right so if you
look at over here
one thing you can do is that we can
write in instead of having like an event
handler that defines that uses a
variable input 2 over here you can write
a higher order function
what that means is that we can hire a
function
uh
create next on enter so so we write a
function that returns us this event
handler
right why we want to do that is that
we can
create this function that returns us and
it can take in parameters so you can
text in a parameter called like input
and then we can use it over here instead
right so input could be again uh
the next inputs are undefined right so
I'm going to say if input
then it's inputs.focus
and else I'm going to be event
so this is the same thing that we have
done to the actions earlier on so even
the current Target dot blur
all right so so now instead we can
remove all these three Event Center
rather we have a
function that creates a new event
handler all every time
and we're going to call it over here
instead
input one
oh sorry input 2 and this will be input
and this will be
no inputs right so once again we can try
still works still works right
so you may ask whether
um
this is better do it this way or
uh using actions right
well if you ask me I would prefer to do
it using an action and here's my reason
why
right so if you take a look at over here
this event listener which is uh this
over here when we pass in an event
listen over here it's um
this thing is the create next on enter
is a function creator that creates a new
function every time we call it right so
what that means is that
we are creating multiple event handlers
every time
um over over every time when we have a
when the input 2 has changed uh the
input over here has changed right so so
the first time is that input 2 is
undefined so this will return us a new
function where the input over here is
referenced to undefined
and then as we mounted all the inputs
where we assigned the value of input 2
to like reference of the inputs to input
2 then this will get this function will
get caught like this expression will be
inverted again which means this function
will call again with a new input
reference and returns us a new function
right so every time when we change input
1 2 or 3
we will create a new function
right is that costly uh I'm not sure but
it's definitely something right so in
this very simple example probably you
don't feel it right on the other hand
over here results too
uh when we use an action on an element
this action will be only called once
when we Mount the input
and then it will return us two methods
and then we just call that method right
so whenever input 2 is changing to maybe
pointing to different references what it
does is only call this uh method which
is the updates and it will do an
assignment to update that reference
right so there's no it does not create
new functions or create anything new
right so that that's the difference of
using an action versus like um maybe a
higher order a function Creator over
here in States
right so um probably in this example the
differences is negligible and if you do
it well
um namely like if you make sure that you
don't have any memory leaks probably new
functions they created the old function
will be Memory garbage collected and it
does not feel much difference to your
app anyway
right but just for the information it's
that's the differences that's the
difference between using an event
handler and action
right so we have seen two examples and
let's move on to the last example which
is example three so I'm going to change
this to example 3 and the same time this
as well so I'm just gonna copy all this
and create a new file called result
three
and paste all of them in and let's take
a look at what we have for example three
so in example three is what I call a
secret inputs uh
combo uh
inputs so what it means is that I can
have
um
so I I'm listening on key down and if I
typed some sort of secret combo like
Arrow up down up down left right left
right so I'm going to do now up down up
down left right left right I'll unlock a
secret right
so how it works is that I have this
secret key over here I can Define it
um and then on key down I will push
whatever I click on and do an array
called keys
and then
um
also and make sure that uh if I stop
typing for maybe uh one second then I
will just clear that array right so I
need to click fast enough that in
between the keys does not um
um lasted more than one second right so
at the same time I will so after I click
a key I will I will set a timeout so
that I will clear but at the same time
if I type another key then I will clear
that timeout meaning um
which means that sorry which means that
the timeouts will be cleared and then uh
it will not this this callback will not
be called you will not clear a key and
then we'll register a new timeout to
clear another in the next one second
right so once we type in enough uh
keys that it matches the secrets which
will just simply do like a rate of join
with a comma so all the items in the
array will be drawn with a comma and if
it matches the secret then it will
unlock the the unlock right so
so that's that's how the code works
right I think I think I need to do
something over here which is I need to
make sure that uh once I set timer over
here and ID equals to now
and then I'm only clearing if
there's a timeout ID over here instead
okay
so
um let's rewrite this I'm gonna I'm not
gonna explain like how you would do it
otherwise but
I'm gonna ex like show you how I would
rewrite this using action
and you can judge yourself whether
it's better writing and using an action
or writing using like event handler like
like we've shown earlier right
so
first thing is we're gonna call this a
secret use
Secret
combo
action
by the way you don't have to always name
your action with ending with an action
it's just
to let you know that it is selection
that's all
um
I don't usually add that suffix of
action right so I've heard I will call
so the action will text in an element
and probably taken us a params which I
would
um see let me see what I can do so I
will take in the secrets
as the param
as well as maybe something like a
callback function right so if I want to
pass in a secret as well as a callback
like I want to pass in multiple things
then a easier way of doing it is to pass
in as a function sorry as an object so I
can pass multiple things within a Sim
object right so an action will only have
two parameters so the second parameters
if you want to pass in not just more
than one thing then probably you have to
pass in as an object that collects all
the things it could be an array as well
so anything like object or array that
has that is like a collection of
multiple things that's all right so I'm
going to say secrets and a call back
and over here I what I'm going to do
here secret combo action is I'm gonna
add event listener and event
listener
key down
okay and then I'm gonna copy all this
thing over here
format nicely key Downs are on key down
right and then I'm going to return
an object where I will have update
as well as the destroy
so on Destroy I need to remember
remember most important thing of all is
to remember to remove event listener if
you are adding an event listener in an
action right remember to clean things up
you don't want uh if you do not do that
it will memory leak because
um it will still listen so your elements
itself still listen to some even
listeners and probably you couldn't and
key down is probably referenced
somewhere and you just couldn't garbage
collect your elements right so
over here let's see
um so I'm going to clear I can remove
this
so the way of using it would be instead
I'm going to say use I'm going to say
use secret combo action
and I'm going to pass in param so I can
pass in an object so I'm going to say
I'll create that object over here so uh
the outer brackets is like whatever you
put in a param and then inside I want to
pass in objects I create another clear
brackets right so over here I have
um I'm gonna pass in
Secrets which is a small key lower key
passing as a secret and
then a callback function which is a
function
and this function will be setting the
unlock
to
true
right so
now let's update the code over here so
this is the secret
and this if it matches I'm going to call
the Callback
right and now uh
all these things can be defined inside
so it's locked within the scope in a
scope it's not leaked out outside you
can still Define keys and timeout ID for
other users
right so now let's see what we have come
over here which is the results up down
up down left right left right it's not
working hold on let's see
secret secrets
unlock callback
okay let's let's see what we have over
here uh console log key start drawing
come on
type in something up down left right
left right oh okay it works well it
works
so
um
there you have it uh rewr write it using
actions
right so we can have multiple inputs
over here you can have
um
a different kind of Secrets maybe over
here we want to just uh
up down six uh three times up down up
down up down
then this one will be up down up down up
down unlock the secret
right so um callback
um yeah so you have it uh using a secret
and a callback
today I'm going to share with you how to
create events using spelled actions
so you may ask me why do I need to
create events what do you mean by
creating events
well
you know the last video we talked about
how to reuse event listeners using
spelled actions and there's this one
example that we use in actions to allows
us to create like a custom secret unlock
inputs which we're gonna see over here
so I'm just a recap so if you haven't
seen this you can click on the videos
link over here on the top right corner
and so here's a recap on the examples
that we've created so over here we
create an actions using secret combo
action that takes in two parameters one
is a secret one is a callback so in this
example we pass we call use secret combo
action where we pass in a secret which
is a secret combo key and then a
callback which is whenever we
successfully call this key like press
that secret combo Keys the Callback
function should be called which will do
things that we want to do when it's
called right
so um nothing wrong about doing it this
way but so let me copy this over and go
to the results
but what if we can
have an event listener that listens to a
custom event which tells us that the
secret is unlocked
right so probably we can have like a
custom events listener over here which
is like we so it's a custom event
listener right so we listen to this
custom event so we can use on directive
to listen to it and the events name so
for example like input you can on like a
key down key press or you can have on
value events listener change but over
here we can have our custom event name
that we can Define ourselves right so
this name probably would be something
like since we are using a secret combo
action would be like secret combo
achieve
and since this is a event listener we
can pass in an event function so here we
say unlock equals true
right so uh which means that we don't
need a callback function right we can
call we can have our secret combo action
that looks like this
and by adding this action probably we
have a custom event that's called secret
combo achieve when that event happens
the triggers will call this callback
function which is to set out on not to
be true
right if you write it this way you you
find it um slightly more elegant than
what we have done earlier where we pass
in a callback right now we can have like
events listener right so this is what I
meant by creating an event uh so an
action can create events
I mean you can create events yourself
but we can use actions to create a
custom event that is being triggered by
a custom trigger right so by for example
in this case is when the combo action uh
when we when you type in a combo uh in
in your input right so how do we do that
so over here when so in the existing
Hood we pass in a callback which is
being called over here so over here is
where
um we successfully triggered I mean we
successfully pressed down the combo Keys
which is a callback which we'll call the
Callback so now we don't want to get the
call back from the uh
action or on the other instead you want
to
um dispatch a custom event so I'm going
to say elements dot dispatch
events New custom events
right and the custom events can have a
custom event name which in this case is
the secret combo achieved
right and that's about it so instead of
passing a callback where you pass in the
Callback function that we call we just
dispatch events and you can decide
whether you want to listen to it or not
right so having a callback function
passed in you probably have to check
whether
um this callback is uh it's passed in
it's a function and then you call it
right doing it this way it decouples
with like whether you the need of having
to pass in the function where you just
dispatch events whenever you feel like
it and in this case uh and then the user
itself will be deciding on its own
whether to pass in this and then we do
dispatch an action this like it's
whether the there's event listener or
not it's optional uh so one great thing
about it
in this case we change it this way and
yeah let's try it out so
um like in the last video we have uh in
the apps itself we have the example and
the result which is the example would be
the original code that does not create
an event and result is the one that
creates an event right so this uh is um
Rebel will be shared down the link in
the description so that you can play
around with it right so on the left is
the example and on the right is the
results which we use the create custom
events so let's see whether it works so
I'm gonna press in the custom uh combo
key which is up down up down left right
left right right so up down up down left
right left right secret unlocked right
so that's so easy right
yeah so let's take a look at another
example and so just to like drill you in
this like way of uh creating custom
events using actions
right in this example example two we're
gonna change to example two and result 2
which is the same I'm going to create a
file called result two dots felt
right and over here
example two
it's what I call a triple click event
right so over here I can open up the
console
so I I sent an on click event listener
and when I click and I have to record
account so when I click I'll in clip
increments accounts right so when I
click three times in quick succession
then it will be triggered like it will
call like console triple click
right so how do you know that it's being
clicked fast enough in succession uh
basically we set a timeout
so I'm just like arbitrary time in this
case it's 800 milliseconds So within
eight milliseconds if you haven't
figured another click then you will
reset the counts back to zero right so
what I do is I record this timeout ID so
whenever the next time I click on it
I'll clear this time up so it won't
reset my account and at the same time I
create a new timeout so that I can
record I can see whether the next time
out next click and then next next
subsequent click whether they are within
800 milliseconds as well
so if I click once there's no effects if
I click twice no effect Okay click one
two three and you'll see a triple click
right so
um in like in elements you don't have an
event called triple click but what uh
how good it is if you can so a copy over
the result if you can have some you can
write something like uh
on Triple click
right what how good is it that you can
do this and you can console log triple
click
right
how good is this to have have this right
so how what can you do probably you can
write an
um an action right so that that's like
the aim of this video you can write an
action
and you can apply that action on this
button and once you apply that action
uh amazingly it has this triple okay try
click triple sorry let me
triple click event and then you can
listen to and you can pass in the
Callback function
so that is what the action that we are
going to use that we're going to write
we're going to say use triple
click action
so not all so so I'm just adding a
suffix of action to this so that you
know that it is an action uh it's not a
mandatory thing to name your action that
ends with an action got nothing to do
it's just you just need to be a plain
function and then you just can and then
you can pass it into the use directive
all right so I'm gonna call Triple click
action
and this will give me an important
element
so over here I'm going to copy over the
code over that I've written over here
uh over here
and over here
as well as this on click
right you're gonna paste it in
okay so I paste everything in and then I
need to remember to up uh the elements
that add events listener
click
on click and when I add event listener I
need to always remember to
um I remove events listener on Destroy
so that you remember to clean it up
let's say elements remove event listener
event listener yeah okay so yeah so you
have this action and hopefully so
to to have this triple cook events you
just need this triple click action that
apply to the button and now when you
click the button three times you get
Triple click
yay so there you have it you create an
action events using swell actions right
so
with cell actions you can enhance your
elements so that it can dispatch any
kind of events where you can listen to
them right so I believe that if you
visit spell rebel I sorry spell tutorial
on actions
um the one that they introduce about
actions which is this Panama as you can
see here you also in this example is
also uh where once you add this Panama
action you
magically have this pen start pen move
and pen and event which you can listen
to and react to it
today I'm gonna share with you something
that I feel that you should know about
spelled actions something that is
important but you may not even notice
about until you run into some kind of
bugs so
um what I'm going to share with you
today is about the order of sveld
actions
so let's take a look at this example
that I prepared for you
so in this example we have um two
variables one called value before action
and the other call Value after actions
and you will see why because over here I
have two inputs input one and input two
one on the left one on the right uh the
difference is that the the one on the
right on the left the value we bind
using a value before action and then we
apply an action use uppercase and the
other inputs next the second input is
that we use an action first and then we
bind the value value after action right
so
you may ask me whether
wait is it is the order important in in
like buying and use
um well that's what I'm going to share
with you so let's before that on the
action itself uppercase
uh is very straightforward I think
um which is it listens and inputs events
on the element and then destroy and to
remove it so in this event listener what
you do is then you get the value of that
element and then you set it to its
uppercase value
right so
yeah and then in this over here we're
gonna say I'm gonna show the value
before action and the value after action
so that you can compare
the two of them
so what do you think about the order of
actions does it matter that you apply an
action before you bind it or you bind
first and then your plan action
well it does matter right so or else
that wouldn't be in need to video this
right so over here I'm gonna pull it
over and I'm gonna type so right now I'm
on caps lock off so I'm not on in any
caps lock I'm going to type ASDF let's
say a
s d f as you can see when I type
the the last character is always
lowercase
right so I'm trying to do again a s d f
that's because whenever type
um the bind will get that value first uh
so uh why when I type I type in a small
letter A
so that that the value before action
will get that value but then an action
applied later on the bind because it
comes later on in the order and that's
when you change it to an uppercase right
so can I type so right now I have
uppercase a I'm going to type with s so
it will applique a and lowercase s which
is the value that I get from The Binding
and so the bind get first and then an
uppercase uh action will apply and then
a change that my action the value of the
inputs to be an uppercase right that's
how you see that
um it's always lowercase on the last
letter because I'm typing in a lowercase
right if I apply an action before the
bind
then the action will comes first before
the bind
right so I the same thing I'm going to
type ASDF in lowercase but notice that
uh whenever I type the value after
action is always in full uppercase right
that's because we change it to uppercase
first and then you get you update the
buying value right so the order does
matter in terms of the in the attributes
in the terms of when you apply that
action
right so
um you may ask me
um
uh like is there a cash on cash on this
right so that
um so first thing is that yes the order
is always applied in the order of
um The Binding I mean in order of how
you declare it in the attribute list
right and and to make this uh example
works is that I know that bind value
actually listens to an event listener on
input
so you you listened so an event listener
the input event listener always adds
um
always being triggered in the first come
first serve on uh first in first out
order or first come first serve order so
uh the buying get applies first so the
event listener for the buying gets added
first and then the event listener for
the actions to apply it later on because
it's applied later on right so and then
when you trigger the inputs
um the bind event listeners get callback
get called first and then the actions
event listeners get caught later on
right so
um to demonstrate this if I add um
events
dot stop immediate propagation
basically what it does is that it will
stop the propagation of that event to
other event listeners that listening to
the same element
what happens is that you'll notice that
this buy will no longer get the value of
the inputs because it's listening to
inputs events listener but then it's uh
what the uppercase will register first
and then stop it from stop from it to be
propagated to the other event listeners
right so if I'm going to try over here
everything still works like normal but
you want to try over here you'll see
that the buying value no longer gets its
value right so
um I not sure when you need this but
this is something very important and
your actions are there uh within the
attribute list is important so it it
works the same thing as applying the ons
event listener as well so all uh on use
and bind the orders are important which
come first and which comes later are
important so that um
if you're listening to the same event
listeners or changing the elements at
the same time probably the the one that
registers earlier will have effect
earlier before the one that registers
later on
let's talk about some examples of using
spelled actions and today we're going to
look at one example which is use click
outside
so you may have seen some applications
that has models or pop-up and when you
click outside of the model uh it may do
a few things one is maybe prompt you
that are you sure you're gonna quit or
you just close that pop-up itself so
we are going to achieve that using an
actions instruct
so as you can see over here we have a
div that is called a class model which
we just add like some paddings and
border so you can see that that is like
the region of the model
and we're gonna add a action an action
called click outside
and we can decide to do something that
we want about it right so but first
let's have
um the action so action is nothing but a
function that takes in two parameters
one is the elements which is these
elements that we we call the actions
with as well as some parameters right so
if we pass in some parameters over here
this will be available as the params
um so a few ways you can do this so
usually before we start anything we
probably want to decide or design how
the actions will behave right so on use
click outside we can maybe a few ways of
we can do this one is probably we pass
in um callback so when you click outside
this is a callback function that will be
called right so
click
I would say
right so this params will be a function
that you just pass in
um or you can use click outside and then
probably you know pass in something like
um
where in
uh we can where we can once we use click
outside probably we have a new event
that we can listen to right for example
on click outside
so this is uh if you are not sure about
what is this probably you can take a
look at my previous videos over here on
the top right corner where I basically
talk about how you can use actions to
create events right so
um like once you add these actions then
this element itself will have a new
event that we can listen to probably
called click outside I mean we can name
anything we want right but in this case
I guess I mean click outside will only
needs one parameter so probably instead
of having it as
uh like kind of decoupled using an event
probably in this case I just want to
pass that function is as a parameter
right so now
um let's go down to how we're going to
implement this action right action is a
function and it also returns uh which
which will be called when this div is
mounted where the element is the div
that is being passing and the parameters
is that function so I think I'll just
rename this to be callback function
right and over here it can return to an
object with two methods one is the
update
um the other one will be called destroy
this is when uh the element itself is
being removed right update will be
called whenever this phone like the
comparable parameter is changed right so
I'm gonna for the completeness sake I'm
going to say this is the Callback the
new callback function
and I'm going to assign callback equals
sorry the new callback function
right
and now we're gonna add an event
listener to the elements right so
instead of adding it to the elements
what I want to do is adding actually
adding it to the document body
and when I click anywhere on the body
um I I would
uh want to be called like so this is the
events Handler event
right I'm going to listen to the
document body so that I can know that
it's not just clicking on this element
but anywhere within like the documents
right so document.body dot at events
listener click and on click
and every time when we add an event
listener we need to remove it in the
destroy
right anytime when you want repeat again
anytime when you want to add an event
listeners in an action remember to
remove it and the destroy method right
clean it up you wouldn't want a stray
event listener registered and you know
that will cause memory leak
so now I've added a click event and I
remove a click event now in the click
event
I can know the event.target which is
what I'm clicking at right and if
uh these things that the element that
I'm clicking at is not within uh the
model which is the element that I'm
calling with the uh action
then uh then I know that it's clicking
outside of this element which I will
call the Callback function
right so let's pull up the console and
let's try to click on the model and
click outside right you can see as it
works
right now so you can use this to be
probably pass in a function to instead
of console out click outside probably
you can do something like you know close
the models and things like that right so
here you go uh creating a click outside
actions
let's talk about examples of using
spelled actions and today we're going to
look at one spelled actions which is use
tooltip
so let's take a look over here and let's
let me tell you what is a use tooltip
action do
right so
um you have an element over here in this
case maybe hello world let me just
change it over like make it simple like
Hello World right no Dynamic elements
and whatsoever but uh over here we can
have
um title
say
um this is hello world and this is a
greeting okay
right so what happens is that when you
hover over hello world
wait for me and then you will see a toe
tip right this is a built-in uh browser
Behavior like when you hover over on an
element that has a title it will show
you that this is a greeting
uh yeah the the title right but what if
you want to customize the tooltip you
want something different you want you
know like something that looks nicer
that suits your style or theme of your
website
right then probably you want to do uh
you you want to build your own tooltip
right so what you can do over here is
that maybe we add like on Hover events
like like Mouse over and like when you
all hover on top of this
elements you want to show like customize
nicely built a tooltip element instead
of like the default browser Behavior
right so that's probably what we want to
do over here and that's what I'm going
to achieve right so
um
so that would be having like use tooltip
uh action and we're gonna Implement that
use tooltip action
right so before we actually dive in
um to implement this
um what I want to do today which is
slightly different let's approach this
differently right why I want to do this
is that there's multiple ways of doing
something right uh I can't say that
actions is always the best way of doing
it
um you know some some other ways may be
better than using actions right so uh
you you would never know which one is
better right it comes with probably a
bit of experience and probably a bit of
like gut feeling as well as like what
kind of stylistic how way that you
prefer to write instead of the other
so what I'm going to do today is I'm
going to try something different which
is we're going to approach this by use
writing it as a component a tooltip
component
and then
we will refactor it a bit to convert
that component into an action
and then hopefully by the end of it you
will see like side by side two different
kind of two codes side by side and you
compare yourself whether you prefer the
way of writing it as a component or do
it as action
right so let's go in and take a look
okay to start writing as a component I
will start with a tooltip component
oops sorry
20 plus results
so
um so before I implement this again I
will have to imagine how I would use
this tooltip component right so probably
I would have like a tooltip
um that wraps around
the inner content right so probably I
have over here a tooltip component and
within it is like the hello world
and in a tooltip component probably I
have a props
um called title and that is like this is
a greeting
right so
um tooltip will wrap around this hello
world whatever it is you can have like
multiple divs multiple like all kinds of
different kind of children elements in
it it will wrap around it and then
whenever you hover on those elements it
will show you a tooltip called
uh type the title which is this is a
greeting
so to do this I'm going to start with
having a script that has a props call
Title
probably I just defaulted to empty
string
um
right so this is how this is what we're
being passing in and then we will render
whatever it is as a slot right we'll
call it as a default slot so whatever is
inside the tooltip component will be
rendered in here
and to add event listener probably will
have to wrap around with a div I mean
because
um you can't add a directive on you
can't add event listener to slots like
say on Mouse over
uh
uh yeah you can't so if I import it you
will see the error now
yep you can't have directives on the
tooltip and this is because you know a
slot over here can have can be this text
element can be having can have multiple
divs and all the stuff right you you
wouldn't know like which of these
elements needs to be applied with that
action or you're going to add apply to
all of the elements right
um I mean it's not impossible but it's
not implemented right now so
you know probably you can go and
implement it right so as far as we are
doing right now in uh version 3.31.2
right this is not possible so we will
have to wrap it with a div and
apply that
over here
uh so on Mouse over
and we are going to have a mouse over
event
and then we were going to listen to okay
so we're gonna listen to three different
kind of events one is mouse over so that
we know that um
uh it's hover on on top of it and then
we are going to listen to on Mouse Leaf
so that we know that uh
uh the mouse is left the element itself
so that we need to remove that
um
remove that tooltip right and over here
we are going to have uh based on the
condition which is is Harvard
I'm gonna show a tooltip which we can
style if you want so we're going to call
div and then over here is we're going to
render like the title in here
right
and okay so over here we're gonna Define
all these three because like you know
spell is complaining about them let's
define uh is Harvard
is false by default uh function on mouse
mouse over
gonna set is Harvard
to true
uh Mouse leaf
is Harvard is false
okay and over here we can start a bit on
our
you know this tooltip so what I'm going
to do here is I'm gonna put some border
so that you know that it's there
uh
um position it's gonna be absolute
um and I'm gonna so that you know it
will replace that right where your mouse
is hover on too right
um
yeah I think that's for now uh probably
background would be white
so that you know back back black uh
border white background and yeah maybe
adding some padding as well four pixels
okay so we're done with here I'm gonna
show this a tooltip component
so I'm going to copy this over
title
I'm gonna remove this
I'm going to call tooltip
right so um
wait hold on tooltip and we will remove
this
uh hello world
us uh I have two div over here so let me
re uh let me add a class for this one
called tool tip
so right now the the I have two divs so
it's applied the style to both of the
divs so probably I want to make it more
specific make this a tooltip class and
states right so when I hover and I hover
over you you'll see that this is a
greeting and I remove my mouse on Mouse
Leaf I will hide that tooltip
right so
um this itself can be uh as previously
what we have is a H1 right so we're
going to wrap replace this H1
tooltip now yeah so one thing you
probably notice is that this is always
below the uh wherever we hover on it
always show that it's below
um the elements right because it's it's
written over here like it's right below
it so we have set position is absolute
but we haven't set like the top and left
position so that you know it's it's
always right below the mouse position
the cursor position when we hover over
so I'm going to have Style
over here
and I think I will gonna have two
variables which is one is the X uh
and another would be y
right and over here we Mouse over where
you can take the event and then we can
set like x equals to event dot pitch X
and Y equals event dot pitch why
so what this means is that
[Music]
um
that we have the event object and itself
has like uh some properties like pitch X
and Pitch y will tell us that the X and
Y position within a pitch right so once
we have this we probably see like the
top
uh well based on the X
pixel and
left sorry top should be Y and then left
should be
X pixel
wait and let's see
right it will based on where but once I
move around it it's not showing because
Mouse uh over will only happens when we
move move in right so moving from here
you will see it's here but it starts
there and I come out hidden and move on
here you will see that it's showing here
it Stacks here and yeah right so
um
if I need to move around as my mouse is
moving probably what I need to do is add
a mouse move event right so Mouse move
event
and I can do this I can copy this over
so Mouse move also have a pitch most
move events also have page X and Y so I
can constantly update the accent why so
here what I want to do is I'm going to
have on Mouse move Mouse move
right now when I come in hey let's see
uh it's it's not showing probably
because as uh it's it's constantly
rendering right below my cursor and as
it's showing right below my cursor
um my cursor is now hover on top of uh
that tooltip that's why it's uh
it's it's like a mouse Leaf because it's
leaving from my Hello wall element right
so I can solve that by probably add some
distance like five over here
so that it's not right below my mouse so
when I come in yeah it's always five
from uh five to the right and to the
bottom of like my mouse cursor so yeah
looks good right
so
um probably I'm gonna say now since we
can see the tooltip I'm gonna start it
slightly nicer right not like a
square-ish white background black border
kind of thing I'm gonna probably add
some border radius
4 pixels
um border will probably
um
slightly grayish maybe uh let's see
888 let's see
looks slightly better
or not I probably even like lighter or
say
DDD right slightly lighter and yeah
looks nicer I guess right
so um this will be okay I think last
thing I
I probably would like to have some box
Shadow like one pixel one pixel
pixel DDD
some sort of shadow makes it nicer right
it's like it stands up right so now we
we have this tooltip implemented using a
component
right
um
yeah so this is how you would write it
as a component and as mentioned earlier
we're gonna write it re-implement this
whole thing
as uh
as an action
and let's see how we can do it right so
we're gonna have like a tool tip JS
which is an action an exports function
tooltip
uh so an action is a function that takes
in two parameters and say one is the
elements one is the params and again
before we even start we're going to
decide how we would want to use this
action right I think over here you have
seen how I
Envision how I would be using it will be
use tooltip and you might ask me like do
I need to pass in a title I mean like no
because the title I can get it from the
elements attribute called title and I
don't even have to pass in like you know
as a string over here as a params yeah
no point
um unless you're telling me that this
title can oh can can be changed right so
are you able to dynamically read the
title from this attribute
and if it's not then probably we might
want to pass in dynamically over here so
that you know when it changes it will
inform our tooltip action that it
changes then we'll update the tooltip
contents and
uh in our tooltip right but I think for
now we just assume that it won't change
so
this is clear enough we just use tooltip
and we just read it from these elements
attributes
so
which means that I don't really need a
paramps right and I don't even need
since I don't have param stand I don't
even need a
an update methods because it will never
update because there's no params parents
is always undefined so over here I will
have to
so I have two tips that I use three
events right so I would have to do the
same thing as well I'm gonna listen to
these three events
so I'm gonna say element
elements that add event
listener
then Mouse over
probably Mouse over over here
so I'm gonna be quick Copy all this
come here paste
paste it in
okay and as I mentioned otherwise when
you you add an event listeners in and
action remember remember to remove them
from destroy method so that's what I'm
going to do now first even before I
implements like Mouse over Mouse leaf
and mouse move right remove event
listener remove event listener remove
event listener okay so now I need to
implement Mouse over Mouse move and
mouse leaf
I'm gonna have it over here
um of course uh
I mean variables over here will have no
effects will not be reactive at
whatsoever right
um so what mouse over is going to do is
going to create a div dynamically and
then append to the body and yeah
so I'm gonna have a reference of a div
here because once we created a div when
we leave we're gonna remove it right so
what this means is that we probably will
have to re-implement this Logic the if
logic right so we know that this
Hardware has always been triggered by
the mouse over and it will be true when
it's Mouse over change to True when it's
Mouse over and we change to false when
it's Mouse Leaf so we can simply like
create a div over here
and
create a div and append it
and we can know that we can now receive
that to remove it over here which is uh
sorry which is document
body dot remove child death
which means
um this uh these two lines and this one
line is actually trying to implement
this logic of if it's hover right when
it's hover the if and the is Harbor uh
we are creating a div and it's false and
we remove it
so we can remove these two lines now
so this div right we need to know what
is the tooltip title
so what we can have over here now is um
we're gonna probably
see let's see
okay we are going to read it from here
so div dot Set uh text content
I'm gonna do it all this right before
the append Channel
just that you know we create elements
and
uh update all of it before we just
append it to the body right
um it's just like uh there's no
particular reason why this has to be
this way
um it's just my personal habit so we're
gonna set the text content as element
dot get attribute title
right and
and then over here uh we need the X and
Y position I think div dot style will
need something to do because basically
we don't have this so we're gonna copy
all of it over here and paste it in
and then X and Y which is the top and
left copy these two as well and paste it
right in over here
right so this is a
so X and Y right so probably this can
move it up so that we've defined X and Y
uh I guess probably we just remove
we just paste this whole thing in over
here
right so you now you notice that
manipulating Dom yourself manually is a
bit
it's a bit hard isn't it right if you
can use components use fill to handle
all this for you isn't that great
so here I need to also install the top
uh
I'm gonna update this as well top equals
this plus pixel
I think better to just make it like a
string literal
uh oops okay and this as well
pixel
so div.style dot left
right and I believe that's it so I'm
gonna uncomment this
and I'm gonna import the tooltip
function
from the tooltip.js
and to differentiate this is Hello wall
from action and this is Hello wall from
components let's see uh whoops create
elements a spelling error create element
whoops let's see whoops it's not
creating uh let's see let's see what is
missing position uh
[Music]
okay this is working this is not
let's see
I think we can inspect elements a bit to
help us out
let's see I have a H1 and a div okay
when I hover
it's not adding something isn't it
and does this show any error
it's not showing any error as well as in
okay I'm gonna just not doing anything
on Mouse leaf and
okay
so it's
is it the same area where it's showing
and then it's removing console. Mouse
the leaf
ah I know okay okay so Mouse leaf Mouse
move
ah this is a
kindergarten Mystic and I made it Mouse
leaf
Mouse move right so let's see
this is a greeting
this is a greeting so from actions and
from
components
right
so um if you're gonna ask me whether
which one I'm gonna do and
I mean honestly I I don't want to pass
any judgment over here you can decide
yourself right
um doing it in a
component is slightly more declarative
right you don't have to take care about
creating a div and stuff
um doing it over a tooltip probably will
have to
manually add event listeners manually
create the div and stuff right
um
yeah but then uh one thing that we can
think about here is that
I mean one thing about the component is
that you wrapped the whole slot with a
div right so that is one extra idea
created even your slot will only have
one element but using a tooltip is
different
uh in a way that you will apply it on
that element that you want right you
don't wrap it with any div so one
difference is that probably for example
maybe I have a paragraph over here let's
say hello story something and I want to
have a tooltip right and I'm gonna say
it's from felt right and then you note
as you notice that this is creating in a
new line because it wraps it with a div
but if say I want to wrap it in a span
you know spend
and I use tooltip
okay I'm gonna add title so that you can
see that it's showing something
uh yeah I wouldn't do this as well over
here and you know I came from spelled
and
uh this is inline because you just add
it to the span you can choose to use a
span instead of using a div
well yeah I mean that that is probably
one of the side effects of using
components because of multiple reasons
one is that you can't add event it's not
directly on the slot right now
and probably then you would stay there
oh
maybe I need to you know dynamically
change this div to it depends on whether
I want to spend I want to div you know
uh is there Dynamic elements no there's
no Dynamic elements for now there's only
Dynamic components so uh yeah I can't
can I like choose div or something else
uh yeah that that's like a
uh some limitations that we have using
components right now but you don't have
it with actions but I wouldn't say
action is better because you know
writing this all this is kind of a
hassle but yeah it up to you choosing
yourself right uh there's things that
you can do it better with components
there are things better with actions and
yeah I'm trying to show you side by side
so that you can see it yourself and I
write it this way like we write it from
a component and then I translate the
actions you can see that actually
that component itself handles a lot of
like adding and removing 11 listeners
some decorative way of writing something
and you have to manually manual uh do it
yourself if you write it as an action
all right
um so one last thing that I want to show
you
uh is that you can com kind of com
combine the both of like Goods of the
Both Worlds which is the good of having
components writing it declaratively as
well as having actions created using
connections right so this is one last
trick that I have for you which is now
I'm gonna say tool tip from action just
to differentiate it
and this thing is gonna be just a
tooltip uh
itself so as a script I'm gonna export
let's title
and over here I'm going to use the title
okay and over here I'm gonna have I'm
gonna copy all these things over here
to apply to the style
apply to the diff
and then this one right
p over
Style
um
this wait
let me just remove this I can make it
multiple lines so that it's easier to
read
enter
right and then so this should be X and Y
I'm gonna export let X export that's y
and
I'm not sure whether you're guessing
where I'm going from basically I'm going
to import this x component
tool tip from
tool
tip from action thus Felts
right and I'm gonna use this to render
uh the component for me
meaning I created a div let's see
register even I create a div
yeah I can create a div
and
let's see let's see
oh no I don't even need to create Thief
I can create a let's tooltip
and told hey
tool tip component
so when I say tooltip component equals
new tooltip
and the props will be
title
will be the element get title
and let's see I am
part of me I'm not fairly sure right now
uh sveld component API
hey Paradox create components components
okay options
right when I say oh props and the
targets right so
props they have the title
X would be the event pitch X plus five
over it I think I have plus five over
here so event pitch X
y equals to events page y
and I'm gonna have uh yeah that's it and
targets is the documents.body
and that's it I think
so I can comment all this away
and comment this out
and let's see it works whether it works
it's kind of work right uh it's just
that we didn't remove it uh so
yeah it kind of works
let's see let's see uh this is position
absolute and everything okay it's
correct so next is that we need to
update whenever we must move and we need
to remove when it's not so here I'm
going to say tooltip component
dot destroy right I think it's called
destroy
right yeah
and here I have this uh
I'm going to set a color sets
right I can call this sets which is
uh tool tip
component dot sets
let's say um
left uh no X and Y right x y
so X is the pitch X and Y is the page y
right top is the ah top is the Y and
left is the X
okay so no wonder just now was place it
weirdly now you see it's working
it's working fine
from actions so you can use
um
you can Define it like as a component
and then you can use a spell component
within an action right this way
um you know what I'm going to copy this
over I'm going to say tooltip
tool tip using
V1 right so that uh
uh this file is still around you can oh
this is GS file
right this file is around you can read
it I will send this a rebel in the
description so they can play with it you
can see the three different versions so
I'm going to uncomment all this so that
it's it's around for you to
play around
I yep let me just do it
so this is you use you you do it with
you know iteratively programmatically
create like a div and then you
set elements and attributes and styles
and stuff you manually update it this
way is you utilize a swell component API
you create you create a component using
Felts you create a tooltip like just a
tooltip you can start your very run like
all the you know the uh CSS scoping of
the style class themes and all these
things are there works fine right even
like you see X and Y you can like
declaratively say X and Y which is the
top and left everything works like a
component as you wish and then you
create a new component instance you can
Target anywhere you want probably a body
and then you just update it with sets
API and you can remove it when you
destroy it when you are done with it
right this way you kind of get the
breath of Best of Both walls right so
I'm going to just leave it here for you
to decide what is your prefer way of
writing
let's talk about some examples of using
swell actions and today let's take a
look at one example which is use
viewports
so we're going to write one actions that
will allow us to uh know that whether an
element is has entered the viewports or
has exceeded the viewport
right so probably will be something a
quick and easy and we can take a look at
how we can do that using spelled actions
so um over here we're gonna have uh one
um
uh
header one tag over here
I think I will just name it hello world
simply just remove all this and let's
gonna have this actions called use
viewport
and let's design how this use viewport
actions would work
so I would want this use viewport to be
just like this but when um and then we
by using this viewport probably it will
give me some events like uh like on
enter viewport
and on exit viewport
so having these two actions are two
events and I can listen to it and I can
handle I can do things with it so right
now I'm just gonna print out enter and
[Music]
exit
right
so um if this is the first time you're
watching my video about spell actions
probably you can take a look at this
video on the top right corner where I
talk about how you can create events
using spelled actions
so basically this actions view use
viewports will create two events which
is one is the interview part the other
will be exit viewports whenever my
elements is entering or exiting the
viewport
sorry let me adjust this okay so let's
implement this action
so we're going to create a new file
called view use viewport action dot Js
and I'm going to Define this use uh this
viewport action so the action is a
function
that takes in and two parameters and
elements and the params so in this case
we're not expecting to take in any param
so I'm going to just leave it as element
an issue written an object that has two
methods one is updates one is destroy if
you're not taking any parameters then
you wouldn't expect that the parameters
will be updated so we can ignore the
update methods but implement the destroy
method
right so this function method would be
called whenever the element is destroyed
so we're going to just export default
this action and I'm going to import it
from here
use viewport action.js
right so now we are going to implement
uh the action
right so I'm going to use um
an intersection Observer
to do it for me so probably I can create
and enter section Observer
new intersection Observer
and the Constructor of intersection
Observer should give me uh should be
ticking in and callback function
whenever and any elements that is
observing is enter or exit the viewports
right so this is something I will have
to fill up later on
and the action itself will be this
function will be called whenever this
element is mounted on the screen and at
that time we'll probably want to observe
this element to see whether it's
entering or exiting the viewport and
once this element is removed from the
Dom we probably will want to get tell
the Observer to unobserve this element
right and now let's fill up the Callback
function right so this intersection
Observer takes in a callback function
that will have an entries of element
where each of the elements could be
either entering or exiting the viewport
right so what we need to do is to look
through these entries so for each entry
and in each entry it has two um
properties one is the entry dots is
intersecting
telling us that whether this element is
intersecting which is true if it's
within the viewport or false it's not
within a viewport right and we have
entry.target which is the elements that
um is within this entry
so what we're going to do here is that
we are going to dispatch a custom event
when the element on the element itself
whenever it's intersecting or
depending whether it's intersecting or
not right so I'm gonna call this patch
event over here I'm going to create a
new custom event
right so this event will be depending
whether it's intersecting or not so I'm
going to say I'm going to Define a
variable called event name
and if it's intersecting which means
it's within a viewport I'm gonna
dispatch an event called enter viewports
which is this one right it will copy it
over I'm gonna paste it in here and if
it's X it's not which means that it's
just exiting the view you copy this
which is exit viewport event right so
entries will have only the elements that
has just triggered the intersection
Observer so it's either just entering or
just exiting right uh so that's why uh
whether to know whether it's existing or
enter entering based on this flag and so
that will depends on this slide will
depends on what events that we're
dispatching and I'm going to copy this
event nymph I'm going to paste it in the
custom events
right and I think that's it
that's that's easy right
um so to test it out what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to create some
you know some placeholder elements that
we can push this uh hello wall header
down and then we can scroll up and down
to see where the like the intersection
Observer is being the enter viewport
like exit viewport events being
triggered all right so I'm going to
create div style if it's like
um maybe height of 200 pixels and
background of read
uh
uh I'm gonna copy a few probably just to
know that it's different I'm gonna say
blue and green
go copy a few over this and paste a few
at the bottom as well okay so let's take
a look at the console right uh once at
the first when we adding this
um
use viewport actions the moment that we
start observing probably we need to know
also whether the element is entering or
exiting or is like within or outside of
the viewport so this is when the exit
viewport is being triggered the first
time
right it depends on whether you want it
probably you have to handle it so that
you know whether you are you should be
doing something or not right and as you
scroll
um
once we see that hello was entering the
viewport you see that enter
and then if we scroll Plastics as it
right coming back enter
and exit right yeah that's that's pretty
easy
right I mean that's that's about a use
viewport action
so before we end this I want to add a
few tweaks to my viewpoint actions which
is over here as you can see that we
created an intersection Observer once we
like at the beginning like in the entry
of this module uh what I mean is that
when I import this action whether or not
I'm starting to observe an element uh I
am initializing a new intersection
Observer at the very beginning right so
even I'm not using it at all it's it's
been created right
um I can either create a new
intersection Observer every time for
each of the elements that I'm monitoring
I could use just one instance of it and
I feel like just using one is good
because you know it's designed to
observing multiple elements at the same
time
but I wouldn't want to start
initializing this in the section
Observer uh right at the start right
before I'm observing anything probably
you can see where I'm coming from what I
want is that this intersection Observer
is being lazily initialized so let's do
that right now
so I can Define this intersection
Observer
um
at the very beginning
but I would create another function
called initialize intersection
Observer
which I would initialize it over here
right and there there's a few ways
multiple ways of doing this
uh one is that I can
keep calling this over here many many
times
but within this function I would check
that if it's defined or return early
right another way of doing it would be
not checking it over here but you know
uh if it's not defined then I will
initialize it
right I think either way is fine uh it
depends on how uh how you like to write
it right
um but for me my personal preference is
that if I'm doing if I name my function
called initialize intersection Observer
then probably I will check whether it's
defined first before I initialize it
right it doesn't make sense for me to
call this initialize many many times
because it should be call it once right
but if I want to do it the other way
where I check within itself then uh I in
this case right
um
written then I will call it like Ensure
intersection Observer initialize is
initialized right
so it's just me where I'm particular
about the name of the function that
because it carries some meaning about
how you should use it and yeah this is
this is my
uh pet peeves about names and how it
should behaves right so either way if
it's unsure then yeah you can call it
multiple times and if it's initialized
then you return earlier but it probably
is not even it's initialize just ensure
that intersection Observer right ensure
that it's it's there
uh but if I call it initialize then I
will check if it's initialized first
before I call it
right this way we have our intersection
Observer being lazily initialized so
meaning
um if you don't use uh the intersection
Observer at all uh which means you the
element that has a user viewport is not
mounted at all then it's not initialized
right you are not creating a new
instance that is doing nothing right
that's lying over there and doing
nothing
let's talk about some examples using
sveld actions and today I'm going to
talk about one example which is I'm
using swell actions to integrate with
this UI Library called popper.js
why am I talking about popular.js in
specific well um the last time when I
wake up did this video about using swell
actions to create tooltip
um someone commented on Reddit about
about if you want to use proper GS which
allows you to create Dynamic tooltip
that overflows and I click in to look at
the implementation of the svelt proper
JS by Brian Lee and I find that it's
pretty interesting you can take a look
at it if you want but we're gonna do it
on ourselves uh why is it so interesting
is that if you take a look at the proper
GS API you import a create popper from
proper JS core
and you pass two elements in this proper
JS API which is the one is the
uh the tooltip uh the the elements and
then the second one will be the tooltip
right so you wrap this API you call this
API with two elements and remember when
we use actions we only use
we're going to apply it on one element
so what if you want to apply it to two
elements like this proper JS and how
would you do it and that is what we are
going to try it out in this example
right so over here I have my ripple open
up let me split it on half so that you
know okay look it side by side
what we're going to do here is I'm going
to copy this whole chunk of code over
here and I'm going to create use popper
uh dot Js
which we're gonna export an action
called use popper
and an action is a function that takes
in an element
and a paramps and it returns uh and it
could return an object that has like
updates and destroy
and over here we're going to import the
proper JS which we're going to take in
um
if you call create popper we need to
take in two elements right one is the uh
the elements and the other one is the
tooltip
right and probably we also need to copy
this which is the placement on top
right so now we have a problem right
where do we get tooltip right if you use
use popper with this element
um
how do you get the tooltip or whether
it's these elements the tooltip but not
the elements
um yeah so the thing is you can only
apply an action to one element and how
are we going to
do that if
if your API requires two elements right
so this is something we're going to
explore now but in the meantime I'm
going to say div and then use use pop
use proper
right
I'm going to add some words over here
uh hello world
right so tooltip is undefined so how do
we do it
so um let's think about how you want our
API to look like
so let's imagine our API
so if this is the elements that when we
hover will show a tooltip then we
probably will also have another element
which is the tool tip itself
right and
we would also want to apply some sort of
actions over here
right so that probably this is like
proper tooltip and this is the proper
element
in such the way that you know uh this is
the elements that when we hover there
will show two tip and this is the
tooltip itself and so that we can get
two elements and then apply the action
to it
so if we're going to have two elements
two actions that are in a pair
why don't we create a function that
returns these two this pair of action
what if we have a function that looks
like this
um probably
it returns an array of actions a way of
two actions so the array of contains two
elements first is the action for the
elements and then the next would be the
action for the tooltip
and probably here I will call something
like a create popper
action
so probably here we will have a great
proper action
and go level
so probably here we will have the great
proper action
and that will return us two actions and
these two actions should work in a pair
where once the action is applied on both
elements we get both elements only we
call this create proper API from the
proper JS core
and so let's take a look how we can
implement this right so now we have
imagine our API
let's come back over here and think
about how you can write this we will
have a create proper function so I'm
going to say a function called create
proper action and it should return us an
array of two action
right the first action is called the use
proper element
so use proper element
and the next action is called the use
proper tooltip
right use proper tooltip
and these tools are these two are
actions so they both text elements and
params
which um in our case probably we're just
gonna ignore the problems for now and
you're gonna return these two action
over here
so these two should works like a pair
um
and we'll take a look at how we're going
to implement this right so this we're
gonna make it as our default exports so
we're gonna remove whatever is here
and we're gonna call this uh create
proper action for the use popper
right so now let's come back to the use
popper let's open up a bit over here
we are going to call this function uh
this action will be called when the
proper element is mounted but at that
time the tooltip element may not be
mounted right so we want to have like a
reference somewhere like the proper
element and the proper tooltip
and we're gonna assign this
um
elements
whenever the element itself is mounted
so we're gonna say this is this and this
is sorry this element
and because doing so we will now
probably want to have a function that is
the actual grid popper
uh I'm gonna say initialize popper so
because create popper is here already so
initialize proper
so this function uh will be called in
both actions so we don't care about
which uh order of like proper element is
defined or proper tooltip is defined but
we're gonna call it call it on both
sides and we only do our thing when both
proper elements and proper tool tape is
ready right so if this function is
called first then proper element may be
ready but it may not or if this is
called First and proper tool tip is
ready but proper element is not so
only the second time when we call
initialize proper after in both actions
where the proper both element and the
tooltip is ready so we're going to say
popper element
and proper tool tip
is ready what I call the create popper
uh
API
right
let's see here
let's see process is not defined ah I
believe this property.js core itself is
using some imp process
environment what I can do as a hack here
is that Define process
JS let's say um go window dot process
equals to F production
okay and
no
so this is ignore me this is going to be
a hack uh
and we're gonna import this Define
process first
yep
so yeah probably let me explain a bit on
this hack basically we're going to
Define process as the global variable
which is the nth node nth is production
because I know that in some Library they
like to assess a
process.f.node f as they assume that
this is being imported uh in node.js as
well as your
bundlers like webpack or roll up
understand this process.nf but not in
the browser right so we're going to
Define this right before we import our
use proper which Imports this proper JS
which itself is using that process so
now as you can see this is showing up
over here
I believe this is working let's see
placement uh top end
um
would it be because the hello world is
gonna okay how about let's try bottom
starts
uh pot placement
bottom starts
right ah yeah so probably the default
placement is over that right corner now
it's bottom starts so this is
the placements and all the power arms
probably we would also want to pass it
in somewhere we can decide whether we
want to pass it in the proper element or
proper tooltip but decide only one
because you know what happens if you
pass two conflicting problems on both
sides I'm going to reconcile that so I
probably would want to pass it in the
tooltip element because it feels like
it's a tooltip related power ramps so
over here we're going to say proper
params equals to Prime Rams
so I'm going to Define this over here
and I'm going to replace it over here
right so after replace it I'll probably
have to pass it myself so it's at the
proper two tip I'm gonna say um equals
to placement bottom starts
and now it's back to the bottom start
again right so if you are curious why is
there two curly braces well the first
outside most the outermost curling
brackets is just telling that this is
what is within is an expression and the
one inside is just like an object
right so the expression is an object so
we say use proper tooltip and we have
params and over here we do popular dot
equals params right that means that
we're accepting prompts here we also
need to prepare to be prepared that you
know there will be an update whenever
you're using that params be sure that
you also Define and updates methods
because
params itself can change
right if you don't have it over here
then yeah we don't have to care about
but if you are taking problems here yes
please define new params let's see
proper dot params equals the new params
by the same time we would also want to
like changing it this alone wouldn't
affect the proper here so probably would
have to have to look up and the proper
API documentation to see whether how we
are going to update the params so I'm
gonna say prop I'm gonna guess probably
it's in over here create popper
and see let's see
instance
updates set options
I would believe this is the options
right so set options
takes in an option
write a shape of options right so
probably is this one I'm gonna
come over here and say uh
popper
dot set options with each the proper
params
but what is proper well proper will be
this instance of after you create a
popper right so I'm gonna come over here
and say popper equals to create popper
lead popper
right so now if you okay see let's let's
try and see it's a buttons
uh let's create let's make placement
uh variable
I'm gonna say it starts I'm gonna
replace this placement over here
and I'm gonna have a button that
click me
that when I click
we change the placement to say
let's see
what other placement you have on the
right all right let's let's try on the
right
equals right
so when I click yeah it's on the right
right
okay it works right so make sure when
you're taking the pumps please be sure
that you also Define updates so that it
it it feels good where it's you can
dynamically change whatever is inside
the params and see it reflected
immediately right if you don't have
updates defines then it will not update
itself
so um as you can see over here
um when we're looking at the apis we
also see a destroy which is to clean up
the instance which means that whenever
an API provides a way to clean up we
also need to do our own cleanup
which is over here we will have to
define the destroy
to do a cleanup
and
[Music]
so if proper
uh okay because we can destroy this
tooltip as well as this proper element
so I'm gonna extract that method out
um just like how we say initialize
proper right so when I say uh destroy
popper
uh over here I'm gonna I would copy the
same thing as well over here
and then
um also once we are destroying then
probably will say proper tool tip is now
and over here we're going to say proper
element is now
so that you know we don't hold the same
reference against uh we release the
reference from from this action pair and
Destroy popper let's define this
function destroy proper and I'm gonna
say if you still have popper
then popper
dot destroy
and we also
you know popper equals null so that's if
you call destroy multiple times it's
it's not going to call the destroy API
anymore
so how do we validate this so probably
we have um
show tooltip as a variable uh we're
gonna say True by default
I'm gonna come here and I'm gonna
uh probably have the tooltip as you know
down in place shown whether this show
tooltip is
is true or false right and to the
easiest way to check uh true false is to
have a checkbox
uh buy and check
equals to a show tooltip
so when we turn it off
tooltip should be hidden and we turn it
on it should show and height show and
height
and we say click me which change the
placement to the right and we show it
should be on the right right
so that's about it we we have shown I've
shown you how you can uh integrate the
proper JS using action and in this case
why is it so special is that popular.js
Library uh takes in two elements and
usually an action is only taken one so
you would have to create an action pair
in this case where you have two actions
and they have to work together to to
create the proper tooltip right and so
as I said you can return an array of two
actions and to coordinate between the
actions you would have to kind of
abstract like the initialization or
destroy function where you would have to
check in during initialization is to
check whether if both elements are
present only you create the proper and
when you destroy make sure that as long
as one is being called you will destroy
it once and you don't destroy multiple
times because you know both elements can
be hidden at the same time you only
destroyed once
right and then
um
also when you have two actions that
potentially can take in params you have
to decide which action to take in params
or you or you or you kind of like split
into some params to be configured on the
one action and some to the other or you
just make all problems to be configured
on only one action well this this is
because it will be slightly harder if
you want to reconcile the pumps you know
what if both actions params one says
that you need to place on the right one
says you need to place on the left you
need to come away to reconcile that and
in either case I don't feel it makes
sense you know like why must tooltip
takes priority than the proper elements
right so an easier way is to say proper
element will not take any params and
proper tooltip will take all the params
and once you're taking params make sure
that you have an updates methods so that
you can make sure your parents is
dynamically reflect uh the library under
the hood right so that's about it
so in the last video we talked about how
we Implement uh use viewports and this
video we're going to talk about how we
can use that and to implement a use lazy
image basically it's an action that
allows you to lazily load your image
only when the image is within the
viewports that's why we're going to use
the use viewports over here
so let's take a look at the code
so this is uh continuing what we had
done so far we has we have a H1 that has
used viewports and if you scroll you'll
see that when it's enter it's it will
cancel out enter and when it exits you
will say exit
right so I'm going to reuse this I'm
going to firstly create an action called
use uh I'm gonna lazy image action
so action is nothing but a function
I'm gonna say lazy image default
that takes in parameter which is
elements and optionally params if you
provide if you are allowing people to
provide parameters to the action
and okay so this is your action and we
import this okay import lazy image from
lazy image
over here and we are going to use our
lazy image action to replace this H1 so
I'm gonna have an image tag
I'm gonna say I use lazy image
and I'm gonna remove this so now I need
an image okay I'll take I'm gonna say uh
lazy image demo
I need an image so
um let's see
let's probably let's steal this image
over here I'm gonna inspect
and it says oh hold on
says a background image you're gonna
copy this over here
um so let's collapse this
so I'm going to use Source equals to
spell dot def slash spell logo dot
horizontal SVG probably needs to add the
https over here
so if I scroll this you'll see that the
image is already in the screen
and if I inspect the elements and take a
look at the network tab
so let's clear everything let's let's
collapse everything unused let's only
focus on the image tag filter with SVG
um let's refresh
and see that the image is loaded
immediately
and if I scroll up and I refresh you can
see that the image is still loaded
immediately
right
immediately and what we want to do here
is that we want to prevent this we want
to we want the image to only load when
we scroll until we see the image is
within the viewport
so what we can do here is that instead
of using the source attribute which will
lets the browser to load the image
immediately what we can do is we can
rename it to data source right so
um it's just like random other
attributes but over here I just use I
use the data attributes custom data
attributes here
uh it can be data Dash anything that you
like but I'm going to call it data
source so if I refresh this again
you'll see that the image is not loaded
which is good and if you scroll down you
see that the image is not showing it's
not loading so what are we going to do
so let's come back to Lazy image action
and let's try and implement this
so uh we have implemented
um use viewport action that uses
intersection Observer to know whether
the element is entering or removing
leaving the screen so why not reuse this
logic over here
and we use this actually we can reuse
the action itself so action is nothing
again is nothing but a function that
takes in the elements and optionally in
params and it could returns us an object
like destroy with a destroy method or
updates method so to use an action
outside of svelt what you can do here is
you can call it yourself so let's see
let's import viewports from use viewport
action
what I mean is that you can call this
viewport action
rename this
Yarns
right you can do that
um
you can do this and it should work
because it's nothing but a function
and he returns us
um I'm gonna say uh action methods
viewport action methods it returns us an
object
and this object has a destroy and
updates methods so if we are going to
destroy these elements which we'll call
the digital method of this lazy image we
should also call the destroy of the
inner action as well so that is what I'm
going to do now let us come here and
destroy
I'm gonna call viewport action methods
dot destroy as well
all right so this will cleanse up
whatever is called set up when we call
the action right so if if you have
something like an update and it's
relevant to your action then probably
you can also call like dot par update
with the new params
right so probably over here you have a
paramps and you can pass it in and if
something updated you can call updates
method of that
viewport action methods as well but in
our case we don't have it our viewport
actions
does not take any problems that does not
return us any updates so we're gonna
remove this
remove this revert this okay right
so once you use the viewport action
remember what happens you have two new
custom events right the enter viewport
and exit viewports and what we're going
to focus now is just the enter viewport
because when we enter the viewport we
want to load the image
so we can
elements.at event listener
call enter viewports and then we're
going to have enter viewport
event listener right and every time when
you add an event listeners in your
action you need to remember to remove
events listener over here
okay so let's see and the Viewpoint now
defines so let's define enter viewports
okay so what are we going to do when we
enters the viewports right
um over here the element is an image tag
and we can get the source of the image
that is supposed to be the actual Source
in the data source right so we can
basically get
elements.datorsets.source which is this
the value over here
and what we do we can do is we're gonna
set the source of the image
to this value
right so when we enter we're going to
set it to to this value right so let's
let's refresh this let's clean this
come over here
let's do a refresh okay you can see that
there's no image being loaded and when I
scroll
and as soon as the image comes into
viewports you see that it's being loaded
and the image is being downloaded you
can see it it's reflected in the network
Tab and why is it two entries over here
well it's basically because one let's
see not quite sure why
um
but I think that's
besides the point
so uh
over here
um
let's see one thing we need to do also
once our image is loaded we probably
wouldn't want to kind of load the image
again so what we can do over here is
also to remove event listener over here
so once it's done we can remove the
enter viewport listener so we don't care
about whether it's entering reports
anymore and
yeah that's that's about it that's how
you would Implement a lazy image using a
viewport action right so what you have
learned so far is you can use an action
to compose an action within another
action right so if you have multiple
actions and probably you can use that to
compose it right so here you have it
lazy image using actions
I want to talk about
Ensemble actions so what is Ensemble
actions well as you can see if you
Google around you probably couldn't find
this because this is a makeup word for
uh patterns that I found arising in
creating a few actions and I find that I
need something I need an actions that I
can apply to a group of elements and I
want to apply an action to them together
right so I have an action so usually
actions is applied to one uh per element
basis where you just interact with one
elements but sometimes I want these
actions to be interacting with a group
of elements that apply this action
so it's not applying to all the elements
you can group different elements
together with one actions and so we're
gonna look at some examples about this
right I come up with three examples as
you can see over here in the rebel and I
would I will go through with you in
detail in the first example right so
we're gonna see how I transform
something into that an ensemble actions
and we're gonna take a look at example
two and three which I already come off
with that actions so for the example one
uh over here you can see I'm use showing
example one example one is like this I
have two box
that I have enabled Dragon top drop so I
can basically drag an items into the box
and then you will see that it shows up
whatever I'm dropping into so I can drop
into the box 2 as well but
I can't drop a into box two
well uh so so there's a limitation of
like I can only drop A and B in drop uh
in box one but not C and I can only drop
B and C but not a in the Box too
right so this is a very contrived
example but I want I I purposely
designed this so that you can show you
can see one coming over here right so
over here I use a drag and drop API
I use on drop and drag over event
listeners for for different boxes and
then for each of the ABC I add draggable
and on drag starts and on drag n
and as you can see because of the I want
the first bug to only receive a and b
but not C and second box for only B and
C but not a what I have to do is that my
on drop will have to be I I can't reuse
the same on drop actually I can't use
the same on drag over because on drag
over I I checked for a flag whether I
can drop it if I can then I'll prevent
default I will prevent the default
behavior of the browser which is to
prevent all drag and drop
so uh so because of that I have to have
two different kind of event listeners uh
checking different flags
and for the on drop I have to use a
different event listeners again because
I am going to call uh I'm gonna append
the drop the data to a different Drop
Zone string so this string is going to
be shown over here
so
um if you have watched my previous video
about how to reuse event listeners with
action you can even immediately see that
uh I have defined a lot of actions over
here and probably I can reuse event
listeners and create a new event out of
it
um same thing goes with the drag up
draggable uh token the circles A and B
and C
um but then I also want to incorporate
this logic of what can be dragged into a
certain Drop Zone I I don't want to just
apply this draggable on all of them and
then
proof I can drag and drop all of
elements into all the Drop Zones right I
want to have
like I want to scope
um certain items to be only drag dropped
into a certain Drop Zone so so that we
shall explore how I'm gonna do this so
I'm gonna come over here and create
example
three final
okay so this is the end result
and the main point mean time I'm gonna
copy example one oh sorry example one
final no example three so I'm gonna
paste it in
and we are going to use the example one
final instead
and so I'm going to keep this example
one for you in the meantime I'm gonna
change this example one final
so uh let's imagine how I would want the
end result to look like
so let me collapse everything so that
it's cleaner for us to
explore imaginations
so I'm going to come over here and this
is how I would imagine instead I would
want to have a function uh function I'm
going to call it get drag
and drop actions
so you see it's not an action but it's a
function that creates an action so this
function hopefully I gives me a pair of
uh drop uh drag and drop action so
hopefully these two are actions so I can
have two different pairs of this drag
and drop action so I'm going to call
drag one uh drag two drop one and drop
two
so if this two pairs I can come over
here and okay so so the first drop zone
I'm gonna use drop one
and for the second one I would use drop
two
and now I'm gonna come over here for the
draggable part I say A and B I can drag
from am so for the drop zone one I can
only drag from A and B so I'm gonna use
drag one for this two
and for B and C uh for the drop zone do
I can drop B and C right so I can come
over here and then use drag two
okay so as you can see it's it's quite
clean I have dropped one use drag one
and use drag one drop two use drag two
and use drag two over here
so this is the end result that I would
once my actions to look like
um so of course you say uh drop one what
does it what happens if you dropped yeah
then I would have probably a custom
events as dispatch right if you don't
know how to do how to create a event
using actions you can watch my video
links in the description
so probably I will with this drop one
action I will create a new
um
new actions I called it uh on receive
drag data
so on receive direct data
oops so for here I can have my event
handler I'm gonna inline this uh by
saying uh
dragzone Drop Zone one plus equals event
dot detail so hopefully the string that
is carried over from the drag one and
drag two will be in the events detail I
will be received from the drop one event
and then receive as event or detail so
I'm going to come over here and copy the
same thing over as well but change it to
drop zone 2.
so this is how you're gonna look like
and maybe I can change this as well so
previously I'm just use a
when I start dragging I use the inner
text as the data that pass into the drag
and drop API data transfer
but over here maybe since I'm using
actions probably I can pass this data in
for my action so then this data can be
dynamic as well uh as you if you change
the data and then I can change my
I can change my poweramps over here
hopefully by now you should able to know
how to
um
updates these poweramps to your action
so
um if you are adventurous enough you can
pause over here and try to implement
this pair of actions yourself
if not I'm going to continue over here
so I'm going to Define this get drag and
drop actions so I'm going to come over
here say function get drag and drop
functions so I'm going to Define two
actions right so the first one is called
the drag action
and the second one is called
the drop action
so you may ask me like why is it
returning it as an array and you do this
um I think since
react comes up with the hooks pattern
hooks API a lot of us realize that
actually we can return an array of
results and then you and then you can
destructuring using array destructuring
right we all know that but then this is
one good way that we can return
something without enforcing the
the name of the thing that we are going
to return a lot of times if we are
coming you're going to use this multiple
times then you kind of have to think out
of a name to rename it right so if I
gonna return uh drag and drop as an
object then because I'm gonna use this
twice I would have to manually rename it
like come and drag drag one and drop
equals to drop one and do the same thing
for drag two and drag drop two
but if I know by convention by Design I
say that okay this will only always
return two items or maybe one or three
items okay not one but two or three like
a fixed number of items I think the best
number is two at most three
then since it's
only three items and I design in a way
that maybe for some convention there's
always a pattern on in terms of the
position of the items they're gonna
return
then I can say that I'm going to return
it as an array
so you can come up with your own name
without having to destructure in this
structure at the same time rename it
so I don't force whatever name that you
want you can come up with drag one drop
one or blah blah blah one and blah blah
two right so it's up to you
so here I have my functions and I'm
going to return it so these two are
actions so remember actions is a
function and function that takes in a
note and a paramps so I'm going to come
over here and do this two for now
and now so I need to incorporate some of
this logic uh so for the drag uh
previously when I have drag I have set
the draggable to true and on Drexel and
on drag and so I'm going to copy this
and come over here
and whoops and Define it
right I'm gonna Define this too so first
thing is note dot draggable equals to
True okay that's settle
and then I am going to say
hold on let me check my notes
I'm not sure whether I can pass it as a
string but let's just try as a as a
Boolean and then I'm gonna add um two
event listeners right on dragstart and
on drag n so instead of writing it I'm
going to copy
um come over here and drag start drag
and
so previously we have a custom
um
Logics over here that says a what can be
dropped right so right now since we're
returning as a pair we don't have to
come up with this custom logic we just
need to say Define a variable here can
drop
it goes to false and can turn this flag
on so anytime when we are
dragging anything it should always turn
on as true
so this flag is going to be used on a
drop right so I'm going to use the same
flag in my drop event so that so that's
why I'm Define it outside of the drag so
that the drop can use it as well so as
long as this flag is turned on then I am
I am open to receive this data coming in
so okay then on drag and I need to set
reset it back to false
okay and then the data instead of
reading from text since we're in passing
as params this is going to become over
here
and I think that's it so I am going to
add event listeners
uh drag start
and then on drag start
and do the same thing for on drag n as
well
and then
if I'm adding event listeners I need to
be a good citizen I need to remember to
remove it when during this drawing so
I'm going to come over here copy these
two lines paste it in
oops
and then replace it with remove event
listener
and one thing I need to do also is I
need to make sure that I can updates my
program if it's Dynamic so this will be
the new Power ramps
so uh I think name it to be the contents
is better so data right this is a data
that we are passing in so this will be
the new data
and I just need to update this as the
new data over here
so this will always get the latest data
okay I think that's that's great for the
first action so I'm going to remove this
sounds good okay now let's focus on the
second action the drop
oops so I can come over here and let's
see
okay hold on this
I need to be a string
okay so I'm gonna come over here for the
drop I am going to copy the drop
handlers over here
okay so for the drop action
I'm gonna do this too right on drop and
on drag over so in drag over you so
let's let's copy these two events
listener
uh okay just copy these two so on the
drag on drop is to handle when this is
being dropped I'll do what happens and
then on drag over is to handle the time
where
should I prevent default which is if I
prevent defaults which means not the
browser default Behavior which means you
allow uh people do drag over this item
right the default behavior from browser
is to prevent anything
so I come over here and I said dot on
drop
uh event and then I'm gonna get the data
out of it so this drop event I I don't
have to do this handle it myself I can
come over here and dispatch a new custom
event new custom event
and I'm gonna call it
receive drag data
and for the data that I'm going to pass
in for my custom event will have this
detail called the data
okay
and on Direct over
what I need to do is I need to check the
flag to see whether this is turned on
which is only when I'm dragging anything
that is covered by this drag action only
them can be dropped into my drop zone
and check this flag if it's true then I
event different defaults allow the
dragging over and I think that's it so
I'm gonna add event listeners again so
note that at events listeners
drop and then on drop
note that at event
drag over on drag over and by now you
should know what I'm gonna say be a good
citizens remember every time when you
add events listener you need to do
destroy to remove them so copy this to
come over here
replace the ad to remove
oops
and I think that's it so let's remove
this and let's Okay add event this there
a listener not listeners listen there
okay I think that's it's it's good now
and let's try
so okay I can remove anything that we
don't need anymore so on drop one all
these functions can be removed even this
flag can be removed okay so we have this
get drag and drop actions probably you
would you if you want to reuse across
multiple components you can move this
into a file and you can create it you
can call this outside of swell component
as well and then pass this drag one into
um one of the components in any
components that you want to drag and
then drop one the drop pair into any
other components you want so you can
doesn't have to use these two pairs in
the same components you can pass it to
multiple components as soon as they come
with so that's the beauty of coming as a
pair you can control where uh you can
control what are the pairs and then use
it as a group all right so they together
these two actions and because they come
as a pair the internally they are sort
of like linked they and then all these
actions all the elements that apply with
these actions works together to achieve
one effect therefore I call it the
Ensemble actions
so does it work let's try it out
let's come come over here and I'm gonna
drag okay it looks draggable go over and
drop a drag drop B
yeah I can't drop C okay let's look at
the second I drag a okay I can't drop it
that's good I can drop B and can drop C
well that's that's great we've achieved
it I will achieve a Ensemble actions a
group of actions you can be one actions
or multiple actions but they are and
they can apply to on a list of elements
a group of elements and these elements
apply with these actions works together
in a in an ensemble manner so I come up
with a few other
um
examples it may be some contrived but
let's take a look at them
so let's take a look at the example two
so example two is what I call a Mac
update action
so um this action again it returns of
action
this function returns an action and this
action I can apply to multiple elements
and they worked together so what this
does is that this function over here uh
I call before updates within this
function right I can call this because I
call this function immediately within
the component initialization so it still
knows that I'm initializing this
component so it register a callback
function for this component what I
purposely call it inside this function
so that it has a scoped it receives the
same scope as the action that I'm going
to create later on so I'm create this
action
so this action what it does is that
every time when you use this action I'm
going to add and the element that is
applied to into a set over here
and when I destroy it and I'll remove it
from a sense
so anytime when there's an update I'm
going to come over here and iterate
through the list of elements that
applies this action and add an outline
color read to them so every time I
change online color read and great thing
about this is I can't uh instead of use
it over here I can
call it I can I can call this function
so say uh I'm gonna name it first get
Mark updates
right and I can call this function
immediately in my gets default right so
what this means is I can oh hold on I
can't ah I can't do it can't do it over
here because I have to call before
updates well well that's that's a that's
that's it but
um I can't figure a way to pass this
Mark update function around right so if
I come over here and say
let's see
let's let's think of our work around
over here I'm gonna pass this Mac
updates in do okay and then design
something very ugly but just for the
moment just for demonstration purpose
design function called sets mark the
so I'm going to create a pair of get and
center and I'm gonna come over here Mac
updates
so return this
and so bear with me this is this is ugly
this is not what you're gonna do but
this is just for me to demonstrate that
I can come over here check mark update
and pass this action in
so for the sake of demonstrating that
this a
this thing works this actions that
you're gonna see what works in a pair
I'm going to come over here and okay I'm
gonna come over here an app over here
and I'm gonna import that actions
and I am going to
use it so see whether it works come over
here get Mark updates
okay Mark Updates this should give me an
action
and then come over here diffuse action
uh
okay so probably there's a risk
condition where basically this get my
updates
uh this this registration
this this initialization calls after my
app thoughts felt after right that's why
this is not set yet so probably I can
come over here uh action
all right I'm gonna say this is even
uglier and I would I imagine I didn't
prepare this ahead of time but let's see
whether this works uh I'm gonna say on
Mount
so by default is a no function so I'm
going to say a function that does
nothing
but then I'm going to change my action
let's see
hey there's whoops I don't think it
works I think it works this way uh
action itself is
um not
reactive at all
um
well I can come out again another
weird idea they're gonna compose an
action right so
sorry for this I didn't plan this but
let's come up with a new uh an action an
actual action over here
and my action what I will do is I am
going to
ah I don't think that works sorry
so um
let's grab this but I think one is point
out this
this I can't point it out if it does not
work well I can okay I know I want to do
when come over here example four
I am going to pass that function in
script okay export
let's
action
and I'm gonna come over here I have a
div full
use this action all right I'm going to
pass this action in
uh
okay I don't need all this
I don't need all this crap
I'm gonna import example for
well it's not an example the stricter
stance it's just a sub component I'm
gonna come over here action it goes to
mark update so I'm passing this action
in as you can see now it applies the
same action and if I come over here and
do this update right this will
turns the ball outline of this will turn
into red as well
um there's nothing relates to them they
are not the only thing that relates to
them is they are applying the same
actions so all the elements apply the
same actions they have the same behavior
or they form together to form one
behavior and therefore I'm going to call
it Ensemble actions I can call this name
again and again so that it will be a
real name uh when everyone anyone tries
to refer this next time
all right so
last example example three I'm gonna
come over here change it to example
three
this example three is again contrived
but I want to show you something
uh again the idea is the same
I am going to a
uh create I'm gonna apply this action uh
stats I'm gonna have again have a
function that returns me an action so
why oh what so you you I guess you kind
of slowly see this pattern where on
simple actions you have to have a
factory function that creates this
action you have to have a function that
creates this action because whatever
this function is this function is always
to be created anew and
and only the function so this function
itself is unique and if you apply it to
a few like so so that when you apply to
these elements they work together right
it's slightly different where you you
already Define a function all the
function is the same function going to
apply for all the elements
yes they can still works together right
but this has slightly different sense
where you always come up with a new
function and this new function so so you
can apply this function to a group of
elements so you can have multiple groups
of elements applied to this same action
that has a similar
Behavior but then they are grouped
together they are only formed in smaller
groups because each groups use this one
unique actions that was created for them
you can create three if you have three
groups you create three actions that
logically they are the same but because
of the scoping that you you do because
of the closure sorry not scoping but
because of the closure it it stores this
growth elements in that closure so the
the behavior happens together in that
way
so over here I have again I create a
stat actions and this um
I got applied to all the items so one
thing interesting is I can actually uh
this stats action is not an actual
actionation experience object so if you
come over here and look at the code I am
actually returning an object
and one of the property contains that
action itself right this is the action
and this object can also have more
methods where I can use these methods to
control my elements that apply this
action so I have more
x uh
I have more methods over here from this
action so I can actually apply an action
uh this way where I use and then colon
and then together action I go to call
object dot actions right so you can
actually it doesn't have to be just a
function you can be a method or yeah in
this case actually a method right
because you define action on the object
itself so it can be in a method so it
can be a yeah and so I get past
something some information to this
action
and over here whenever I change I have a
different I does something like I do a
toggle what it does is that it will call
this object dot get all the elements
that has a value less than 20 and change
the background to Red so if I toggle on
and see all of them turn rates and
toggle off back to normal you can
Shuffle again and this way and just
demonstrate that this item data
can be dynamic and again uh I so because
it has can be dynamic I'm gonna up when
I during the update I'm gonna update uh
what other elements that is less than 20
or something after the sets things like
that right like I could have uh done it
within this function as well instead so
I can have a set of all the elements and
then only filter out filter them out and
get less than 20 or I can do it
um during the update as well so up to
you
so I shuffle Shuffle and then toggle we
can see it it's updating all right of
course this has a glitch in this example
if you
haven't spotted let me show it to you so
I can I can toggle it on and then I can
Shuffle so whenever I shuffle uh I am
not going to call this reactive
statement again because a shuffle does
not change this variable nor this
variable so it's not run again and
therefore uh I couldn't like go in and
highlight the elements uh that uh that
is less than 20 to be read right so this
is not highlighted rate and the rest
also not being removed background color
because I only take care of the element
that is less than 20 right so if I
toggle on and off on Tech cast items S7
and 20. well there's a bug on this but
yeah I'm just trying to show you how you
could do uh with an ensemble action but
yeah I didn't really bother to fix this
Behavior Uh well if you if you're
interested you can come up with
something else uh refine it to be better
but I yeah so uh Ensemble actions
you've seen three examples and
so Ensemble actions again is an action
that applies to a sample of elements and
because they apply to the same actions
the works together to create one
Behavior
So today we're going to talk about
slots
so what is slots
well slot is a way for us to compose
components
what what is compose components well
um in in a HTML Dom elements you can
have other elements within your Dom
elements right you can have a span
element within a div element
and you can do the same thing for
components as well you can have other
components or other elements within your
components
and
well let's take a look at one example
and you'll know okay so here I have
prepared an example where I have created
a component called component
right and I'm going to use it over here
so if I said earlier
uh within a div you can have other
things like text and spend right and
spend element and inside components you
can have same thing as well so I can
come over here within components I can
paste other things within over here
but how would you how how does this
elements that you created like you
insert it over here gonna be used within
a component
well
over here I have a component where the
content of component is like components
right so where where do I place in the
hello world over here within the
component
um well you can decide your own
you can decide within this component you
can decide where this uh if if the user
of this component provides something as
like so-called like a children within my
component then where will the content be
go to where will the component be
inserted into
and you can specify that using a slot
so if you guys come over here say slots
over here component and Slot then you
can see that it's slotted after my the
text call component if I put it in front
then you can see that hello world
component is slotted in front right
wherever so depends on where you have a
slot then there it is where where it is
being slotted into and you can actually
have multiple of this right so
slot is it's like a place where you can
insert the content into and you can have
multiple of them
if you like to
and if you have other other Logics
within our components say for example
I'm going to create a variable called
show
which will be which you can toggle it on
and off using a checkbox
then I with if it is true right if show
is true
I show a slot
if it's not I will hide it
okay so
um over here if you see if I show I will
show the slot if not I'll hide it this
way if I turn on you will see the slot
if I turn it off you'll be hidden so
this so within a component you can
control how you want any contents that
is being passed within a component
inside your components right you can so
all this uh what what whatever things is
passing over here you can control from
within a component so that you know that
where it will be slotted into and you
use this special element called slot to
decide that
and just so that you know that uh
elements over here is is nothing but
like a normal elements that you can
expect that you can write within this
app.s felt I'm going to create a
variable called count equals to zero
and I can show this value over here
count
show the same value over here as well
and I can have a button over here
to
Maybe
increments the count
and have another button over here to say
decremented all right so this is
decrement
this is to increment
so if I show this component if I click
increments you can see that this this is
just like uh other uh just like a normal
Expressions that you can write within
this M plus felt got nothing to do with
this component this component just says
that where you're going to slot my
content in right if I hide there's no
way to study in that that'll be it if
you unhide you should say that okay here
you're going to be sliding then yes
you're gonna slide it in right but then
the data inside the expressions or
whatever you have inside is still be
treated like you are rating them within
this emboss felt you can increment you
can decrement them
and remember when I talked about
um scope Styles scope CSS I say that
when you have when you write Styles
within a component say for example if I
say button where the button font size is
say 42px it affects all the buttons
within this component file right it
affects everything within the file so
you have one button over here and one
button over here they'll be both
affected
this is not depends on whether this
button is you know kind of like placed
inside somewhere within a com this
component does not matter the only thing
that matters is that this button is
written within this file then your style
uh your scope style will be effect to
all to the button itself
so now you have a slot and you have
components and you can insert content
inside
so what if uh what if your slots on the
other hand
does not have any content which is
so over here you write slot to say that
okay if if you have anything within a
component you could just slot it in
right what if you create another
component like this
and you close it immediately so that
there's nothing inside then what happens
then right so this is the first one
you see you slot the content in this is
the second one you slot nothing in right
of course you've slot nothing in there
there's nothing but what if there's
nothing and you want to show like a
fallback well there what you couldn't do
is you're gonna have you can write slots
and you can put some content inside so
whatever you pass in over here inside
the content it's like a fallback
the fallback content if you have nothing
right if you have something then you see
something but if it's nothing then
you'll show the fallback content
so this is one way you can fall back
content so that it does not really
depends on whether
so it depends on whether like whether
the parents passing something into your
component if there's something that you
Slaughter in if there's nothing then you
just show the fallback
so one last thing before I end this
video is
um what if you have more things that you
want to pass into the components uh
leave more places to slot into right
over here you only have one component
called slots and you can only pass you
can only pass in a
or what all the things that is within
this component will be slotted in what
what if you have multiple places of
so-called placeholders or slots that you
want to put things in and you want to
decide where and things like that what
should you do
well you can have name slots so let me
come remove this and let's create a few
slots uh first thing is I'm gonna remove
okay I'm gonna remove everything first
I'm gonna come here and say this is the
header
and this is the footer right so for
example you have this maybe like a
layout component where you create a
tether and a footer
right and you can allow people to pass
in different content for header and
different content for footer then you
can have different slots
all right so if you pass in a steam slot
over here then you're getting the same
elements into both of the slots but what
if you want different things and you can
have name slots you can have name for
the slots over here you're gonna name it
um call it footer
then this is a folder name slots so if
you want to pass something to footer
then you can have to come over here
maybe you create an element
for food element for footer
and what you do is you're gonna call
you're gonna pass in the attribute name
footer and the value will be the name
for that slot right so this is the slot
attribute to determine which element
should this
um
slots to be inserted into so this
specify that I'm gonna go into the
footer slot this attribute tells you
gonna put the slot and over here you
have a name slot you have a name for
this slide called footer and there you
there is where you insert the the
elements that has a slot attribute
called footer in
right
so uh by default uh a slot without a
name is actually named default
right so you can't have a slot named
default
right this is reserved for the default
slots
so yeah one thing you have to take note
about
so you can have name slots and come over
here I'm gonna say this is going to be a
hitter slot
and now I am going to add this button
into the header slots
right but I also want to add the the
count into a header slot
so now what we can do instead is create
what I call a slots template
and this can this allows me to wrap over
multiple elements
so I can
I can have
multiple elements wrapped within the
slots templates and all all the elements
within here will be part of the slot
header because of the attribute called
slots header and they will be inserted
into the slot named header right so you
can see slot header has has zero and
minus right a button and you can have
element for footer over here right so
you have name slots so let's recap what
we have uh gone through so far we can
have child elements for your component
right and the the way where these com
elements within the component will be
inserted will be depends on the slot
Right Slots is where you slots the
content in
you can have fallback content for the
slots if you have if you pass in like a
children within a slots element
and if you want to have multiple slots
you can but if you want to differentiate
from different slots that like this is
the Halo content for the slot this is a
header slots for header content and this
is a footer slot for Fuller content then
you can have a name slot you can provide
a name for your slot
and then since you provide name for
slots so determine which where does the
element goes to Which slot that will
insert into you can pass in a slot
attribute to name like Which slot you go
into so if you slot in on one only one
element then you can pass it as
attribute but if you want to group
multiple elements
into the same slots then you can use a
slots template
and same thing slot attribute to
determine which slots name slots you're
going to slot into
and we also talk about Styles where if
you have
uh again just a recap of scope styling
or if it affect button then it will
affect all the buttons within this
component file it will irrelevant
whether this is being inserted in like a
child component right so any button
that's written in this file will be
affected
so in the last video we talked about
slots
we talk about slots it's a way that you
can insert elements inside the component
into
a slot right within a component you can
provide elements as like a children to
component and they can be inserted into
the slots in this video we're going to
talk about how we can pass data into
that element or pass data from the
elements to the outside world
right so here in this example that I've
prepared for you
I have a app.felt which is the parent
component which uses the component the
child component
and I pass a an element right I pass in
a fragments of elements which is the app
count data
and do these slots so inside components
you will have this element called slots
that determines where this
app count is going to be passed in if I
don't have this then you will see that
uh although you pass in the app counts
but there's no nowhere that you're gonna
specify because you're gonna insert it
into right slot is where you specify you
can insert oops where you're gonna
insert that into
now inside this the elements that you
have that we have we use data like app
count which comes from the apps file
right from this file you have this
variable called app account where you
can increment or decrement you see that
this data updates
uh accordingly this is what we have
shown in the last video as well
but how about the data within this
container components I have accounts
minus and count plus plus uh sorry I
have accounts and I can increment a
decrement but how do I pass this data
into this element inside over here
well you can do that using a slot props
which is props for this slot element
so for example I can pass in counts like
this pass in accounts as a props to this
slot
then I can read it out into this uh
slots templates
so what I do is I can come over here and
say let's count
so let is the way it's a directive and
it says that if I have a props
for the slot then it will be available
over here uh
within this uh
fragment over here
so uh I'm gonna say this is the
variable uh count so it has to match up
and now I can use this variable count
over here so component I'm going to say
component count is this count
right so if I increment like this you
can see it changes if I increment like
this you'll see that it changes for the
component's count
uh that let me
right uh so so that you can see that
there are side by sides one is I'm count
one is component count
so um so this is how you can get so
within your templates within this swell
fragment you can have data coming from
two places right one is within this app
component file
and another is from the
the components right the child
components the other one is from here
the component counts
now um
so this is I wouldn't say like past data
in or out right uh because it's it's
probably it's a bit confusing for you
over here to think about that like
passing in or passing out but you can
take a look at you can think of it this
way so all the data that's from uh
there you if in the perspective of this
felt fragment think about where the data
can come from and where the data can go
to right it can come from this app. so
This resides in this app component and
also within the component component
right so you can have the data from here
and you can have the data from component
from component from here and this comes
by getting it from a slot props and you
assign that count over here you can
reassign this variable to something else
or if for example you have like count
over here instead
then you run into the issue where if you
want to use count
you realize that uh they are both
they are both coming from this slot
props right so you can actually rename
the variable if you want to you can
rename it from here I see I don't want
to use count I want something else I'm
gonna say uh
a count
then I can let a call in States and get
the value over here
but what if you have no choice uh this
is the problem the name of the problem
is called count you have no choice to
use let counts then you kind of actually
rename it you can rename to something
else so actually you can come up here
and it goes to a new name you can bind
it to a new name and bind it to count
from component
and I can use it over here like this
right now you can see that I'm getting
the count from this app component and
come from components from the component
component
right so we see that how we can get data
from here inside to uh from app and
component now let's take a look at how
we can get
something out of it out from here from
this field fragments to inside this app
dot spell or component as felt right so
first thing is if you have say a button
I'm gonna copy this button and paste it
over here but if this button
um whatever I do over here actually will
affect outside whoa or I can also Define
a function say ink uh increment
which is
count plus plus and can also call this
function over here to notify that this
uh
let's
let me add this okay I can also so this
button is is within this felt fragment
right I can
have any function declared within apps
felt and I can call it right I can call
this function so it's like passing data
outwards right I can also do things like
increment and say increments by five
and then again come up here and say
Delta plus equals Delta so I can also do
it this way by passing different kind of
data out to the app.f files and how
about passing data into the components
Fields well it would be like passing a
callback function right I can come over
here copy this function I can have my
own increment function over here
and I can pass it in
as a slot props
now I can come over here to get to
receive the slot props from within my
template I can come and see let's
increment and because this is using the
same variables name as the function over
here and I don't want to override it
then I can rename it again I can rename
it but I say int from component I can
rename anything I want right and I can
come over here and use it
so I have two buttons uh
one is to increment in the apps felt one
is to increment from the components
right so if I call this you can see this
is incrementing if I call this this is
incrementing so you can pass different
data from this templates out to the app
and the components felt and we have seen
how we can pass data from app.strual and
common spell into these templates so
things over here is is you can have a
combination of both walls you can also
maybe swap this out where I'm going to
call this the increment by the counts
from components and increment for
component with the count
right then uh if this is three then I
can increment by three and if this is 12
now I can increment by 12. right this
you can mix and you can take data from
both sides and then do your own
combinations and and also sending data
out to both of the components
so in the last videos we talked about
slots and how we can communicate data
through slots and in the previous videos
I might have misspoke about the slot
template there's no such thing as slot
template it's spelled fragment
uh so sorry for misspoken and mistyped
it I must have been sleeping while
recording this video uh that video right
so uh today we're going to talk about
slot forwarding it's a good way for us
to
um revise and ensure that we really
understand how slots works so let's take
a look at what is slot forwarding and
have a check where how good we know
about slots
so first thing is over here I have
prepared a rebel where I have three
components I have a I have B and I have
C right so a in Parts B Be import c c
and the app will import a so we just
just leave the app component alone and
we're just gonna take a look at the a
component
or rather let's take a look at the C
component first so the C component is
the most interesting one we have three
slots the header
um
we have three slots element three of
them are named slots so they have names
for it right they are not default slots
they have names right we have header
content and we have footer
okay so how do you pass elements uh into
this header slot
well if you are in the B component and
you want to do that you would first
create a component called C
and within C you can have elements as
long as your elements has the slot
attribute called header then elements
and all these children will be inserted
into the header slots so for example if
I come over here
I have say
a div the slot name header so you have
to make sure that this slot attributes
value is the same as the name then all
its content will be
all its contents will be inserted into
the header in C right so here I'm going
to say C header
and this is C
footer
all right so C header C footer so you
see that this is being inserted into it
right if you have a few elements right
uh that is so one element can have only
one element cannabis attribute called
slots with the same uh
so you can have multiple elements within
this components but the slots attribute
value has to be unique right you can't
basically do this where you have
multiple elements with a name called
slots uh no elements with attribute a
slot attribute value that has a is the
same right you can't have two slots
header so if you want
to have two siblings elements to be
passed into the same slots element then
what you need is is felt fragment right
this is a way for you to group your
elements
you group your elements so over here
you're going to copy this slot attribute
and yeah we don't need this copy our
slot attributes and wrap these two
elements these two siblings element
together and now we insert both the div
into
the C header right okay so so far so
good we've learned this before right
this is just a revision so now let's
make things slightly harder so for say
for example now I want to pass content
from a
to B
uh what do I do well B will have to have
a slot say for example I come over here
and Define the slots
I'm going to this name a b header
okay I have a slot okay I just can close
it directly I don't need any fallback so
I have a b header over here
and to pass contents from A to B header
what I need is I need to come over here
in a create this component called B and
I have elements inside so here I'm going
to create div again uh header from a and
I need to have a slot attribute to tell
because this is a name slot so this is
not a default slot this is a name and
then I need to create and a I want to
pass something into that named slots I
need to have a slot attribute with the
same
value with this name of the slots so
let's say a slot
attribute value is equal to the same
thing right so now you see that b here
has the either from a
header from a over here
and then
yeah this is the same thing as how we
pass from B to C right okay so let's
move on one more step what if I want
contents from a I want uh I want to have
this slot uh
whatever the content is passing to be
hater slots to be passed into cease
uh header slots
right so what do I do okay so first
thing I could come over here uh instead
of having this div remove all this and
tick and copy this and put the slots in
over here
okay so now what you can see is I
uh I still use the same slots elements
but this slots element is being placed
inside a
instead of being put somewhere else you
can put in here as well right it's how
the the slots element can place anywhere
now what I want is I'm going to place it
inside a c component
and into this slot called header slot
attribute called header so that it is
all the contents from a will be inserted
into the slot named header in C
component right so now you can see that
I can do this and
it's kind of a forward like the content
from a into B uh to be insert into B but
then the content you insert into B is
going to take
and insert into the C component right so
this is like like forwarding the slots
and if you guys do this you can simplify
it by come over here uh if if this is
all you have because slot frame as well
fragment is usually used when you want
to group multiple elements to insert
into one's slot right but in our case we
only want to
I have only one element which is this
slots element so a further way to
simplify this we can copy this slot
attribute and pass it inside this slot
elements and we can remove this uh cell
fragment right and you can see that it's
still working
right it's still working you taking
contents from a
in the a file
uh you take it in and pass it into the B
component over here right so the slots
attribute says b header so we're going
to pass insert into a slot element in B
component named B header
and then I want to pass this B uh this
elements this whole element coming from
a I want to slot it inside a slot in C
component name header so I come over
here and add slot attribute called
header and there it is it's being slot
slotted into C component right to make
metal worse or confusing sometimes you
want you might write something like this
where the name and the slots is the same
so here it's like this but you need to
know that uh you you after X my
explanation hopefully you are clearer
now where basically slots and the name
creates a slot a name slots element
which says that whatever comes from a uh
whoever create a b component then you
can create something with a slot
attribute called header that will insert
into there right and at the same time if
you have a slot attribute then it means
that I want to insert into this
components right wherever it has a slot
name header inside C component
okay so now let's take a look uh
hopefully this you understand this and
let's take a look
revise again what we've learned in the
previous video where we say about
communication right data how do we pass
data right so say for example if I come
over here I have a script tag
and I have a counter equals zero and as
always I like counter because it's easy
to create and demonstrate
a button
so oops okay uh and I have a buttons to
counter
I have a button to increment this
counter value
okay I want to pass this counter
into the slots counter
so when I pass it in
you will see that in over here I can
assess this value right by via the let
the let's right so I can have a let
counter
right and but
okay I have a let's counter but then
again I have a lead counter but I
you know this is usually used in Elder
elements right if I if I come over here
and if I put div
uh I I would have this
I could now use this counter over here
and you know do something about it right
I can I can show this counter directly
this this is the element
right as you can see it's incrementing
but instead of having a div or something
else I have a slot element right so that
element is for people to insert
something inside right so now probably I
would want to also pass this counter
value to whoever is slotting into my
slots so I can come over here and say
counter I'm do this so I'm going to pass
this counter value go over and insert
and provide to whoever is slotting into
the header so this is the slot header
over here and I can take this same thing
let counter and then come over here and
use this value now
you see that when I increment this data
as being
updated right over here so this data
comes from uh how I pass this data is
when I create a slot element slots
elements I can have props so all the any
props you have the data will be passed
into whatever elements that is going to
insert into that slot element so
whatever elements are elements with
slots attribute with the same name
so in here C component we have slots
attribute called header so this will
receive that counter right the receives
it you use a let's counter
and now because we also this element
just coincidentally is a slot element or
else we were just gonna use this counter
but this is a stock element which means
uh it's not showing anything but
someone to insert content in right so we
also want to pass this data into uh
whoever is inserting into this slots
element so we're gonna create this props
so that we can pass that data down
and of course of course you say that
this slots element could have fall back
right so this is a fallback
so this is uh this content will be
rendered if you don't pass in a element
with a slots named header right so for
example if I say this is header
Z Now you see a fallback and this
fallback has this content right where
basically it's this one right you you
take that counter and you're gonna show
the content over here
but if you pass something that has the
same slot attribute now you want to pass
the counter to that though these
elements right if you want to right you
don't have to you can pass as a counter
you can maybe rename it as say full
equals counter now what you
can do is maybe let full and then take
the value of 4 over here and show full
right
so this is this is the full value over
here you can see over here right so of
course so it's up to you whether you
want to pass it down or maybe something
else or do something with it maybe full
counter times two uh so what you get
over here the full value that you
receives is always two times of the
counter that's that's really up to you
right I'm just gonna show how you can
pass data all the way back in and as as
we learn we can also pass data upwards
or uh over here we we have this data go
through a b and c right so everyone can
be participated into this the data to be
passed in so now I'm gonna have a b
value
create a button
on click
me
okay I have a button called B button
that I will
I'm going to pass a props call sum now
uh I'm gonna counter uh plus b
okay
and so so this one I'm gonna be uh
nicely puts this is C
this is B and now I also in a I also
gonna have something called uh let's a
equals to zero
I'm gonna copy this code over
a plus plus a
a
now uh this will be sum so we're gonna
take let's sum
and sum
plus a
uh so this is a sum from a
this is but then the sum plus a so what
is some sum is actually coming from here
which is let me make it a new line so
it's easy to read sum is equal to
counter plus b so B comes from the B
component and what is counter counter
comes from here right from the left so
which means this come from C so what is
counter over here this counter is this
variable from C
right so we increment any of them you
see that it is adding all the variables
all the counters from a b and c
right so this is
amazing if you uh this this unlocks a
lot of possibilities that you can do
um
possibilities are endless imagination is
endless it's up to you right hopefully I
explain this slot folding concept
um to you clearly
and I think that this slot for the idea
of slots falling like forwarding a slots
really and forces you to think about how
slots really work what is the
relationship between a slots element and
the slots attributes and how do you pass
data across them right hopefully after
this video you don't have any doubts
anymore but if you still do comments
down below ask me any questions if you
have if you still have right I'm I'm
very more than welcome to answer all
them
today we're going to talk about a magic
variable called dollar dollar slots
so what is this magic variables about
well we're going to take a look in an
example and we're going to learn about
from that so over here I have is
uh app a DOT spelled components which it
has three name slots name a b and c
each of them has it's wrapped by a div
and it also contains a fallback for the
content right so if you don't provide
this name a slots you don't provide a
element when you're using this a
component with a slot attribute called a
then you will see the fallback instead
so uh and the same thing goes for B and
C so over here if you come over here and
see a has three uh a has nothing you
don't pass anything so you see fallback
A and B and C and for this one you have
ABC you pass something you so each of
them has something for it right and and
then if you come over here and say you
do this then you get a b and fall back
for C
so this is useful when you so this is
very useful when you have fallbacks
right so if you don't pass something you
you see the fallback but sometimes
um
sometimes you have text like this like
the B and you you don't want to fall
back for B
sometimes you don't want to fall back
right so for B case you don't want the
fallback so if you don't have anything
you don't want to show you you don't
want to show anything right this one you
don't have fallback don't show anything
but at the same time you also don't want
to show the text called B you don't want
to even show any of this div
but you know this is outside of the slot
elements how do you know whether sums
whether the slot element itself has
something or how do you know whether a
component Pro whe whether or not it
provides elements with a slot attribute
called B
well as the name suggests as the name of
the video suggests
we'll use a magic variable called dollar
dollar slots to tell us
so this dollar dollar slots is a
variable uh which is an object and this
object contains key
for each of the slots
um
attributes that is being passed into
this component
so for example in this case I probably
will see
um an object with a b and c right so
this object the value of the object for
now is Trudy
um and if you take a look it's actually
true right but
um I can't say for sure what is going
about so you're looking at you don't
have to you shouldn't care about what is
the value for now
um so at the point of this recording
version 3.37 right you just need to care
about the key whether the key is exists
and where the key value is Trudy right
as long as truly then you can assume
that the slot is there
so over here what we have now uh is we
can use this dollar dollar slots right
so if B is truly which means um I can
use this in the if
I can use this in the if logic block to
determine whether this is truly or not
if it's truly then I'm going to show
this whole thing right
now if someone does not pass in anything
for B it will not see this div and B
colon right so if you see here I have
fall back for a I fall back for C but
you don't see B at all you will only see
B if something for B is being passed in
only when you have an attribute a slot
attribute named B so over here if I
remove this then you'll see that b is
gone right you don't have B at all
um so there
and in those case in those scenarios
then it's uh it's probably pointless to
have any fallback for here right because
for this slot name B because you
probably would not need uh probably it
will be hidden because of this if thing
so this slots double slots it's a
variable again it's a variable it's an
object and it contains key for the name
of the slots attribute being passed in
and if you're gonna check whether if
there's a pass in then you probably will
check whether you have a whether this is
truly or not uh if you check for C then
you probably will check slots see
whether it's 2D or not so for default
slots then it will be default
all right so default slots are the one
that slots element without name at all
right so we don't name that it would be
a default slots
so uh by uh at the point of this
recording version 3.37
uh you don't have a way to conditionally
say hide or show a certain slots add an
element with a slot attribute you can't
really say I want to hide this or show
this
which means that it's probably uh the
slot the order slot itself is it's not
reactive at all right so it will only
look for elements whether it would have
a slot attribute right so if say for
example if you do something like this uh
okay so if you do something like this
yes it seems like it's empty but it is
not you still have an element with a
slot attribute called B so it's not
hiding for this right even if you see if
you come over here and slap spell
fragment
again uh this is this is not empty right
as in you you sorry you still have
elements with a slot attribute called B
it it's not it does not care whether
it's empty or not it just care whether
you have element called slot attribute
called B at this point of recording
right I'm not sure this is the best way
of doing it the best feature we have but
at this point what we have from svelt is
that we'll check for elements with the
slots attributes I will not care about
the contents so even if you have no
content uh you you still this this thing
is still
hold on
slots B
yeah if you have no content
okay because for this yes you don't have
a content right because it's empty at
all right yeah so so I also sorry
but if you
um
but if you have something like this if
some condition
then
oops
then again this is some sort of like
content right this is content so I
correct myself
um you will check for the slots and then
it will look at the so-called content
but the content itself
um
uh does not have to be like actual
having a Content it's really like uh
whether anything is written inside this
uh spelled fragment or elements that you
have right even if you have a if logic
block inside you because of the
condition you're rendering nothing is
still considered as having some sort of
content uh for your slots attribute B
and therefore you you this is still a
Trudy so it will only be falsy if you
have if it's totally empty right totally
empty
um so I think even if you have a space
okay space is too empty okay ignore me
right so
yeah every day within us new things
right we're trying to test boundaries
and and I would say this is not like the
personally I feel that that there's room
to improve as well probably in the
future versions future versions but at
this point and the point of recording
version 3.37
um does double dollar slot stop B only
checks whether you write anything inside
these slots
all right so hopefully you you learned
something today the slots where you can
use it to determine whether
um a slot attribute is being passed in
if it's not sent you can use this to say
to to wrap it around with elements so
that you know it's not just about the
slots if it's nothing is passing this is
empty right but then also the
surrounding elements if you want to hide
surrounding elements if the slot is not
being passed in you can use these total
slots with an if logic block
so we have learned a lot and we have
come a long way we've learned how to use
a store how to create a store we have
learned how to create an action how to
use an action and we've learned how to
compose or create components how to
share data across components how to
create slots where you can insert some
contents from your component into
somewhere that you want to insert into
the inner components right and we learn
about how to transfer data across we've
also learned about how you can
dispatch an events from components or
dispatch events from elements we've
learned a lot and today we're gonna try
to use all of them all of the things I
have mentioned so far into one example
which is how are we going to create an
infinite list
so what is an infinite list you probably
have seen this kind of UI where you
scroll and scroll and as you scroll it
loads more data and then if you scroll a
lot small data and it skips scrolling in
finely and we are addicted with this
especially in social medias with you
keep scrolling and keep seeing new
contents where you just can't stop
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
I'm going to create this
um component called in finite list
whereby you can pass in different kind
of data to this component and you can
decide how to
um how to render or how how how does
each item within the infinite list looks
like
so this will involve in how we compose
our components so first thing first uh
let's take a look at this Ripple that I
have kind of prepared actually nothing
much over here except that I've created
a few files the app the list component
which we are going to do the data.js so
this is where we're going to fetch the
data and an action use viewport action
you probably have seen this you probably
have done this before in the previous
video where I showed how I create this
viewport action
so links in the description if you
haven't seen that before
so over here app thoughts felt let's
let's imagine how we're gonna use this
infinite list so most likely most likely
or this is how I imagine right I'm gonna
share how I come up with this and uh if
you if you if you disagree or something
let's comment down below and let's
comment uh discuss about it so this is
how I would imagine my list component
uh will be will be used right usually
when you come up with a component you
probably instead of like hit you that
there's two ways right first is you want
to experiment you want to play with it
then yeah go ahead uh go hits down to
the component and try to experiment with
something but sometimes on the other
hand when you want to design a component
you want to think in terms of how you
want to use it how you want to
allow people to use it and then figure
out how to provide that behavior so over
here I want I am imagining that I have a
list component
okay I have a list component where I can
pass in
data right I can pass in data like this
right so this will be an array of the
elements okay so this is empty array for
now
and
I would imagine that I would have also
um ways to get so this list will render
in finite list right so for each of the
elements I probably would want to uh
Define how how each of the elements will
show right so uh for each of the
elements probably I have a variable
called a item
over here item item is like one of the
item of the list of arrays so I don't
have to do like a four inch Loop within
like in in this app right so the list
will do that looping of creating each of
the items whenever they need
uh all I need over here is I let item
and I probably will able to say maybe
show a some contents for each of the
item right something like this
right this is what I would imagine my
component will look like
I I pass in a list of data and then for
each of the item I have I can bind it
and then I probably will show like how
how each of the item will show
and then probably I also would have
maybe an event called load more
so this will prompt me to load more data
right fetch more data so that uh so most
likely this will be called when I scroll
to the end of the list
so this is roughly how I would imagine
my list would look like of course there
might be more things say for example
loading you know you never know that
whether you are loading or not or
yeah you never know whether you are
loading or not right so
um I I could pass in as a props
or probably maybe like a lot more is a
maybe it's like a async function so
um then maybe I don't need loading right
so every time when I call load more I
will just wait for it and when it's done
I would
when it's when it's pending then I will
show a loading icon indicator and when
it's done and I I don't need right so
then in that case I don't even need to
pass in the props called loading
um and probably one more thing that is
uh
maybe like no more data
right this is uh helpful when you scroll
to the end of this and you realize
actually there's no more data to fetch
right maybe this this can be a props or
maybe we can somehow indicate from the
load more I don't know but this is this
is one way
right so the way I design it this way
which means that uh in this app does
felt I
I will have to Define how what is the
data and how do I load the data right
um of course there's a lot of different
ways of Designing this list this
infinite list
component it could be that your load
more will always return the next items
right then probably you would not need
this data props because every time when
you call load more you will try to the
list itself will handle like a pending
will maintain a list and pass it right
um there's another that that could be
another way of doing it but for now I'm
probably will keep it simple where list
itself will handle that right so
probably you'll come here you'll call a
fetch more will we will update this data
and we'll pass the data down to the list
component
right
um of course you can trick around if you
want to feel free to grab the rebel Link
in the description and play around and
try out different ideas you have
so uh first thing is so this is what
we're gonna go and first thing is let's
come up with an API or what is the data
they're going to show right I I found
this lorem pixum
which gives us a lot of mock
photos and there's
um there is this link list API where I
can call
where it has a page ID and a limit so
that I can keep calling for get the next
page so I probably will gonna use this
and use this to show images right so
probably my item would have a say
download URL which is the image URL so
if I click this this is the image URL
you can probably would have a download
uh download URL over here so here I I
let item right I can I could have used
item but I can also assign it to a
different variable right I think we've
learned that where we can say
another variable
and use like another variable here
we can rename the the variable name
right and actually you can also you
could also if you don't know you could
also destructure it
and use this download URL instead so
here in my list probably I would have
image source as the download URL
and probably also have like maybe the
author where I could use this author as
the alt all right I'm gonna say uh taken
bye
stunning view taken by author
right this is
this is just to show that I I could
destructure and you know have a
take out different properties of the LED
okay now let's let's since we have this
API now let's try to implement the data
right okay so first thing is I probably
will use a writable data so that
whenever I change it changes you your
component get notified and then you you
would render right so here I will say
import writable
from svelt Star of course you could use
a normal data and then in the app itself
you can update that variable right so if
I put it in an external file then most
likely the best way to update and get
notified is through a writable here I'm
going to Define some variable say maybe
loading
false I have no more no more data
false and then I have my uh page so this
will increments every time when I Fetch
and then maybe I have my data over here
as an empty array
so the first thing I'm going to Define
is the list
which is the writable
all right so this I'm gonna have the
data itself and the no more data
all right I think I probably would want
to yeah this the same name so it's
easier for me to do to
to assign uh to use it later on okay so
so this is the list writable
um I I could have just exported this
list writable but I also
um I I want to also add more methods to
this list uh to the store that I'm going
to export and also remove some of the
methods right I so here is the final
star that I would have is I'm gonna have
a subscribe method
all right subscribe it's a must
for to be considered as a store
according to the store contract but I
don't want to expose the sets and
updates method right so I don't want the
user of this data this uh image lists
data to to update it to modify it I
don't want to expose the sets and update
I just want to expose subscribe but I
also want to add one more methods which
is called Fetch more
this will allow us
um
the user of this store to call this and
fetch more data right so in later on I
will probably come over here and you
know look more I will say uh the store
dot fetch more
I I would call this to fetch more data
uh
uh yep
so before that let's come over here and
say okay so now when I called this
um I maybe just make some some checks
first for example if there's it is
loading
or is there's no more data
then probably will just end immediately
so so nothing happens right but then I
would say loading to be true
and next I would come over here and
actually refresh the data right so
called Fetch copy this API let me use
uh so the page will be page okay I'm
gonna say plus plus
the limit I'm gonna say just limit to 10
10 items every fetch
so here I'm gonna get a response
from waiting this fetch API
and I would also need to wait for the
response to
um after I get a response I'm gonna get
the Json
format of I'm going to Json data of the
response body so we're gonna say uh data
uh okay I don't want to use the same
variable over here we're going to say
new data
equals to a weight
response
Json
and then
um okay so now I'm gonna update this
loading it's going to be false now
and then a no more data will be depends
on how many data that I have so this
returns me an array right so if I go to
the extreme end say 100 then I get empty
array so which means that if the new
data.lank equals to zero then it's no
more data
and now I my data needs to be updated
I'm going to push all the new data in
and finally I'm going to update my store
right so I'm going to say list dot sets
uh here and get the data and no more
data
so I'm going to update my list okay so
there we have it and now we're gonna
import from
data so this is going to call data from
data
so this is not started this is the
data.fresh more
um so I'm going to create an async
function that calls and return fetch
more right this is this can be
simplified to just pass it like this
right data.fresh more and over here
because my my store value has data and
no more data I could actually just
spread it right I can just spread the
data right because the the value of the
star is an object with data and no more
data I can I can spread this instead of
having to come over here and you know
data.data and data no more data right I
can I can spread it instead
okay that is done and
we have that done which is nice and now
let's take a look at the list components
okay so in the list component
I need first to create some of the props
that we're passing in so the first thing
is the data
and next is the no more
data
right and then yeah that's it and
because over here we have an event from
this component so probably we also want
to import create event
dispatcher
all right so you will create a dispatch
method
to dispatch this to dispatch a no uh
do dispatch
dispatch a lot more event later on
right now I'm gonna create a list
so firstly I'm gonna have
unordered lists
whoops
and we're going to use each to Loop
through the data so each data as item
and look through each of the data
um over here I could use a
key each block if I want to
um or okay let me think now we can use
key each block all right so that
if if we somehow reorder them then then
it's it's useful
but let's let's leave it like this first
but if you want to use a pH block you
would have to decide what as the key the
prop or the attribute to treat as the
quiche block and if we're gonna do that
but we we have no idea in this this
component to know what is the
um what are the attribute of this item
to be treated as the key for the for
each of the item right then probably you
would have to say exports that key you
would have to have it as a props and ask
maybe the user of it to Define like okay
so the key should be ID
right because you know we can see over
here uh for each of the item ID is kind
of unique so I can come over here and
see Item ID is the key sorry item key is
the key and key in in this case is a
string ID
so in my uh in my each block I'll what I
need to do now is actually to create
each of the list item and have a slot
so slot is where you pass in a
this uh where where we we have a default
slot so whatever is being written over
here this is being inserted into the
slots right so as we Loop through we
create one list item and every list item
will have its slots and for the slots
for each of the different slots that we
have that we iterate through we can
actually pass a different item
data right we can pass a different item
so over here maybe the first item so the
item will be the first item the second
the second first image second image
third image and so for each of the slots
elements that you create maybe you
create because of the each block you
have three slots elements and each of
them has a different item right so each
of them will actually insert a different
image from here because
this image takes in the props of the
item and takes a download URL as a
source right each of the download URL is
different so you have a different image
um okay
so although I'm not quite sure why is it
not okay so next the next thing is we
have a fresh data that's why we are
seeing nothing over here so to fetch the
data we're gonna create another list
item
and this list item uh I would be uh
let's see I'm gonna come over here uh
okay use viewports we're gonna import
the viewports
use view Port action
I'm going to use viewport
for this list element
okay so if say if no more data
if if no more data then probably would
we would not need to use this again
right this list item this last list item
will have the viewport so that we know
that when it's entering the screen
so uh you call enter viewport event
on enter viewport so when it enters what
we want to do is actually to call uh
fetch more data right so uh over here
instead of calling a method we are
dispatching a new event called load more
so here I'm gonna say a hold on load
more
yeah I I could have
um
was that I I could have a used event uh
forwarding by for the enter viewport
instead so if I don't do anything then
this will actually create whenever this
event is happen this event happens it
will dispatch a new event from this
component called uh this enter viewport
right that's where you see this is being
called and fetch more data but I I for
the sake of pattern naming because it
does not make sense of list to have a
and the viewports events so I'm going to
come here and dispatch action myself I'm
going to say here and dispatch
uh enter viewport sorry not enter
viewport but load more
right um okay so the image is a bit too
big so I'm gonna come over here and
maybe have a style
with equals a hundred percent
right so I have a smaller image right
now as you can see as you can see my
scrolling if I scroll to the end it will
this enters and it will load more right
uh the image just now is it's like it's
trying to load the image right and as I
scroll down you see that it will loads
more image more image is being loaded so
every time when I scroll uh when I this
list item enters the viewport you will
see that the viewport uh enter viewport
event will be dispatchers and here I
handle it by Dispatch a new event
component event called load more and
over here I listen to that and fetch
more data
um I I initially I was planning like
maybe to use this
um to give us like the loading but then
because events when you dispatch events
it's kind of like a couple you don't
really get whatever is returned from
this event handler so probably I would
want to pass in loading into uh exports
that's loading
uh in in here so that you know uh when
when it's loading
if loading
Flash
show a text call loading
but we haven't passed this loading in
right we haven't passed loading so I can
come over here and maybe have this
loading as part of the writable as well
so loading over here
so that means when I said loading to
true I also need to update the store by
set loading to true
right I could use sets I could also
because of writable I could also come
over here and say update so I have my
original
uh see
data and then return Yes okay no
it takes in a function and returns right
the
current list
and I can create a new list by setting
loading
only
which answers okay I need to
return new
current list
or I can do this as well now I have my
loading I'm not sure this is easier to
read uh probably I'm going to change it
back to just to this this is this is
much simpler
to my eyes right uh in terms of like the
effect is is roughly the same it's
simple to my eyes with this right so now
you can see when I scroll down you will
see loading and then you load more data
and then you you kind of
show more data right so what you've seen
over here is probably we
didn't really mention it but it's
possible where you can have multiple
slots elements in a component and you
can have multiple slot this slot is the
same slim slot name right this is a
default slot right if you can have you
can have a different name maybe like
item and you can come over here and have
like this image as a slot attribute
called item then they are the same this
is still inserted into this slot right
so you can have multiple slots elements
in a component and you can create them
using if each or all any logic blocks
they can think of you can have a lot of
those kind of slots and for each of the
slots you can actually pass in different
data right I can I'm passing a different
item as props now you get different item
over here for each of these slots and so
that you can
show different Data Insights you can
create a different image for each of the
item right we can create different image
over here so here you go here is how we
create an infinite list using all the
techniques or knowledge that we have
learned so far we'll learn about how we
can create a writable star custom
writable style basically you have at
different meta Studio writable store
we learn about actions although we
didn't write an action today but we we
use it right inside this list components
and in a component wise we learned about
how to create components how to create
slots elements and how to have slot
attributes to inserts into them right
how we can pass data in so we are
passing item from the list components to
this main component we'll learn about
events so lists we we are listening
events from an item we are also
dispatching a new event called loot more
so you can fetch more data over here
we will learn about spreading yeah we've
done spreading over here as well so
here you go how you can combine all the
knowledge you've learned into an
infinite list
So today we're going to attempt to build
another component which is tabs you
often see this or even you see this
every time when you try to use the
spelled Ripple which is the tab right
you can come over here and switch a
create tab right and you can switch
between tabs and the content will change
because
yeah because you switch the tabs right
so let's come up with this tab component
and let's try to design this tabs
component together right oftentimes when
you want to try things yes you can go
hit down and try it out but sometimes
when you want to design a components you
will try to imagine how you want the
user to use your components so for here
let's try to put on our thinking hat to
try to go into imagination try imagine
how you would want to use this awesome
superb type components that you write
right so
how this is how I would imagine how I
would want to use I'll probably want to
have a tabs component at the outsides
right I have a tabs and inside I can
Define as many tabs I want right so I
have tab
I can have multiple tabs I want
and sometimes based on certain condition
I want to show or
or remove or hide right based on certain
conditions so see if here I'm going to
say is logged in
okay just just a random condition I'm
going to say if based on this condition
I'm going to show us hide certain tabs
right so for example maybe this is a tab
that can at least be seen by a login
user right and maybe sometimes I want
more than that right I want uh maybe
height two tabs at the same time I'm
just trying to imagine how I want the
user to use this okay uh these are
annoying so let's let me just come over
here create a script tag
just let Define tabs like tab
let's
log in
so they stop bugged me okay let's come
back and try imagine again okay continue
imagine I have a tabs component inside I
can shove as many tab I want
and I can have certain conditions to
show hide the tabs right so
another way of doing this show or hide a
certain tab so this is when your height
is like it's gone right you don't see it
over the tab it's not like whether you
are choosing that tab at the current
moment right it's just gone so sometimes
uh some a different alternative
alternate way of Designing this would be
maybe
uh maybe come to use a props right show
uh
like shoot show right is look it may be
like alternate way of Design This will
be uh uh this way right you use a props
to decide whether the tabs itself should
be shown or not but I find that maybe
what I want okay let's let's try to get
our imagination well right I want to
design it in such a way that I just use
the if logic block 2 decides when to
show or hide a certain tab I want it
this way right okay so I here I have it
uh so here is what I want and then next
thing is what about tab content right
type content should be as easy as go
into the tab components and write things
right I wanna hey hey for this one
and log in content one
and I have a login content too and here
are like
who ha
okay so I have three tabs four tabs two
of the tabs may be showing uh maybe
there or may not be there because
depends on the condition call is logged
in
um so here when you I write this you
probably
think of like oh I'm gonna use slots
Right Slots is the perfect way of having
contents inside the components to be
inserted somewhere right yeah that's
that's right probably will use slots
slot element for this
and tabs usually comes with a title
right so title probably I can come over
here and write the title of my tab so
I'm gonna have my tab is this is a lack
of good names I'm going to call this
type one
uh this is gonna be a log
in tab 2.
secret tab three okay I will probably
just call it secret as well secret tab
two and so type three
and this is the final
final tab okay maybe final tab will be I
want to just show that this can be
dynamic I'm gonna come out Divine a name
called username
and the final tab is actually based on
the username right so huhahi this is the
user con user
uh this is the
info for the user
name okay so this is the content itself
can be dynamic as well this is how I
like it and let's try to figure out how
to implement this right we just it's
come up with like all the things that we
want and then we reverse engineer about
how we can implement this okay so we
need
two components right the tabs and tab so
I'm going to create the tab component
um
so for the tab it's quite obvious right
you need a props called title and
whatever inside is just that types
content so I'm going to come over here
I'm going to create script export let's
title
and I have my slots
for all the content inside tab
right so for the tabs itself yes again I
need
to use slots to basically insert all of
this into somewhere right if you if you
don't have a if you don't have a slot
for this then you you know shorten all
this content will be nowhere to insert
and it will not be available at all
right so I'm going to come over here and
add the slots for this tab
so here I now instead of let's tabs I'm
going to import Steps From the tabs
those Felts
same thing goes with tab Imports tab
from
tap dot spelled
okay so now
so now I have all
the tabs showing on the screen okay
username I should say username is me
right Liao
okay uh oh we've said we wanted it to be
dynamic right so we're going to create a
input mind value
called username
so that I can come over here and
come over here and change my name okay
so we have all the tabs shown at once
which is not really what we want we want
to
uh we want to
we want to only show the one that is
being selected at the moment right so
probably here we can have
um I would say like a key for the tab
right so usually you you would have like
certain things like a key or ID for the
tab and in the tabs component you want
to see what are the default selected tab
right the selected
uh
uh I selected tab will be the ID would
be say something right so I'm going to
call ID would be this is this number
right so I'm going to see here will be
one
so I'm going to create id1 id2 ID3
and id4 for this
so usually you will have a default
selected Tab and you could be changed by
someone else right so uh you can up this
is optional so here my tabs I'll
probably will have defined these props
all right script
uh export let's selected tab
and default maybe I'm just gonna say one
for now I have no idea what's going to
be
okay and then tab I also needs to come
over and say Define the ID as well
okay so now
tabs and tab has to talk to each other
right I need to tell my tab when you
should show your content right now my
all my tabs is showing all their content
let me let me wrap this whole thing with
a div so that it looks
nicer right I'm gonna wrap all this with
a div
so that they are on different lines
so I have two tabs content right now
because it's login is false right so
once I set this to true then you see
that you have four contents
so I want to have a way for the tabs
component to tell the tab that hey uh
you should be hidden or hey you should
be showing right now
and usually that is being done by if you
if you have the tab component within the
tabs component then what you usually do
is you probably pass the props tell that
right but in this case we don't really
part don't really import tab component
in the tabs uh but we actually pass a
tab inside tabs so tab is actually a a
children it's actually a children of
tabs but we just don't have a way to
communicate right so there's a few ways
to do this
first is you could pass it through slots
right you can say uh select the tab is
this
select the tab is this and you can come
over here and use let's binding
right let's select the tab and for each
of the tab you kind of pass in selector
Tab and decide whether you should be
showing a you should be showing your
slots
right based on a certain condition
whether your selector tab is equal to ID
and it should show or not right so let's
So based on this ID this decides whether
you should show your tab or not but
we're adding one more thing over here
which which is I don't like right I
already come up with a design where I I
don't have to pass all this right I just
want to write like this
so what's the alternative to pass data
besides going through props
context are you thinking about context
hopefully hope I hope that you are
thinking about context because that's
what we're gonna use so we're going to
come over here with tabs I'm going to
import
set context
from these Felts
and I'm going to set a tab context right
so we're going to set set context
um call selected tab
I'm going to pass the selected tab over
okay and over here each of them I don't
have props anymore to read it I'm gonna
say get contacts
and
let's select it tab equals to get
contacts
select a tab
and now you can see that you only have
one tab showing right which is hey hey
because right now you're selecting
number one if you say number three
number two then number three then you
will see login content two right you can
say number two then you'll see login
content once right that's great that is
what we exactly what we want
now
um now we have one more thing that we
haven't settled which is the title right
there's no way to click the tab right
here you can choose between tabs because
you can see the title and click it but
here you can't right so once again how
do you pass data from one component from
a grandchild from your tab component to
the parent right previously we learned
several props where you can do something
binding to pass but uh we we've come
we've come to the conclusion that we
should use the context to pass the
selector tab to the child component
which is a tab
and we can do the same thing as well to
use context to pass data from the tab
all the way back to tabs right so here
I'm going to create another context
uh called titles
and here I'm going to gonna have a
personal object uh with two methods one
is called register tab
and one is called unregistered tab
so this is a way for me to register and
unregister tab uh using a so I'm going
to call it with a ID with a title and
unregister with an ID okay so here I I
provide these two methods let's say tab
titles
well probably doesn't matter okay
provide two methods so that uh over here
my tabs I can get this and I'm going to
register myself and cover here gets
contacts
uh this is the uh tab titles
and I'm gonna register myself so guys
call here type titles
register
uh ID
right and when I am
unmounted so say for example on Destroy
I need to unregister myself because say
tab titles dot unregister ID
actually I need to pass ID and the title
okay so I've registered myself and I
remember to unregister myself of course
I need to import this from sveld as well
okay hold on tap titles is not register
oh I should call register Tab and
unregister tab
all right so you register yourself when
you are being created and when you are
destroyed you unregister yourself so
that is how we can achieve when certain
things is on and off you
um when this is false then you are
destroying these two and we need to
unregister ourselves to remove the two
tabs right
so here now I can come over here and
implement the array
okay
probably do it here array which is a
titles that I have
let's see probably I'm gonna use okay
I'm gonna push
on the title and the ID
as an object into this array
right and when I want to register
unregister I need to find out uh
index want to find out the titles so I
need to find out the title that you know
I'm gonna title that ID that matches
the ID that I'm gonna remove
all right Tap index and I'm gonna remove
it so I'm gonna say type if tab index
if I find if I can find it if it's
greater than negative one then I will
say titles dot splice
uh okay that this have to be less than
title dot supplies
um type this tab index
and what I'm going to remove one item
and I need to make sure I update the
title so I'm going to say titles equals
titles over here same thing goes for
here so that's spelled knows that I am
updating this variable called titles
okay so here I have all the titles I'm
going to create all the tabs so can I
use I'm just gonna use simple things
like button
uh and I'm gonna use each to Loop
through all the titles
titles as so each of the item is an
object that has I ID and a title
oops that's let me come over here and
each
right so each of the button I can show
the title
right so I have four tabs right now
and upon clicking
I want to set the selected
tab
to the ID right
so here I have four tabs and if I come
over here and say for example if I have
certain condition
inputs fine
check
equals to is log in
this is my favorite way of defining a
of to control a variable right using a
checkbox so if I unchecked you see that
I only have two tabs left if I check
then you have
um
four tabs right okay the order is wrong
now because this is being pushed in
later on so this probably something that
we need to think about and figure out
later on but here let's have all my tabs
um let's here let's switch between tabs
does not work
right we've updated this variable but
it's not a
it's not updated it's not reactive
because variables are not reactive
across context you can't react make it
reactive across components and we have
to talk about this in a context versus
Star when when should you use a reactive
star a reactive context using store
which is a writable plus context combo
and this is exactly the case when we we
need it so someone come over here and
say import writable
from svelt's store
I'm gonna make this a writable object
okay
make this a writable
so I'm going to pass in a writable
selector tab
and here since it's writable I'm going
to come here and see where where am I
yeah I'm gonna update this using a
dollar sign right select the tab equals
ID
okay
but
um this over here we pass in selected
tab S2 right this again has to be uh so
two ways of doing this this can be a
default
uh a default selector tab or this we
want to pass in a string then probably
we cannot reuse this anymore
we can we would have to create a new
variable called selected
tab star
and create a writable store like this
right writable
selected tab
and I'm going to pass it this over here
write this instead
and now what I'm getting is a star so I
need to use a store to to to get the
value of the store right now as I switch
you can see that I am switching the
switching the step right and the title
is it uh reactive no it's not
so what should I do I need to come over
here
um get the title exchange right every
time my title change I need to do
something right I probably would
whenever title change I want to update
my title right so this slide starts to
become more complex we need to come over
here and see we can register and
unregister we can also come over here
and
do things like update my title my ID
title because the all the list of titles
is being managed over here in the tabs
right I need to provide a way to update
Title if I want to and I'm going to copy
this
find the ID I find the index and then
I'm going to say titles tab index.t
title
equals to the title that it wants right
so now if I come over here
I need to call tab titles dot update
Title
with the ID and the title
now when I change this you can see that
the title is updating now right if I
switch to this tab this is updating as
well so it's remove right I can update
my title dynamically
okay so what's next what's left right we
can switch between tabs
we can have a
uh we can hide and show tabs although
the order is wrong but they are still
working fine I I resume okay so here I
can also change the selected tab from
outside
can we I think we we should allow people
to change the tabs right so say for
example for some reason I have a button
over here
click me
for some reason I can change the
selector tab
to say 4 okay
so this now suddenly becomes a variable
that I can change that is dynamic I
select the tab equals to two
let's see yeah
so I can switch between tabs
and I also want to click this and switch
to 4 but it's not it's not switch to so
what should I do well again come over
here you see that this uh it's just red
once when you create a writable and then
it that's it so here probably you will
have once to have a relative statements
to update this variable every time right
selected
tab star equals to selected tab right so
this what is the dependency of this
statement select the tab so every time
select the tab change you want to update
the value to the store
all right so we can just come here to
switch my tabs and if I click this it
should switch to this tab as well
uh of course here we can't really see
what is being selected from the button
so maybe I can come over here and maybe
add some Style
right so I can come here and say a
button that says that has a class called
selected maybe you should have a
background
color uh background black
and color white
so we have learned this before how do we
dynamically add class we can based on a
certain condition you can see it's class
selected equals to
this right this is the condition if the
class is selected
it goes to ID
let's see okay now this is this this
should be a dollar right at the class
when it's being selected so now you can
see that secret Tab 2 is selected a
switch is it will highlight the tabs
being selected
right if you can switch the last tab
come over here and
hold on oh yeah so this switch
internally but it does not update the
variable outside so that is something
still something slightly wrong
um so I would say we can come over here
we want to update back this variable
called selected type right so probably a
better way is to bind it right to bind
the value out to the variable outside so
over here you can see that a selected
tab is number two right and I switch I
should update this variable as well uh
which means I need to come over here and
do the reverse of this if you come over
here and say select the tab equals to
to select the tab star
right uh however it gives me a cyclical
dependency detected okay so
um let's see what should I do
obviously you can see that I never
planned this before I just wing it so
let's let's figure out how we should do
this right so every time uh
select the tab has changed we need
updates like the tab store and select
the tab change
okay obviously uh
I wouldn't say Obviously but a
workaround to bypass this cyclical
dependency is to create a function
uh
so that it does not see this
dependencies cyclical dependency
but that does not mean it's a good idea
to do it because we if we
override it
if we do it this way
we may end up with an uh
we may end up with a circular recursive
endless request recursive Loop of
updating right but let's try and see
okay I I at least right now it seems
okay
let me switch this before switch back
again yeah it looks okay from now set so
hopefully that is still doing good so if
you have so what what what's happened
and what how do we divert this hard
limit well
um we we change this to a function
instead of like assigning the value
directly and what that changed is that
now spell only sees that uh you only as
long as update props change or selected
tabs store changes then you will call
this declarative statement right
so what's what what happens is that
um
if you have a variable over here instead
then it would know it will look at this
variable and say this depends on this
and so it depends on this store
and this star depends on selected tab
right if you have selected tab equals to
store and start go to selected tab then
they are depending on each other right
so if you remove it and you just shove
it into another function spell will only
see this statement and couldn't figure
that that is actually a cyclical
dependency here so I'm not telling you
that you should do this uh do it at your
own cost I feel that there are some
things that I I I can't think of right
now but there might be something that
may not be that right maybe there will
be a few Loops before it settles
um but let's let's so let me know if you
see any issue with this right so I'm
just going to leave it here because
apparently it seems like it's working
right it changes my variable and I click
I can update them as well
and now if I come over here and I hide
this
and I turn it on again
it's showing but at the wrong position
so now let's take a take a look at here
and let's think about how we can fix
this
well apparently again I've never
prepared for this so that's why I'm
thinking together with you so here I'm
hiding I'm showing
okay so let's let's take a look at how
do we how are you able to tell
the order from here to the uh
to the tabs right
there's no way that we can tell and how
how but how do we get the order right in
the first place well the order was right
because its login was turned on
okay false
in the first place right so if you it's
false and you create this then these two
will be definitely be pushed later on
we push later on into the array and you
never know where it was intended in the
first place right so now let's think a
bit at how is there a way for the tabs
components to know uh their relative
position amongst each other
I feel like there's no way to do that so
it means that there's no way that we can
fix this
now for now I don't think there's a way
that we can fix this so let me know
again on the comments down below uh
comment if you have any good idea to
handle this right so there's no good way
then which means that we kind of have to
sacrifice a bit with our design
and come about and say maybe other right
if you want like some fixed ordering
come up with a props call order and uh
and therefore you can get away with
having a
yeah come up with a thing called order
and then you can register and pass this
order to the titles so that you can have
a control with the other
right
I guess that's why
uh
maybe a less
obnoxious way of doing like having to
pass order is to pass maybe a condition
to say show tab right so this way
uh
this way you maintain the order because
the component has obviously created but
then because of show tab you can say
that hey you can tell over here you can
have a way to say hey this tab is hidden
and another method they say hey show
this tab now right so you you have your
titles being created at the right order
at the very beginning because all the
components has already been there except
that you also pass in the flag to tell
that which tabs should be shown or
should be hidden so that
um when you un untoggle that you still
maintain the right order
so that's all for now I think because I
can't basically I'm hunting of a better
way of solving this so as I said I'm not
I I don't know every no I I don't know
everything so if you have a better idea
comment down below tell me and we can
learn this together
right so uh what we have done so far
we've created a tabs component uh by
coming up with a nice uh a nice design
component uh component design that we
have and then figure out how to fill in
the gaps on how to achieve what we want
right so things that we have used so far
we have we have used context to pass
data around from tabs to the tab and
pass the tab to the tabs right we pass
um we pass like uh one other selected
tab from the tabs to Tab and we pass uh
titles register like our title register
our
contents ID and title from tab to tabs
then we use uh store in our context
right a reactive store a reactive
context and along the way we also use
things like binding and let's see how we
can use a rectif statements and we have
some workarounds with that so hopefully
this is useful for you to implement
something more nice nicer than what I
have over here my tabs is hideous right
although it's working but it's hideous
but I believe you can do something much
better
So today we're going to talk about two
more magic Global variable which is
dollar dollar props and dollar dollar
rest props
so what are they what are they used for
what are they good for well we'll take a
look at examples and I'm going to show
you what are they for okay so let's take
a look at the example
so here I am trying to come up with a
super nice button component so maybe say
you're a button Library author and you
write very good button library and you
come up with this button
and
and you saw that the user can pass in
different kind of button different types
of button so you can pass in a primary
type or secondary type which renders a
very nice red and gray button for
primary and secondary well that's that's
great so let's take a look at how the
button is implemented over here we are
actually using an actual button but
based on the button type we create a
different class for this button right
and whatever is being passed into this
button and what is whatever is passed in
will be slotted into this slot element
that we've written over here so users
can come over and say do different
things to a button maybe add some bold
text
right it's up to them this looks fine
right this looks great until someone
requests new features to a button say oh
I like your button but can I add
custom styles to your element to your
button component I say yeah sure you can
pass Styles right you can pass Styles
like this a let's see font size equals
to 20 pixel right you can pass those
like this
yes but I have to handle it so you go
over to your button component and you
export let's style you create a new
props so that the user can pass that in
and after that you have to pass the
style to your
um button element as well so you pass it
around to a button element
and that's it now your button can have
custom Styles isn't that great
and then again more requests comes the
user was happy but now they want more
they want to see him
I read about a accessibility I want to
pass in
area label to my button because for some
reason my text is X but it's actually a
close button I want the I want the
uh
speech sorry what's that called again on
a screen reader yes I want a screen
reader to read out this button as a
close button I want to see Aria label
for this is close
can does that work it does not work I
pass this property but it does not work
so you say let me think about it okay
I'm probably gonna say how about I I
can't really name my prop as
Arya
props area label contact I can't do that
right I probably will have to say a real
label no it does not really work that
way as well so I will say okay I'm going
to come up with a property called Aria
label
and I'm gonna come over here and say
Arya
label
to this Aria label
and now you should change it to this way
right
so you go and change your code you add
more props to your component and
sometimes you have to rename your
components and
so that you can pass it you can you can
handle it and pass it to your button
elements that's great right again user
wants more they wants to do more thing
with this button they want to say um is
it possible to pass in like on click to
your button is it possible to
um
passing other attributes that is
available for HTML elements right on
click is available for HTML elements
Aria label is available HTML element
style and there's a lot of other uh
elements HTML attributes that you can
pass the button I want to add them I
want you they want to add it to the
button and they want you to support it
and now you say now you have a headache
every time they come up with a new
attribute someone invented a new
attribute you kind of have to think
about I need to add it to my props and I
need to pass it to my elements so is
that a way that you can
um do it once and for all
all right let me just remove this I
think three attributes is enough to
handle this is kind of too much to
handle
I feel I'm not sure about you
all right so what should you do well the
dollar dollar props and dollar rest
props is here to rescue
so what are they well basically uh
dollar dollar props if you try to
console
dollar dollar props it's actually
I kind of showed it here why can't I
let's see no problem I shall come over
and
just show it here
so dollar dollar props
is actually an object
which
has all which is all the properties that
you bring past into this component all
of them right so if you see style area
label and maybe you add class
do it
um let's see Class A B C all of them uh
you can even have like uh full equals
bar all of the props that you can pass
in will be available as the in object
called dollar dollar props and it will
be reactive so if you change your if you
change your value over here say for
example if it's a timeout
so maybe your type initially is called
primary
and then maybe one second little type
becomes secondary
uh let's see
all right then you see that it changes
as well the props the props itself is
reactive
and that's great so now you basically
need to you have an object and you have
an element that you want to apply it an
object of properties to it what do you
do well you use a spread props so over
here you try to spread over all the
props that you have
oops that's that so you can remove all
of divs and spread all of them to your
button right as you can see your button
itself now
um is big
because you spread the style over the
button itself is now
um have an area label of clothes so
you've inspect
the button element in the inspector
oops
inspects it you should see that the
button itself
has an area label of close it has all
the properties that you were passing
into that sorrow
it has
all the properties that you're trying to
pass through right the class area label
the food the style name type and
everything
well but we lost the color aren't we
right uh so we we kind of lost this uh
the color of the
button because we we spread all the
things over here which include which
include class let me let me remove these
two since we are not using it anymore
we spread everything over the props
include a property called class so that
class overwrites whatever in the class
over here right so so that's that's too
bad you kind of spread everything that's
being given by the button so all the
props that you can see type style area
label class full are all spreaded to
this which is great but not that great
because first thing you you override the
class because you already spread the
class over and you overwrite it
um the the way I walk around is probably
come over and reverse it but
um if say for example in my app does
felt I really do have a class called a
okay I should make it Global because it
does not match anything at the moment
okay Global a I'm going to make the
phone uh style to be italic
now you don't see or you don't see your
buttons to be italic don't you but if
you reverse this
you see your text is italic but then you
don't see your class button primary
applied
aren't you so what should we do about
this
uh maybe we should take out the the
class
um are we supposed to come over
spread over first and then uh class and
then we add a prop start class right is
that is that is that how we should do
yeah probably right but then again if
you inspect element you also see that
the type is being spreaded onto this
button as well but we don't really need
type right type is something that we
can't kind of invented for our
components that is just for us to decide
what kind of class that we apply to the
button and we don't really need that
type to be spreaded into the attribute
of the button
so what should you do
well
Here Comes rest props so rest props
on the other hand
is the rest of the properties that are
not defined as the properties
okay so Props are whatever so dollar
dollar props are whatever being passed
over here right what are all the props
that you pass over here are dollar
dollar props
and rest props are all of the props so
everything of dollar double props minus
the one that is declared as props so
type is declared as props so you don't
um
so dollar dollar rest props itself will
not
have the type right if I come over here
and you inspect
this button
you'll probably see that you'll probably
see you probably won't see type oops
let me close this drag it down yeah you
probably don't see type over here let me
zoom in a bit so that if you can see it
clearly you don't see types over here
all right previously if you use
props instead
then you'll see that the type primary or
secondary is being passed in so rest
props is great if you know some of the
things that you don't want because you
want to handle it differently so you you
export them as props at the same time
you want the rest of the things that
unknown kind of like being specified to
your but being specified over here as a
button that is unknown but you want all
of them collectively and then do
something with it then rest props is
great for that case so I use rest props
and then
I can also I can also do this I can
Define class as my props as well
okay class is ah this is tricky because
class I can't really use this as the
color the
ah okay I can't really do that so
um so I can't uh kind of fix it with
class but we can show uh how about style
right let's just show about style so say
for example I have a star over here and
say a color it goes to Green
right you have a green text and if you
come over here and say I want to add
other styles like font size you probably
see that the font size is being undoed
right uh and because this style comes
before it comes after the rest props or
if you reorder this you'll see that the
text itself is now no longer green and
if you are one both of them you probably
will have to like this way you do dollar
dollar props and Dot class right to get
it but if you say export let's start
over here then you extract the style
away from rest props early because rest
props is what it's all the things being
passed as I shouldn't come over here
it's all the things that you're being
passed as the props minus of whatever
thing that you kind of declared over
here so you have a type style area label
class full minus type and style so you
get only only available class and full
right and now you can just get this
and add it over here right nicely done
and you can see you get a big text and a
green text as well
so here I was initially I was thinking
of doing it for class but then you can't
really export let class it's it's not a
JavaScript it's not a valid JavaScript
syntax so I'm just going to leave it be
all right so now you learn about rest
props and props
we see mostly I think most of the time
it's it's kind of useful when you want
to spread all the attributes to your uh
elements from a component props to a
spread all the unknown component props
known on unknown mostly unknown uh onto
the component from the component props
to something else right for example like
the elements attributes
and let's take a look at another example
so that you don't uh let's try and see
different possibilities of using props
or rest props
here I'm going to create a component
called joke because I found this joke
API web that can create jokes for us
okay so this API is called joke API dot
Dev
and I'm going to come over here and copy
it so here I have I'm going to call this
API with a width uh
okay I probably would want to just have
a button to load so just in case we
don't
um
uh hit the rate limiting so I'm going to
create button and I'm gonna say load
joke
okay so here I Define a function called
load joke
I'm going to call this API
and I okay right now I'm gonna call any
joke with a single type
so here I'm going to async
okay response a wait
and I'm gonna uninstall
um data equals a with response.json
and let's see what should I get from the
data
um joke right I'm gonna get a joke so
here I'm going to Define a variable
called joke
and I'm going to assign joke
equals the data.joke
okay so every time I load a joke I will
get a joke and I'm gonna display it so
here is the joke
okay this is my joke component I'm going
to come here and import this import joke
from joke that's felt okay let me Let Me
Maybe remove this let's see where I'm
gonna use my joke over here
okay when I load the joke you see that I
get a new joke
okay so what does this gonna do with
props can you please direct go to the
point well over here if you take a look
at the joke API there's a lot of things
that you can configure
and it doesn't make sense that you come
over here and Define all the different
props that allows people to Define for
your joke right
um sometimes you want to have joke that
is maybe of type a single
see type single
or you want to type okay no let's let's
not do single things where do you have
we have done that let's do a two-part
joke so the type if it's the type two
parts then you're gonna see a two-part
joke
okay and what else can we do for joke
API we can have Flex to Blacklist so now
I want to Blacklist Flex called NSFW not
safe for work okay let's let's do that
okay what else can I pass to my joke API
say for example I want a custom joke
maybe just a programming joke
um so this is the type it's the
categories right so categories
it's called programming
uh let's see if I don't miscellaneous
what happens okay if I miscellaneous I'm
gonna have comma right so I'm gonna have
programming and dark joke so this is
gonna be my
Doc and programming joke okay so uh what
else can can I get different kind of uh
configuration amount of jokes on my
language let's switch for a French joke
so language code is called French
although I don't understand French but
let's try and do that so language is
French
okay so we have custom joke component
with I want to customize through the
props and
I could have defined all the different
possibilities all the uh
the things that you can pass over here
as an API but I don't have to do that I
can say I can only I think I just need
to define the categories
because the default categories that I
can do
the defaults categories that I can have
is called any if I don't pass in
anything
okay so now I can take this I and I can
use it to change my
query params
so say for example if I come over here
and I'm going to create uh I'm gonna use
what should I use props or rest props
well rest props right because categories
I don't need it anymore as my query
prompt I only need rest props so I'm
gonna come over here and get my rest
props okay rest props
but I need to convert it to a
URL search params so can I say params
equals to new URL search params
do I get the correct I'm not quite sure
let me let me Google there for a while
okay yeah you are such parameters yeah
okay I need to capitalize URL
okay search params
and let's uh let's insert all of them
so what I need is I've got a pen uh all
the rest props
look through my uh
look through the key in rest props
and I'm gonna append this
up and
key and the data
and I'm gonna get the two string to get
my query params okay so here I'm gonna
say
oops sorry
I need the yeah I need question mark
come over here question mark and params
dots to string
okay what did I miss
yeah I don't miss anything okay so now
let's see I have my custom joke that is
dark and programming and two parts
and French joke
and I have another joke that is just
dark and what other languages that I can
have
um say
Portuguese joke PT
which is just a single joke one part
joke
okay and let's try and run this little
oh no what's this ah man let's see can't
access data before initialization
oh this is key this is not data
okay so I have a Portuguese joke
hopefully it's loaded
no please loot the joke
what is happening let's see
Haram starts to string
loot joke
yeah that's correct
and probably I can't load any joke
because
let's see what do I get for data okay
there's no
no matching joke found okay I don't have
a Portuguese duck
joke
that is not safe forward let's try no
Blacklist Flags
let's try run this
no matching joke okay probably just
Portuguese joke with no categories
ah
there's no such language oh no
okay how about just come back and get
some German joke
d e
oh man that's so sad okay let's just use
English joke
okay now I have
an English joke
right
let's talk about this one I can have
um no matching joke found again uh that
is still so sad I'm gonna use French
with two parts joke
no okay two parts you have a setup and a
delivery okay so I am
gonna just make it one thing it's a joke
okay so uh let's see what's the again
probably I have the
uh what is that let's type two parts
right so if data DOT type equals to true
part
then the joke
will be data.setup
plus data.delivery just punch it in
in one sentences
if it's not if it's a single joke then
I'm gonna just do it this way
okay A little joke I have a French
two-part joke
and I can also have an English single
joke
okay so here you see I can use rest
props in in anywhere I want it does not
have to be spreaded over as attributes
on elements I can use rest props or
props as as part of data when I want to
want to fetch something or I will just
use it in somewhere else I can use it
any way I like
so this allows me this opens up that I
don't have to Define all I don't have to
declare all the props over here I can
and allow people to just Define as many
props as they want and I used dollar
dollar props or rest props to access
them
So today we're going to talk about lazy
components what is lazy component well
lazy component is like any component but
you only created create them lazily
which means you only create a component
only when the user can seize it or only
added at a later time what is this
useful for this is useful when you
um have a big huge page a very huge list
or a page that user may scroll to see
more and oftentimes user may or may not
see more of the content so you want to
get only download the necessary
components or the informations you need
and only load more if the user Scrolls
to see them or you know expands or click
on certain interactions to see more
content so we're gonna use what we have
learned so far like the a width block as
well as maybe the dollar dollar props
that we've just learned so far right so
let's take a look at example a rebel so
over here I have app.spel that written
that is importing the component
um not lazily so I'm going to call say
it's importing synchronously so you
directly import this components and this
component will be available right when
you are using the Applause felt
so you import this components and we're
going to pass some props like full and
bar so this component is just like any
other components that you have seen so
far
and now we want to see how we can lazy
load this component
so first thing is we're going to change
how we import this component so if you
use Imports components from a file you
are you are saying that when you have
this app.fl components this component
should be ready together as well until
so you will wait until this com this
file is ready only you you
um
only you proceed with whatever in the
appbox files and usually with a bundle
with a bundler with a build tools like a
webpack or roll up you usually bundle
these components together with the
airport spout right so they are they
come together so they are not loaded
later on deferred
to be loaded later on lazily
so what I'm going to do here is to
change the way how we import this we can
use the dynamic Imports to import the
component file so as if I say this
component does
felt
and I remove this
this okay let me just comment this out
first this hints the browser that okay
this we're gonna fetch this file now
right if you call this function now
you're saying we're going to fetch this
file but this does not blocks whatever
app.fl is doing right now so you import
this and this will return to you a
promise this will return to your promise
that will be resolved
when this component is when this when
this file is being fetched over the
network and it's ready for you to use so
this will return the promise that's why
it's not blocking you can continue to
see whatever over here uh continue to
have whatever in your approach field
while
waiting this later on and you know when
the problem is resolved then you handle
it later on so this creates a promise
and if you use build tools like webpack
and roll up that I mentioned earlier on
what this what the build tool will do
for you is that it will create a
different it will not bundle the
Commerce field together with the AdWords
felt it will create another file right
often in case we call it a separate
chunk so it's a separate file that will
be fetched over later on so they are
although the bundle will try to bundle
all the files together but you'll create
a separate file for this component as
well because it knows that this import
statement hints the bundle that this has
to be a separate file this can be
fetched later on this can be deferred
later on it should not block whatever we
are doing so far
okay so come back to this we right now
we are loading this we
we are fetching this as a separate file
and if you take a look at the network
tab right this is a let's see
I'm not sure whether we can see this but
let's let's try
you should
okay
okay uh sorry I think you can't see this
from a network type but if you use a
build because because of the Ripple
um all these files uh
are not actually fetched they are
somehow simulated to be fetched lazily
but they are not actually going through
the network so if you use a build tool
and you build it probably will see that
you have two files over here on a
network tab one is the bundle for the uh
like the Applause Road and another one
will be the component as felt right
so uh trust me when I say that this will
be loads lazily right so over here when
it's finished loaded it should return me
a promise right this this is a promise
so I'm gonna say a component promise
I can wait for this promise so I can use
a weights block to do that for me I can
see I can wait
this component promise
and I can say maybe loading
right and when it's resolved
um this will give me an object
with
a default property right so I can I can
do I can have my destructuring over here
but you have not uh familiar with it
this is like
um
yeah I I can have a destructuring so I
can get out the get the default property
from this uh from the resolve object
from this promise and can use it later
on so over here when I want to use it so
first thing I would want to rename this
property because if I can use default uh
but I can't really use the uh but if I
destructure it as a default I probably
can't use it like this as an element
called default because
um it starts with a lowercase letter
which means it should be an element
rather than a component right itself
just looks at the first character and
say okay it's a low case there should be
a element it's not a component we want
to create a components that's being
returned from here and the components is
in the default property so what we can
do is we can rename this we can rename
it to say component
okay and we we use it over here so this
is capital letter so we can use it and
now we have our components same thing
goes we want to pass some props to this
component we can come over here and
we can pass it to this component and now
you see that this component is is being
loaded and you can see full one two
three bar four five six
right as if nothing has changed
but you can come over here and
um
load this later on so here we call
Imports immediately when we we call it
immediately when you uh
in the initialization of the app does
felt right but sometimes that is not
what we want we want to wait for certain
interactions or wait for this components
to be actually shown to the user only we
load this uh this component because for
example sometimes you have a very huge
list and you want to okay so I'm going
to create a huge list over here so
imagine I have a big uh big block of
content over here
and let's say background is blue
and the height is
1000 pixels you have a very huge blue
content over here and if I come over
here in a component uh console.log
you see that
this initialize has been called
immediately although I haven't seen my
components I can actually load this
later on until you know when I scroll to
the end and see this component so what I
can do instead I can come over here and
maybe create a small div
that has this used viewport action so
this viewport action is an action that
we have written I've created a video
over here that talks about how we can
write a viewport action in the use
viewport action example
so this action what it does is that it
will observe
um your elements if it intersects with
the viewport if it comes into the
viewports then you'll get notified you
get an event and therefore you that's
when we want to load our component so
I'm going to use this use viewport and
then import import viewport from the use
viewport action
okay you import this file viewport when
you use this action on this component
using use
and then when it's entering the viewport
you will see this event called
on enter viewport
so I can call on enter viewport and I'm
going to do something
which what I'm going to do is
I am going to load my component so here
I can
I can have maybe a flag over here is
loaded it goes to false
and here when I enter I'm going to say
is loaded
to true
and I want to load my component as well
so I only want to load it once so when I
say check if it's loaded
if it's not loaded then I'm going to
load it and I'm going to set it's loaded
to true and therefore I will load it
once so what I'm going to do here is
that I'm going to change this component
problem is to be let
and we'll come over here and
uh set this component promise
to this import
ant component.felt over here
okay and now my component promise is
um is is undefined at first so I
probably wants to check first before I
await for it I wait for anything okay
for now I wait for undefined I will get
resolved uh to do whatever it is right
because sometimes uh when you await a
promise you will get whatever is you you
wait for that promise to return but
you've await something that is not a
promise then you kind of immediately
resolve with whatever that thing is so
uh so right now what happens is that we
are awaiting undefined and undefined
it's not an object and we can't
destructure here that's why it says
cannot be property default of undefined
so we're going to first check if a
component promise is
something right I can do this just make
sure that it's not undefined and we
promise that we always set it to set it
to something else which is a promise
when we want to actually load it so now
you see when we do this
um
first thing you'll notice is that
component is not loaded yet if you look
at here initialize it's not called and
if you try to inspect the elements you
probably gonna see that there's nothing
here right you only okay let me Zoom it
up a lot more
I think this is big enough
you probably see that you have the blue
diff over here this is our little div
that we try to see whether we um
we are
uh whether whether we are entering the
viewport right this is like our little
marker over here that that is right
above the component where the component
will be right so now if I scroll
scroll and when this div enters the
viewport oh no it's not working
let's see let's see uh on enter viewport
is not loaded then
okay let me check over here whether an
interview part
will be called okay so if I come here
and scroll
ah it's not being called so something is
wrong with the action itself maybe is
the event
name
and maybe is that this div has no
content
maybe I'm gonna set maybe like a style
wait hold on it's entering viewpoints ah
man what happened
uh
okay so if I scroll
you see that it's loaded so I'm not very
sure what
what's happening probably
I was okay I typed this out maybe my
spelling was wrong so play back and see
what happens I have no idea what's
happening so here uh as you can see we
didn't really change much but but only
when you so so only
when this initialize it's not called
this component is not loaded yet it's
not being fetched yet and when we scroll
down all the way you see that once it's
entering a viewport it's being fetched
and it's being loaded and you see this
component right
um because how the rebel works this
component is being finished so fast that
you can't see the loading state but yeah
you probably have to handle like a
loading put something like a placehold
over here so that when it's loading
um you you you have something nice to
wait for
right so uh this is how you would
roughly create a
lazily loaded component but then again
to do this to to do all this is a lot
and if you want to do it for every time
every every time you want to lazily load
a components that you have to write this
right viewport and have a promise and
wait for it and all this it is not that
hard but how about let's make it into a
component that handles this for us so
we're gonna have this component called
lazy component lazy
and let's again go for API first
approach to design how we want to look
how we want this lazy component to do
feel like how you want to use this and
then if you go take a step back and
figure out whether this is possible is
feasible and let's see how we can
Implement that so how I would want my
lazy components to be is I'm going to
write lazy over here
all right I want to have my lazy
components and hopefully this lazy
component handles all the viewports
thing for me so I don't have to take
care of that
and probably I would want to also pass
in uh maybe like a props call this
which is the com uh the okay not this
but get
component
right it has to be okay it has to be a
function
import
okay it has to be a function at first I
was thinking of writing maybe lazy
uh let me let me enter a few lines so
that we don't get disrupted by that so
initially I was thinking of like writing
as lazy and
look at this just like how we would
write the spelled component with this
right I was thinking of having this kind
of similar props and API Style
but the thing about it I need to have a
function rather a component I can still
use this the name
I'm kind of not that hinting that it's
gonna be a function but I can still use
this okay maybe let's just decide that
it's called this I'm going to call
import right this this has to be a
function because this only will be
called this function will only be called
when we want to load it right if it's if
it's a components then there's no point
and if it's already if you already call
it Imports directly then it has it has
no point as well because this is like
yes it is another file but you kind of
call it immediately right we want this
lazy component to handle the viewport
when we only load this only call this
function I'll call this import when we
are entering the viewport so we're gonna
change this to a function
and of course what we want also we want
to come over here and pass whatever
props that we want to pass to this
component
so that yeah we want to pass all of this
to this component so that uh you can
pass it over to this component itself
okay now we have this and also maybe we
want to think about loading States we
can have a fallback for a loading state
that shows loading dot right but we want
to also may be a way to specify that by
the user so I'm gonna come over here and
say lazy
and I can use a slot to do that for me I
can write a
okay not not that different but I'm
gonna write loading
but I'm gonna style it over here so that
it looks slightly different at style
okay first thing I want to have a slot
attribute first because I don't want to
use a default slots because I may want
to use that for something else but this
one the name slots uh I'm gonna name it
I'm going to name it as a loading state
right loading
and now I'm gonna install my
style my div let's see what I'm gonna
have is
uh div
ING with all this indentation
nothing wrong okay
it's my div I'm gonna say a color is
blue just just to see that it is being
styled right okay this is not class this
should be an element okay we are done
with here and now let's design our lazy
component
so far so good although you can't
respond but hopefully you you can see
where I'm coming from now let's design
our lazy components so you can see over
here we we can pass arbitrary
numbers of properties to our lazy
component and hopefully you can see by
now uh what we have learned so far we've
downloaded all the props all the rest
props this is what we're going to use to
pass all this to the component to the
underlying components all right first
thing is we're gonna take in a prop
called this right this
spot let's this
uh let's import lazy import lazy from
and meantime I'm gonna I'm gonna copy
all this
and then comment it out right we don't
need this but we probably would have to
implement something like this over here
okay so we can't uh oh no we can't use
this let's this over here
um
that because this is a keyword that we
can't really use this so probably we can
rename this somehow right I'm gonna say
this is gonna load component
and let's see I wanna but I I can have I
can do this where I simply
rename it with my export so export load
component as this
so here this is not going to complain
that this is a a special default uh it's
this will treat this as just a normal
variable name it does not have the
context of being a
uh was that call again
uh
uh yeah
a certain a special keyword a projected
keyword this over here whatever you pass
in can be any string or even emojis if
you want
so here uh let's let's try to import
some of the stuff that we have imported
previously
the viewport
and then a I think that's all so we need
a state called it's loaded and the
component is
component promise right so you can see
oops that's not what and let's is loaded
and let
component
promise
okay
uh we are done with this
and now let's see
external reference only please con
so I'm gonna use this load component
over here in States
so we enter viewport we're gonna load
okay so I'm gonna uh I think all this
will is okay now and you're gonna come
over here and use the rest props instead
um yeah rest props because we don't need
the this props as the props to our
component right and I think that's all
so uh one oh another thing over here
um we we have our slots loading slots so
we're gonna install have a defaults
we're gonna have a slot component named
loading
and of course we're going to provide
some fallback called loading if it's not
provided so if I scroll down
see again it's called initialize and
then you see the data over here and
everything is still passed through
nicely because if you use a rest props
so we press everything that is being
passed to our lazy component
to our components to the underlying
component so let me clean this up we
don't do this anymore
okay we're not don't need all of this
anymore
and let's clean this up
so before we end probably let me do some
more do some more cleanup right uh first
thing is I don't need this div anymore
uh once I've entered right so the way I
do it is I still have it and I still
listening to the viewports but every
time
uh it's entering again the next time I
will check this flag when this flag is
false uh when this flag is true then I
am not triggering anything anymore but
what I can do instead is I can have a
different flag which is uh I can use the
same flag but only render this div when
it's not loaded so if it's loaded if
it's not loaded I'm going to show this
diff
so every time when I enter I will load
something right
but then we also know that
one is being called this load is loaded
Will turns to True which means that it
will hide this div and that's
oops
which means we'll hide this div and that
is the only time you will see this on
enter viewport uh
the events being triggered right so once
it's been once it's called loaded
uh
it doesn't mean that it's actually
loaded right it's just that okay we now
we are trying to load this uh component
uh this lazy component so maybe I can
change this name again to to some more
suitable to our case oh yeah uh
uh
okay I'm just gonna leave it I can't
think of good names right now so this is
only this is like loaded it just tells
us okay now we are going to show this
component right if you haven't show uh
okay I'm gonna stay showing okay it's
showing component
right if it's not showing
okay by default is false if it's not
showing then you have this div that has
this viewport action that tells us
whether it's entering a viewport one is
entering we set it to True which means
we're gonna hide this if
we're gonna hide this uh
div anymore we're gonna hide this div
and now we're gonna fetch our
a lazy component
right so over here we also don't really
need to check if component promise
because once we know that if it's
showing component is true uh the
component promise is
assume that it will be a promise right
so we can also remove this check uh this
is unnecessary now because every time a
showing component is through this
component will always be a promise so
let me nicely format everything and here
we end up with if showing then we if
it's not showing we have a div that
tells us whether we are entering
Viewpoint once it's enter showing is
true then now we're actually waiting for
our component promise to wait for this
to resolve and show our component so
let's let's scroll back up and let's run
this thing again
right okay let's see okay run this thing
again so now you don't see the
initialize combo is not loaded and once
we scroll it all the way down you see
components here and immediately it's
initialized so that's all well
I thought so too but then I think about
it even more I realized that yes I have
my lazy component but at the same time
I'm kind of lost something is lost along
the way for example if my component self
have same binding for example I'm going
to come over here and create this uh bar
that can bind to a variable
so input bind value equals to bar
if I create this input
and somehow over here I also want to
show this value of bar which is a
variable let's bar
over here
and I want to bind This Bar
with bar
and let's okay let's initialize this
with four five six
let's try this so let's scroll all the
way down okay we see four five six over
here and the bar and the input and if I
try to do something like this you see
that the binding is not working
and you may ask like why
well here's why
um
binding is actually passing a
property called bar to this component
and also tries to subscribe to any
changes in the props of the lazy
component but the lazy component itself
does not have anything does not change
the props directly it spreads all the
props to this component so it passed
down the bar to this component but
itself does not pass down The Binding
that it's receiving to the component
itself so there's no way uh as in once
you use this lazy component you kind of
lost the thing that you can do with
these components now you can't do events
you would have to to add events you
would have to forward all the component
events uh through the means of component
event forwarding and at the current uh
and currently there's no way to forward
all the events you can only forward
um
again only forward based on the events
names that you know right so there's no
way that you can in advance know all the
events that you need forward so that is
one issue and also binding does not
works so you kind of lost this when you
are using this lazy components that
tries very hard to encapsulate the logic
of lazy loading right and capital logic
of trying to know when to load when
you're entering viewport and then
showing a loading uh components when
it's loading and then only use the
components
so I I think about I thought about that
and I realized that hey there's one
thing we haven't utilized that's one way
they can use it's like it's uh which is
to use a let props
so here is how it is going to be so
imagine here I have my lazy components
and I pass all this uh properties and
bindings and stuff to this uh via this
lazy components right but what about how
about uh we can also create another slot
attribute over here I'm going to call it
uh spelled fragment
oh sorry hold on this should be a
closing
I'm gonna use felt fragment so that I
can read more things uh here as also
components here my lead binding I can
actually use a let's component I can
have uh I can only I can get this
component from lazy components right so
it will load and here I'm going to use a
slot attribute called component
right meaning when this component is
finished loaded it will try to have a
slot element with a name called slot
name called components so this part
whatever I'm going to render within this
felt fragment will only be shown when
the component is loaded and what is that
component the component itself is
provided through this let's binding so
here I can actually do I will change
actually create this component
and I can pass all the props I want
myself right so here I don't have this
limit of having to
um
event forwarding for the component
because I'm already using this component
right here I don't have to worry about
buying things to pass down bindings and
stuff uh because I'm doing myself
directly to this component
right so this component can be any
component being resolved from here
uh this is just like a variable but you
can treat it as yeah it is a variable
you treat it as a variable but it itself
is a component and I'm gonna use it over
here
so now how do I uh
uh implement this
so um we've learned so far that if you
are slot attribute called component then
you need a name slots call components so
here when it's done and create a slot
name component
right and we learned that if you want to
use a lead binding over here this data
is being passed into the slot as props
so here we what we want to pass in is
this component so we're going to pass
this component as props to my slots and
now I can remove this because I don't
need any more
and let's and everything still works
fine right so now let's take a look
Moment of Truth and now we're gonna
scroll so nothing is initialized until
we scroll the way down
so this component as you see even if we
write it here it's not created yet right
and all the way when you scroll down now
it's initialized and this component is
created and added and mounted to the Dom
here during initialization phase you see
the console log right and now when we
want to try The Binding or type
something you notice that this four five
six seven eight nine comes from here so
The Binding Works The Binding Works
nicely and we don't have to sweat about
trying to figure out how to pass down
The Binding through a component
and if you try to add events over here
right on click Maybe
oops
I'm just gonna say this and let's add
the buttons and forward that event
you'll realize that when I click this
button let me uh add more space over
here I'm not sure my hit is blocking
this so let me add it at the front
so now when you click me you'll notice
that this event is also being dispatched
and I can listen from here right so
there's no need to go through this lazy
component previously we create this
component within the lazy component so
if you want you have to forward the
event yourself and now we don't have to
do that it's so easy right now so I
would say that this will be what imagine
my lazy components be like
So today we're going to talk about a
special elements called svelte component
so have you ever have this situation
where you want to based on the condition
use component a but as a different
condition you want to use component B
and at a certain condition you want to
use component C
this ABC component I actually
interchangeable they are they're taking
a different the same props it's kind of
taking the same
um have the same behavior but you just
want to use different components
different of them
for different situations
and how do you do that usually let's
take a look at an example usually what
you would do is you would have a if
statement and switch between them right
so right now I have if statement based
on the condition I want to use full and
sometimes I want to use bar
and actually Foo and bar can take in can
bind value
right you can bind value to full and Bar
and so that full and bar can handle them
right can they oh no I haven't
implemented so let's come let's do this
so let's have this let's value
and full will show an input type
uh number
and bind value so full have its own
input
and bind a value bar will do almost the
same thing as well
um yeah except they show a different
words okay
um of course there's better way of doing
this but let's assume that the looks
almost the same takes in almost the same
props and have almost the same behavior
actually this is exactly the same
behavior so let's maybe let's try uh
something else let's say aim
okay I need actually exports let's value
in the states
so that it's a props
for bar I am going to have buttons and
States on click
this is 200
okay on click value will be 200.
another button on click will be 400.
okay so bar has this button that you can
click and change the value and full has
this number
uh that you can change input text that
you can change
so they they both have the same props
called value and they can they work
slightly differently internally and what
when do you want to render full or bar
basically based on some other conditions
right in this case based on value if
it's 50 you will show full or else your
show bar okay this is very contrived but
this is just going to show how this
works right so when you come over here
and you change this value to say 70 you
will see full right and full can change
this back to zero and then you see bar
but I can click to change to 200 and you
see full right based on the condition
you want to switch between different
components
so one way is of course use an if else
statements then you would have to
implement
uh if you have a lot of props that you
want to pass in a equals something b
equals something c equal to something if
a lot of props that you know pass into
both of them and both of the case have
actually the same props that you want to
pass them
then you may start to question yourself
is there a way that I can extract all
this out
and switch between prop components well
if you don't have a bind value then yes
there's of course some ways that you can
do say for example you can come up with
props object so I can say a equals a
b equals to B
C equals to C
and I can spread the props right I can
spread the props so
so I can kind of still keep them the
same uh try to reuse as many code as
possible but buying you can't do that
right if you have events like on click
over here and on click over here you you
can't reuse it right uh so directives
you can't really reuse by using a
spreadable using a spread props you have
to write them manually
so again you are thinking Hmm can I have
a way that dynamically changed between
full and Bar while you're watching The
Right video to learn the right stuff as
a title show this is called swell
component so we are going to use felt
component to solve this
so how does that work well spell
component
over here
it's spelled component
is a special elements in swelt so
usually special elements starts with a
swelt and a colon right so these are not
normal elements there are special
elements in svelte okay so Spell
components must have a this attribute so
what this attribute though is that
whenever you pass in should be a
component
so for example based on a certain
scenario I want full or one a bar I can
say uh okay I can I can have eternal
real over here and say I want full based
on this scenario and I want bar for this
scenario okay so I can now come over
here and copy all the rest
to this special elements and this will I
can replace whatever I have written back
there with this all right so spelled
component this is the this takes in the
component that I want and then I can
pass in however many props that they are
sharing right you can have some extra
ones that just for full and of a bar
um if but does not text it it's okay you
can have more than you need for for one
of them right but I think it's okay
um so here you you use this and now
let's see does it still works if I
change to 200 now you see full and I
switch it back to zero now you see bar
and all the binding still works right so
for example if I change it to 200 and
come over here and I change it uh 200 to
300 oh sorry 200 and I'm gonna type
something all the binding still works
you can just treat this as a component
that is being created with full or with
bar based on this condition over here
and and all the all the directives uh
different kind of directives bindings on
event listeners and as well as props
spread props all kind of props they are
all works they will all of them will be
passed to full or bar
so here you go you have a spell
component that allows you to quickly
switch between uh different components
and while while you have while they can
text in the same props
right so sometimes you don't write it
this way where you don't kind of a
uh
uh have this Expressions over here maybe
sometimes you may want to say come over
here and declare a
reactive the variable called component
and do it this way
it's fine as well this works as well
right if you switch between it still
works
and sometimes for some reason right say
for example maybe value is greater than
then you actually don't want to show
something you use a null or undefined
over here
let's see I think undefined works as
well so in this case when you hit 400
you're actually not render anything
right I think now works as well let's
let's let me try I can't remember yeah
now works as well so now or undefined
now or undefined as long as the
component is now undefined that you pass
it over here for the disk so if this is
now undefined you don't see anything
right there's no error there's no error
where uh the component is undefined and
you can't create it right spell will
just remove it so if you are rendering
nut if you chose nothing here then you
don't see a component and if you go back
turn it back to 50 then you you start
see your component based on this
condition so what components you're
giving was your comp component you are
getting out over here
So today we're going to learn about a
special swell element wait
it's felt special Elements which is
spelled self so what is civil self well
it's well let's take a look and we shall
see take a look at an example so the
example I prepared for you over here
is I want to create a visualization for
arrays right so if I have an array say
the data is one two three four five
I'm going to display it uh
um like like this right I I wrap the
array with a blue box and each of the
item with a red box so you see that this
array has five items
nicely done
but sometimes life is not that easy
sometimes the array is not flat this
array is flat right you only have one
level but sometimes some people may
create a really that are nested for
example like this you can you get nested
arrays so what should you do with it
right
um by default if you don't do anything
if you get an array it will you you will
make it a string by calling like a
string and wrap it become a string and
when you wrap a make a real string you
get a comma separated value of the item
right so this is what you get
um
yeah but this is not what we want we
want is wrap this with a blue box and
each of the item with red box and then
do it recursively because 3 is another
level of another level of the array
right so what can you do probably we can
extract this out into another component
and call it again right call it
recursively
well how about call yourself recursively
because this component itself will know
it already handles a rape and we can use
ourselves inside ourselves recursively
when it's an array
and as a title suggests you can do that
with this specials spell special
elements called spelled self so let's
take a look at how we can do this right
so over here if you come up here you see
that item we can check the type of the
item right so if say for example if the
or the item is an array I use array is
array
then we can
um come over here and use I'm gonna
render ourselves right so our self is
self
and can pass data to ourselves right so
here what I'm gonna do is the data is a
props I'm gonna pass in item the sub
item over here
pass in data and if it's not okay let me
let me format this nicely right so if
it's an array then I'm going to use
myself
and if it's not which I'm going to use a
else
then I'm going to show my I'm just just
showing myself so over here you see
um
it creates this nicely recursive pattern
so I have a blue box which is the big
the array itself and I have three Red
Box inside right one and then this uh
two I have two red three three Red Box
because I have three items and within
one of it I have another blue array a
blue box because it's an array and I
create uh two three four right three
items and then this is a server yourself
and I create this thing over here over
and over again right so when you want to
recursively render yourself over and
over and over again you can use this
component called as well cells and it
pass props to it right so
you can or can uh you you can choose
past to pass or not to pass any props to
it and you can do this recursively right
render yourself recursively with spelled
cells so there's a few rules that you
when you use felt self right to prevent
yourself to unconditionally render
yourself again and again and again and
reach and infinite Loops you can't use
felt self outside here right so it says
spelled self can only exist inside if
each or within a slots right so inside
if hopefully it's because hopefully you
are smart enough to not come out with
condition like if true and always render
myself right hopefully you don't do that
at the top level of course this is still
kind of uh safe in a sense where item
itself can is is numb
is
uh sorry what was I'm trying to say
yeah save that this is this bricks
because items sometimes is not an array
it's a data right so if you still pass
something that is
um
something that is part of yourself then
yeah you're still okay you're still
stiff right
for example if I come over here and as
long as I wrap it with if right even if
I say if always true
um then I can come over here and pass
like some some data that probably
supposedly to be lesser than itself and
no that's not true also so you have to
have a condition to stop that recursive
Loop if you have that then you are safe
then you don't end up with a un
unconditionally
going all the way down the rabbit hole
and never ending
all right so let me undo all this and
let's come back and enjoy and be amazed
by this recursive components created
using spelled self
let's continue with our svelt special
elements we'll talk about spelled self
and sveld component today we're going to
talk about svelt window
so let's take a look at some examples on
when we can use this spell window and
what is it about
so over here we have our application
so sometimes you want to listen to
window events for example over here we
try to listen to resize because we want
to get
the windows inner width right so we
listen to on the window and then you
um listen to this event listeners and
then get the window in a width so every
time when you resize you get a new value
right so as you can see here the width
itself is changing because I'm resizing
the window
and sometimes you want to also listens
to events uh for example key down in
this case so it's the same case
previously as we listened to precise and
then we get the property from the window
and this time we listen to events and
try to react to it right so this time
this one when we add event listeners
like key down for example when you click
Ctrl f
you will want to focus on this input bar
rather than having the bit default
browser Behavior which is event prevent
default right prevent the default
behavior from the browser which is to do
a global search like here
uh let's see like
yeah something like this a global search
you want to change that you want to
Focus over here in States
so um
so how you would usually do is you would
maybe wait for a component to be mounted
so you add the event listeners in on
mounts and remember to return a function
to clean it up so that you don't lead to
like a memory leak
so um yes you can do it this way but
today we'll talk about swell window
right and spelled window is actually a
way for you to add event listeners and
read out some properties such as inner
width from the window without having to
manually set up your event listeners and
listen to it and update it so let's take
a look at maybe the first one which is
this one which is closer so that we can
change one by one so here we listen to
the keto events and we add this
um call this event handler right
so
uh
an alternative would be having a spelled
window
element
and we add this event listeners over
here so you can treat this special
element spelled window like your window
element except it won't render anything
so there's nothing being rendered uh
that there's nothing new there's no new
element created by this special element
itself but rather this special element
is here for you to add event listeners
so here I can add on key down
and let's stick let's copy this event
handler let's collapse this and comment
all of them
uh on key down
so pass this in over here
and let's try to click Ctrl F and
everything still works
so you can
use you can write this instead using on
key now
and the same thing as how you add event
listeners with elements spell well take
care for you when you want to announce
this component you remember to remove
the event listeners from window so this
is a slightly shorter version of writing
all that we have written so far adding
event listeners and remove even
listeners when we are when we don't need
it all right so it's felt window again
it's a special element so that you can
do this on a window object another
example that we've seen so far is to add
a resize and then read this inner width
right so
so we can add also or you can come over
here and
add this on resize
and this event listeners call on resize
I'm going to copy all this
I wouldn't say all this but it's just
one
a few lines over here
on resize
copy this and pass it over here
right so now when we resize our width
you can see that we still update the
value we still have these event
listeners and update this value uh in a
way right
um is there a better way or is it a
shorter way I would say better but
that's a shorter way of writing this yes
that's actually a shorter way of writing
this which is if you which is you can
use a binding right binding is like a
two-way binding uh where you can bind
you can set the width of the window well
I'm not sure whether you can but you can
also when when the events happening you
will update this variable from the
property of a uh from property of your
element right in this case of element is
window we are we want to listen to some
event we want spell to handle that know
what event so listen and listen to the
event and then update our variable so we
can actually bind inner wave over here
instead of writing it on resize so let
me comment this let me remove this let's
come over here bind ER with and I'm
going to bind to the variable with the
same name
all right so there's a shorthand writing
there for binding which is just do this
and now we can even go ahead and remove
this on precise handle
and everything still works fine
so one of the things that you can buy
into and what events you can listen to
well for events you can listen to all
the events uh that is available on
window or any elements right but most uh
but of course it's on you make sure that
it makes sense to listen on to the
window right so you can basically listen
to any events you can there's no
restriction over here but for binding on
window elements there is
um some of the things that you can do so
here I'm at the tutorial for swelt and
this chapter where it says well binding
it's spelled binding you'll see that
there's a few properties that you can
bind to
um so in a weave in the height of the
width of the heights scroll X scroll Y
and online so you can bind all this
variable so the first four is more about
the window size and as you can see here
everything except scroll X and scroll y
are read only meaning although you are
using a two-way binding The Binding but
you only have one direction from it
which is from the element events and
then update the variable instead of
having a variable update step right it
does not make sense that you have a
variable that can update can change the
window size right that is most of the
case I use that is only user Dragon like
resizable height and width right um
as well as online status right online
whether the user is connected to the
internet or not this is um
this is not you can't change the user's
connectivity you can only have events
like the online on offline events from
the window and then read this property
out of Windows and Navigator
although of course scroll next and
scroll why you can change both ways
right you can change the scroll position
or get the scroll version to change your
variable so these are things that you
can bind to the window and instead of
writing your own event listeners on a
window object you can use this special
element called spell window
let's continue with our svelt special
elements we've covered spelled self it's
felt component spelled
was that spelled window and now we're
gonna conquer threat body
so by the name svelt body you kind of
know that it's kind of similar with
spelled window which is allows you to
add event listeners on the body so take
a look at this example that I prepared
for you so far
um I spent some time to create this nice
visual which uh at a mouse move event
listeners on the body so whenever I move
my mouse on the body you see that uh I'm
updating the mouse position X and Y and
does create this very nice pattern which
I use two linear gradient so one is
linear gradient from top to bottom from
a transparent linear transparent color
and do all the way to a solid color
solid red color but with 50 opacity so
that you can see that on the next
gradient I'm going to lay on top which
is from left to right transparent and
then on the right side you have blue
which is again opacity of 50 so on the
so you get a top bottom transparent to
red and then left to right transparent
to Blue so on the bottom right corner
you you see a combination of both color
which is kind of a little bit of
purple-ish color so um so the gradient
we use a color we use a stop point which
is the percentage which is calculated by
the mouse position X and Y divided by
the body kind height and width therefore
you can see this when I move my mouse
you can see that it's drawing a gradient
at uh stopping at a different position
so with n we use document body event
listeners to add this
and as we've seen in the earlier video
which on the spelled window we say that
if you have we can use a special element
like spell window to add event listeners
on it so that as felt can also help us
take care of removing even listeners
when we are not needed anymore so same
case like this we don't have to come
over and add our own village at our own
village event listeners and remove them
you can create this special element
called
svelt body
and add our event listeners over there
so sveld body itself will not create
anything on your screen except it's just
a special element that allows you to add
event listeners onto the body so here
I'm going to say add on
and we're going to use a mouse move
event
and call this function Mouse move
so at the same time we're going to copy
this mouse move event handler collapse
this on Mount and comment everything
oops let me let me do this comment
and now I'm going to create this
multiple function
so
um now everything still works the same
except now we don't have to come don't
have to add event license on unmount and
then remember to clean it up we can have
all this handled by the special element
svelt body to allow us to attach event
listeners onto the body
so um that's all about cell body there's
nothing more that you want that's all
about it
um so at least if you download this if
you go over take it over to the link on
this Rebel you can also play around with
this so that you learn something
unexpected
so let's continue with our special
elements
if you talk about self spell
component
spell Windows felt body and now we can
continue with svelt hit so what is felt
hit similar to sveld window and spelled
body it allows us to add event listeners
to the window or body weight but we
don't add event listeners to as well to
hit to the Head element right no we
don't do that but we do use a head
element to add links meta tags and other
stuff right so swell hit is these
special elements that allow you to add
things to the Head element in your HTML
right you usually use as well components
to
um render something or to add elements
on a specific Target which is usually in
the within the body but sometimes you
want for for what for some reasons you
want because of SEO reasons you want to
add some meta tags meta tags based on
your content onto the title or onto the
description or you want to add external
links just only when this component is
loaded you want to add some external
links to the head you want to do
something add something to the Head this
is this special elements swell hit 4.
so here I have an empty rebel I haven't
done anything but just to show you that
how this works I'm gonna create
um svelt hit
and I'm gonna come over here and
go to I randomly Google some
um Mana text for SEO and here is the
first link that I see so I'm just gonna
come over here and copy some of the
stuff okay so we need some title text so
how about the title of the tag is based
on
[Music]
um
based on the name variable so here I'm
going to have a input by value
equals a name
so here is the wall and here I can use
this variable over here like name like
this
so you although you don't see the title
change over here but because this Ripple
is within an iframe so I'm going to
inspect element and take a look at the
HTML within this uh documents these
iframe documents so here if I zoom
enough so that you can see clearer I
have my head elements and there's this
title called wool so as I type over here
as I type you see that this title is
updating right the content of this title
is changing based on is is dynamic and
it's based on the variable or content
over here so that's why you you will
want this felt hit a special element if
your hit content is fairly static you
know that you want this for all your
pages then you can just write it into
your HTML you don't need this special
elements you usually use it because you
have some Dynamic contents inside
right so next if I take a look what's
next over here is some description
right meta description text so copy
again and I'm gonna paste it in
um again I'm just gonna use name for the
contents in this meta tag
and you will see that now the meta
description the content is called world
and as I type the meta description
changes as well so here you can add as
many meta text you want anything as long
as you wrap it within swell hit they
will be inserted into the head
so let's take a look at another use case
that sometimes I would use because of
the rebel I want to add some
some fonts to this Rebel and usually
when I come over here on Google fonts
when I select some of the fonts it tells
me to come over here
to use it on web use a link and add it
to your head of your HTML but on a rebel
I have no way to whoops sorry
and the rebel have no way
to add HTML to control the HTML so I
need spell head to do that for me so
over here I'm going to copy these two
links this links uh over in the head
and now I can apply the style to my
elements so here I'm gonna have
I'm going to add the div
over here and I'm going to add style
tags so that I can style the div
oops Style
the div and the input
and come over here and copy the font
family I'm not sure you can see this
hopefully not covered by my head but I'm
going to copy it
um over I'm just copying things from the
Google Phone website you can see here my
phone family is just now dancing script
and cursive if I switch over you can see
that now I am showing a cursive script
on both the input and the div
if we take a look at the
um the head of the HTML you will see
that besides title and some Styles this
Styles is added uh this is the style
that is added for this newly Creator
Styles and also have some meta tags
links as we added over here in the spell
head
okay so there's a lot of things anything
is possible within swell hit you can
even have say a style tag added over
here and maybe a
maybe use some uh so anything that you
can write over here will be inserted to
the spell head right so here maybe I
want to do something like
um style and then I have what is that
I'm gonna say Okay root can add some
um
CSS custom properties I'm gonna say
roots and over here I'm gonna have the
maybe font color equals and then I'm use
name for the value okay and here I am
going to use my CSS custom property so
color equals to VAR font color
and as I change this to say red hold on
uh maybe I'm not doing it right let's
take a look at
whether this is updating correctly
because it may not be
uh
let's take a look at our special Style
Elements that we just created root okay
this does not handle nicely okay so this
does not work but we can use HTML
and set the content over here instead
wait hold on I'm not supposed to add it
over here but rather I'm going to add
this whole thing
to wrap over the whole Style Elements
so I'm going to use a HTML tag to add
content over here and this content and
add this content on to the hit so if you
look at here this is being added okay
sorry hold on this should be like this
this whole thing is added to
the it's holding is added to the Head
Right the style is added to the head if
you want anything to edit hit use a
spell hit element and here now if you
change this word to Red you kind of see
that this font color turns to Red
because we set uh the font color custom
property to be
uh to be whatever we are typing in the
inputs and we use that value to be our
color of our uh text over here so if I
change it to uh Rebecca purple
you can see that it changes to replica
purple
of course it doesn't have to add this
Style Elements onto the head then you
can yeah add it over here somewhere in
the body as well it's up to you right so
because style element itself does not
have to be just on the head it can be
anywhere right but usually people like
to edit on the head that's why we are
adding it over here like this
so there you go as well hit element a
special element that does not do does
not add anything on the screen
that you see but edit at the behind the
scenes which is on your head element it
adds anything you add to this felt hit
element will be added to the Head
today we're going to talk about svelt
options
so as well options is a special element
in svelte which allows you to
customize compile options of your Spell
components
customize compile options for as well
components what is that
well if we're not sure about compile
options of components basically spell
options is it's it's beyond our Beyond
us right so let's first take a look at
what are they so over here and I when
I'm looking at API docs which shows uh
which if you go to the spell compile
section it says that you can use this as
well or compile method a function to
compile just felt source code so usually
you don't do this yourself you use it
you use some plugins or loaders
in based on your build tools so for
example if you are using roll up you're
using rollup plugins welt if you're
using webpack you're using spell loader
using something else it's something
something plugins well something
something right so under the hood they
are calling svelt's compiler which is a
metalcore spell.compile to compile your
code
into JavaScript right it takes in this
source code that you write and it spits
out JavaScript code
and this method itself the first
argument is the source code you write
the second argument is the options it's
actually the compile options uh for your
result component so over here there's a
lot of things for example the file name
so this is useful for debugging there's
like name there's format there's
generally there's Dev uh whether it's a
development mode or production mode so
that whether you insert more uh runtime
checks or insert more debugging
um
debugging methods or functions inside
right then you have immutable
hydratable Legacy assessors custom
elements so there's a lot of things over
here which I'm not going to go through
each of everyone especially those that
are related to its custom elements we're
going to talk about them more
extensively we will talk about custom
elements okay so stay tuned if you want
to watch about that subscribe to my
channel so that you get notified when
that's it out so here
um if you scroll through you probably
see that some of the things
sounds familiar
if you read the docs for or tutorials
for spell options okay if you haven't so
here I'm gonna jump over to take a look
right here I'm at the spell tutorial it
says that you can have small options to
come to make some changes right so here
here are the options that you can set
immutable assessors namespace and tags
um so these are here right so you have
tag you have accessors and you have
immutable
so here if I read it out it says that
blah blah blah blah blah right so
instead of reading them out we're gonna
try one by one and see what that affects
the source code that's about is
generating for us
right so we are going to focus on these
three uh rather we're going to focus on
two which is immutable and accessors uh
and name space so three so for tag which
is related to custom elements again I've
said we're going to talk about that
extensively when I talk about custom
elements subscribe to my channel again
okay if you want to get notified for
that so here let's take a look at the
first one which is a more simpler one
right we start from simpler and move our
way up to something more complex so
we'll start with namespace so here we
are back at our Rebel over here this is
our code and over here on the right is
the output
so if you take a look when you write div
and if we write some SVG elements for
example a group element
if you go over here and look at the JS
outputs
you'll realize that they end up
a different code which is one is created
using a function called elements and the
other is using a function called SVG
elements why are they different that's
because the underlying API is different
one is created using document.create
element
and another will be document create
element name space right if I'm not
wrong so
um
why is this different well because svelt
has a little how does veld knows that
this G element is supposed to be SVG
Wells felt uh maintains a list of all
the elements over here so here I'm at
the source code
um and compiler
where it sees that over here SVG
elements are all this right odd glyph
devs animates animate motion Circle
color depths and all everything that you
see over here so they are created using
a different API from the Dom that's why
you need to differentiate them but
however if for some reasons when you're
creating an element and this element is
not in this list in this SVG list as
well has no idea that this is actually
an SVG element
then there's one way that you can tell
spell that okay hey how how about this
all these elements that is written in
this component should be considered as
an SVG element
and how you do that is you're going to
use a namespace option over here so you
could either pass it to the
I'm not sure you have this name space
over here
yeah you could either pass it as
namespace over here in the compile
options
which you can have a HTML math
ml SVG foreign and and foreign over here
what we want is SVG right so you can
tell that okay hey you create this
element using SVG element so you say
you'll come over here and write asphalt
options
namespace equals SVG
uh you can close it immediately you can
create you can close it later on it's
okay but here you see namespace is SVG
and you take a look at the code now
we're creating elements we even treat
divs as SVG
right so if you're using other things
like say spelled natives or other
um compose elements that seems like a
normal Dom elements but it's not then
you can actually pass different
namespace for example Hub but instead
you're using document elements maybe you
create a new namespace called foreign
and you use that to create an element
right Custom Custom namespace so this is
um
the namespace option fair enough right
just treat all these elements whether
they are using a normal element document
create element API because that's only
for HTML with SVG or it's other things
math HTML and other stuff you use a
different you just tell them you just
tell spell that okay use a different
name space
okay so let's move on to the next one
which is ancestors true or false right
adding Getters and Setters what does
that mean okay so here if you have props
for example here I have name props I can
add accessors which is like Getters for
this Getters and Setters for my props
so um let's take a look at
what does that mean so over here I'm
going to copy all these codes and come
over here and say component
paste this in
I remove this
okay so here I have my components and if
I import this component in Parts
component
and
add this in over here
I can bind the
instance of this component to a variable
so I'm going to bind this to component
here
um
I'm going to add on Mount so that I know
for sure this component instance is
available
and on Mount
cover here and say component
I'm gonna console log this component so
this should gives us the instance of
this component so of course I need to
declare this variable
so here uh probably you can see anything
but if you inspect you open the console
you should see that
okay let me clear this and run this
again you should see that this component
have some methods to it
um most of them are private the only
thing that you kind of able to use is if
you come over here to look at component
API which is this these are the
so-called slightly public methods for
example sets and for events and Destroy
to remove your components right so if
you come over here and you set
uh you can set uh the props right so
here I'm gonna say component
dot sets
I'm going to pass in a object and here I
have name right so I'm going to pass
name to something else name to buy
foreign
[Music]
update the value of the props using the
sets dollar sets method to update the
buy a name to buy and you see this value
has changed
uh of course this you can use this but
sometimes you want a slightly easier way
of getting the props or changing the
props over here there's no way that for
you to basically read out the value of
the props right so what we need is
so-called assessors so we're going to
add the swap options to the components
that we want to have accessors which is
this component come over here and say
spell options uh assessors
equals to true
so false is the default
if we take a look here it says false
it's the default if we want the asset
getter and Setters we need to pass it as
true
so here we have accessors as true now
what we can do is you can convert here
and say component dot name equals to buy
at the same time if you take a look at
one of the components that's log out you
can see properties over here right now
previously there's no such thing and now
you have new property and we can now
read the value out and update value
directly over here using accessors so
now if I close the console and take a
look at the output let's see what's the
difference right so we'll focus on the
components and see the code over here so
it generates a class
for your component
and it adds this to the name the getter
for the name and the center for updating
the name right under the hood is still
using the dot sets method except that
it's much easier for you to just call
component.dame equals something right so
that you can set it if you remove this
line or just change this to false
then these two getter and Setter is not
generated
so by default this is false for some
reason if you want this you can turn it
to true all right this is usually I'm
not sure what is being used in real life
but one very nice cases that been using
is in the test test cases for source
code you will see that this is turned on
so that we can just read out the props
value so that we can verify you can
check uh but we can check in our test
cases asserts whether the props is right
now the value that we are expecting
so this is excesses so if you have
multiple options that you want to change
for example just now we were saying like
a namespace and now it's accessories
then you use the same Spell option
element and add more stuff over here
right
um if you try to create another spell
options elements you probably see that
you will say that one component can only
have one spell options tag so you can
only have one so if you want to have
configure multiple of them just create
multiple attributes right here now we
are fully that's okay for assessors so
we're gonna move on to
um the last one which is immutable
so if you watch my previous videos on
spell store you probably noticed that uh
in the immutable star we talk about how
we use this when we are saying that we
want to have immutable data so what is
this immutable options okay so here is a
ex explanation from my a slightly easier
explanation on this option itself so by
default uh if you come over here let's
continue using this component let me set
it up first say for example I have
another state object called uh object
okay this is an object
and has a few properties say maybe
name equals my name and maybe ish oh no
it's a secret okay secrets
so here I have an object
and I can
show the value of this uh state so I'm
coming over here and object dot uh okay
let me
okay this is not let's just
commence this out
right hey what's wrong with okay
now we have object dot name
and is
object.h
okay so I I'm gonna read this name and
of the object a name and object H and
you can see this display on the screen
okay that shouldn't be a problem so now
we have a buttons that we want to uh
updates the object right so when I have
this button when I click this button
what happens is that
uh I will set maybe object.name it goes
to
felt so I when I click this button let's
see let's have this button button
hey where does my button go okay names
access namespace is fpg so it's creating
an SVG element equipment element in the
SVG namespace that's why you don't see
the button over here let's remove this
or change it to HTML to tell you that
this is the default see the button over
here so here if I click on the button it
mutates the object
uh by setting the name equal to svelte
and now you can see this is updated on
the screen right I think we've been used
to do this for and this is the default
behavior of svelt right so what happens
is that actually uh what spell cares is
uh down to the bottom of this is it only
cares about the state variable right so
name is not really a state variable it's
it's the object itself is a variable
that is a state so any top level
variables over here that is being that
can be changed and is being used in a
template is considered as States
variable so like name and object over
here not this object name or object.h
right so
every time when you change something
when you change this object it will
um it will
go to spelled and say okay this is
changed but before that we also need to
verify whether is it actually changed so
for example if you come over here and do
something like name it goes to world
since it's already wool and you try to
click and so if you do this you're
changing name to bank to the same value
nothing will happen when I say nothing
will happen it's not like you click and
you see nothing and husband right of
course it's gonna even if something has
happened it's updating the variable wall
the name to the value wall and you don't
see it happen but when I say nothing is
happening has happened is that it's
actually nothing has happened so if you
import
uh say before update
so technically this function should call
when there's an update and right before
something has updated right so if you
come over here and register before
update and let's just add uh maybe like
a console log to let us know whether
something is happening like something is
updating
you realize that okay when I click this
button nothing has happened you don't
see a before update it's being logged
out we change this to world to wall two
when you click you see that before
update is being called right two times
right the first time is when when we
Mount this component second time is when
you click on the button but you are
changing back to the same value nothing
has happened why because right before
when you assign or right after you do an
assign and before I'll say hey this
variable has changed and this file does
one check it checks whether the value is
the same as what is being assigned to
so if the value is exactly the same
then we can just even skip this update
cycle don't run like before updates and
you know go and check like updates as
elements and then call like after update
and all those stuff don't do anything
because nothing is Gonna Change
um but how about object if you do this
if you come over here and do this to
object
what are you going to compare with if
we're going to compare by the object
reference
nothing has changed right you are
mutating the object object reference is
still the same then technically nothing
should happen
but because we've been kind of promoting
mutating this object uh in a sense where
we're saying like you can just change
this object directly and it should
trigger a
um a change and update so this
comparison this compare method of
comparing whether something has changed
or not is not your typical triple equal
it's not your typical referential equal
that compares and see whether something
has changed it actually has an uh
special case for
special case for objects and function it
treats all objects of function as it's
always changing right as long as you do
this and say oh I guess object is
changing and you call this function a
check it will always say that okay if
it's on the object it should be changing
right I don't check the value at all and
if you take a look at this
um
generated code over here what this
function that I just described is called
save not equal over here and you can
read this Source or save not equal
over here let me find it for you it's
called runtime internal util it's called
save not equal
let me Zoom it up if it's not clear
enough it says that compare this object
right if something has changed or as
long as the object is object or function
it should be changing just treat it as
it will change if you if you assign to
something else although you're assigning
it to the same object reference as long
as you are assigning to an object it
should just you just treat it as it has
changed right so this is how it is
um
and you can actually change this
Behavior right if you all the assessors
that sorry all the assignments that
you're doing even to objects are not
mutable meaning you are not mutating
this object then you can have this flag
turned on which is called
immutable immutable we set it to true
then now it's spelled
uh trust you that you say that
everything when you want to change it's
going to be an immutable change meaning
it believes you say that this is not
gonna happen so whenever you try to
assess or something like this it will
just check the object reference it will
check your object versus the reference
of the object that was currently and if
you try to click this button now you see
that nothing has happened before update
it's not being called
but don't forget you are still mutating
the objects meaning if you come over
here and say uh maybe we add some time
out uh some interval to log out the
value of the object say here on Mount
and we're gonna add this uh when on
Mount
let me type uh let's interval ID equals
to set interval
uh every maybe one second
I'm gonna say console log object
and return
clear interval
interval ID
okay so now every second we are
Consulting out the object
and
when you click yes nothing has changed
but you realize that this object name
has changed to svelt okay that I believe
we have been running this uh there's a
lot of things being running because we
we refresh so let me just refresh and
only it it
hot reloads every time when I type
that's why maybe there's a lot of things
printed out at the same time right so
now we only have one object printed once
a second so here again when we click the
button nothing has changed but you
mutate the object and now you see that
the object name is spelled emitted
object right but then because swell
trusts you that when you you won't do
mutation right meaning when you do this
it will still say Okay I want to
something has changed object has changed
here okay go and check but now you're
not used this uh what's that called
again you're not calling save not equal
you're not using save not equal you're
using uh not equal over here you're
using not equal which is comparing uh
it's a triple equal comparison to your
um
to the object right so if you take a
look at the source code now scroll all
the way down it's called not equal right
this is a triple equal meaning if your
object reference is still the same
we are not considered it as a change
right there's no special case for object
over here so if you do this then
yeah you're not gonna see any
changes happening on the screen
so the way to now is to do this right
object equals to and then you do uh uh
you do not mutating object rather you
try to maybe update the object over here
manually so H equals to object.h
right you create rather update red sorry
I shouldn't say updates but rather you
uh create a new object every time you
want to mute it
so here you call name spelled and H
equals the original H are usually what
people likes to do is to just spread
this object and because there's a lot of
properties that could be changing so you
do a spreading
uh let me let me oh no wonder it's not
working it should be clear interval
no wonder it's not cleaning up for me
okay let's be refresh again
right so here
uh you you do this
and now uh you look at the object when I
click it change to spelled right now you
see I'm I'm not gonna mutate I'm I'm
gonna create a new object for you right
so when is this useful this is useful
when you are using when you
when you update object every time
immutably right meaning every time you
want to update something you create a
new object or maybe when you're using
some sort of library that promises your
data that makes your data to be
immutable
right and you can turn on this immutable
flag only on that component when you're
using those kind of data you don't have
to apply to all the components right
some usually when you come over here to
your compile options that we've seen so
far uh usually you specify this in your
build tool to your plugins right or
swell loaders or roll-up plugins felt so
that will apply to all the components
but here you are only turning it on for
this particular component if your other
component is changing object mutably is
still okay it is still okay so right now
if I look at GS output this is still
safe not equal but for components felt
if you scroll down it says it's not
equal right so this will only apply to
one component only
so um using if you so the the inverse of
it is you're gonna say immutable to be
false but that we know is the default
Behavior right it says this is the
default Behavior
so so there you go we've talked about
immutable options namespace options and
assessors options so options are like
compiler options that determines what is
your output your generated code will
look like where to add extra code or
change some of the output of your
generated JavaScript code from asphalt
source code right usually you apply you
Pro you provide this to your plugin for
your build system but if you want to
apply this only for particular for one
component only then you can use these
swell options element which allows you
to change only this component
so there you go spell options if you
have any questions any questions
comments down below because I believe
all these are very
different from what we have used to be
doing because this is more of a meta
level you try to change the output code
and tweak a bit on the behavior which we
don't usually interact every time when
we're using svelt but it is there
so we have seen how we able to style our
elements in svelts using the style
attributes class attributes we've talked
about how we can use the class directive
that you can toggle on and off apply
certain class to your elements and today
we're going to explore another features
from svelts that allows us to pass
custom properties from CSS CSS custom
properties to a component and we're
going to explore how that help us to
style our components control certain
Styles within our components well this
is actually a new feature added and it's
felt in version 3.38
based on this RFC as you can see on the
screen RFC
pr13 it says passing CSS custom
properties to components and it's say
that there's a lot of text that you can
take a read about this I'll link this in
the description
explain the motivations and things like
that but you know uh it's we're not
going to read all this out for you
rather we're going to explore how this
will help us
um in part like controlling some parts
of your components uh
stylings from the outside this feature
will give us one more tool in our tool
chain to help us style our components
so let's take a look at an example that
prepared over here
so here I have a button component I
create three buttons on the screen with
the red button the blue and the yellow
and as you can see how I control the
style of the components is by using the
props so I'm going to pass in a props
called button color and sometimes I pass
a props called text color that control
the color of the text
because if you take a look at the codes
in this button component you'll see that
actually allows two props a button and a
text and the there's some default colors
so the default will be the red color and
default colorful text will be white and
as you can see we're gonna use these two
uh value in our style attribute so the
background is using the button color and
the color is using the text color
so all good
um yeah I would say that this is this is
one of a good pattern for you to allow
um
installing the your components right but
sometimes you you might want you might
think that sometimes you know for some
reasons you you don't want to
um
use the props to control the style of
your components because sometimes you
think that a
like props should be more of like data
kind of thing more for JavaScript site
if you want styling maybe you want to do
it on a CSS side right so here we have
another here I would like to propose an
alternative
um to what you can do over here I
wouldn't say this is better or like
worse is it's just like an alternative
one more tool in your toolbox that you
can use and employ
so here sometimes you want to style your
elements using a CSS custom properties
so CSS custom properties
um
custom properties that is
um that that are not like world uh
that that are not defined then you can
customly Define so properties are like
background and color they are like
built-in properties right but then you
also can Define some custom properties
for example
um
uh
um the way you do it is that you come
over here and you add
two dashes and you name your custom
properties over here so here I can say
maybe a custom property called button
color
um and then I pass in a value so maybe I
can pass in value like red and to use
this custom property I will come over
here and say VAR button color
in States
right so now you can see all my buttons
are in red color so this is the custom
property right you can Define it
anywhere any element and it will follow
inheritance based on the Dom tree
structure right so if your parents
Define this custom properties all the
elements Dom elements based on the Dom
structure of the three Elementary will
will receive these custom properties and
can able to use this custom property
right so here you uh we we are defining
and using it on the same elements so you
can have you can come over here and have
a span instead
uh and come over here and use this value
if you want to so say style background
it equals to yeah over here and it does
not have to be used in an inline style
you can also have uh things like maybe a
style tag and say Define like a spine
elements with a background equals to VAR
background color right so you can Define
this custom property over here called
button color and all its elements and
its element to room will be able to use
this custom property
um so depends on what the value is you
you will use that value over here and
you can use this value across a lot of
places right it doesn't have to be just
in Span background color it can if you
have another say a div over here
um
see some text some text you can also use
it uh multiple places right so it's just
all all the elements that uh is
underneath of
all the elements that is within this
scope of your custom property will be
able to use this custom the value of
this custom property over here so as you
can see you can have the text and some
text in different color and yeah using
background and color different
properties can use the same custom
properties over here
so
uh what this means is that because you
can use this uh element uh this custom
property
once you apply to one element all these
children will receive it right so
meaning it doesn't have to be come over
here it doesn't have to be within uh
this button component you can have this
written somewhere else somewhere higher
uh as long as it's a parent of the uh of
your elements in the elementary
structure in your Dom tree structure
right so if I say I wrap this button
with this uh if I wrap the button with a
div and I come over here and Define
the style of say button color
as read
you can see that now this button will
receive this button calibrate because
these two Now does not have any color
plight because the button color is
undefined and if you have undefined then
the background and color will be
undefined
so you can uh this so in CSS if you want
to use a custom property and sometimes
you know that maybe this may be
undefined you want to provide a fallback
so the way of providing fallback for a
custom property will be come over here
in your bar you see a custom property
name and then a fallback value so here
I'm going to fall back to say blue
uh and here I'm gonna fall back to say
blue as well
and now as you can see
oh sorry yeah it's not working because I
shouldn't have the quotes and now you
can see that now uh instead of red
you'll fall back to Blue
and if I come over here and ramp this uh
buttons
and I say
style equals to button color yellow
you'll see that now this will be in
yellow color
right and so in this is this is all CSS
right it has nothing actually has
nothing to do with felt
um and one more thing I want to point
out is this itself can be uh there there
is like hierarchy uh there is like
inherit some sort of like inheritance in
terms of the elementary of of your
custom property right if
um the when you are reading a custom
property you read from a nearest parent
that is defining this custom property
meaning if you come over here and uh
and Define another div
that
has a style called button
color green you see that you still the
yellow still applies this is the same as
how you add CSS property in your in your
style of sheet in your elements right
when you when you change the color to
green and you change the color in this
div to be yellow then all the text will
be in color yellow because the nearest
parents rule applies right and it
overwrites whatever is set out there
right so if I if I remove this you'll
see that now it's in yellow in green
color because now the the nearest one
will be this one that's been defined
right so so CSS custom property is very
similar as a normal property in CSS
except uh this is custom you can Define
any name you want and you start it with
two dashes and you can use it in any way
you want uh like like a variable in CSS
where you use VAR and then this custom
property name and then if you want
optionally you can have a fallback value
right so all of this is is about CSS
we've got nothing to do with components
but now we're going to tie it back a bit
on how we can use it
um in our components how we can use this
to style a component
so here instead of providing props if we
now have another way that we can instead
of providing props now we have another
way that we can
um
allow people to affect
um the colors or the styles of our
elements right here we instead of
providing props we now we say if we
Define you know docs somewhere like in
our component if I say that okay we are
going to use this property called button
color to style our button
then from outside here we know that okay
we just need to provide this style like
color green then you'll affect a color
yellow over here then you will affect
the color inside right this is this is
somewhat like a props but it works in a
element Dom tree Dom element structure
way and it works using CSS it got
nothing to do with the Spells at all
but here once you define like okay I
would accept CSS variable like color and
CSS uh maybe property called text right
let me let me go back to here and say
let me revert some of our changes let's
say background color it's going to be
VAR
button color and then fall back to red
and color will be
using VAR text color and fall back to
White okay I forgot I shouldn't use
quotes because quote the snow Works in
CSS okay if I do this
um I can also remove all these things
all right just let me just revert all
the changes I've made so far
now we can don't we don't have to take
in any props and we can allow people to
come over here and style this right I
can see uh text color is black
and now you can see I'm styling this
yellow button to be yellow color and
black and this button to be a div
style button color
blue
and text color
uh
uh yellow right
so some people will prefer uh using CSS
to style like everything relates to
style use CSS some people may have that
preference and this is one of the way
that you can use right this is this is
purely CSS got nothing to do with uh
spell at all it's just about you can use
you can pass a CSS custom properties
from the outsides and then you can
affect Styles and inside of your
component
uh one good thing about using this
method is that you don't have to come
over here and reach into
elements inside the components so
meaning you don't have to know uh like
for example
uh previously if you if you don't have
CSS custom properties to to change the
style inside using CSS and you don't
have any props to change that the one
way that you can do uh is to to use the
style to to try to change it right where
you would write div and then maybe you
know that somehow you know that within a
component there's a button so you look
for the button elements and you want to
change uh something inside there right
uh maybe font size
20 pixels and because the button itself
is not written like there's in this
element itself there's no div button and
because this button is written inside
the components usually right here with a
global so that we can Target uh go
buttons that is within not within this
component file but it's within some
components that we are using so we we
have retargeting the div that is scope
to these components all the div and if
they have a button inside those buttons
should be font size of 20 pixel
right so this somehow is a bit leaky in
a sense where you kind of have to know
uh what elements is rendered inside your
components of course you can document
that you can you can publicly say okay I
will have a buttons elements and you can
style it right it's up to you but
sometimes you don't want to expose that
sometimes you know sometimes you're
using a button element sometimes for
some logic you're using a span or some
other elements and you don't want to
expose that as a public API for publicly
for other people to know
um so so that is so in that sense you
wouldn't want to do this
so here is an alternative where you can
use CSS is that okay how about I don't
tell you what kind of elements that will
be but I tell you like what kind of CSS
custom properties I've been using for
example in this case button color and
text color and just style them right you
don't know how I would use them because
I may have multiple elements that use
the same custom Properties or use a few
custom properties say I can use this
button color as a background I can use
it in my box Shadow and all these things
I'll just let you know you don't have to
like find a way to override them I just
let you know I'm going to use this
custom property and you can just change
it to change the style of my component
right in that way uh you use a CSS
comfortable property to override them
over here
so so there is there you go how to use
Uh custom properties to do this but
sometimes you don't want to add an extra
div and that there is for good reasons
you don't want to add an extra div
um because if I revert all this you may
notice something happens when I add an
extra div uh you notice okay not just
the color I've changed notice that this
button and all this button button itself
is an inline element uh display inline
block uh you notice that now
uh these two buttons are side by side
but once you add a div like this
kind of create a new uh
for Block formatting context which makes
this diff uh renders in a new line right
so you add Styles over here and you say
uh
button color yellow
and text color black creates a new light
right so oh I think I need two dashes
over here create a new line and
sometimes we don't want that right so if
you know okay this is creating a new
line maybe we can use a span because
span is inline itself but that means we
kind of
uh have to know like what kind of
elements inside and kind of have to
decide whether we are going to use a div
or span or maybe you know within these
components is actually rendering two
buttons
and it itself may have some sort of uh
if if the parents container is using
some display Flex or something you may
adding an extra element over here means
all that your will break your layout
right for example maybe you you're using
a grid right a grid is a good example
because using a grid uh each elements in
a grid level uh decides which
um
where do you place that grid element
right so for example I come over here
and say div
uh over here with a div we're going to
use display grid
um you create template columns
uh I'm just gonna one fi one FR grid
template rows okay I don't even need
this right you notice that now I have
um two by how many however many rows of
a grid okay maybe I just do three right
uh if you know if I don't have this div
all the wrapping diff you'll notice that
buttons are rendered in a three by two
Matrix but once you wrap with a span
over here this whole thing is considered
as one right this whole span is
considered as one now these two buttons
are rendered within a one grid one grid
cell
right uh which is which is which is not
great which is not what we want we just
want to have a way to style at like a
style custom elements on over here and
it now breaks our layout
uh it doesn't matter whether we are
using default span right it's just
because
previously there's two elements now it
becomes only one element
so the way to solve this again we're
going to reach out to CSS a way to solve
this is to use a custom display value
which is called display
contents
what this display contents means is that
uh treat this div itself as nothing SS
nothing at all in terms of layouts right
so what this means is that I'm it's I'm
just don't consider me at all when
you're doing layout just consider all my
contents right if my contents has two
elements it should consist two elements
and and you place these two elements
separately in your Grid or whatever
layout you're using just consider me as
nothing consumers has gone I'm not here
at all in terms of layout so which means
this element itself cannot be applied I
cannot have like padding can I have
margin can I have anything right just
it's just gone in terms of CSS layouts
so here uh we kind of solved this with
display contents and
um and now again we can add uh CSM Uh
custom properties to this button right
of course this is a very contrived
example because sometimes you don't have
all these different buttons that you
want to have different styles maybe in
your case all your buttons are all your
buttons you want is yellow and black
text button right then maybe you don't
even need to wrap div at this level
you just need to wrap it over here you
just need to add this custom properties
over here right uh
just need to add over here and all the
buttons are yellow color and black right
then you don't even need to worry about
display contents at all because yeah
it's it's this does not matter at all
right so the the case that I've showed
you just now is when
um you want to start a particular button
component over here you you want to wrap
around a particular components because
it wants to have
starlings custom properties defined on
that is specific to this button itself
right so let me revert some of the
things uh let me copy back this and I
just want to say that it's different
because this is
green and white okay you can see now
again it's not too um it's not occupying
two cells separate independently now we
use display
um contents
and now you see there are individual
cells
so we we have talked uh we will spend
the whole video talking about how we CSS
CSS custom properties how we can use
them what kind of uh situation that you
may occur how you can work around and
fix it how you can use display contents
and things like that so where does this
where does our passing CSS custom
properties to components come into play
well
uh we are actually staring at it pretty
close right now
so here we we say that we come into some
sort of conclusion when you have certain
scenarios where you want to wrap a
component with a div just because you
want to style it and you want to have
this div to have display contents
because you don't want to affect the
layouts because maybe this button itself
the parent of it has some sort of
display grid or display Flex you don't
want to break it
and you want to have a div elements that
you define some some CSS custom
properties so that you can
um
affect this button only and not its
neighbor and stuff like that right so
um so svelt actually provides a sugar
syntax so to to
um to have a shortcut syntax to write
all this to write this div that as has
display contents as custom properties
applied to it right so it's a shortcut
uh it's a sugar sugar syntax what it
means is that we write some nicely
written syntax but under the hood it's
going to translate into what it is which
is what we're going to see over here
right what you're going to translate is
you have a div and display contents and
all this thing over here
so let's let's see how the sugar syntax
looks like so here instead of writing
this we can have okay I think these two
props are useless so we can remove
and just to compare I have my original
code over here and I'm going to show you
how it will turn out to be uh
in in over here right so the sugar
syntax is that you can have a props that
starts that starts with double dashes
and you can name with uh you can have a
property value like this
right and now you can remove this div
yeah and both of these looks the same I
will inspect element you'll notice that
this and this is actually the same
exactly the same just that allows us to
write this way it looks like Slicker you
don't have to figure out you don't have
to write display contents you don't have
to write extra divs uh your your code
looks shorter and nicer sweeter because
of the sugar but under the hood it's
actually doing this right this this just
translates to this and then you you
um
yeah and then you get spelled to uh
render whatever to control this div
right and also what this means is that
we've seen previously where we can have
Dynamic styling from on the diff where
you can have say color over here a
property called color
let's that color equals to Green
you can have that over here as well
color
um and then this variable itself can be
dynamic so if I have an input type color
buying value equals to color
you can see over here if I come over
here and choose uh
pink you can see all these button colors
change so this is dynamic
right so uh here you go passing CSS
custom properties to components
um so one caveat over this is that this
is this custom property these custom
props that you pass in as a custom
property for your component
um
um has to be written this way you can't
use a spread props meaning you can't
actually spread it uh if you have an
object that have discount property
right this does not works because
um it's a limitation of this
this custom properties for components
right now because in compound time we
actually have to know what this uh what
what are the whether you have an extra
whether you have custom properties uh
defined on this CSS custom property
defined on this component itself if you
do this and you have like some sort of
variable that you can spread over in
compound time there's no way to know
whether you have custom properties using
right with custom properties then you
will wrap the component with a div
without then you don't even need this
div at all because yeah pointless right
so you need to know whether you need to
create this extra diff compile time
that's why itself cannot be spreaded
across this this custom props cannot be
spreaded
so I hope that explains why and the
limitations of what you can do and of
course you don't always have to reach
out for this as I explained earlier you
can also Define custom properties over
here if you want to when you want to
wrap across all the components you want
yeah then you don't have to actually
reach out to this this will be even
better
but instead of having like wrapping all
the button components with extra div
elements
So today we're going to talk about ad
HTML so what is it well we shall take a
look
so imagine you have this scenario where
you have a HTML string that is
dynamically generated and you want to
insert all this HTML string in somewhere
in your head in your document right in
your Dom so what do you do so maybe you
can use an action well let's take a look
if if you want to use an action and how
you would do that right so here I have a
div and a text area that I can edit my
HTML so what I need to do is probably
use an action over here uh
inner HTML
and I'm gonna pass my HTML into this
action right so let's define this
uh this action so I can have inner HTML
as an action that takes in a node so
node will be the div that I'm applying
this action to
and the HTML which is the text that I'm
going to pass in over here
right so usually what you would do is
maybe you want to add all this HTML
inside this element right so actually
dump your your Dom API provides an API
called a you know HTML so you can say
node.inner
HTML
equals to no it goes to HTML
right here you see that you get
this is a baltex and click me button
right
that's that's easy right so next thing
is if you try to update this
uh return so you need to return an
update method over here
HTML what we need to do is constantly
update the
in the HTML of your nodes so if I type
something
it should update
a sequence uh update on Demand right as
you as you change the text
so you could use this
um
action to achieve what you want to do
but that's an even easier way to do it
in sveld which is used at HTML so as
HTML actually does all of the above that
we have done so far but using
uh but we we've packaged it up in a nice
API which is called at HTML so let's
write add HTML
and you can throw all these things away
and here you pass in an Expressions so
an Expressions can be anything that just
form a string that you would like to be
installed as an inner HTML in your in
the element so you would say HTML over
here
and now we remove this action
see that everything still looks the same
and you don't have to even handle the
case where Dynamic taxes text you can
change it dynamically it will update by
itself
that's good right so
um sometimes uh this is good enough for
you but sometimes you have some
requirements right so sometimes this
HTML comes from some API somewhere that
you can control
um but itself have some some
parts of the HTML is Interactive
right so uh there's two parts over here
so if this HTML is somewhere that you
can't control at all then you kind of
have to insert it as ADD HTML over here
right uh dynamically update it right but
if it's somewhere that you can control
then my suggestion for you would be copy
all this come over here create a new
component paste it in and then just
import it right then
um then it's once it's a lot way easier
to add interactions to elements over
here for example adding on click for the
button have some Dynamic contents to
update the text things like that right
but how about your case that is that you
can't control for example this text is
being clapped out over here
um and so so the text is generated On
Demand on the Fly uh somewhere that you
can't really control like for example
this is being typed out by the user and
now uh the tricky part is you want to
add interactions to some of the elements
so for example you want to make all the
buttons click to have a kind of like a
similar
click you want to have a click
Handler on the buttons right so each
button probably has some ID right over
here I have some ID uh XYZ and when I
have a quick function I want to know for
example here
I want to know uh maybe
once the
buttons ID and I can do something with
it right so here I could have say
event.targets uh dot ID
and I just console out but you know I
can I can do anything with projects
right the thing is how do I attach this
event listener to this button that we
just generated
so this is tricky
right so when you
right right now when you want to do it
you realize that you haven't have the
reference to this to any of the buttons
yet so how do you add event listeners to
the button right so where you have to
edit is you have to add it during on
Mount why because before once models and
only if you do it over here for example
you come over here and say
document.query uh selector button
and you will add event listener
you realize that uh
realize that you have error because the
button you can't find the buttons yet
because the button is not yet available
for you
so what you have to do is come in here
use unmount
and then run this during unmount so I
can come over here and say on Mount
and find the buttons and then add event
listener right that that's that's only
when the button is available for you but
in this case
it's a bit tricky
let's select all the buttons on the
screen right uh meaning uh because your
query selector on a button on the
document so if if uh
if this is an optional uh if if I said
for your situation that it's possible
for you to find out all the uh like a
container elements then a better way is
you have maybe like a div buying this
right you have a container reference a
container and you use that to query all
the buttons inside this div right so
this is slightly safer than doing a
documented query selector all right
you're finding all the buttons within
the documents right so here we only find
all the buttons within this div
so
hopefully that's only limited to only
this HTML buttons over here so over here
I add event listener
um and I console log
click right
now you see that it works
however if I'm going to change this now
this most likely will set in the HTML
updates all this all everything over
here replace the HTML
text which then will uh by for the
browser it means to recreate all the
elements right now when you click on
click me nothing happens
so what should you do now
well uh one way that you can do is
um have a way to
uh runs every time on HTML changes right
and that is to use a reactive statement
right so you have over here HTML
and then you would do something
uh
Dutch button this
so what what this line of code means is
that forever for this is how a reactive
statement works right so when you look
at it you'll see two variables over here
HTML and attach button listeners
whenever either of the uh whenever
either of the
um
either of the variable has changed then
this statement will be reruns right in
this case since function attach button
listener is a function and we never
change it then it's indirectly means
that anytime when a HTML changes uh this
this whole statement is being
re-evaluated because uh you can write
this way as well it doesn't
in our case it doesn't really matter
because HTML is kind of always something
right so if you write this HTML attach
button listener then yeah you want to do
something
foreign
selector you'll realize that there's a
few errors first is that div is not yet
available because you have a mount a
you you will run this you either this
first before your first mounting any
elements right so relative statements or
reactive declarations will be run uh
even before like after initializing your
component but before you try to
mount the elements when you're trying to
create elements the all the reactive
statements will be run because sometimes
you want to declare some reactive
variables right and you're going to use
it in a template so this has to be run
ahead before you
before you actually create an element
and mount it on a Dom so over here diff
will be undefined
um so what do you do in this case I
would think that um
we would
either check like we could check if div
is it's not available then
we return right so we we over here if we
look at console log
every time I will change something
where I said it will be Evil Dead
but again this is going to be evaluated
before we're going to update something
so
um what this means is that if you notice
that uh I uh although I I I type and I'm
gonna call this every time but when you
click nothing happens why because this
runs right before any changes right
because you you want to if it's a
reactive statements or variables that
you're trying to update it you want the
variable to be updated before you
actually make changes with them right
before you update them and things like
that because you want the variable to be
ready first right all those reactively
declare variables to be updated first
before you up to the top so over here
when this is being run you're actually
accessing the old contents right you are
finding all the all button and then
attach event listeners to them
so this is
not what you want what you want is you
want to come over here at
tick
you want to wait for a tick before you
oops
you want to wait for a tick before uh
before you actually search for the
buttons and then make some changes right
so now once the tick is done actually
the div is also being defined because
the tick happened the tick will be
resolved the tick will return a function
that will be resolved when updates or
mounting has has done if you're not sure
about how tick works I have a video
about tick you should check that out
links in the description and hopefully
you're on somewhere in your screen right
so
uh we wait for our tick and then we
select uh so we wait for updates as wait
for updates happens and then only you
look for buttons and attach even
listeners right so here if I click now
you can still see a click me I'm gonna
change something and then I click this
will still happen because uh you will
anytime HTML changes your your way for
the changes to be applied then only you
figure out uh you find the the newest uh
buttons and then you attach event
listeners
so here we always attach event listeners
um
but we never remove them so will this be
an issue and how do we resolve it right
so here uh let's let's try to just use
this event listener in States
no matter no big deal it's just that uh
it's easier to remove this because we
can reference to the same function right
so here
um
this still works right we still print we
print out the XYZ of the button so if
you have multiple buttons over here
I can use selector all and then for each
button
button dot add event listener
all right so here if I create more
button
ID equals to exact
click me to
whoops
what's wrong with this
okay
okay so if I click this you see exactly
it click this you say XYZ right and
every time we change something uh
everything still works but we actually
haven't we haven't removed event
listeners for for previously selected
button so here what should we do is that
we should as I mentioned here we kind of
know that if we call this is every time
when a HMR changes right so there's two
phase one is before you want to create
uh any elements right the first time
when the component is mounted you run
this uh first and then only you mount a
component and we use a tick to wait for
that mounting to what be done only we
select for any elements and updates
attach event listeners right the same
thing happens when HTML changes you call
this function
but that's update hasn't been done right
you call this function so we wait for
tick we wait for the changes to be
actually applied to the Dom
then we select the newly created buttons
and attach the balances so there's
there's always like before the update is
done which is like the prior right which
is over here before things has been
updated or before the things has been
created over here we can actually find
out all the buttons that we have over
here and then
um remove evaluations from them right so
here uh I would need to check if this is
being defined first because
um
there's two cases right one is mounting
One is updating right when you're
mounting the diff it's not even existed
uh you don't even have any buttons that
you can query for right so if you you
check if div only you try to if it
exists then only you try to remove any
evidence from the buttons right over
here I'm going to copy the code and say
button remove event listener click all
right so now uh although if you take a
look at the code nothing much has
changed but we remember to remove event
listeners that we just uh added to to
their
uh
add it to the buttons right and that's
now we have we handle the mounting case
and the updating case we actually have a
handle one case which is when we try to
remove unmount the component right over
here when you unmount the component this
will not be called because HTML is not
changing we just just want to remove the
component right so right before that we
still have one last chance to do cleanup
which is living on destroying
so on Destroy we're going to come over
here on this drive I'll just removed I
comment this on this try I'm gonna find
out all the buttons that we have
and remove event listeners so now when
you detach I remove this container all
the all the buttons has already been
clean up with all the event listeners
so here you go here is how you would
have to if you want to not just adding
HTML string as as part of your container
you want to add some interactive like
event listeners and do something you
would have to do this dance of
um a wait for the content to be changed
before you apply some changes right and
if you want to add event listeners
remember to un remove event listeners
when you're not need you don't need them
anymore
uh of course uh depends on your design
sometimes you don't have the luxury of
having uh
a div container that wraps your elements
right in this case uh HTML you have to
write it at the root level well then
it's
um how do you Scope this so this is just
about like how how do you Scope the
query selector right um
uh if you ask me I would say that every
time when you want to apply like when
you have something like this and you
know that you want to find out all the
buttons
um probably you can add some hints to
the HTML right so for example over here
I can see because this is a string right
so I can come up here and replace all
I can replace all pattern text
ah okay uh so so the thing about here is
okay is I think it's just a syntax
highlighting
uh I can replace all button text
with button and maybe add some data
attribute that I can query for so
special
okay uh lee how right so I I replace all
this button to be button data special
the house so what does that mean if you
inspect element over here
you realize that
um this line of buttons that I created
all have this special attribute called
Data special my name right so here you
don't have it here you have it so uh
this is because HTML is just a string
right you can you can replace string you
can make some manipulation before you
insert HTML into the Dom right so here
you kind of
have some way to scope up all the
buttons that you only created in this
component so maybe this is a string that
not just the harmony dynamically
generated you ID that attached to this
component and now what you do instead of
div the query selector all you come over
here and say
uh
document like query selector
all
button with this special attribute
data special equals the how
and then for each of them you attach
event listener
right and now if you try to click this
yeah so uh I think it's just like the
hot building something messed up just
now so now if I try to click me you see
that this this works and we only scope
out to the buttons uh that has this
special attribute called lihao my name
right so any buttons outside will not be
selected right so you can remember this
is just you can pass in any string and
even if it's a dynamically generated
string that provides to you you can
still manipulate the string replace like
the button to add some special attribute
things like that of course this does not
handle some edge cases where maybe this
is part of your text that you don't want
to be transformed this is some button
that you want to replace you want more
sophisticated things then you have to
have some more specific way of doing the
replace all right but this is just a way
to this is a very simple case to
demonstrate for you that
you can do a simple replace all to um to
scoop out the button that is only at
created via this HTML and then only
attach event listeners to them right
only at
interactions right so you don't affect
other buttons outside
um but if you're lucky enough that you
have a container then I think the easier
way is to just uh query selector from
the content itself so only find out all
elements but if you're unlucky enough to
have maybe like other buttons over here
then yeah maybe you would have to do
this to only limits button that is
created only from this HTML
so let's talk about at debunk
so this is a very useful uh
tag in svelt that allows you to help you
to debug
um some of the data that you're using in
your field components so let's take a
look at an example and see how we can
use this at the back tag in as well
components so here I have a components
that has a written array and
attacks a value right so I look through
the array to render some input tag and
also use an input to bind some value so
I can type on it
so as a type yeah you can see that it uh
you can't really see a data change
unless you try to come over here and say
value so that you know that you're
actually updating the value so when you
type you see that the value is changed
maybe this is okay for you but let me
show you an alternative that you can use
as well right it does not mean that my
alternative is better it's just that
more Tools in in your toolbox so that
you can try and mix and match different
kind of things that helps you to debug
your application
so here instead of using value I can use
add debug tag so I say I will write
start I will start with a curly brackets
and say add debug and then I can pass in
any Expressions that I want to debug so
here if I say I want to debug the value
or say I debug value immediately you can
see in the console you see it's printing
on the object with a value and a value
of the value itself
so as I type you sure enough you can see
that this value is is updating you'll
see more things printing out in the
console
and one script about this is that if you
internally inspect Elements which is
when you try to open up your Dev tools
and one when you try to type something
uh the debug tag itself also will send a
debugger so here you are you are you are
breaking so the the Chrome Dev tools
will break at a point where
we are printing out the value of this
value right so here you can see that's
what that's how this value is being
printed out console.log value and now
you all console can do things like
getting this value and you know type out
in the console say what is the link
um do something and check check some
other things right so if you have some
sort of complex object that you're
trying to log over here then this is
very useful where you can uh like you
don't have to manually set a breakpoint
somewhere within your Spell components
uh this will get triggered will be
tripped and now you can
um yeah open up console and check things
like that right so let me close this and
get out from the debugger
um and I want to show you one more thing
right so besides like using this debug
value and like in the normal input value
or things like that okay it doesn't have
to be in value you can come over here
have some uh reactively declared like a
double equals Value Plus value you could
also have double over here
right so every time you change you see
double bring that double over here
so besides doing this at the top level
you could also have this debug tag
somewhere in in inside like each tag or
if tag uh each each block or each block
uh why is this useful this is useful
when you know when you're trying to
iterate through an array and uh you want
to debug like a certain item inside the
array and exactly ah I want to
take a look at this item over here
here right I want to I want to look at
this um uh what are all these item value
is right so let me let me remove this
depart let me just comment this out I
want I want to debug what are the items
available over here and if I try to type
something and see you know uh it will
print up more and I can say that oh this
item value is 12 right it would be
useful for me when I have a breakpoint I
can break this uh at the particular item
but of course uh you see that every time
I change something I'm updating the uh
the array itself so all this uh all this
item is being updated and
um too bad there's no way that you can
just limit scope limit this debug in for
particular index
um at least you don't have you can't do
it this way so a trick that I have is I
can have each each block if in the index
goes to say I just want to check those
the second one which is index at one
and print out this debug right so now
um I when I change something else it's
not cheap anything only when
you know what I think this is a bug and
I'll probably fix this so um if you're
watching this video uh right now I'm
using at version
3.32.8 uh 38.2
um this does not work but I'll try to
make it work in the future versions and
hopefully this will be very helpful that
you just need to you know debug at a
certain item and and see it changes
right so uh yeah too bad I feel this is
a bug but anyway I hope that you learned
something to use an ad tag
so today I'm going to talk about module
contacts in svelts what is module
context well we shall take a look at
examples and we'll figure that out along
the way so let's take a look at examples
so here I have my app and I have a
component called map
this is a very contrived example I tried
to come out
a very convincing example but I feel so
this is a very very contrived example
but it it serves its purpose well I
believe to explain this concept for you
okay so bear with me with like
unreasonable
variables over here so I have two
components I have one components but use
it twice I have two maps over here and I
have inputs okay so over the map
components uh I have a div so this is
one map component it says it has
some uh it it has it Imports some stores
and it has some buttons that you can
click right send me and who sets so the
store itself
um because we want to share it across
um components as in it doesn't have to
be across like component a and component
B it's more of like across all the map
components instance then I probably
would have to create this store
somewhere else outside the component and
to be able to use it and import it over
here right because if you try to create
a star variable over here like I try to
say import writable
from svelt
s spell store and try to create a star
from here
what I end up creating is this store is
actually like a stitch within this
component
um so if I have multiple map components
I will have multiple store created and
that's not what I want I want to be able
to share across all the map
um all the map components that is going
to be created so what I do is that I
create a new file external file and
create and store here so all the every
time when I import here when I create a
new map component where it imports from
this store they're actually importing
from a steam store right it's the same
store instance so there's only one
instance sometimes you call this a
Singleton because it's just single one
done right so if it's a single turn one
star instance then I would have to ex
move it out into one separate file and
import it from here right so here I have
a map store file I create this in store
instance and I import it into the map
component
okay so uh so this is the map store and
I also use this uh star
uh over here in the app component right
so here in app component I render uh
inputs that I can change and I can
update the value of the store from from
the outside right so that's um so this
star is like external where I can import
from uh
I can import from across multiple files
but and use it and update it there right
so here I have some problem over here I
wouldn't say a problem but
um I have some questions over here where
I would think like is there a better way
of writing this is that the map store
itself uh we kind of agree that I can't
in create this map store within this map
component because it will end up become
like a state for this component I want
it to be a Singleton I want one instance
across all components but this map store
itself is
uh it's very couple or related to this
map component right so
um I doing it this uh imported from
separate files feels like they are two
separate things so
um
that is something that I doesn't really
like so this is something that we're
gonna take a look and how we can fix it
later
right uh so now take a look at another
file another file I have is called a map
data so this is also an external file
um where I have variables up that
exported so this is again like a single
turn right this is a module oh no matter
how many people import this module
there's only one instance of this module
so there will be only one instance of
the current map and I also expose
functions to update this current map so
what this current map does is that no
it's contrived but what it tries to do
is that it will take in a current map
for now this current map is like a div
that wraps around each of the map right
it takes in this div if it's uh there's
something that's set as a current one I
will set the border to none and then
um so this is kind of like reset the
previous set previous current map and
now we're gonna update my current map
and also set a border so that you can
see that it's being set this is the
current map this is the value of the
current maps right now
so uh so fair enough so here in my map I
have two buttons when I click Send me is
to set call Set current map the current
div so that you can see that it's it has
a border so that visually you know that
I have updated the value
um but uh you want to actually know
whether the value then I have another
button called who sets that will console
out current map so this is what we
exported so you may not know this this
may still this may feel like a variable
that you to you that uh does it gonna be
updated but it it will right it it will
because uh anything that is being
imported is actually a live binding
anytime when you try to out the variable
value over here like this this variable
actually will be updated live uh this is
uh this is not some magic from spell
this is actually the specs from
JavaScript okay so if you import
something uh if this is a variable uh
like you do export let something or
export con something this variable
itself
okay export coins you can't change
because it's a constant right export let
something this variable itself uh if you
update it from anywhere uh wait I'm not
sure about anywhere but if you update it
from a file like here uh this real value
actually will will change right this
will actually change
um so uh let's see so let's try run
something right so here I call set me so
this has a border and I call whose sets
you'll see that in the console so I will
print out the the current sets value so
I click whose sets you'll see this div
if I hover it you see which one is being
turned on right so if I click on this
button it is still showing the same
current map
if I'm trying to change this sent me now
if I click who sets you'll see that now
it's uh log print out this different
state this button is the same thing
right so now I can change my div and I
can print out who is being set
that's great
um so what is this context a module
context thing how does this help me
improve my code
um I mean in this situation over here
um so map data again like map store I'm
going to say is that this current map
and this Set current map is very very
tight to this component itself right if
it's possible you want to actually write
them in the same file but unfortunately
you can't right because if you try and
declare current map in this map as well
if you say let's current map
then these variables itself over here
will become a state of this component
which is not what you want you want to
share this variable across all the maps
instance right as you see just now when
I try to click who sets across this
current map is the same value across and
it's being updated with the same
function to update all across them right
so this is something that you you
wouldn't want to put it in the Sim that
you can't put it in the same file
but with model context we're going to
show you that actually you can there's
actually ways to do that
so
um remember the point the time when I
say that a file you can only have one
script tag well I kind of actually lied
a bit because we haven't learned about
model context module contacts is
actually telling me us that uh you know
you can have another tag another script
tag but whoops you have another script
tag but this time around uh yes you can
only have one script tagged but this
script tags we're gonna add module
contacts which is I'm going to say
context is module
when I do this you see the errors is
gone so this script text and the this
script text is different so take a look
at the errors right let me remove this
and look at the errors it says one
component has only have one instance
level script element
instance level so uh what's felt called
this script tag is actually an instance
level of script tag right instance level
of the script element so instance
meaning for each of the instance you
create like variables right so these
variables are for are created for each
instance and therefore they are like
States within your component every time
you have a new map component you have a
new div variable uh for for this new map
instance right but if you have a context
module over here this is
a module level uh script it's not
instance level so anything they find
over here is is on a module level
uh do you hear what I'm trying to say is
a module level so meaning previously I
say that you you have to import over
here and you have a module Singleton you
import from this module everything over
here is defined like in a more in this
module and everywhere you import is
important same thing this is actually
creating a model inside your component
and anyone can import or do something
like this this is shared across this is
this only have one copy for one module
um
and therefore what we're going to do is
we can actually copy these two file this
the two code from this file into this uh
context module and and you can just
refer it directly over from your
component
so uh that that makes us have uh just
write one component file and and have a
code that can be on variables that are
like instance level are like states to
your components and as also variables
that are like module levels so like this
content map is module level all the
instance are importing from the same
level so if I come over here and Define
current map
uh of course this this has conflict but
uh right now I'm gonna just uncomment I
commence this out I'm gonna say this
current map is actually just one copy of
current map
um
um and so what happens later on is that
when you try to call sets you're
actually updating one copy all the
instance all the component all the maps
instance that you're going to create the
two different components only have
sharing one current map variable
right here I'm going to copy this
function as well to set current map to
come over here and
do it over here right so now your Set
current map and current map actually
interestingly they are available over
here in your
everywhere in your code right so now
what I'm trying to do now is that I'm
going to click Send me
uh and and I'm gonna open up the console
again and take a look at what is whose
is being set right so now this variable
is like a module level it's not your
State anymore and if I click who said
from here it's pointing this who said
from here is still pointing the same
variable right they are actually
pointing the same variable they are not
like States in your component I try to
set me over here click who sets is this
who said from outside is still this
um this this div right so they are
actually being shared across all the
um components just like how you would
write it over here uh one module and
every component is important in the same
module right so this is a module level
variables functions and everything that
you can think of
so
um before I go ahead and talk about more
you you may have questions like how how
would this be different from
um from other states like yes I I get
what you're trying to say but why is
this different right how does spell
um create this like module instance for
me and actually there's no magic to this
right so you know like every spell com
file like the file that ends with DOT
spelled it's going to be compiled down
into JavaScript right and and you import
this field component you're actually
importing the file you're importing this
file and it export default the component
itself right
um so this is actually a module that
you're importing right it's because it
dot spell file it's actually a module
and you're importing and all this code
over here if you open up the JS code you
realize that all of these are being
um paste it over
that's that's fine it's actually on the
module level right over here so this is
so-called module level uh it's it's in
this JavaScript module level so let if
you have other things like like States
like for the div they are actually
defined inside this function called
instance so this instance function is
being called every time when you have a
new map instance component being created
right so this variable every time we
have new map components this new
instance function being created this new
variable is being created and and being
used but variables or functions over
here like current map and Set Card map
are defined at a model level there are
paste like they are copied over at the
module level so
JFL does not do any uh Magic over here
anything that you write on the content
or context module over here will be
pasted over here no no magic over here
at all and no reactivity at all you
can't really expect that you change this
um this this variable over here and get
everything to be updated you still need
like a start you still treat this like
like a shortcut of not having to write a
separate module file to declare them
just paste everything in here and if you
want the reactivity you still need like
you want to up you have you want the
store like reactivity you still have to
do that
um yeah so now I'm going to copy all
this over here as well and create a yeah
a map value so now I don't need this I
can directly use this map value over
here and do you notice that I do the
export cons over here so if I export
things over here this
uh being exported like like a module
right this is module level so I can
import map value from this map dot smell
so personally I'm import this over here
now I can write this
like this
I can import map and map value this is a
module level export and get if you use
exports in the instance script tag that
could be a props or could be a component
method but if you have it over here then
you're able to import it in your module
so this is like a module level export so
you module you import like a module name
exports from a module right so you do it
over here so one thing you can't do is
export default over here uh because you
already have export default which is the
component itself so so you can't export
defaults
in a module context hopefully that's
reasonable
so we have everything copied from the
two files map store and map data into
our component as a con module level
module context
and let's try to see whether everything
still works as previously right so the
star still works as we said just now
and
so here we see that we have a function
called Set current map and actually it
does not matter whether we you define
this function over here or actually in
the script tag the instant script tags
um that's big so you may ask like okay
will this be
um creating an extra functions every
time well it depends uh spell actually
will do some optimization so you will
see that well this function is actually
updating something uh that is like a
state or it's it's not a state at all
right so this is not a state if you take
a look at the codes you would probably
realize that
um like this is still at
the module level right so it doesn't
really matter whether you you do it at
over here or within an instance right
but as soon as you try to set something
like this
then then that's a difference that's a
different story you you make it
um
inside as like a States methods right so
here
um since we can do it this way we can
update this current map like this then
we might as well not have this function
at all and in the sets me we just
directly sets
you know our current map so you can you
can directly change variables inside the
context module context you just can't
assume that it's like a state right so
every time when you so what it means
what that means is that if you try to
say Define maybe a variable like count
over here
and I I'm showing this count right you
can see that it is
one for now but every time when you're
trying to change it
uh on click
cons plus plus you
you can't really expect it to change it
it does not work this way you have to
you have to think that all these
variables are like variables that you
have defined in external filed external
modules so when you have this usually
what you do is you make it the writable
star
right
and you that you update the very
valuable value of the star using a
dollar sign
to reference it and to update it right
so this will update all and you can see
that this shares across all instances
it's it's not a state of your component
so hopefully you get that right and
that's all for now
here I have a task list application
where I can add more items or remove
them I'll create more lists
and remove the list
so here I'm going to take a look at
another implementation of the similar
application
so here I have the same Task List
where I can add items or remove them
add a list
and remove the list
notice the difference yes the second
application
feels more fluid
because we added Transitions and today
we are going to talk about how you can
add transitions in this felt let's take
a look a bit on the code structure
before we get started so we render each
of this list within the each block
and depending where the
the list should be shown or not we have
a h block and then for each of this list
we have another each block that Loops
through all the items
and then here is where we each of the
items is rendered with a list item to
start using transition since Felts we
need to import spell transitions cell
transitions provide five built-in
transition fade blur fly slide and scale
and we are going to look at how we can
use them in the example
to start using transitions you can use
the transition directive
here you type transition colon and the
name of the transition in this case fate
so here I add transitions to the list so
when it's added or removed
it will fade in and Fade Out you can add
arguments to the transitions in this
case we're going to add duration equals
to four seconds
so now it will fade in four seconds
and fade out within 4 seconds
to look at a complete list of all the
arguments you can provide to the
transitions you can take a look at spell
docs under the title of spell transition
here you can see that fit takes in three
arguments delay duration and easing next
we are going to make the item fly in
when we add or remove the item so I'm
gonna add the flight transition so
flight transitions takes in the X and Y
offset which means that in this case the
item will fly from 30 pixels from the
right if I want the item to just fly in
but not fly out I can change the
transition directive to in
now the item will fly in but not fly out
and similarly I can change it to the out
directive
then it will not fly in but it will fly
out so I can use the ins or out
directive to control the enter or exit
transition
this also means that we can have
different transitions for enter and exit
in this case I want to fly in but I want
to blur out
we are going to look at how we can
coordinate between transitions so take a
look at this example if I click on this
button
the item will fit in and the item
supplies it are slice in at the same
time right let me do that again
two transitions happening at the same
time is it possible that we can
coordinate them such that the first
transition happens at the first and then
after that subsequently on the next
transitions so it is possible to do with
a property called DeLay So in here we
can look at transition phase tickets 400
milliseconds over here on all the items
we fly in and the default delay is zero
seconds so which means that these two
transitions is happening at the same
time so if you want to make this happens
right after the fade in of that list
what we can do is we can add a delay
of 400 milliseconds as well so this
fades in in 400 milliseconds and 400
milliseconds later the item flies in so
let's take a look at the effect
right take a look at that again so 15
and then after that slides in
so if you don't want the elements say in
this case to slide in all at once what
we can do here is we can have the delay
based on index of the item so for
example if I add an index so this is the
index of that item we can add 400
milliseconds times uh but plus index
time 300 milliseconds right so it
depends on where the item is it will
have a different kind of delay right so
let's take a look at the effect right
now
if I have multiple items
close it one two three
right
one two three
so here is how you can coordinate in
between transitions using delay
so the next thing I want to show you is
this let's take a look at what happened
if we close this list
well it's not that obvious but let's
change this to slides and let's take a
look at it again
so when I close this and focus on this
item When I close this
it slides up when it close
right because this element is going to
be removed together with the parent and
when it's being removed it will play
this out transition
right but what I want to do is that I
don't want the transition of this
element to play when I'm removing the
parent I'm okay when I want to remove
this
elements itself but I'm not okay to play
that transitions when I want to remove
the parents
so what I can do here is to provide a
modifier called local
so let's take a look at how this local
effect
When I close
it does not play the transitions right
so the local modifier makes that this
transitions will only happen
when this element itself is being
removed or being added
but if this element is being removed
together with the parent the transitions
will not be played
right so if I removed it you can see the
transition but I remove the parent it
will not play the transition so if you
take a look at here when required to add
an item it takes a while to be added and
it takes even longer to be added for the
third item that's because the duration
for the transition elements is based on
the index so that is what we're going to
fix in the next video
So today we're gonna fix the bug that
was mentioned in the previous video so
the bug was like this we added a delay
based on the index of the item in the
list so that when we have multiple items
when we try to close it and try to play
it the item is added in succession
however because the delay is based on
the index
um the the transition better is coming
in is being added as item or the
transition is being played together as
the with the list
it's the same transition so now the
delay when we add the third item is
going to be very long
because that is how we've coded over
here so what we're going to do in this
video is to try to see whether we can
have a condition for the delay so we're
going to have this condition based on
whether the list is being shown if the
list has been shown then whenever we add
a new item
the condition should be true and the
item should be added with no delay if
the list is not on the screen try to add
the list item then the condition should
be false and each of the items should be
played with a delay so over here I'm
going to have I'm going to write this
condition list
dot shown
then the delay will be zero and if the
list is not being shown
the delay will be based on the index
so now what we're going to do is how or
when are we going to update this value
the list are shown
we can do this using a custom
transitions event
so on the list item we can have a few
custom
transition events such as on intro
starts on intro and
on outro starts and on outro n
as if the name suggests interest time
will be played when the intro transition
starts to play
and when it ends it will call this event
handler
and if you have outro when it starts
playing this event will be triggered and
then when it ends this will be played
all right so these are the events
handlers so now we can add event
transfer for intro n
and outro n
I'm going to remove these two
so now intro n we're going to set the
list start shown equals to true
and on the outer land we're going to set
list dot shown equals to false
so let's see what we have right now when
we click on it you have a delay
so when you click on this element you
have a sudden delay when you are showing
the item
but when you're trying to add a new item
because the list as shown is true
there's no more delay
I try to close this and try to play
again
the delay is based on the index if I add
a new item it shows immediately
so a summary of what we've done so far
we have a custom condition to determine
what is the delay of the item
and then we also seen a custom event for
transitions such as intro start into n
Ultra start and Ultra n
so we have seen how we can use delay and
duration to customize a transition but
there's one more thing that we haven't
covered which is easing easing can add a
lot of flavors to a transition and
that's what we're gonna look at in the
next video
in this video we're going to take a look
at how we can use easing to add flares
and add flavors to a spell transition
so the first thing is what is easing
so easing is a function that specifies
the rate of change of the entire
duration of your transitions so there's
a lot of built-in easing functions from
spelled and these are all of them
right and you can visualize them through
each visualizer
over here we have each visualizer open
what we're going to take a look at is
firstly a quad is in easing function so
this is the shape of the easing function
so on the x-axis is the time and the
y-axis is the value of the animation
that we are animating right so in this
curve if you play it again you can see
that how does it takes from the
beginning point to reach the destination
point right so different kind of easing
functions have different kind of curve
for example for this elastic it moves
towards the destination and goes further
from it and goes all the way back up to
the destination so different easing
functions will give you different kind
of flavors in your transition right so
let's head back to the task list and
let's try one of the easing function to
use easing we're going to import it from
the spelled easing so in this example
we're going to import bounce and out
ROMs felt easing to use this we're going
to copy the name of the easing function
and we're going to find one of the place
where we have like so in this case we
are going to add it in the fly where
when the this items flies in I'm gonna
add easing to be bounce ins out
so take a look at how it will look like
now so the element will fly will bounce
in when you fly in
right probably let me add this
to have a longer distance for the
element to fly in and probably that
would be more obvious
all right it says like that it's shaking
over here uh we can add slightly long
duration to make it even more obvious
right so that gives us a different kind
of although we are using the same
transition which is to fly in from the
right
but then with easing functions we can
control how it flies from the source to
the destination so let me try another
easing function and in this case we are
going to use sine out I'm going to
replace it over here and let's look at
how it is different right now begins
slow and then it accelerates and move to
the destination if we remove this all
the way you'll find that the elements
just fly in without any acceleration
right so easing functions you have a lot
of different kind of easing functions
that is built in from swelds you can
import damps from Spell slash easing and
the list of all the easing functions are
specified in the swell docs and you can
visualize them with each visualizer
today I want to talk about something as
important as making a site cooler with
decorative animations or transitions
because some users outright experience
motion sickness when faced with Parallax
scrolling zooming effects and so on
I mean vestibular disorders reactions
includes dizziness nausea and migraine
headaches so today
I'm going to share with you some
techniques on creating an open and
inclusive spelled app
we're going to continue on this to-do
list app which we added some transitions
such as fade slide and blur when adding
a new item many operating systems have
accessibility settings for specifying a
preference for reduced motion
on the web we can use media query such
as prefers reduced motion which was
introduced in a media query levels 5 to
detect if the user has sets an operating
system preference to minimize the amount
of Animation or motion so now we are
going to take a look at how we can
utilize that firstly svelt's transitions
or animations depends on the CSS
animation
so we can use a media query
to disable or set the duration of the
animation to be zero
so right over here I'm going to add
media
prefers reduced motion
to reduce so there's two values that you
can provide for this media query sorry
for the typo
which is reduce or unspecified
so if the user chose to prefers A
reduced motion then we can Target the
element that has animation or transition
and add animation duration to be zero
seconds I'm excited to important so that
it always has the highest priority
right I'm using a star over here because
I'm going to Target all elements but you
can do that for in this example would be
div you can do it to div only as well
so it depends on your use case you can
use a star to Target all the elements in
in this component or you can Target
specific elements in the component
so let's let's try that out right now if
we click on this button it has
a transition to emulate prefers reduced
motion on Chrome you can go for the
Chrome Dev tools
and then search for rendering
over here there is this emulate CSS
media feature prefers reduce motion so
if you choose prefers reduce motion to
reduce
and let's try to close this list and try
to open it again
now you realize that there's no any
transitions for this container
right although there's still transitions
for the item that's because we are using
a list items instead of a div
so over here we're going to add list
and now the item itself does not has any
transition so you try if you try to open
the list you may realize that there is
some delay on the item showing up on the
screen
right so when we use CSS a solution to
disable animation duration by disabling
how long it takes for that animation but
in this case we still have a delay when
the item is showing up on the screen
so we need a JavaScript solution so that
we can pass a different delay for the
transition over here
so the delay right now is based on list
shown 0 or 400.
plus index times 300 so we need to add
another condition over here where if the
user prefers reduced motion and that's
what we are going to do now
so over here
we're going to have
cons media query
it goes to window.match Media
prefers
reduce
motion to reduce
and the value where it matches or not
would be
media query
dot matches
so this will be computed at the very
beginning of your component and
depending on the user which I think is
unlikely
but there may be user like us where we
try to switch between reduce and no
Emulsion back to reduce so if you want
to check that as well you want to
constantly update these variable matches
you can use media query
look at event listeners
change
and you can update the value of matches
equals the media query
that matches
right in that way the matches will
always
reflects the latest CSS prefers reduced
motion
right so the user may go on to the
system operating system settings and
change it and you want that to reflect
on your spell component immediately then
you would have to listen to any media
query changes for this prefers reduce
motion
and now we know that whether it matches
or not to this media query so if it
matches which means that the user opted
to reduce the motion then we are going
to pass this in as a direct condition
for the duration
all right so we're gonna add here our
matches
then if I
click now there's no more delay for this
item to come out on the screen
right another alternative that if you
don't like to pass in a delay or
duration
for each of the transitions depending on
whether the user opted A reduced motion
what we can do here is that we can
create a custom transition
right so I will talk a bit more on
custom transitions later on but over
here a custom transition is none other
than a function that returns an object
that describes how your transition works
over here we can pass we can return a
delay of zero and duration of zero so
meaning this custom transition is
actually no transition right you can
still pass into the transition directive
but itself has no effect at all because
it has no it has no duration it has no
delay it just happens immediately right
what we can use here is that we can use
this node transition
and then we can have what we call a
reduced fly is equals to whether we
matches the user preference for reduced
motion if it if thus we will return a
node transition
or else we will return a flight
transition from the spelled transition
right so we can use this reduce fly
instead of
the
built-in fly
this way this reduce fly will have no
effect at all you don't have to use a
custom delay and whatnot and this itself
will be a no transition if the user
opted for a produced motion and it will
be back to a normal fly transition if
the user didn't specify any preference
all right so let's try it again
it works
and that's all so we have seen how we
can use CSS solutions to have to stop
all durations that would be one way of
doing things we also see how we can use
JavaScript with match media query and we
use that to have a custom transitions or
we use that to set like the delay or
duration to be zero once again I believe
that web should be open please for
everyone and we as a developer should
take responsibility to build an open and
inclusive web and app for everyone
so the other day I saw this um talk and
swell Summit by Annie Taylor Trent on
building a mail flicks which you guys
should definitely check it out
um within a talk I saw her slides when
she moves from one slice to another
there's this very amazing transitions
that swipes through the text and then
transitions to the next slide so take a
look
um so I played it slowly at a quarter
speed and as you can see the there's a
block but there's a color block that
swipes through the text and as it
shrinks it reveals a text behind so let
me play that again
so
um the color blocks grows and shrinks
and reveals the text behind
see that again
growth shrinks rebuild attacks
and what we're going to do today is so
what I'm trying to do today is to try to
replicate this behavior in a spelled
Rebel using custom transitions so here I
have my basic setup so you can see
there's a checkbox and then as it clicks
to check to show it will reveal slow
text hello world and custom transitions
and as I unclick it it will hide it so
it's implemented using IF block over
here
so the first thing we're going to do is
to write a custom transition
right so custom transition is nothing
but a function so I'm going to call this
transition name swipe
and it returns an object
right so it takes in a note that you're
going to apply the transition to so now
I'm going to apply the transitions to
the element itself it's going to call
transition swipe
over here as well transition swipe
okay so what's going to be returned from
this object so if you check the docs
about custom transition
since that it's gonna return an object
that has the following key values uh
delay duration easing and CSS
and today we're going to focus more on
writing the CSS function
right so in the CSS function
uh it takes in a parameter called T
which represents a time through the
transition
so the time T itself will
grow from T will gross from zero all the
way to one right
um so I'm gonna
replicate or reproduce these transitions
right is to try to break it down into
two parts so the first part is where the
solid color block grows from like zero
width all the way to
um
full width covering the whole text so
I'm break it
and then the second half of it will be
shrinking the solid color block to
reveal the text behind
so I'm going to chop the time into two
halves so the first half is
from 0 to 0.5 which is where we will
grow the solid color
and at this point the text is hidden
and the second half would be from 0 to 5
to 1 which will shrink
the solid color
and the text is revealed in this case
right so so I'm gonna have a basic
structure of how the code will look like
so 0.5
and else it will be
here
right so the next thing is how are we
going to create like a growing solid
color block
um so I have an idea is to use a linear
gradient as a background so let's try
out like how linear gradient looks like
here I'm going to write the div with a
width of 100 pixel and height of 100
pixel so and then let me put a border
right so over here you can see like we
have a solid square with 100 pixel width
and height
so linear to gradient takes in a few
parameters uh which is like the color
stops so it specifies like the color and
the position of the color
so you can specify multiple color stops
that will create the gradient right so
when I have the first stop as red color
at zero position
and the second color will be yellow at
the 100th position
you can see here it starts from zero all
the way to Yellow at the bottom
so we can change the direction over here
so I want it to be left to right so I'll
write to right
now you can see the color grows from Red
all the way to the right which is yellow
100 if I shrink this number to 40
percent
you'll see that the rate transitions to
Yellow is from zero percent to forty
percent off the block and then from 40
onwards all the way to 100 will be a
full solid yellow color so in linear
gradient there's a concept called a
color hint which indicates how the two
adjacent colors should transitions so in
this example if I specify 40 percent
it means that the color red will start
to transition from 40 of the position
all the way to Yellow which is at forty
percent so in this case both values are
forty percent so you'll see like a very
sharp distinction uh from the first 40
of a break color and forty percent all
the way to 100 is um
yellow color so I can change the yellow
color to say transparent
in this case you will see
a red color block at 40 width
so if I change this value from 6 40 to
60 then you'll see a solid color block
of width 60 percent
so I'm going to use this as a means to
create a solid color block which grows
and shrinks based on the value that we
can control over here so let me just
copy this out and remove the rest
so in CSS method you are going to return
a CSS strings so in this case we're
going to return
this ring and here I'm going to do the
same thing as well
so now let's figure out how what's the
value that we are going to put in over
here
right so in this case
um oh it should be less than 0.5 so in
this case we're going from 0.0.5 I'm
going to grow the solid color from the
left to the right
so um over here we have the rate which
is a color which we'll Define later
so let's say color goes to read
and the value of here should go so it
grows from zero to a hundred percent
right so we have a value t
that goes from 0 to 0.5 and we are going
to calculate the value uh percentage
that goes from 0 to 100.
so let's do some math over here so
percentage
should be a value times t
and this value is um so
200 because 0 times 200 is 0 and 0.5
times 200 is a hundred
so we're going to use this value
percentage
but here and over here
right and over here on the other hand we
are going to have a gradient of
transparent all the way to the red color
so you should start from transparent
to read That's because
um the red solid block color will shrink
um from the left to the right
so let's calculate the value of here
so as it shrinks it's also going to grow
from zero to 100 percent
so T is now 0.5 to 1 and we're going to
calculate a percentage we should go from
um zero to a hundred so how to calculate
that
um so we can shift the value from 0 to 5
to 1 to 1 to a value of U which is um T
minus 0.5
this value itself will go from 0 to 0.5
right so 0.5 minus 0.5 is 0 and 1 minus
0.5 is 0.5
and now we have a range from 0 to 0.5
which is the same as above so we times
it 200.
so U times 200.
now we have the value of percentage
let's pass it in over here
and we're going to use a variable color
instead of red
so let's see what we have
right so it's a bit too fast I'm gonna
change the duration
to let's say three seconds
it says it grows and it shrinks
all right
so if I don't have the first half of the
so let me comment this out first so that
you can see what it's doing on the first
half
right
and what we have on the second half
okay
um
so we're almost there the next thing is
that we are going to hide the text
right so for the first half the text is
hidden and the second half the text is
revealed
how we're going to do it is that we're
going to change the color of the text to
transparent for the first half of the
time and change it back to the original
color on the second half of the time
so assuming the color of text is red
we're gonna
or rather this very variable color that
we will compute later on
we'll set
um over here color is transparent for
the first half of time
and here is the color is
color
right so let's check it out again
right
and transvestit
yeah it looks okay now right so on the
first time of time we don't have the
text and second half you see the text
and then as it transitional the first
half you see the text and then the text
is heated so when you hide or you
Transit out
um what happened is that the value will
goes from T from the value T will go
from one to zero instead of zero to one
if we calculate all of this correctly
it's still the the same animation will
actually be reverse
so the next thing we are going to do is
we have to figure out the color of the
text
so we can use a browser API called
window dot get computer Style
sorry let me fix the text okay and pass
in a node
and color
okay so over here you will get the color
that is being
computed for this node in CSS so
depending on how what the specificity or
whatever you specify in the Styles or in
the CSS once it's sets we can get the
computed style and we can get the color
of this
so here let's take a look at again
right so the the color of the block is
no longer red but rather the color that
is specified for the text which we
specify over here in the CSS
all right let me show that again
so the last thing is the ice the icing
on the cake is to
take in a parameter called params over
here so the second argument of um a
custom transition is actually the object
that you can pass in over here so I want
this to have a certain kind of delay
which is say
um
500 milliseconds right uh if I so this
params will be that object the delay
500 milliseconds right so I need to use
these params and provide it to the
transitions itself if I don't do
anything there's no delay
right
so what I'm going to do is uh if nothing
is being provided I'm going to fall back
to an empty object and I'm going to
spread this over here
so I'm going to return the same delay or
duration that's being passed in by
the object itself and take a look
it's a five second of delay sorry 500
milliseconds of delay right nearly five
milliseconds before you exit out
and
so I'm gonna remove this duration so
that it goes to a default duration
right think so in default in spell for
duration will be 400 milliseconds which
is things should be written somewhere in
here in the docs
right 400 milliseconds that's the
default
um so here you go custom transitions uh
with the animating color solid block
based on the color of the text
today I'm going to show you how I create
a custom transition which I call a
Flipboard animation transition
this inspiration comes from a tweet from
Pine where he showed one of his art
created using JavaScript and CSS as you
can see over here this is one of his art
and while looking at it it reminds me of
a Flipboard where you can see in a
departing terminal where basically text
being flipped in the Flipboard and in
the transition you can see different
characters showing up before it reveals
the actual text that you want to the
Target text
right sorry for my bad explanation but
you get the idea right so I'm thinking
of creating this animation as a
transition where if you reveal the text
you have this kind of a transition where
it flips uh show different kind of
characters until you actually reveal the
actual characters the text that you want
to review
right so that will be a great transition
idea that I think of and today I'm going
to try to do that so first of all we
have this custom transition starter
which is uh nothing but a checkbox
which uh check and uncheck to reveal the
text
as you can see here we use a if block
so if you want to follow along you can
get the link at the description where
you can get this starter and you can
follow along with me right so let's get
started
so first thing first a custom transition
so a custom transition is nothing but a
function so let me name this transition
I'm going to call it a Flipboard
and it's going to return that object
so to use this custom transition I am
going to use the transition directive
I'm going to apply for both of the span
okay
and over here uh what we are going to do
is we're going to use the tick function
which takes in the T
right so um a custom transition is a
function that returns an object and that
object has several properties that you
can Define
and that uh that will Define how your
transition will behave right take is one
of them so this tick function takes in a
t which so this tick function will be
called by its Fields when the element is
being transitioned out or in and it will
be called on every frame so this T value
will represent whether it's it stands
for time but it represents uh what the
state of that element is so if you are
transition in meaning uh from nothing to
something then the T value will be a
value from 0 to 1 and as so zero as in
it's not shown on the screen and one is
being shown on the screen and if the
element is being transitioned out then
you'll get from one to zero right so
this tick function will be called a lot
of times while transitioning and the T
value you get for each time will be
different right from one to zero
so to get started uh Flipboard over here
on the other hand actually takes in an
argument called node so this node will
be the actual the elements that uh the
animation is the transition is being
applied to so this node for this case
will be this band and for this case will
be this band right so let's get started
so the first thing first is to get the
text for the text contents of the node
so this is the text that we are going to
reveal we're going to keep it as a
variable because in the meantime when we
are transitioning we're going to use um
we're going to change the value over the
time right and so this will be the final
text that will be shown on the user
right so over here uh if
T equals to 1 which is at the ending
state
ending where it's it should be revealed
then we're gonna set we're going to
revert back the content of the node to
be the text and then we're going to
return over here so we're going to stop
here
and in between we're going to figure out
what should be the value of the text
right so
um
okay so now uh if it turn on and off you
didn't see much so let's let's figure
out uh how we should try to do this
right so imagine this is the text right
imagine I have a text like a b c d e f g
this is the text and if the value of T
is say 0.5
um what should I see on the screen
right so
um
so this is
this is something that we figure out so
I'm thinking
uh if the time is T is 0.5 which is a
halfway point then I should at least see
half of the text and then the rest of
the text is
probably nothing right so probably I
represent it with Dash
um
and probably uh
some of the text will be revealed as
like X which is the
which these two characters will be
actually tries to
uh will be replaced by a random
character right so
imagine these two will be replaced by a
random character and then this is the
characters that has been revealed
because we have passed the time of 0.5
right so if the time is say at the sort
of like beginning
then if my text is a b c d f g again
then the text I'm going to see probably
will be a and then some random text and
then dash of like this is like kind of
empty space that represents uh
the unrebuilt text right these two will
be uh
random characters
right so as you can see here is that um
it what characters that we are going to
show it depends on the position of the
character
right so we are gonna
probably create a string like this this
will be the string that we're going to
create so I'm going to call it like
uh SDR string I'm gonna start with the
empty string
and probably we're going to set the text
content equals to string
right so now what we're going to do is
we're going to try to construct this
string
okay so uh probably we're going to look
through the length of the text right so
this the length of this string that
we're going to construct will be equal
the length of the original string over
here
so I'm going to look through the length
of that original string uh so I less
than uh text Dot link
I plus plus
so now what I'm going to create is a
variable called J
which is the value of I
divided by the text length so this is
the percentage of
where the character is so I'm going to
represent like each character will be a
percentage of where it is the position
of it uh relative to entire the length
of the string right so the character
would be one out of say
uh seven and the middle of text will be
say 3.5507 and the last character will
be seven out of seven right so J will be
that position so if J and T is the same
or J is less than t
meaning J is uh at the position that is
in front of the T value
we are probably going to
reveal the actual text right so if J is
less than t
then I'm going to append
the actual text which is
um
the text I
right
and then probably we're going to have
one or two extra characters over here
um so this is a bit arbitrary but what
I'm gonna try is that probably I would
say if it's 0.1 I'm gonna like
point two percent of the text
less than like point one two point two
percent of the text should be a random
character right so in this case I would
say like 0.5 to 0.75
right which is like
um 1.5 times of t uh if it's less than
else if J is less than
1.5 times of T I'm going to have a
random character
and the rest of it will be
a dash
right
so let me Define this function called
random character over here firstly is
let me collapse this
can Define the function over here
okay so
um I'm going to create a string called
uh
random cars
that contains basically all the
character that you can think of
even including numbers
right
so what I'm going to have here is that
I'm gonna randomly pick one of the
character so math dot random
uh times the length of the
so this will be giving a random value
that is
within the length so I'm not sure 26
characters plus 10 so it's a random
correct random number that is within 36.
and I'm going to round it so I'm going
to call it floor
and after I get that number I'm going to
pick it I'm going to use that over here
right
so this will return me a random
characters from from this set of string
okay so I think we are done over here
and let's see how the effect looks like
it's a bit fast so let me slow that down
uh rather increase the duration
so I'm going to have the relation of um
say five seconds
so the default duration of a custom
transition is 400 millisecond which you
can see uh which you can find it on the
spelled docks
so now we have a duration of five
seconds so let's take a look
as you can see here the text is
the length of the text or the length of
the span is is vibrating right you can't
see the dash fix at one point
um that's because
the width of each character is diff is
different right so while we are randomly
choosing one character
um say I is actually narrower than say n
or S right because different characters
has different width and if we choose a
narrow or Slimmer character then the
dash will be then the hold width of the
text will be is narrow that's why you
can see that uh the a jiggly part on the
dash over there and that's because the
text has different width right if we use
a monospace text a font so if I use
monospace
font family
then you will not see that jiggling in
fact
because in essence a mono space font
have the same for weight for each
character
right now as you can see the dash
basically steals
fix fixated on the screen
right I think we are really good we are
making really good progress uh this is
exactly the effect I'm looking for
um exact except one point that I
probably want to point out is that I
find that the character is moving
uh random uh shuffling way too fast
uh probably I want to slow that down a
bit
but let's see but how are you going to
do that because we can't control when
svelt will call this tick function and
actually still will call this tick
function on every frame right so we
can't
on everything when this function is
called we are going to generate this
string uh every time right and because
we have random characters generated on
every time the tick function is called
we can't guarantee that we're getting
the same random character therefore uh
the character we're going to be
change very fast or rather out of our
control over here right so one thing we
can do is that probably over here in
this function before we start to
recreate the string we can do some check
uh check that uh sub check the
subsequent invocation of the tick
function to see whether it passed a
certain number a period of time if we
pass that period of time then we're
gonna recreate a new string if it's less
than that period of time then probably
we're gonna say hold on here we don't
have to do anything let's just skip what
am I going to do next
right so every time when you want to
measure like the time we need a variable
outside of here because we can't Define
that variable in here because this
variable will be created every time so
we're going to create a variable out
here in this group that basically
represents the last time that we just
execute this tick function right so
every time when it has tick function
we're going to calculate the current
time
and if the current time
is
minus the last time
is greater than say 30 milliseconds
right so
uh
usually a browser will execute on it if
we execute this on every frame usually a
browser renders at 60 frames per second
that means that it will be this function
will be called on every 16.66 second a
milliseconds
right so this will be like double of
that amount of time
so if it's greater than that then uh
or rather if it's less than that we're
gonna end here we're not gonna do
anything
but if it's greater than that uh then
last time will equals to the current
time
and then we'll allow to calculate a new
string
all right let's see the effect
right you can see here definitely it's
shuffling less frequent than we had just
now if you can't tell the difference let
me bump this up a bit so 300
milliseconds
so text is being updated every 300
right probably very slow right 100
milliseconds
slightly faster
right so this is updated on every 100
milliseconds
rather than every frame so every frame
this function will still be called but
we are not going to do anything if it
doesn't pass a hundred milliseconds
right so this is one of the way that you
can kind of control or throttle how fast
that you you want the tick function uh
the rest of the tick function to be
called so there you have it a custom
Flipboard animation
so today I'm going to talk about
component API in svelte more
specifically client-side component API
so what is that about
so let's take a look at one example
um where we over here I have app.strout
and importing
components.felt the component is all the
things that we have talked about
previously for example dispatching
events having prompts having reactive
statements and some uis binding event
listeners and all these things right so
this components when we import we write
import components from component.s
Fields so in this statement we can see
that the component that we just written
in this component as well file is
exporting a component that you can use
in a default export right here we are
imagine if this is normal JavaScript
module then this will be your default
export right so we're importing default
exports importing a component and we
just write this and we can use this
component on the Fly
of course this is in the app cells but
what if you want to use this component
and use it somewhere else
so we know that a component if you look
at the JavaScript output it says that
it's a class that is being exported
right so we want to use this class
somehow mounts on
um somewhere else on us by ourselves so
what do we do well we will just
instantiate this class and and use it
and that is the component API that I'm
going to talk about we in this example
we're going to talk about how we can use
this class one other API that we can use
and for example how we can update the
props as well as how we can listen to
events coming from the component
so here we
it's a bit limited to do this in the
rebel so I'm going to download this file
download this project and on I'm
compress it and I'm gonna use it and
open it on vs code and do it over here
instead okay so here we've seen that uh
in the main JS file this is the main
file of your application over here we
can see that we are importing app from
app.felt and we are actually
instantiating the component like this so
um there are some properties that you
can pass in for the app right if we
remove this line if we just do nothing
don't do anything from here
you see that now there's nothing shown
on the screen
right so this part is where it will
attach or Mount your app component onto
the screen
so what I'm going to do here is I don't
want to use this I want to use my
component directly because the component
I've written has has props as event
listeners
um
as as component events list component
events and and we're going to play with
that instead right so here I'm gonna
import directly import the component
directly
and now uh just like how we did for
app.spel we are going to a mount these
components onto the screen so I'm going
to say app equals new
component
and Target
document.body
all right so how about just use the same
use component instead of app so now if
we go if we split the screen into two
parts you'll see that we can still see
the components of the screen
right so here the first thing we're
going to take a look over here is what
are you what can you pass in uh for the
as as the parameters for your
Constructor right you are constructing
this component instance and what can you
pass it so the first thing you can see
is we can pass in an object and the
first property we can see is targets so
Target is where you are mounting your
components so if we come over here
inspect elements uh if you take a look
at the HTML let me try to zoom this up
all right let me close everything else
we try to expand you realize that now
the component is mounted on the document
body right this is this diff is what
we've written over here in the
component.s fields right exactly the
same div with the grids right so
um let's try to play with this let's try
to mount it somewhere else so let me
open this file uh in the HTML file I'm
going to add some div over here I'm
going to add maybe like header uh well
hello components
API
and I'm gonna come over here and then
create
a div or maybe a main tag right main con
main content will be added over here in
the main tag
and then maybe some foot over here uh so
here I'm gonna put the second hitting a
footer right footer uh
examples
prepared by the house okay so I have I
have a title main tag and a footer right
by default you will realize that because
we are adding the com we're mounting the
components on the body itself so it will
be appended to the body right so here
you see that all this H1 main footer is
still intact on on the
on the screen but then the components
right this this div is a component is
being attached
um appended at the end of the document
of body right so now we can change this
target to
um to the main uh elements instead so we
can do document dot query selector
Main
and now if I refresh realize that this
components being sandwiched between the
header and then a footer right so now
inside main is where you see the
components
okay so uh how do you know all this is
you can come over here to the document
and you probably can whoops you can
probably scroll all the way down to find
client side
components API then you'll probably find
that it says Target is where the HTML
the elements of the component will be
rendered to
right then you also can find things
um like props so Props is something we
can pass in as well so over here I'm
gonna
um since we in a component of spells we
created we have two props right A and B
so the default value of the props is one
for both of them that's why when you
create the components it says one right
so now how about let's just try and re
uh change add some props to these
component props let's say a equals to 5
and b equals to 10. I save this you
realize that now it's being rendered
with 5 and 10 as a props value and now
you the product is 50 right so so here
is how you can pass in the props if you
don't have props then it will be it will
use the default value of of the props
okay fair enough right so if we take a
look over here again it says context you
can pass a context uh for your
components so say for example if I have
my components over here and say it gets
contacts
foreign
text I am going to get a value called C
equals get context
C
okay I'm gonna show this value C value
over here on the screen as well
okay as you see
okay maybe put it at the end see
okay so if we see C is right now
undefined and we can come over here and
say context
and we can create a new uh context is
where we can pass in a map it's uh here
it says default is a empty map so you
can create a map a map with some value
in it right so I can create uh maybe I
create a new variable called context it
goes to new map
and context dot sets C equals to
10 20. right and then pass this context
I save this and then you realize that
now C is 20 because C is is
um
the context will be reading will be read
from this map that we just created right
of course if you don't like to write so
many lines of code you want to have a
more compact code then of course your
map can be instantiated directly with
um key value pair so here I'm going to
say uh
C and 20.
right
so here uh so just like a
explanation of how this works is that
you can pass in an array of key value
pairs so you can have as many uh key
value pairs over here for your map that
you're creating and since we are doing
this we why not we just inline this
whole thing over here this whoops
this would work as well right if you if
you really like a very compact uh code
for for some reason right so just to
just now I was trying to like explain
you can pass in a map and creating now
just like yeah one liner okay so we can
pass in our props that we want you can
pass in contacts uh what else can we do
over here anchor anchor says that this
is a child uh that the render
immediately before an element right so
for example over here if I come over
here and say previously we will say
document uh body right we were we're
rendering uh at the body so by default
it will be appended at the end of this
uh body so you see H1 main footer and
then the the components that we just
written but we can add an anchor anchor
and see where we want to anchor anchor
meaning this will be
um
uh this component will be inserted right
before the anchor so here if I say uh if
I come over here and maybe query for the
footer right document
dot query selector
footer
save and realize that this now this
component is inserted right before the
footer right right before the footer so
anchor is where you want so by default
your app when you're inserting to the
targets you're inserting you're
appending this components at the end of
the children so if it's there's existing
children you will add at the end of the
children list but Anchorage is that you
want to add into uh as my children but
before something else right so if you
are familiar with the Dom API called
insert before this is how
um this is this is being used by when
you're trying to insert elements right
so anchor is like inserts these
components before an anchor and by
default anchor is now then insert before
if you're passing and now actually
you're inserting at the end of the list
so
um so there's nothing unique or special
over here okay
so let's take a look what else we can do
right so hydrate and intro right hydrate
is when you want uh when your HTML has
already has something in it uh and you
want to
um hydrate it right meaning uh if if you
use a server-side rendering and then
then you probably will want to specify
uh hydrate equals to
true and you want to
hydrate the uh
but existing HTML dot Dom elements with
with your components right probably will
explain this more extensively when we
talk about server side rendering all
right so let me just remove this for now
um then what else okay so lastly Intro
by default is false right so what is
intro say for example if I come over
here and try to import
fade
from svelt transition
and I add fade
transition to my
component
okay by default if I try to refresh this
you don't see any fading right although
I'm adding this transition fade
um to to the component
um why that's because by default when
you are in the initial
when you initially the first time when
you're trying to show the component uh
the transition will not be played by
default right of course if you come over
here and maybe add another variable
called D equals to truth or initially
and if and we're gonna use this D to
depend to try to show a height
um
the whole component content
and then I maybe create a check box
now I
notice when I refresh the page there's
no transition being played
at all but now if I try to turn it off
and turn it on you see that the
component is fading right but then the
first time when you see on the screen
there's no fading being played
um right I refresh no no fading is being
played so uh this is
um to some people this is not what they
want but to most people this is this is
good right because you you wouldn't want
um at first glance when you try to add
components everything is fading right
this is this is some like the initial
content it should be just there
um of course if you want to change this
Behavior then this is where the intro uh
useful right remember if we look at the
docs by default it says false says that
it will not play transition on the
initial render right it will not play
but if it's true you will play
transition on initial render
so if I come over here and say intro to
true I save this
um
okay and I try to refresh you see that
if you take notice over here it will
refresh you'll see that the intro fading
is being played
right so this is uh how did how this
intro is being useful right so even if
we don't have this at all we don't have
any condition we have just our
components with a transition the
transition will be plate uh during the
intro when during the initial mounting
of your component all right so here
basically we covered
all of the options that is available uh
in your Constructor
but let's move on to other things that
we can do with a
with the components instance results
right because when we try to initialize
this and instantiate these components we
have the component instance and this
component instance actually you can do
certain things to it
so for example if I take this component
and come over here and try to
do something right so before we do
something we maybe let's add some
buttons
tradition the traditional old school way
adding some buttons over here I'm going
to add one button called ID a
random okay let's say ID goes random
random mice
okay so old school way we create a
buttons and now we want to add some um
we are going to add some
um event listener to this button so
we're gonna say document dot query
selector random
at event listener click
ok
not sure you can see this clearly let me
try to expand it bigger wider and let's
just make this narrower so that okay
hopefully you can see the whole lines
okay now I have my function uh let's do
something with this right
okay so uh when I click on the on the
button what I want to do is I want to
randomize the props so I want to pass
the different values to A and B so first
thing is how do I pass values to A and B
uh what I can do over here is I can come
over here and say component dot sets
and sets the props value so set is a
method for you to actually set props
value to the component so here I can say
a
a equals to 20 and b equals to 70 right
safe so when I click randomize you'll
see that it will change a to 20 and B to
70. so I want random right so probably I
can map.random
um and then let's see
um times 100
math.flor so I can get a nice round
integer number and a range from 1 to 100
so let me save this so now I randomize
you can see that this is changing A and
B right every time when I click so this
is useful when
um
for example now we we don't have we are
not being restricted on just using a
spell component in another swell
component you can actually take this
component and use it anywhere right so
for some reason you have an existing
um react app or have existing PHP
application Ruby on reels any framework
do you have existing uh you if you want
to uh just have a very small part of it
being written in svelt then you can
compile your spell component right you
can import the spell component and if
you compile it using a Serial compiler
what you get is a a spell component
class right so you import that class
you're trying to instantiate this class
and you can pass all these things like
say props and context into it and can
use it and you can still interact with
your components by sending the props
or you can set the props with this
component and if you watch my video
about uh props the two timer props one
is like normal variables there are also
um what I call a component methods for
example if you export function say do
something
uh what this will do is
um I'm gonna say Okay instead of do
something called resets do so a sets
reset a and b equals to one
uh this component method can be also
used by
uh from your component instance over
here right so here I can't come over
here
uh maybe have another button called
reset
and I'm going to call this method reset
all right let me save this let me add
another button called reset
okay
so here I have two buttons a randomize
and change the value and reset and we
reset everything back to one right so I
can interact with these components by
setting the prompts or getting some
complementals and call it directly
right so the last thing I want to show
you is actually how do you listen events
component events being dispatched from
this component itself so here I'm
dispatching a product event the name of
the event is called Product right so
here I want to listen to it how I what I
can do is I can come over here and say
component dots
on
and pass in the name of the events so
this is called Product and I can get a
event listener
and the date um let me think let me just
console out the data right so console
logged
uh product event
events.detailed right events dot detail
is where you can get the detail of the
product which is the data that you're
going to pass in over here which is the
product itself all right so here let me
open my console
uh let's show the console at the bottom
let me hide my head and let's see so
here uh every time when I change the
value you you notice that the product
event is being
triggered and you get the detail of the
events which is now the value is 70
right of course you can pass more things
say products
oops Pro product Oh I mean our products
A and B can pass in all these things in
here and so every time when you change
you get products A and B right so you
get
um
data coming out uh by listening to
events so I believe this is almost
everything that you can do with the
components right you can't set the props
or call functions or even listen to
events coming out from the components so
lastly
um here we introduce how you can
mount the components but what if you
have some buttons that you want to do
where you want to unmount components
right how do you unmount your component
that will be calling the destroy method
right so first thing so this fry will be
here in the docs right destroy so first
thing is I am going to create a button
for that I'm going to say destroy
okay so upon's click clicking on this
destroy button button whoops
let's see destroy ideas destroy
I'm gonna call destroy
okay so once it's dimming destroyed
you'll be removed and it will be it you
can't uh Mount the component backed
again anymore you have to have to create
a new component because the Destroyer
will do all the cleanup for example
remove any event listeners being added
for the component it will
um stop everything it will call the on
Destroy component lifecycle events and
things like that and the it's the best
for you to just recreate a new instance
and mount it on the screen Dom right so
that's why when you create the component
you have to pass in a Target and like
when you create an instance it's like it
should be immediately mounted on the Dom
and when you destroy there's no more
mounts method that you can call anything
else right so now let's take a look over
here if I come over here
um I
click destroy and this whole thing is
being removed and that's it you try to
inspect
um or take a look or anything uh it will
it should be it will be gone right you
won't see this anymore and and you have
to create a new component instance
um I see in the docks that says like
component props I I believe this we we
talked about this before
um if you if you remember the video I
will talk about uh spell options called
accessors
um links will be in the description if
you haven't watched that video so if you
set if you use an access uh set
accessors to true then you will also not
uh you you will get a getter and Setter
method for your prompts so not only you
can set it with a dollar sets methods
you can also directly assess the value
of a or sets a directly
um as like like as if this component
property like this right
so today I'm going to talk about
components API in svelt
specifically
server-side rendering component API
if you have watched my previous video
it's about client-side component API
meaning you can import components
um on the client side which is in the
browser and then you try to
instantiate a class and to mount it on
the dump and then you can call like the
set or on to set the props call some
functions or listen to component events
and runtime
right so but today we're going to talk
about more on the server-side kind of
things right so uh spell supports server
side rendering meaning
um svelts can actually uh provides a
method for you to call which returns a
string which is like a HTML string which
you can then return to a user so this
code can run it on the server and
whenever every someone tries to
um query something from you you can
um return some contents to the user so
the content can be dynamic
um maybe your your site is about food
blog and every time user visits a
different URL you want to return some
different different foods then it's good
to have this function in a server site
where you can call and then returns a UI
HTML content HTML string that's rendered
for different food right so you have
this function that returns and we're
going to talk about this function which
is the server-side rendering components
API
so here we are take looking at the same
examples that are prepared for
client-side component API the same old
components that we have
um but one thing is different right now
is that we are going to stare at the
JavaScript output for a while so this
JavaScript output is what you would
expect from client sites uh codes right
this is what you expect to be run on the
client side you see methods like
mounting elements
um sorry let me just open on the
component of spells you'll see codes
like creating elements mountings
elements you see codes like listen to
component events handle it or set the
component elements values and things
like that and then last but not the list
you'll see that this is exporting
defaults the component which is a class
which you can use to
instantiate amounts on the Dom and call
the methods that I've said early on
right but you do you know that there's a
compile options uh for swelts that will
compile this code that you write the
same old code that you write but compile
it for server side rendering which is
the function I just mentioned where you
can call this function and return you a
HTML string amazing right same piece of
code can compile to JavaScript that
adding elements on the Dom as well as
can compounds to a function that returns
a HTML string that can run can be run on
the server side
and you can use a flag on a compiler to
turn this on which is called the
generate right by default it sets to Dom
which is for the client sites but you
can change it to SSR which is to export
a function that returns a string right
so if you take a look at here still
again it is expanding default components
but now you look at the component itself
it looks different now and it feels like
a function over here where you can see
that this is a function that's written a
pretty much like a string right returns
a string
um so it's a Pity that you can't really
run and try server side rendering
components API
um or server side rendering at all on
the Ripple this is meant to be
interactive and only for client-side
rendering only
so what we're going to do is we're going
to download this example and we are
going to try to
run it ourselves right so that we can
verify how this works okay so before I
start running anything I want to bring
attention over here in the roll up
config this is the config file for
um this the basic setup for to to start
to compile your spell component and
start a Dev server
um so here if we scroll to look at
spelled you'll see here we're passing
compiler options this is exactly the
same that we are looking over here
compile options and now I want to change
a bit I want to add generate
to SSR so that we are generating
server-side rendering code uh uh in
States okay so I changed to generate SSR
and now I try to run this young Def
and before we run anything we're gonna
now take a look at the main.js right so
previously in the previous video I said
I want to throw all this away because
I'm going to take a look at just the
component as felt so I am going to
import that component
that's felt
but now I I can't really instantiate
this like a new
component and mount it on the Dom it
does not work that way for server side
rendering now anymore
so suicide rendering uh what you import
you you still get the export default
right as we see here export default is
the component but this component itself
has only one method which is component
whoa
components dot render only wants methods
so this is where you uh rent you this is
the function I mentioned
because uh all in all and again this is
a function that returns you
a HTML string so I'm going to console
log that because it does not really
returns a HTML string per se it's
returning an object and then object
contains some HTML string and some other
information that you would want to know
about right so I just console lock
everything out
so you can call this function so if I
come over here and try to open
this browser open the points you see
nothing because we are not mounting
anything anything on the Dom but if you
open up the console let me drag it all
the way up you probably see that it's
it's printing up a
um
it's printing up some content right CSS
hit and HTML
so um
you can pretty much see that the HTML is
the uh you can pretty much guess that
HTML is the HTML string that I mentioned
but you also see strings like hit and
CSS
so if you have a style tag in your
component then you probably have
something in the CSS which is
um
some CSS code that you would want to add
to your uh in in your HTML they want to
return to the user so usually what you
would do is you probably come over here
and piece everything up into one nicely
one nice HTML document and then send it
to the user
um
yeah send it to the user right so here
let's let me try to instead of doing
that let me just uh have a quick code to
show you how that would roughly works
right so first is in this object you
have CSS you have hit and you have HTML
okay
okay so now
um in the
so first thing first thing let me try
how about that let me do this let me
come over here and in the body I am
going to add a pre-tag
uh and I'm gonna add all the contents
over
a to the pre elements right so here I'm
gonna document dot query selector free
dot inner text equals to the HTML
so now you can see that
um
this is the
this is the HTML uh string that is being
written right you you get a div
um yeah basically everything that you
you can think of right
um let's see and I think what we want to
uh focus our attention is over here uh
first thing is so two things right so
this component that we just written as
props called a equals one and b equals
to one
all right so here you would uh if you
pay more attention uh here we have an
input that we binds a value right a the
value of a and value of B
so here if you zoom in let me zoom in a
bit and you focus over here I know it's
not nicely formatted but let's let's try
our best if you focus over here that I'm
highlighting over here you see that the
value is is one right so this is like
the default default value that you will
find in the
um
in your input when you load this HTML on
the screen
right and here you have the second input
value equals one and then here you have
the product which is one as well so you
can change this by passing a props to
your render function right so here the
render can actually takes in US quite a
few options
um so that you can
you know same component but render
different kind of content and here the
first thing you can do is you can pass
in the props
um says
a equals to 5 and b equals to ten if I
save this and I try to
oh hold on let me did I did I get it
right let's see
uh oh no okay so the first first
argument is the prop itself so there's
no props okay so I'm gonna pass a equals
five b equals to ten let's save this and
now immediately you realize that here
same inputs but value is five
and this input value is 10. you can see
here the product the product is 50. so
you can see that you can't
um generate a different HTML string
based on the different props that you're
gonna pass into this component right so
um of course not just about props you
can also pass in some context
so here let's come over here in our
components let's write some context uh
import
contacts uh get contacts
from sveld
okay and I am gonna get C from context
lowercase C just in case
and then I am going to show the value of
C so c c okay
so here let's take a look at the docs it
says that second options you can pass in
context which has which is a map same
thing as the client-side component API
right so uh first thing is we take a
look here it says C is undefined so
we're gonna change that we're going to
come over here and pass in the context
right so here we're going to create the
second argument it says context equals
some new map
C equals to 10 whoops
uh let me make it 20 right so now if I
come back you'll notice that c is now
20. so uh you can pass in context you
can pass in props and that's basically
the extent that you can do with
um you know on the server side rendering
right you you can't really change props
uh it does not make sense right you are
you are have a function that just
returns a HTML there's no reactivity or
whatever that you you intend to because
this instrument was just going to be
sent to the client and then the client
browser receives it and render it on a
screen right that's uh and that's the
end of the job of the server side
rendering right there's a job it's just
to return a HTML string so there's no uh
methods for you to play with uh change
the prompts or there's no mentors for
you to sort of like listen to component
events
um the X so the extent of server side
component API is just returning a
function and returns
um HTML string
of course we we said earlier on there's
also CSS and there's also hit so
um if you come over here you take a look
at this HTML this is like not a very
complete HTML right you you probably
what you want to send to the client is
probably a full HTML document right
nicely formatted so here let me try to
do that uh let's let's create a template
string so here I have HTML
right as as how you imagine a HTML and
now I have a
uh so the this usually goes to the body
so I'm gonna have a body element let me
Zoom it up a bit so they can see clearly
body and I'm gonna add this over here
nicely done and then sometimes you have
a hit
right uh where you put in things like
titles and stuff like that right title
so let me refresh you probably see like
this is more like it a nicely formatted
HTML uh document that you would usually
um use right so here
um let's come into this components and
add some
contents to the head right so what you
can do is you can spell uh whoa spells
okay and you can add things like title
why why you can add things like meta
I'm not very familiar with meta decks
let me try to search for One HTML meta
uh
okay this this is this sounds like good
enough author uh keywords
okay
um let's save this and let's take a come
over here and take a look at how this
hit would look like
right
um oh I didn't print that out so let's
go back to our editor
um here I'm gonna print out what is in
the hit
so you'll see that the heat now contains
um
this it is also a string which contains
everything that we just returned in
these felt hit element so let me copy
this and
let me try to replace this in States so
anything in the head will be
head
so if I ref I don't think I need to
refresh let me just collapse this down
now you see that everything is over here
is in the head everything in the body is
nicely your component so if you have uh
maybe you have a props that is like the
title
let's
and you use this props in your title
over here like this
then you could also pass in a as a props
and to change it so like this is server
sites rendering
[Music]
components API
and take a look here is your title right
you can pass in title as props and then
you render it inside the spell hit as a
title and when you call a server side
component API to rent a DOT render
function to returns then the hit will be
a string that contains all the elements
in your
in the render function over here and
HTML will be everything about
that is that should be that is over here
that is not in a spell hit every part of
like the body lastly you have CSS right
um I think we've seen CSS it's like an
object right uh if I come over here you
see CSS like an object so you just need
to peer focus on the code right so
there's code and that's map so map is
more like a source map it'll be useful
if you uh you want to debug something
um I believe it will be turned on if you
pass in the developer mode to be true
then you have some more debugging
information
I'm not quite sure this is my guess
right but I think the focus here is the
code so here you will come over here and
say uh maybe in a hit you would also
have uh
say for example a style tag
and then put everything in the css.code
inside over here
okay
uh yeah everything like this
so now you see the style also have some
inputs and this class name matches the
one that you added so this this has like
the CSS class CSS scoping built into the
component it's not just work on the
client side it also works on a server
side as well
so here now I have everything
um how about just you know um
add this let's let's save this whole
thing let's let's copy all this whoa let
me try to select all copy all this and
let's try to save it into a file
all right so public I'm gonna say
um SSR dot HTML let's save all of this
into a file let's try to open this file
right so let's try to visit SSR
and here you have it we have styles you
have everything nicely done
um of course you still don't have any
interaction because
um we haven't load any JavaScript in it
right this this whole uh file that you
see over here if you view paste sauce is
exactly everything that we just copied
uh being written from the server side
rendering function render function
right so this is
this is what you get
um so probably the next thing we're
going to talk about is hydration
today I'm going to talk about stroke
compiler API we know of swell is a
compiler
or kind of know about spell as a
compiler because I've been on and on
saying that you write your spell
component and then uh spell or transform
it into JavaScript right so that process
is called a compilation you compile your
code that you've written in one language
or something into another thing which is
Javascript in this case so we the spell
compiler compiles a component code that
you write into plain JavaScript that
browser that can execute right so most
of the time when we interact with felt
for example import get contacts
um import uh create event dispatcher
from svelt we are interacting with the
sort of like the client side of a uh of
svelte which is the runtime of svelt the
code that actually runs in your browser
but today we're going to talk about one
step back back which is how
um the the part of sveld which is the
compiler part how do we use it to
convert your spell component into
JavaScript code
all right so we're gonna take a look at
how we can use the spell compiler okay
so in most of the time you wouldn't have
to do this because most of the time you
will probably be using
um
uh some bundling tools some build tools
that you're using for example roll up or
webpack and there's already a roll-up
Plugin or webpack loaders that can
handle those for you
but you know it's never
um there's nothing wrong to learn
something else uh that how how these
plugins Works under the hood right So
eventually these plugins for example
spell roller Plugin or Rolex file Plugin
or spell loader in webpack under the
hood they're still using the spelled
compiler API to compile your component
code to JavaScript code right so we're
going to take a look at how that is
being used one of the options that can
be used and and probably some scenarios
of how you can use them right so let's
take a look at some examples right now
so here
on the screen that I have is a very very
very basic setup you can see that I have
on the left or I have
um
four files right so I think three of the
files that you just need to pay
attention for so the first one is the
component as well so this is a plain
this is my typical spell component that
you would write just a normal cell
component that has
um yeah that import forms felt that has
some functions templates hit and
everything else over here
so index.js is what we're going to fill
in later on so this is where we're gonna
import the spell compiler API and we're
gonna use it to compile our code
but here package.json
um this is very common
um npm uh sorry node.js setup where you
have a package Json where you specify
all dependencies so that you can use
them right here I specifies felt as my
dependencies so I'm importing's belt so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to import spell compiler and
start compiling our spell com code into
JavaScript so here I am going to
index.js and I'm going to import this
field compiler so this is this felt
compiler from oh sorry require
swell compiler okay and of course I need
to find this file so I'm going to use uh
f
I'm going to read out the content of
this file first so that I can compile
them so I am going to use FS require RFS
so FS is a built-in node
modules API that you can read content
from a file
um also I'm going to use path so that I
can form a path
for this component so here the path
would be
path to my component
will be path.join
current directory
Source component does
let's see
okay
then I would have next thing is that
okay hold on I oops sorry
let me wrap around okay
so next thing I'm gonna do is I'm going
to read the content so fs.read file
sync I'm going to use a synchronous
version of the read file so that I can
just uh
yeah or whatever everything is like one
line we don't have to use uh promises uh
deal with promises and stuff so here I'm
going to read the file content
encoding is utf-8
uh spell code so this is a spell code
that we just read out from this file and
then the next thing is we're going to
call sveld compiler
to compile our codes so let's take a
look at how we can use this so if you
import compiler you get a spell dot
compile so here's dot compile
and then you pass in the code
so this is the code
and then you can pass in some options
over here so some of these options we've
seen before for example like file name
um sorry some of not not file name but
some of we've seen before such as
um but in the in a episode when we talk
about asphalt options we say that spell
options allows us to specify some of the
spell compiler options so these are the
ones like immutable
accessors custom elements
um tag right these are the ones that
we've seen before so I'm gonna I'm not
gonna go through them but for file names
and names would be what will be the
um
uh class of the the name of the the
class name of the cell component right
so if you take a look at spell rapple
over here sorry
where we see that this is the JavaScript
output let me take a look come over here
we see that app is the class name right
so you can change this you can specify
what kind of class name it will be and
by default it will be component right so
um I'm not touching this but this is
like just to tell you like what will
what you get if you will change this
right so by default also if you don't
have if you don't specify a name it will
try to infer from file name but founding
by default is is now if you don't
specify so found it if so meaning
uh if you specify file name and uh
if you like if you specify a file name
for example in this case our file name
is the uh
component component that's felt
right uh then it probably would know
that
uh it will probably will infer this as
as component is the as the class name
right if you if our component name is
say tab bar then Tap bar will be the
class name so if you don't have file
name then you're based on the name that
you specified so Name by default is
component if you don't specify one if
not you can still change it as I say
name is a
um scrollable list right then then the
name will be the component class name
will be Scrabble list okay
so here we also have formats which is
esm or CGS this uh this will change how
the code will be exported right so uh
things like uh
okay you can't change it here so
probably we will continue and we'll take
a look we'll compare the uh the
difference of the output and then we
will take a look at it right so by
default I think we don't have to specify
anything
we can come over here because most of
the things has reasonable fallback a
reasonable sorry reasonable default for
example format is esm generate this term
and things like that so what you gather
from here is gonna be
um JavaScript CSS EST warnings variables
and stats so a lot of things that you
don't really need to know or care about
I think the most important one is the
JavaScript and CSS
so Jessica and CSS would be an object so
let's take a look let's just console off
for the moment
all right JavaScript and CSS
uh no let me Zoom this up a bit as well
okay
no index.js
okay so now you see that
um the JavaScript would be an object
that has code which is
the JavaScript code that you see as well
as a map which is like a source map so
Source map will help will be helpful for
you if you want to do debugging later on
right so this is the source map object
that you probably would want to save it
in a separate file
um yeah as a separate file
um then CSS will also have two uh it's
also an object that has code as well as
Source map all right so first thing what
we can do is now is we're just gonna
save the JavaScript into a file right so
we're gonna create I'm going to write
this file write file sync and I'm gonna
create another path
so half name.join
and I'm gonna
maybe called output.js
and then the JavaScript code
and
format is utf-8
right I'm gonna say for CSS file as well
output.css
okay so let's run this again
we're done let's open our you'll see
that we have
oops uh I think I save JavaScript code
into the CSS okay now let's try running
again
okay we're done I'll put CSS we have
we have a CSS file over here
okay JavaScript we have a Javascript
file over here
um
yeah we have everything over here let's
scroll all the way down
um yeah this is the component so by
default the as I said component name is
component right so let's try to change
that
um so I can come over here and say
um
let's think let's see our name equals to
fool okay if I run that again
okay and now you see that output is is
full right let me try to just open both
sides so that uh
probably we can see changing immediately
hopefully if we have enough space okay
so
um a big cramped maybe not
okay so this is one thing we can change
the class name and here you see that
it's using ES module so it says export
default full
um okay so let me interrupt for a bit so
you may ask me like what what does it
matter of the class name well
um most of the case it doesn't matter
unless probably you are using something
uh for some reason you um
uh maybe in the script module you write
you you have another uh
uh context
you have something else over here
um like a class
component or something then maybe you
are worried about conflict but I will
assure you that
um
it doesn't really matter
because uh the the name is it's like
it's it's based on
um
yes you you give a hint about the
component name but when during the
output it will still try to deconflict
and prevent prevent any conflict between
um
uh prevent any conflict between the code
that you write and the code that we the
spell compile is going to generate right
so you don't have to really worry about
that so it's mostly for nicely printing
out the codes where you have a nice
class name and also maybe when you print
out the instance some debugger will tell
you like this extends from a certain
class and if all the spell component
class that you created are all named
components it's a bit hard to debug I
would say so this is mainly for nicely
printing out and nicely debugging right
so as I was saying that this output
export default is es modules so you can
change that you can come over here
and make a change right so we can see
uh this is part of the format so now if
I change it to format to CGS common GS
now if I run this again
you see that the output now change to
common.js right previously it's export
default
um something now it's exports.default
equals to something this is the common
JS export so you still get not default
so that when you import no matter
whether you are importing from a common
GS file or like um
yes modules I think your bundler will
know how to handle this case where uh
components will still be the dot default
export so it could be the named defaults
or like actual default export from es
modules
so next we have generates I think we've
seen this before the last video when we
talked about server side rendering so
this would depend or will
um
will allow us to specify whether we are
generating for a server-side rendering
so SSR
so this is a service ironing code or it
should be a
code that run on the client side on the
browser right so by default is Dom okay
so
um we have some Dev this is to turn on
or turn off some of the
um
uh debugging code that you have so for
example if you use add debug or if you
are using a spell Chrome extension to do
a spell debugger
um this actually will when you turn this
on by default actually it has some sort
uh will add extra code for you to for
for the for your code to talk to the uh
swell Chrome extension
um so here we have we've seen yeah I
think it's best for me to just also show
you that
what are those codes so if I def equals
to true
I think it's true by default
but
um over here you'll probably see like
things like add location
uh things like insert depth so it's a
developer a Dev version which when you
call this function internally it will
also inform the
uh Chrome extension that oh you're
inserting some elements over here uh
there's also some Dispatch they have
some some Dev uh some communication is
happening from your code to the swell
Chrome extension right so if you specify
this as false which you should if you
are building for production
then all this code will be will not be
generated right so you you don't have
this yeah all those codes will not be
generated will not be inserted into your
compile code
right so here um
you can also have this flag turn on
called Legacy so this will try to
generate uh try as as much as possible
to generate code that will also work in
ie9 and IE10 so try not to generate
codes that is uh
so this okay so so there's a difference
between using this and using Babel for
you to do Transportation right so uh
this will only ensure that the code that
smell generates spelled injects
will also works in I9 and IE10 but if
you are yourself writing
syntaxes that is not supported in 9910
for example if you are writing optional
chaining for example uh those will not
be converted to support for I9 and A10
you will need to pass this code that you
have for example right now it's
outputting a JavaScript code right so
this code will be uh what we will inject
some of the Spells code so those will
work for I9 and 10 but the code that you
write will also be copied verbatim so
so we don't do any transformation for
those code except for like reactivity
and stuff right so here if you have code
that is written for I like newer
browsers and you want to support all the
browsers Legacy browsers then your
JavaScript code over here you probably
will have to come over here and maybe do
a Babel transform
[Music]
sync with a JavaScript code and you get
a transform
[Music]
yeah maybe a trans like a Babel
transform over here and you write this
to your your to the output right so if
you so this will help you to transform
the rest of the code that you write into
uh to JavaScript code that uh ie9 or 10
or any browsers that you're targeting
that supports them right so uh in this
example I'm not going to show here I'll
just leave it as it is
okay so the rest of the options are I
think you've seen before uh most of the
things are
uh pretty much
um
self-explanatory like the file name
output file name CSS Apple file name
that's felt path so this felt path
itself is interesting because this right
if you come over here and take a look at
the output code it is importing from
svelt right it's spelled internal
spelled and spelled right so this uh
assumes that
um spell is available at this current
location that you are putting a code to
right so for example and this is okay
and most of the case when you are using
a bundle because this uh but the bundle
will know how to look for a Sprouts in
our case also I think we reinstall in no
module so this is okay for us as well uh
but in rare cases that maybe yours felt
um is in some other folders that you
somehow
for some reasons okay you can change
that you can come over here and say
spell path equals to
um XXX right just just for demonstration
then you'll see that now instead of
importing as well you're importing XXX
internal so if you have a custom version
of svelt or your spell is in certain
folder somewhere then you can have this
you can change this and
and the rest of the code is still like
like normal that how cell generates
right so here if we take a look at when
we are generating for Dom you'll see
that there's a function called at CSS
this uh will try to add the CSS into so
this this function will be run when you
are mounting your component and this
function will try to add a style element
with the CSS that uh
that it's generating right but we really
have an output CSS file as well right or
this will also give us a CSS code that
we can write in a CSS file as well so
it's up to us whether we want to have
the CSS as like a separate file or or
just let the JavaScript to just do it
right so if by default the JavaScript
code that the slot generates will also
take in charge of adding CSS to the Dom
so you don't have to worry about that uh
so yeah but then if you don't want that
you don't want that extra could uh thing
that you've been generated by JavaScript
you don't want JavaScript to insert CSS
but rather you have an external you you
want to get a CSS output and save an
external file and include this CSS file
in your HTML right if you want to do
that then what you need to do is you're
going to come over here and specify CSS
to false
right so this is this option it says
over here CSS false then you will not be
included in the JavaScript so if I run
this probably see that
now you don't have the CSS function over
here right we don't the jet skill will
not take care of adding CSS but of
course your your component is Right will
still have
the class names right those those are
scoped class names so it's up to you to
figure out how when you want to load
your CSS so you still can get your CSS
output from here and you know try to
write in a file or do whatever you want
with it but just make sure that you have
it available so that at least your
component is style right
uh there's another function called CSS
hash so this one
if you take a look over here it says
that it's a function that takes in a
hash CSS name and file name and you
should return some a string right so
what this means so over here you see
that CSS uh to to do a scoping we add
some Spell customs felt hash class names
to your elements right and here is a
spell Dash and blah blah right so this
this hash is generated
um
uh based on it's a hash
of your code that you you written so
every time when you change your code it
join a different hash right and and some
people doesn't like the prefix call
spell Dash prefix so you can change that
uh so this is a CSS hash uh function
that can change these class names right
so it's a function that that's not so
you you just Implement you you specify a
function that returns a string and that
string will be used
um will be
will be used in States
that that string will be used instead of
the the default class name that provides
right so by default a hash is a function
and you can pass in a CSS or whatever
and then you generate this right this is
the default uh spell class that spell
generates but you can change that so for
example I'm gonna say I don't care about
hash I don't care anything I just want
my all my class to prefix with uh x y z
okay but you have to be careful with
this so everything prefix if x
everything will be x y z
okay uh let's take a look over here
so all your special scope class name
will be x y z and when I say you have to
be careful is that now if you have
multiple components that has this class
name then they are not scoped to just
one component anymore because all the
components share this special unit class
name right previously this class name
also includes a hash that is unique to
this component because it's generated
based on this component based on the
code that you write you've written for
this component so if you don't have that
stand
um yeah it's it's a bit uh you have to
it's a bit worrying that your scoping
may not work right so by the uh so it's
recommended that you use the hash
function to generate some hash right so
you have a hash you have CSS you have
name and file name right so this name
and file name is the one that being
passed over here previously we say we
can specify name and file name right uh
of course
so here we're gonna say this plus uh
maybe a hash CSS
all right let's try run
oops
let's see so at least now you have some
hash in injected as well or maybe you
don't even you don't like xyzing you can
total it's totally up to find so this is
customizable it's really up to you what
you want you can have a hash only uh and
if you find that hash hash is too long
you can change it but you have to be
careful right
um just make sure that there's enough
characters to make sure that the
Collision the possibility of collision
is very very low right if you only have
like one character imagine you only uh
have like a to z and one to zero to nine
that's like 36 characters and it's very
high probability like 1 in 36 chance to
get Collision all right I hope I get my
match correct so anyway
um oh okay I think my match should be
every as long as my pigeonhole principle
more than 36 if you have 37 components
then you will have one two components
that will have Collision right so uh
here we have some um
other flags that are just uh for
developer uh that is turned on for
developer mode for example Loop got
timeout this one is we added this for
the repo for example if you
um
for example accidentally added a while
look that never ends this will try to
throw an error for if your Loop goes uh
um goes more than like how many cycles
or something like that right so this
will oh if your Loop goes more than like
a certain period of time so this guards
the the loop so um yeah you want to have
this if you have a look if you
just in case your your code will like
in finite looping and freeze up the
whole browser
but this is mostly for developer
potentially right because once you your
code is written you you tested it most
likely you don't have any infinite Loop
happening right I believe I believe in
you
so uh here are some other things like
say whether you want to preserve a
comments or you want to preserve some
white space in between elements and
things like that and I think that's
mostly of most of the options that you
can do with uh your spell compile
the last video we talked about spell
compiler API and this video I'm going to
talk about spelled pre-process
so um in a spell compiler API will learn
that we have a function called
spell.compile which takes in the spell
code in string that you write and it
will return an object that has like
JavaScript and CSS which you can use it
and write in a file or use it somehow
right so
um you you take self code that you write
and it transforms to spell to JavaScript
code
but sometimes the spell code you write
it's not actually it's spelled code per
se for example uh as well expects that
the code you write is in normal CSS code
and also like normal JavaScript code and
HTML but sometimes you are lazy or you
want to use some tools that you have for
example like typescript or you want to
write a says or less instead of normal
CSS or you want to use park instead of
normal HTML then you want to pre-process
your code before you pass that code that
you have into
this filter compile function so imagine
your code whatever you write spark CS
says less subscript or coffeescript the
code you write over here on the on your
on the left so this is my right spot I
know this will be reflected on your left
um whatever you write you have to pass
you have to transform them into normal
code which is just HTML CSS and
JavaScript and then use felt the compile
to transform that into JavaScript and
CSS right so this step from whatever you
write to HTML JavaScript and CSS
um you can do it yourself you can just
transform yourself or you can use
pre-process which is a helper function
that extracts out
um pieces uh it will break your code
into pieces into like CSS uh not CSS it
will break into the style text script
tags and markup everything that you
write
and you break them down into pieces so
that you can
um
so that you can transform each part
individually if you want
right so let's take a look at an example
over here so here we have the code that
we we just written for as well compiler
API so we we read all the code from
asphalt code from a file and we pass
that file directly into our search
compiler right so say for example right
now let's remove everything from the
slope
component that we have that except we
just left with normal script tag style
tag and some HTML right so first thing
is maybe we don't want to write a script
tag we want
um
let's see okay let's let's just try to
write some basic CSS right let's Stitch
equals that name
equals to over here I will say I want to
have
like a global variable uh which I want
to be injected when we were uh by some
process right so maybe I have a value
that I I only would know during
composition process so here I'm going to
replace it with a placeholder like uh
maybe using this right so name
um using a percentage sign okay so this
as you can see I have some red underline
You by by the looks of it you know that
this is not a valid JavaScript code
right you can't have a variable name
that starts with a percentage so
um
and then we have HTML code so here I'm
going to have a div tag
that that restart name right so here we
want to
um take this code read this piece of
code and then we're going to process it
we want to transform it into a normal
JavaScript uh sorry a normal Circle and
then only pass it to spell compile
because if I just take this read this
code oh this file and pass it to spell
compiler uh what you see that is that it
will have a past error because the code
you just written is not a valid
JavaScript code so let's see so here we
read this file out it's a normal code so
what we can do is we can
um
process I'm going to have a new variable
called process code equal to 0 could
not replace
uh this thing
into
whoops
into valid string so here I'm going to
say it has hello world okay
now uh if you try to look at this
process code you realize that we have
replaced this percentage into a string
and hopefully that will be that will end
up with a valid JavaScript code in the
script tag so if you run this now
hold on okay we need to pass this in as
well I run this now
replace
let's see what do I missed
um
okay so most likely we don't have CSS
that's why this is this is throwing an
error okay
now we run everything works if you come
over here and take a look at the output
JavaScript code we'll take a look at the
code over here you see that the name is
now replaced to hello world and
everything still works right so
um of course this is
you so this is the essence of
pre-processing you have your code you
run through a function in this case a
function that we're going to run through
is replace like name and then we pass
the preprocess code to the cell compiler
right so sometimes it's not as
straightforward as this sometimes your
code itself the entire piece of code is
is written in like say typescript or
coffeescript that you can't really uh do
like just a normal replace you will have
to go through like they are compiler to
transpile it out to just normal
JavaScript then you probably would want
to have this function called a
preprocess so sveld compiler has a
function called preprocess
that's again taking our string
and taking a list of preprocessors
okay uh it could be an array or it could
be an object and this will again return
us a process code
okay let me comment this out okay
Returns the process codes so
here in a pre-process what you
what you pass in is an array
of objects so each of this object is
called a preprocessors and this over
here you can
this object itself can be a
can have three properties one is the
markup
or the
style or the script so individually each
of this is a is a function that takes in
the code just in the script tag and
transform it out right so uh what is so
let's take a one example I'm going to do
here I have this you know we said about
this is is have in our script tags but
we also have the same
text over here in HTML so we want to
handle only the case in the we only want
to trans uh replace it okay so let's
let's do this
we want to replace if it's in a script
tag but not replace it if it's in the
HTML
so what we can do here is that we can't
really rely on replacing all anymore
but rather we have to come into a
pre-process serve preprocess part and we
only do we only transform in the script
parts right so here it takes in a
Content which is the codes
so it's a function so this is a function
so taking contents and we're going to
replace the content right so we're going
to use the same code over here and do a
replace
and now we then that's it that's like a
simplest preprocessor that I can think
of now you have a pre-process code and
you pass it on the compiler and now we
run it through
hold on it must be a string
okay and then pre-process code is
oh it's a promise okay
now I need to uh okay so I have done
uh value
okay I'm gonna copy all this shove all
this in
so value like code is the code
so value is an object that has a code as
well as a source map so that Source map
can works or can map back to the
original code before you do a
pre-processing okay so for now we just
for Simplicity we just pass in the codes
in
uh let's
going on
that's oh I need to return this right
and what you return is actually going to
be
um
object as well
and you should return a object with
content
right so it says over here that sorry
not contents code
it says over here that your preprocessor
should return
um
if you return the object with a code
property that represents the transform
code right so here let's run again and
we are done and let's take a look at the
output which we have Hello World being
transformed over here at the same time
in the text content you still see like
the normal percentage percentage name
right so
um if you try to log out from here you
try to console out from here you notice
that the content will just only uh
having the contents in the script tags
so this is how you would probably use
this spell preprocessors
um because then you probably would have
to handle like uh like and so so you can
write your own preprocessors if you like
too right so it's not just about
contents what you get over here is also
attributes so attributes is all the
attributes that's available on the
script element here so for example uh
sometimes you know we don't want to
transform all the script tags uh it
depends on maybe say a language is it a
typescript a coffee or you have some
other things like contacts also special
things like that and you only want to do
a pre-processing for
um code that has this attribute script
tag that has only this attribute if you
want to do that then what you can do is
you can come over here and check the uh
attributes right so say for example uh
maybe I have attribute say name
equals to special so this attribute is
what we're gonna read from this
attribute and actually we're going to
replace percentage percentage name with
this name right so for some reasons you
already know it but you just want to use
it over here and you want to replace
everything from here to here so what we
can do is we can't
um
check attributes dots
name this will give us a value so this
will gonna replace it over here instead
and this is the string itself right and
we can't just put in a string if we just
put in a string like this what you'll
get is
um
what you get is
special like like a variable right but
what you want is actually like just a
string so we're gonna do a Json string
G5
as in a spring literal that directs with
a quartz sign so now if you drive run
again now we see our code will have name
equals to special
right so here you can read
um attributes and most of the times it
will also some people would like to do
is it will check say for example
attributes the type uh language is
typescript only then we do some
transformation or else we just leave it
alone and things like that right so you
should also you could probably see some
examples over here as well like if it's
if it's attribute this language it says
then we we return we don't do anything
if it's not sense we don't know anything
and the rest will be like pre-processing
for for sales right so here um
uh you see that this is how you would
write your own preprocessors and code is
just one of the
um
uh
property that you can return you can
also return one thing that's called
dependencies so here optional array of
dependencies so dependency should be an
array of files that
um
that you return from from the process
code right here process code actually
will have not just
code you can also have
dependencies right this will be an array
that combines all the dependencies for
all the preprocessors so um in our case
we don't really need uh this this array
is useless to us but in some cases it's
useful for uh your bundles for example
roll up a webpack because they want to
know like what your file is depending on
right it's not just depending on the
current file itself it also maybe
depending on some config file some of
the files so for example if your if
you're writing a preprocessors and you
uh
uh you read the name like this name from
some files then you probably also have
to specify the the the path of the file
so that every time when someone change
that file
um your bundler will know that it will
have to
um go come over here again and run
through the previous process again and
update so that it will pre-process again
and up have an updated name for your
component right updated value for this
name right so dependencies will be that
array that you specify like what other
files will depend on so another example
would be say you are using Tailwind you
pre-process Tailwind in your CSS and you
will want to specify Tailwind config as
your dependencies so every time when you
change the Tailwind config like changing
like the font some colors then the your
bundle would know that oh
um all the files are depending on that
config will have to be recompiled have
to be run through the preprocessor again
and and that's where this dependencies
array will be useful for you
so uh we we've seen how um how we can do
with scripts but it will be the same for
style and a markup
right so that I will not go too deep on
that anymore I'm gonna not gonna show
any examples
um so this is this felt compiled a
pre-process is only uh useful if you are
like me then write this code and show
you an example but most of the case this
pre-processors pre-process function will
be called the same way as how the spell
compiler compile will be called by the
plugin for your bundles say for example
spell rollout Plugin or like spelled
loaders right so
um in in those loaders or plugins
usually they have a few called
pre-process that you can pass in
preprocessors so that is where you can
pass in this object into that option
right so it's still useful to know that
um how to write like one preprocessors
and you can try it out with a spell
compiler and try it out yourself but
usually you wouldn't want you most cases
you wouldn't call pre-process directly
and you would let your uh
bundles plugins like Plugin or spot
loaders to do that for you
in this video we're going to talk about
hydration so we have talked about how we
can use client-side component API
server-side component API we talk about
compilers API and naturally I'm not sure
whether it's natural but we are going to
talk about hydration so what is
hydration
um and how do we use hydration in
Sprouts well we're gonna check that out
okay so what is hydration so hydration
is a process where you have uh content
in HTML that is coming from the server
be it rendered dynamically whenever
there's a new request or the HTML has
already generated ahead of time via
pre-rendering and you get this HTML
download it to your browser and it
creates all the Dom elements right so
you already have existing Dom Elements
which is the same elements that you
might have or you could have or you
would have created using uh on a client
site uh you over by your cell components
so instead of recreate like instead of
recreating elements
um you look at the existing Dom elements
and say hey actually they are the same
element we are going to use this
existing Dom elements instead of
creating everything from scratch then uh
you would do the process called a
hydration in which you kind of find
you'll try to go through on elements in
your template that you are supposed to
create and instead of creating them
you're referring you're you're pointing
a reference to elements that's existing
existed on the Dom
and later on when there's interactions
you since you already have the reference
or Dom you can immediately later on you
can immediately make changes to it or
react to any user interactions so that
is in essence uh how what is a hydration
and in this video we're going to take a
look at how we can use how we can do
hydration in svelt are you ready okay so
here I have my component written ahead
of time so I have two props name and
language at the same time the name is
actually a state where I bind and inputs
to this name variable right so you can
see I will expect this when on the
client side when I hydrate I still have
my own the same input and I can make
changes to the input
and over here I have some elements that
shows the content
um based on whatever the data that we're
getting
so uh first thing of hydration is you
probably want to render this out in the
server side right you you want to have a
way to generate a HTML first and then
you serve that HTML user so here what
I'm going to do now is that I'm going to
come over here in next year's and I'm
gonna write all that out right so first
is I'm going to import this felt
compiler uh from spell compiler
um
so here I'm gonna write out
um the raw process the manual process
that you you might uh you would have to
write if you are not using any framework
such as um swiper or in future maybe
spell kit right this is what is being
done under the hood I'm gonna take a
look at like the the raw way of doing
things right so we have a spec compiler
and we're going to compile our code
um uh using a Target to SSR so so that
we get a function and we can call this
function to get us a HTML right so first
thing is I'm going to call spell
compiler dot render uh dot compile
and when you pass in the code right so
first is we so we need to read our code
so we're going to use import file system
from node API and as well as a path
so that we can read out the path
um so our source code would be here uh
path to component is path.join
okay
okay and then we're gonna read out the
source code so code equals to read file
sync so I'm going to use a synchronous
version of the read file so that I don't
have to away from anything I can just
like read it out so I'm gonna pass in a
path to components and encoding would be
UDF
so here I'm going to pass in this code
in and I'm going to specify my targets
uh no I think it's called generate to
SSR so we're going to generate an SSR
code and also most importantly because
we want to do hydration we also need to
pass in a flag called hydratable to be
true
so this will generate uh the function
the that the function that we end up
getting that will return as a HTML will
be a hydratable HTML so uh cell may do
some optimization or add some reference
here and then
um so that it's easier for us to find
out where the element is later on when
we want to hydrate this um from this
from the HTML that is being returned
from our code right here uh if you take
a look
we have just cut and CSS
I think we can leave the CSS alone and
get the JS and so now js.code
uh would be the
code outputs that uh it's a function
that there's a function right so what we
can do is we are going to
um
take this phone uh take this piece of
code okay so first is let's take a look
at what this is
right this is a piece of
code
um JavaScript codes
that is compiled using SSR mode right
um probably we would let's see
yeah so
um
we have to call this we will have to
treat this as a module and then call it
later right so I think the easiest way
is we're gonna write this piece of code
into a file and then we execute the file
later on so I'm gonna do that so
right
file sync and then they wanna say
path.join
um
oh
uh
component.ssr.js so we're gonna write
this content into a file and we're gonna
import it later on
so this file is
um see it's an es module and right now
we are running in common.js so probably
we also say the uh out
what's that
uh we need the option call let's see
formats right we're gonna change our
formats to
CGS I'm going to write this file
the this this the JavaScript code that's
generated into a file
so if I run this
you'll see that now we have a new file
called component SSR which is in
common.js and probably we can run it so
the way you run it is to just require it
right so probably I will save this path
as a
path to SSR code
um so
SSR component
and remember we use a Xbox on defaults
right so we can probably we need not
default to get this
value
now if you console out SSR
components it will be the SSR you'll be
object with a render function right so
we're going to call this render function
to render
um to render our component into a HTML
code and glass so now we're gonna
call this
render
and I'm going to pass in some props so
the first so here if we took a look at
our code there's two props name and
language so I'm going to say uh name
would be
uh
Scout and language
it's also called sprouts
right okay maybe name is the how Okay so
we're gonna call render and this
will return us
um
some contents right so if you take a
look at server side component API this
is the results result will return us
ahead the HTML and the CSS
right so he HTML and CSS so we're gonna
piece all this together and then we'll
um
to form HTML content I'm gonna send that
contents to a user right so here we're
gonna what we're gonna do is we are
going to firstly
okay so I wanna my plan is I'm gonna
write this HTML file into a folder
called public
um so that later on we're gonna open
this folder right so this folder will be
uh I'm gonna create this folder now
public
so this folder will have our HTML file
and later on we're going to compile the
JavaScript code uh and we're gonna
include that JavaScript code in this
public folder as well so here we're
gonna say a
let's see
okay so the
output HTML would be looks like this so
we have a HTML
and then we have a hit this is where we
put in the hit content
and also we can have some Style
this is where we put in our CSS
and then we have okay
I think style text should be placed
inside the head
all right let's say format it okay and
then we have a body
and I guess that's where we'll put in
our HTML con our
our HTML content right so here if I
output HTML that looks like this and
we're gonna write this HTML output to a
file inside public folder right so I'm
gonna do that now so
um write file sync
path dot join
public
index.html
content
all right so we're going to write this
file into a HTML
file into the index HTML right so when I
run this
see that now I have a new file over here
and I have all our content so
ah wait hold on CSS is not
so CSS knob and object which will have
to write the css.code
in
all right now we have everything ready
and if you try to open this file over
the browser it's gonna say open
public
index
I'm sorry
public index HTML
oh
whoops
foreign
you see this now okay but there's no
interaction yet so when I type something
there's no reactivity at all because uh
we haven't load our JavaScript code so
now the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to compile our codes uh for
JavaScript for the client sites
and write it to a file in a public
folder as well so next thing is we're
gonna do is we can come over here
um
I'm gonna have the same Parts but we're
gonna we'll still do a compilation but
now we're gonna do we're gonna compile
for our client sites and make sure that
we also have high readable to true
and we format will be I think we can
leave the format as it is as esm
okay and next thing is uh let's see
and okay so because uh server side we
already have like CSS inserted so here
we can uh
just don't have to compile CSS for our
client-side component so if you check
here there's this flag call
CSS right so CSS you can find as false
because we don't need don't need it
right so now we get our JavaScript code
I'm going to write it into a file so FS
dot write filesing
uh now we're gonna have uh
this one and I'm gonna say index.js
yes I could and
encoding as UDF
okay so um
now if you run this we
oops sorry
ah okay so we have to rename this I'm
gonna say JS client side Js
okay you're gonna build again
uh I don't see anything different yet
but we have X at we have a new
file created
um
add over here index.js right so here uh
we are going to also we are now we need
to
add this file into our index uh refer
reference to this file in our HTML so
that we can load this JavaScript on the
by the browser so let's see uh we can
come over here and add a script tag
Source will be index.js
and because we are using import
statements so we also need to make sure
that uh it's uh the type is module
right so let's let's try to run that
again
and if you take a look over here it says
that
um
okay uh we can't we need to be a
relative path
okay so the thing is we can't load a
module scripts
um
uh using
uh in the file protocol right so if you
open this file like this you can't
really serve this file so what we need
is we need a file server uh that serves
all the folders from the public folder
so here I'm going to open a new tab
um and run the hdb server to serve the
public folder
so here I'm going to visit this and it
will still serve our index HTML right
you can take a look now
uh we realized that oops
we reloaded index.js and
still not working
take a look at
um I think jet index.js is loaded
correctly
hmm I'm not sure maybe because of this
right uh how are we going to import from
svelt slash internal because if I come
over here and say
um part 8080 spell internal
um this does not lead to anything so the
files felt slash internal is giving us a
404 we can't find this file uh fair
enough uh this file is not even in the
public folder at all
so if you're using if you're using a
bundler this shouldn't be a problem
because a bundler will look through all
its dependency and try to bundle
everything into one file in our case
um we don't have this we don't have a
bundle we only compile one code one
spell component code into like one
normal JavaScript module right so all
these import statements are still there
um we will have to figure a way to
find this file and
um resolve it ourselves right so first
thing is this is not like a valid import
statement you can't really import
um like this it's either where you start
with a slash where it says it's absolute
from the root folder root as in this
case is the public folder or relative to
the file the current file which is
public index.js relative to the current
file right so we're gonna
um what we're gonna do is we're gonna
probably try to copy this file from the
new modules and paste it into the public
folder so here this will be coming from
root folder uh Slash internal and also
you need extension so that you know what
file to find right uh it's unlike
unlike you when you're doing a bundling
uh the bundle will figure out that okay
spell internal uh which file am I
reading from in this case if you take a
look at the node modules you'll find
that
svelt's internal slash internal there's
a package Json so a bundle will look at
this file and then figure The Next Step
so if it's internal it's a folder and it
finds a package just on your figure okay
let's read this one and figure out okay
uh a bundle so figure out whether to get
like the main file or the module files
or you know and and try to get resolved
to that file but in our case we don't
have a bundle so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just copy this index MJS
file and gonna paste it into the public
folder right
um so these are like manual works so I'm
gonna copy paste the index so I'm gonna
have root paths slash
internals Dot
MGS okay so here I need to rename my
file to be spelled slash internal MGS as
well so that I can resolve to this I can
find this file right luckily this file
does not have any more import statement
so I think that will be the extent of it
so let's save this let's save our
index.js as well uh let's and let's try
to refresh again
um interesting this is not
uh resolving from the let's see bundle
will load this file index.js type module
oh we didn't close our script tag that's
why that's problems over here okay so
let's see uh let's come over here and
close our script tag
uh we I think we just come over here and
do it ourselves in the build code as
well
okay and let's refresh again
okay in this case we loaded index.js as
well as internal MGS right everything is
loaded but if you try to run
nothing happened yet right so what's the
problem now uh the problem is we have
this component we loaded but we haven't
really used it right recall the
client-side component API where we
actually import this component and then
we actually use it in a sense where we
uh instantiate this component right so
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
move this index.js file into a
component.js
and I'm gonna create another file called
index.js and here I am going to write uh
Imports component from component Dot Js
right and then I am going to create an
instance okay component equals new
component
and now I need to figure out my targets
so in my case in our case the target is
the body because we pasted everything
HTML into the body so we're gonna say uh
I'm gonna come over here and say targets
it goes to the body
sorry document.body
and then hydrate the bow
uh let's see so let's look at the
component event hydrate the ball
whoops
I think it's called the
hydrates we need to pass it as true
now we need to specify the same props as
what we get over here as well in our
server side when we render this
component a our component let's see
where are we
okay we don't when we call this uh props
is Lee how and spelled so we're gonna
copy this over as well
you see there's a lot of things to make
sure everything goes correctly
right but when you have something like a
stepper or spell kit all this is being
done for you
so here we
instantiate okay so the most important
thing that is different from what we've
done previously is that this has to be
true hydrate has to be true and
I have to make sure that this uh our
code that we built is hydratable to be
true for server side as well as the
client side so let's save this save
everything
and let's try to refresh again
this time round uh we loaded in next
year's component and internal MGS now
hopefully the uh we there's no error in
the console except we didn't have a
fevicon very con right but now we we
already Mount our component so if I try
to type something you see that now
everything is reactive
right so
um
so this is how it's it's gonna be what
uh how it works right so now you maybe
will ask me like oh okay
um it feels like nothing's different if
say if your HTML has no elements at all
right if I remove everything from the
body
I remove all this
like this nothing inside the body
um if I refresh again
everything still works fine how do I
know the hydration kicks in and how do I
know whether it's being hydrated
correctly or not well let's take a look
so let's restore back the
let me put it back put back the original
elements right and let's refresh
everything looks normal uh so how do I
know whether hydration Works usually
this is how I'm gonna take a look first
is I'm gonna open up the network
condition
so let's let me find where is the
say Network condition so I use command P
to open up this drawer and find like uh
you can manually type this arrow symbol
and say Network condition
so here I'm gonna see I'm gonna okay
sorry I'm not sure I'm not going for no
condition first is I'm gonna disable
JavaScript
JavaScript disable
so what this do is that now I load my
page this whole thing is so called
server rendered because we uh of course
on our case it's more like we don't
dynamically render this page on per
request but we render ahead of time when
we run our code to generate HTML right
so this HTML is already rendered is
being generated so here you get this
static HTML that has no JavaScript at
all so no interaction at all you can
still type but no reactivity at all
right so here when I
I can do is I am going to look at this
elements right look over here these are
the elements and if I turn on JavaScript
uh what I expect is that later on when I
refresh uh let's see
okay
I think I miss one step so first is I'm
gonna come over here
and set a
timeout
you know timer is a bit uncomfortable
okay let me add another
button
in the HTML
let me add one button so it's okay that
you have extra elements over here uh
High trade I'm gonna call it
um ID it feels hydrate so I'm gonna have
this extra button over here
and in our code we will uh
um
only 100
our
HTML when I click this hydrate button
right so I'm going to say you'll see
hydrate
and then I will
instantiate our component so here is
where we actually do the hydration
right so let's let's try refresh again
so everything is done uh but if you look
at console there's no hydrate yet
meaning we haven't hydrated out elements
we try to type something nothing's
changed right so if you inspect elements
you see that these are the elements that
is Created from the HTML written form
when we do that rendering now uh first
thing is I'm gonna ins cop take a look
at this element I'm gonna store the
reference of this H1
so this is I'm going to start as a
variable uh H1 equals to this
so now here's one
is pointing to this session element okay
so what I want to see is that later on
when I hydrate
um this is still the same H1 element
rather than you know being discarded and
thrown away and I want to make sure that
later on it's still the same element and
the
input is still the same input so I'm
gonna do this as well input equals to
this the input is still the same input
but then the input and the H1 has
interactivity has reactivity right
that's what we're gonna aim for when we
click the hydrate so uh at the same time
you can start at this screen usually
whenever whenever element has changed
when something has done to the elements
it will flash us right so let's click
actually everything is flashing I'm not
sure whether we're hydrating correctly
but let's take a look so uh H1
uh yeah it's still referring to the same
element so we didn't we didn't create a
new H1 this is still the H1 that we
reference to just now before we hydrate
and this is the new uh this is still the
same one that we see on the screen so no
new H1 being created right if I look for
input
this is still the same input elements
that you see uh just now and the one
that right now we are looking at is
still the same input element so no new
input element being created is still a
same input element but right now the
input element is reactive right when
you're trying to type something you see
that it's reflected reacted and uh yeah
things change right so this is hydration
hydration is you get the HTML being
um rendered when you uh pre-rendered
meaning render ahead of time or render
when you have a request you get that
HTML
as software user at the same time you
compile the code for the client side
which uh when you instantiate you should
pass the flag call hydrate so that it
will instead of recreate any new
elements it will look for the existing
elements and then
um Point reference to them right so
let's if I don't have this hydrate to
true what it means is that you ask felt
to actually
recreate this component and rather than
recreate actually what swell will do is
it will
create a new set of elements inserted at
the end of the body right we learned
that we can have as many elements we
have on the screen when we do when you
create an element it will actually
create a component the amount component
actually will insert at the end of the
children right so if you don't have
hydrate this is what's going to happen
but you pass hydrate to true then it
will
claim existing elements as uh as the
elements that that's treated like
existing elements as elements that it
will be creating and then pointing
reference to them and then add event
listeners so that whenever something has
changed it will update the existing
elements
so in this video we're going to talk
about svelt register
as I was trying to read through the docs
I found that
um there's this section that says swell
register it says that two render cell
component in node.js without bundling
use requires felt register after that
you can use required to include any.spel
file
but apparently this is like a magic
where you can require a spell register
and therefore you can start import
requiring the spell file how does that
even work right let's let's try it out
so uh we shouldn't know that right we
try we're trying to require something it
should be requiring a JavaScript module
right or else it won't work it should
require a JavaScript
um
common Jazz model because we are using
require
so over here if we try to run this
we'll end up in the
unexpected token syntax error because
this it itself it's not a JavaScript
right so apparently there's this magic
that you can do oops where I can copy
over here
paste it in
and if I run this now amazing we can now
import dot spell file so how does that
work
um in this video of course we're gonna
learn about yes you can do this as
expected but how does that work
um
so apparently from what I found that is
that there's this secret API from
node.js says that
require extension apparently it's
deprecated since version
zero is that yeah version zero so it's
it's added in the very beginning and
it's deprecated since very early on
because right now I think node.js latest
version is 14 or 16 right at this point
moment when I try and record this so
this has been added very early on and
it's deprecated since it's very very
early on but it's still apparently it's
being you in use
um so apparently this require extension
Works uh
in a way that you can
in a spell register it tries to add
um like a pre-processing before you
require any files and it's using this
require extension API from node.js that
does the magic so in this video we're
going to take a look at how it's being
done and how we can use uh use uh try to
write one ourselves right so
instead of importing still module for
now we're going to create a file called
a DOT n f file right so this is a very
common file you see that the end files
you can write some environment variables
that was supposed to be secret and only
so that you don't commit this file it
should be a git ignore file so every
time by then uh to save time to every
time when you run a command you have to
provide some environment variable maybe
you write this file right so this file
usually will look something like this
where you have a secret
a equals to xXx and secret b equals to y
or Y right something like this
so imagine this is a file just like any
files that we have uh imagine what we
want to do is we want to require this
file
oops
variables
I want to see whether we can
um
require this all right if you try to run
of course you will end up with an error
because this it's not even a
valid JavaScript so we're gonna learn
from spelled register where how we uh to
use these require extensions so how it
works is that you can come over here and
say require
.extensions
and you can add an extension so in this
case our extension would be a dot f so
any file that ends super.f would be
uh
have to go through this ex this
e this function this
let's see dot f equals so you can pass
in a function apparently so module it
takes in two parameters one is module
one is file name
so here what you can do is that you can
read the content or file process it make
it like a JavaScript and then uh use
this module to do something to uh
to parse it parse the JavaScript and
then return whatever it is
all right so uh it's it's easier to do
than say so I'm going to type it out
right now so first is uh here we get a
file name so probably we're going to
read the file content so I'm gonna have
FS equals require FS
so we're going to read the file content
content
so here I'm just going to console log
the content here
I'm gonna add some logs
um and let's try to run this
okay we are we able to
it's not defined okay apparently we are
not we didn't trigger this so uh maybe
we need to add some file name let's
let's try that I have no idea how this
works uh maybe Dev dot EnV
so let's require.dev.env
oh okay so now
you you have to have a file name and
then an extension extension so in this
case
um
what we have is when we try to require
any file that ends with DOT ends in this
case Dev dot at the F what we get is
what happens is that this function will
be triggered and you will gonna uh you
able to do something right so here we're
going to read this content and we're
going to process it like treat every
line is a property so we're gonna
content dot splits new line
um
and map for ish
okay the Creator object
for every line for each
line
the line that splits Again by equal sign
so you have a key and a value pair
so object equals key use value
so I create an object from the content
and I want to create a Javascript file
JavaScript code of it that makes sense
so the JavaScript code should look
something like this module that exports
equals to blah blah blah whatever right
so you should be having like a secret
a equals to xXx and Secret
b equals YY right it should look
something like this right hope that
makes sense so instead of uh so what we
need to do is we already have this
object in JavaScript uh so we can
serialize it using Json 25 to make it
like this object to print it out like an
object
json.string G5
and also we need to add this so we're
gonna make a string that looks something
like this
so instead of like having a module that
looks like this we have a
JavaScript code that looks like this so
it's it's a string it's a code it's a
piece of code it's a string
and what we do with this piece of code
is we are going to use module dots
compile
all this
with a file name
and this will return us as a module
which we just returned from this
function
okay now what we've done is that we
create a module out of any file
and if you try to run this you realize
that now
uh let's remove this
uh and let's print out here
realize that we ourselves we make any
file to become just a normal JavaScript
module so this is a secret behind spell
register and actually what it does is
that it will go and require extension
uh those fields file and make it a
module so it will make it
or make it um
a cell module so here I'm going to read
the content
and I am going to use fill compiler to
sorry
to compile our code
compile our code
with a generate SSR
and of course the format is CGS
right we have the code so this is the
JavaScript part of it
I'm gonna return
module so since we already have a
JavaScript code when it is going to
module compile the JavaScript code with
the file name
right so this is the secret behind
spread register so if we have this
you have this code over here it tells us
that we are able to import file and this
function here will focus on transforming
that source code you have into
JavaScript code and then use modular
compile to compile it to a JavaScript
module
so now with this code we have we can
now
import
adjust group uh file like a JavaScript
module
right you see that we don't have short
register at all so resistance is just a
file meaning uh just another module
meaning we can actually move this all of
this into the file register
like this
and we just import it import that
register
module and it will do it will try to try
to set up the required extension for
self module and allows us to import
spell module just like in any JavaScript
module so this is essentially what's
felt register is so it allows us to
import any field module so if your cell
module is important another skill module
what happens is that every time when you
require something importing something uh
it will keep on triggering the
extensions and then therefore you're
able to import so a module just like a
JavaScript module
so that's the secret between register I
hope you learned something if you if you
love this video share it to your friends
uh when anyone who is learning spell at
the same uh right now share to them so
that they can learn as well so see ya
bye